big data is a term i'm sure you're all
familiar with
big data as a technology has grown
massively over a decade and a half when
internet users boomed and companies
started generating vast amounts of data
it became more popular with the advent
of ai machine learning mobile technology
and the internet of things
big data analytics helps companies from
different sectors such as automobile
manufacturing e-commerce and logistics
to manage processes streamline use data
sets in real time as well as improve
their organization's decision-making
capability
big data and analytics can enable
organizations to get a better
understanding of their customers and
help to narrow down their targeted
audience
thus helping to improve companies
marketing campaigns
now there is no doubt that the big data
market is steadily growing and as per
fortune business insights
the global big data market is expected
to grow from 231.43
billion dollars
in 2021 to
549.73 billion us dollars in 2028 at a
cagr of 13.2 percent
as per monster.com annual trends report
big data analytics is most likely going
to be the top in demand skill for 2022.
at least 96 percent of companies are
definitely planning or likely to plan to
hire new staff with relevant skills
to fill future big data analytics
related roles in 2022
this indicates that the career
opportunities and big data are very high
and the scope is really good
now if you are looking for a career in
big data in 2022 on the screen you can
see some of the top big data companies
for 2022. so we have oracle
ecommerce leader amazon hpe
tech giant ibm and salesforce
now
let's look at the agenda for today's
video on big data full course 2022 so we
will start off by learning how to become
a big data engineer and then we will see
the crucial skills
for big data
next we will understand big data
analytics and look at the top
applications in big data
after that
we are going to learn about
big data tutorial and understand the
most popular big data framework that is
hadoop
next we are going to look at the
different tools that are part of the
hadoop ecosystem
then we are going to learn about apache
spark and understand the spark
architecture
finally we are going to close our
full course video session by learning
the top hadoop interview questions so
let's begin
today i'm going to tell you how you can
become a big data engineer now it should
come as no surprise for you guys to know
that organizations generate as well as
use a whole lot of data this vast volume
of data is called big data companies use
big data to draw meaningful insights and
take business decisions and big data
engineers are the people who can make
sense out of this enormous amount of
data now let's find out who is a big
data engineer a big data engineer is a
professional who develops maintains
tests and evaluates the company's big
data infrastructure in other words
develop big data solutions based on a
company's requirements they maintain
these solutions they test out these
solutions as to the company's
requirements they integrate this
solution with the various tools and
systems of the organization and finally
they evaluate how well the solution is
working to fulfill the company's
requirements next up let's have a look
at the responsibilities of a big data
engineer now they need to be able to
design implement verify and maintain
software systems now for the process of
ingesting data as well as processing it
they need to be able to build highly
scalable as well as robust systems they
need to be able to extract data from one
database transform it as well as load it
into another data store with the process
of etl or the extract transform load
process and they need to research as
well as propose new ways to acquire data
improve the overall data quality and the
efficiency of the system now to ensure
that all the business requirements are
met they need to build a suitable data
architecture they need to be able to
integrate several programming languages
and tools together so that they can
generate a structured solution they need
to build models that reduce the overall
complexity and increase the efficiency
of the whole system by mining data from
various sources and finally they need to
work well with other teams ones that
include data architects data analysts
and data scientists next up let's have a
look at the skills required to become a
big data engineer the first step is to
have programming knowledge one of the
most important skills required to become
a big data engineer is that of
experience with programming languages
especially hands-on experience now the
big data solutions that organizations
would want you to create will not be
possible without experience in
programming languages i can even tell
you an easy way through which you can
get experience with programming
languages practice practice and more
practice some of the most commonly used
programming languages used for big data
engineering are python java and c plus
the second skill that you require is to
have in-depth knowledge about dbms and
sql you need to know how data is
maintained as well as managed in a
database you need to know how sql can be
used to transform as well as perform
actions on a database and by extension
know how to write sql queries for any
relational database management systems
some of the commonly used database
management systems for big data
engineering mysql oracle database and
the microsoft sql server the third skill
that you require is to have experience
working with etl and warehousing tools
now you need to know how to construct as
well as use a data warehouse so that you
can perform the etl operation or the
extract transform and load operations
now as a big data engineer you'll be
constantly tasked with extracting
unstructured data from a number of
different sources transforming it into
meaningful information and loading it
into other data storages databases or
data warehouses now what this is is
basically aggregating unstructured data
from multiple sources analyzing it so
that you can take better business
decisions some of the tools used for
this purpose are talent ibm data stage
pentaho and informatica next up we have
the fourth skill that you require which
is knowledge about operating systems now
since most big data tools have unique
demands such as root access to operating
system functionality as well as hardware
having a strong understanding of
operating systems like linux and unix is
absolutely mandatory some of the
operating systems used by big data
engineers are unix linux and solaris now
the fifth skill that you require to have
experience with hadoop based analytics
since hadoop is one of the most commonly
used tools when it comes to big data
engineering it's understood that you
need to have experience with apache
hadoop based technologies technologies
like hdfs hadoop mapreduce apache edge
base hive and pig the sixth skill that
you require is to have worked with
real-time processing frameworks like
apache spark now as a big data engineer
you'll have to deal with vast volumes of
data so for this data you need an
analytics engine like spark which can be
used for large-scale real-time data
processing now spark can process live
streaming data from a number of
different sources like facebook
instagram twitter and so on it can also
perform interactive analysis and data
integration and now we're at our final
skill requirement which is to have
experience with data mining and modeling
so as a data engineer you'll have to
examine massive pre-existing data so
that you can discover patterns as well
as new information with this you will
create predictive models for your
business so that you can make better
informed decisions some of the tools
used for this are r rapidminer weka and
now let's talk about a big data
engineer's salary as well as other roles
they can look forward to now the average
salary of a big data engineer in the
united states is approximately ninety
thousand dollars per year now this
ranges from sixty six thousand dollars
all the way to hundred and thirty
thousand dollars per annum in india the
average salary is around seven lakh
rupees and ranges from four lakhs to 13
lakhs per annum after you become a big
data engineer some of the job roles that
you can look forward to are that of a
senior big data engineer a business
intelligence architect and a data
architect now let's talk about
certifications that a big data engineer
can opt for first off we have the
cloudera ccp data engineer a cloudera
certified professional data engineer
possesses the skills to develop reliable
and scalable data pipelines that result
in optimized data sets for a variety of
workloads it is one of the industry's
most demanding performance based
certification ccp evaluates and
recognizes a candidate's mastery of the
technical skills most sought after by
employers the time limit for this exam
is 240 minutes and it costs 400
next we have the ibm certified data
architect big data certification an ibm
certified big data architect understands
the complexity of data and can design
systems and models to handle different
data variety including structured
semi-structured unstructured volume
velocity veracity and so on a big data
architect is also able to effectively
address information governance and
security challenges associated with the
system this exam is 75 minutes long and
finally we have the google cloud
certified data engineer a google
certified data engineer enables data
driven decision making by collecting
transforming and publishing data they
should also be able to leverage deploy
and continuously train pre-existing
machine learning models the length of
the certification exam is 2 hours and
its registration fee is 200 now let's
have a look at how simply learn can help
you become a big data engineer
simply learn provides the big data
architect masters program this includes
a number of different courses like big
data hadoop and spark developer apache
spark and scala mongodb developer and
administrator big data and hadoop
administrator and so much more this
course goes through 50 plus in-demand
skills and tools 12 plus real life
projects and the possibility of an
annual average salary of 19 to 26 lakh
rupees per annum it will also help you
get noticed by the top hiring companies
this course will also go through some
major tools like kafka apache spark
flume edge base mongodb hive pig
mapreduce java scala and much more now
why don't you head over to
simplylearn.com and get started on your
journey to get certified and get ahead
we all use smartphones but have you ever
wondered how much data it generates in
the form of texts phone calls emails
photos
videos searches and music approximately
40 exabytes of data gets generated every
month by a single smartphone user
now imagine this number multiplied by 5
billion smartphone users that's a lot
for our mind even process isn't it in
fact this amount of data is quite a lot
for traditional computing systems to
handle and this massive amount of data
is what we term as big data let's have a
look at the data generated per minute on
the internet
2.1 million snaps are shared on snapchat
3.8 million search queries are made on
google one million people log on to
facebook 4.5 million videos are watched
on youtube
188 million emails are sent that's a lot
of data so how do you classify any data
as big data this is possible with the
concept of five v's
volume velocity
variety
veracity and value
let us understand this with an example
from the healthcare industry hospitals
and clinics across the world generate
massive volumes of data 2
314 exabytes of data are collected
annually in the form of patient records
and test results all this data is
generated at a very high speed which
attributes to the velocity of big data
variety refers to the various data types
such as structured semi-structured and
unstructured data examples include excel
records log files and x-ray images
accuracy and trustworthiness of the
generated data is termed as veracity
analyzing all this data will benefit the
medical sector by enabling faster
disease detection
better treatment and reduced cost
this is known as the value of big data
but how do we store and process this big
data to do this job we have various
frameworks such as cassandra hadoop and
spark let us take hadoop as an example
and see how hadoop stores and processes
big data
hadoop uses a distributed file system
known as hadoop distributed file system
to store big data if you have a huge
file your file will be broken down into
smaller chunks and stored in various
machines not only that when you break
the file you also make copies of it
which goes into different nodes this way
you store your big data in a distributed
way and make sure that even if one
machine fails your data is safe on
another
mapreduce technique is used to process
big data a lengthy task a is broken into
smaller tasks
b
c
and d
now instead of one machine three
machines take up each task and complete
it in a parallel fashion and assemble
the results at the end thanks to this
the processing becomes easy and fast
this is known as parallel processing
now that we have stored and processed
our big data we can analyze this data
for numerous applications
in games like halo 3 and call of duty
designers analyze user data to
understand at which stage most of the
users pause restart or quit playing this
insight can help them rework on the
storyline of the game and improve the
user experience
which in turn reduces the customer churn
rate
big data also helped with disaster
management during hurricane sandy in
2012 it was used to gain a better
understanding of the storm's effect on
the east coast of the us and necessary
measures were taken it could predict the
hurricane's landfall five days in
advance which wasn't possible earlier
these are some of the clear indications
of how valuable big data can be once it
is accurately processed and analyzed
back in the early 2000s there was
relatively less data generated but with
the rise of various social media
platforms and multinational companies
across the globe the generation of data
has increased by leaps and bounds
according to the idc the total volume of
data is expected to reach 175 zettabytes
in 2025 that's a lot of data
so we can define big data as massive
amount of data which cannot be stored
processed and analyzed using the
traditional ways let's now have a look
at the challenges with respect to big
data
the first challenge with big data is its
storage storing big data is not easy as
the data generation is endless in
addition to this storing unstructured
data in our traditional databases is a
great challenge unstructured data refers
to data such as photographs and videos
the second challenge is processing big
data data is only useful to us if it is
processed and analyzed processing big
data consumes a lot of time due to its
size and structure
to overcome these challenges of big data
we have various frameworks such as
hadoop cassandra and spark let us have a
quick look at hadoop and spark
so what is hadoop it is a framework that
stores big data in a distributed way and
processes it parallely how do you think
hadoop does this
well hadoop uses a distributed file
system known as hadoop distributed file
system to store big data if you have a
huge file your file will be broken out
into smaller chunks and stored in
various machines this is why it is
termed as distributed storage
mapreduce is the processing unit of
hadoop here we have multiple machines
working parallelly to process big data
thanks to this technique the processing
becomes easy and fast
let's now move on to spark spark is a
framework that is responsible for
processing data both in batches and in
real time spark is used to analyze data
across various clusters of computers
now that you have understood big data
hadoop and spark let's look into few of
the different job roles in this domain
career opportunities in this field are
limitless as organizations are using big
data to enhance their products business
decisions and marketing effectiveness
so here we will understand in depth as
to how to become a big data engineer in
addition to this we will also look into
the various uh skills required to become
a hadoop developer spark developer and a
big data architect
starting off with a big data engineer
role
do you know who a big data engineer is
well big data engineers are
professionals who develop maintain test
and evaluate a company's big data
infrastructure
they have several responsibilities
firstly they are responsible for
designing and implementing software
systems they verify and maintain these
systems for the ingestion and processing
of data they built robust systems
extract transform load operations known
as the etl process is carried out by big
data engineers they also research
various new methods to obtain data and
improve its quality
big data engineers are also responsible
for building data architectures that
meet the business requirements they
provide a solution by integrating
various tools and programming languages
in addition to the above
responsibilities their primary
responsibility is to mine data from
plenty of different sources to build
efficient business models lastly they
also work closely with data architects
data scientists and data analysts
those acquire a lot of responsibilities
let us now have a look at the skills
required to achieve these
responsibilities
as you can see on your screens we have
listed the top
top seven skills needed to be possessed
by a big data engineer
starting off the essential skill is
programming
a big data engineer needs to have
hands-on experience in any one of the
programming languages such as java
c-plus plus or python
as a big data engineer you should also
have in-depth knowledge of dbms and sql
this is because you have to understand
how data is managed and maintained in a
database hence you need to know how to
write sql queries for any rdbms systems
some of the commonly used database
management systems for big data
engineering are mysql oracle database
and the microsoft sql server
as mentioned earlier carrying out an e
carrying out an etl operation is a big
data engineer's responsibility now you
need to know how to construct as well as
use a data warehouse so that you can
perform these etl operations as a big
data engineer you will be continuously
tasked with extracting data from various
sources transforming them into
meaningful information and loading it
into other data storages some of the
tools used for this purpose are talent
ibm data stage pentaho and informatica
next up we have the fourth skill that
you require which is knowledge about
operating systems
big data tools run on operating systems
hence a sound understanding of unix
linux windows and solaris is mandatory
the fifth skill that you require is to
have experience with hadoop based
analytics
since haroop is one of the most commonly
used big data engineering tools it's
understood that you need to have
experience with apache hadoop based
technologies like hdfs mapreduce apache
pig hive and apache hedge base
the sixth skill that you require is to
have worked with real-time processing
frameworks like apache spark
as a big data engineer you would deal
with large volumes of data
so for this you need an analytics engine
like spark which can be used for both
batch and real-time processing
spark can process live streaming data
from several different sources like
facebook instagram twitter and so on
and now we are at our final skill
requirement which is to have experience
with data mining and data modeling as a
big data engineer you would have to
examine massive pre-existing data so
that you can discover patterns and new
information this will help you create
predictive models that will help you
make various business business decisions
some of the tools used for this are are
rapidminer becca and nime
now let's talk about a big data engineer
salary in the u.s a big data engineer's
average annual salary is around hundred
and two thousand dollars per annum in
india a big data engineer makes about
seven lakh rupees per annum
that was all about our first role big
data engineer moving on to our second
role we have hadoop developer
as the name suggests a hadoop developer
looks into the coding and programming of
the various hadoop applications this job
role is more or less similar to that of
a software developer
moving on to the skills required to
become a hadoop developer at first it is
a knowledge of the hadoop ecosystem a
hadoop developer should have in-depth
knowledge about the hadoop ecosystem and
its components which include hedge base
pig scoop flume uzi etc you should also
have data modeling experience with olap
and oltp knowledge of sql is required
like a big data engineer a hadoop
developer must also know popular tools
like pentaho informatica and talent
finally you should also be well versed
in writing pig latin scripts and
map-reduce jobs
the average annual salary of a hadoop
developer in the u.s is nearly 76 000
per annum in india a hadoop developer
makes approximately 4 lakh 57 000 rupees
per annum
moving to our third job role we have
spark developer
we saw what spark is now let's
understand what a spark developer does
spark developers create spark jobs using
python or scala for data aggregation and
transformation they also write analytics
code and design data processing
pipelines
a spark developer needs to have the
following skills they need to know spark
and its components such as spark core
spark streaming spark machine learning
library etc
they should also know the scripting
languages like python or perl
just like the previous job roles a spark
developer should also have basic
knowledge of sequel queries and a
database structure
in addition to the above a spark
developer is also expected to have a
fairly good understanding of linux and
its commands
moving to the average annual salary of a
spark developer it is nearly 81 000
dollars per annum in the us in india a
spark developer earns nearly 5 lakh 87
000 rupees per annum
let's now move on to our final job role
that is big data architect
so let's understand who a big data
architect is
well a big data architect is a
professional who is responsible for
designing and planning big data systems
they also manage large scale development
and deployment of hadoop applications
moving on to the skills required to
become a big data architect first up the
individual must have advanced data
mining and data analysis skills big data
architects should also be able to
implement and use a nosql database and
cloud computing techniques
they must also have an idea of various
big data technologies like hadoop
mapreduce hbase hype and so on
finally big data architects must hold
experience with agile and scrum
frameworks
let's now have a look at the average
annual salary of a big data architect in
the united states and india in the u.s a
big data architect earns a whopping 118
thousand dollars per annum meanwhile in
india a big data architect makes nearly
19 lakh rupees per annum these are huge
numbers right
so now that we have understood the job
roles of a big data engineer hadoop
developer spark developer and a big data
architect let us have a look at the
companies hiring these professionals
as you all can see on your screens we
have ibm amazon american express netflix
microsoft and bosch to name a few
let us now understand why big data
analytics is required with an example so
all of you listen to music online isn't
it here we will take an example of
spotify which is a swedish audio
streaming platform and see how big data
analytics is used here spotify has
nearly 96 plus million users and all
these users generate a tremendous amount
of data data like the songs which are
played repeatedly the numerous likes
shares and the user search history all
these data can be termed as big data
here with respect to spotify have you
ever wondered what spotify does with all
this big data well spotify analyzes this
big data for suggesting songs to its
users i'm sure all of you might have
come across the recommendation list
which is made available to each one of
you by spotify each one of you will have
a totally different recommendation list
this is based on your likes your past
history like the songs you like
listening to and your playlists this
works on something known as the
recommendation system recommendation
systems are nothing but data filtering
tools they collect all the data and then
filter them using various algorithms
this system has the ability to
accurately predict what a user would
like to listen to next with the help of
big data analytics this prediction helps
the users stay on the page for a longer
time and by doing so spotify engages all
its users the users don't have the need
to go on searching for different songs
this is because spotify readily provides
them with a variety of songs according
to their taste well this is how big data
analytics is used by spotify now that we
have understood why big data analytics
is required let us move on to our next
topic that is what is big data analytics
but before that there is another term we
need to understand that is big data we
all hear the term big data many times
but do you know what exactly big data
means well we will understand the term
big data clearly right now big data is a
term for data sets that cannot be
handled by traditional computers or
tools due to their value volume velocity
and veracity it is defined as massive
amount of data which cannot be stored
process and analyzed using various
traditional methods do you know how much
data is being generated every day every
second even as i talk right now there
are millions of data sources which
generate data at a very rapid rate these
data sources are present across the
world as you know social media sites
generate a lot of data let's take an
example of facebook facebook generates
over 500 plus terabytes of data every
day this data is mainly generated in
terms of your photographs videos
messages etc big data also contains data
of different formats like structured
data semi-structured data and
unstructured data data like your excel
sheets all fall under structured data
this data has a definite format your
emails fall under semi-structured and
your pictures and videos all fall under
unstructured data all these data
together make up for big data it is very
tough to store process and analyze big
data using rtbms if you have looked into
our previous videos you would know that
hadoop is the solution to this hadoop is
a framework that stores and processes
big data it stores big data using the
distributed storage system and it
processes big data using the parallel
processing method hence storing and
processing big data is no more a problem
using hadoop big data in its raw form is
of no use to us we must try to derive
meaningful information from it in order
to benefit from this big data do you
know amazon uses big data to monitor its
items that are in its fulfillment
centers across the globe how do you
think amazon does this well it is done
by analyzing big data which is known as
big data analytics what is big data
analytics in simple terms big data
analytics is defined as the process
which is used to extract meaningful
information from big data this
information could be your hidden
patterns unknown correlations market
trends and so on by using big data
analytics there are many advantages it
can be used for better decision making
to prevent fraudulent activities and
many others we will look into four of
them step by step i will first start off
with big data analytics which is used
for risk management bdo which is a
philippine banking company uses big data
analytics for risk management risk
management is an important aspect for
any organization especially in the field
of banking risk management analysis
comprises a series of measures which are
employed to prevent any sort of
unauthorized activities identifying
fraudulent activities was a main concern
for bdo it was difficult for the bank to
identify the fraudster from a long list
of suspects bdo adopted big data
analytics which held the bank to narrow
down the entire list of suspects thus
the organization was able to identify
the fraudster in a very short time this
is how big data analytics is used in the
field of banking for risk management let
us now see how big data analytics is
used for product development and
innovations with an example all of you
are aware of rolls-royce cars right do
you also know that they manufacture jet
engines which are used across the world
what is more interesting is that they
use big data analytics for developing
and innovating this engine a new product
is always developed by trial and error
method big data analytics is used here
to analyze if an engine design is good
or bad it is also used to analyze if
there can be more scope for improvement
based on the previous models and on the
future demands this way big data
analytics is used in designing a product
which is of higher quality using big
data analytics the company can save a
lot of time if the team is struggling to
arrive at the right conclusion big data
can be used to zero in on the right data
which have to be studied and thus the
time spent on the product development is
less big data analytics helps in quicker
and better decision making in
organizations the process of selecting a
course of action from various other
alternatives is known as decision making
lot of organizations take important
decisions based on the data that they
have data driven business decisions can
make or break a company hence it is
important to analyze all the
possibilities thoroughly and quickly
before making important decisions let us
now try to understand this with an use
case starbucks uses big data analytics
for making important decisions they
decide the location of their new outlet
using big data analytics choosing the
right location is an important factor
for any organization the wrong location
will not be able to attract the required
amount of customers positioning of a new
outlet a few miles here or there can
always make a huge difference for an
outlet especially a one like starbucks
various factors are involved in choosing
the right location for a new outlet for
example parking adequacy has to be taken
into consideration it would be
inconvenient for people to go to a store
which has no parking facility similarly
the other factors that have to be
considered are the visibility of the
location the accessibility the economic
factors the population of that
particular location and also we would
have to look into the competition in the
vicinity all these factors have to be
thoroughly analyzed before making a
decision as to where the new outlet must
be started without analyzing these
factors it would be impossible for us to
make a wise decision using big data
analytics we can consider all these
factors and analyze them quickly and
thoroughly thus starbucks makes use of
big data analytics to understand if
their new location would be fruitful or
not finally we will look into how big
data analytics is used to improve
customer experience using an example
delta an american airline uses big data
analytics to improve its customer
experiences with the increase in global
air travel it is necessary that an
airline does everything they can in
order to provide good service and
experience to its customers delta
airlines improves its customer
experience by making use of big data
analytics this is done by monitoring
tweets which will give them an idea as
to how their customers journey was if
the airline comes across a negative
tweet and if it is found to be the
airline's fault the airline goes ahead
and upgrades that particular customer's
ticket when this happens the customer is
able to trust the airlines and without a
doubt the customer will choose delta for
their next journey by doing so the
customer is happy and the airlines will
be able to build a good brand
recognition thus we see here that by
using analysis delta airlines was able
to improve its customer experience
moving on to our next topic that is life
cycle of big data analytics here we will
look into the various stages as to how
data is analyzed from scratch the first
stage is the business case evaluation
stage here the motive behind the
analysis is identified we need to
understand why we are analyzing so that
we know how to do it and what are the
different parameters that have to be
looked into once this is done it is
clear for us and it becomes much easier
for us to proceed with the rest after
which we will look into the various data
sources from where we can gather all the
data which will be required for analysis
once we get the required data we will
have to see if the data that we received
is fit for analysis or not not all the
data that we receive will have
meaningful information some of it will
surely just be corrupt data to remove
this corrupt data we will pass this
entire data through a filtering stage in
this stage all the corrupt data will be
removed now we have the data minus the
corrupt data do you think our data is
now fit for analysis well it is not we
still have to figure out which data will
be compatible with the tool that we will
be using for analysis if we find data
which is incompatible we first extract
it and then transform it to a compatible
form depending on the tool that we use
in the next stage all the data with the
same fields will be integrated this is
known as the data aggregation stage the
next stage which is the analysis stage
is a very important stage in the life
cycle of big data analytics right here
in this step the entire process of
evaluating your data using various
analytical and statistical tools to
discover meaningful information is done
like we have discussed before the entire
process of deriving meaningful
information from data which is known as
analysis is done here in this stage the
result of the data analysis stage is
then graphically communicated using
tools like tableau power bi click view
this analysis result will then be made
available to different business
stakeholders for various decision making
this was the entire life cycle of big
data analytics we just saw how data is
analyzed from scratch now we will move
on to a very important topic that is the
different types of big data analytics
well we have four different types of big
data analytics as you see here these are
the types and below this are the
questions that each type tries to answer
we have descriptive analytics which asks
the question what has happened then we
have diagnostic analytics which asks why
did it happen predictive analytics
asking what will happen and prescriptive
analytics which questions by asking what
is the solution we will look into all
these four one by one with an use case
for each we will first start off with
descriptive analytics as mentioned
earlier descriptive analytics asks the
question what has happened it can be
defined as the type that summarizes past
data into a form that can be understood
by humans in this type we will look into
the past data and arrive at various
conclusions for example an organization
can review its performance using
descriptive analytics that is it
analyzes its past data such as revenue
over the years and arrives at a
conclusion with the profit by looking at
this graph we can understand if the
company is running at a profit or not
thus descriptive analytics helps us
understand this easily we can simply say
that descriptive analytics is used for
creating various reports for companies
and also for tabulating various social
media metrics like facebook likes tweets
etc now that we have seen what is
descriptive analytics let us look into
and use case of descriptive analytics
the dow chemical company analyzed all
its past data using descriptive
analytics and by doing so they were able
to identify the under utilized space in
their facility descriptive analytics
helped them in this space consolidation
on the whole the company was able to
save nearly 4 million dollars annually
so we now see here that descriptive
analytics not only helps us derive
meaningful information from the past
data but it can also help companies in
cost reduction if it is used wisely let
us now move on to our next type that is
diagnostic analytics diagnostic
analytics asks the question why a
particular problem has occurred as you
can see it will always ask the question
why did it happen it will look into the
root cause of a problem and try to
understand why it has occurred
diagnostic analytics makes use of
various techniques such as data mining
data discovery and drill down companies
benefit from this type of analytics
because it helps them look into the root
cause of a problem by doing so the next
time the same problem will not arise as
the company already knows why it has
happened and they will arrive at a
particular solution for it initsoft's bi
query tool is an example of diagnostic
analytics we can use query tool for
diagnostic analytics now that you know
why diagnostic analytics is required and
what diagnostic analytics is i will run
you through an example which shows where
diagnostic analytics can be used all of
us shop on e-commerce sites right have
you ever added items to your cart but
ended up not buying it yes all of us
might have done that at some point an
organization tries to understand why its
customers don't end up buying their
products although it has been added to
their carts and this understanding is
done with the help of diagnostic
analytics an e-commerce site wonders why
they have made few online sales although
they have had a very good marketing
strategy there could have been various
factors as to why this has happened
factors like the shipping fee which was
too high or the page that didn't load
correctly not enough payment options
available and so on all these factors
are analyzed using diagnostic analytics
and the company comes to a conclusion as
to why this has happened thus we see
here that the root cause is identified
so that in future the same problem
doesn't occur again let us now move on
to the third type that is predictive
analytics as the name suggests
predictive analytics makes predictions
of the future it analyzes the current
and historical facts to make predictions
about future it always asks the question
what will happen next predictive
analytics is used with the help of
artificial intelligence machine learning
data mining to analyze the data it can
be used for predicting customer trends
market trends customer behavior etc it
solely works on probability it always
tries to understand what can happen next
with the help of all the past and
current information a company like
paypal which has 260 plus million
accounts always has the need to ensure
that their online fraudulent and
unauthorized activities are brought down
to nil fear of constant fraudulent
activities have always been a major
concern for paypal when a fraudulent
activity occurs people lose trust in the
company and this brings in a very bad
name for the brand it is inevitable that
fraudulent activities will happen in a
company like paypal which is one of the
largest online payment processors in the
world but paypal uses analytics wisely
here to prevent such fraudulent
activities and to minimize them it uses
predictive analytics to do so the
organization is able to analyze past
data which includes a customer's
historical payment data a customer's
behavior trend and then it builds an
algorithm which works on predicting what
is likely to happen next with respect to
their transaction with the use of big
data and algorithms the system can gauge
which of the transactions are valid and
which could be potentially a fraudulent
activity by doing so paypal is always
ready with precautions that they have to
take to protect all their clients
against fraudulent transactions we will
now move on to our last type that is
prescriptive analytics prescriptive
analytics as the name suggests always
prescribes a solution to a particular
problem the problem can be something
which is happening currently hence it
can be termed as the type that always
asks the question what is the solution
prescriptive analytics is related to
both predictive and descriptive
analytics as we saw earlier descriptive
analytics always asks the question what
has happened and predictive analytics
helps you understand what can happen
next with the help of artificial
intelligence and machine learning
prescriptive analytics helps you arrive
at the best solution for a particular
problem various business rules
algorithms and computational modeling
procedures are used in prescriptive
analytics let us now have a look at how
and where prescriptive analytics is used
with an example here we will understand
how prescriptive analytics is used by an
airline for its profit do you know that
when you book a flight ticket the price
of it depends on various factors both
internal and external factors apart from
taxes seed selection there are other
factors like oil prices customer demand
which are all taken into consideration
before the flight sphere is displayed
prices change due to availability and
demand holiday seasons are a time when
the rates are much higher than the
normal days seasons like christmas and
school vacations also weekends the rates
will be much higher than weekdays
another factor which determines a
flight's fair is your destination
depending on the place where you are
traveling to the flight fair will be
adjusted accordingly this is because
there are quite a few places where the
air traffic is less and in such places
the flight sphere will also be less so
prescriptive analytics analyzes all
these factors that are discussed and it
builds an algorithm which will
automatically adjust a flight sphere by
doing so the airline is able to maximize
its profit these were the four types of
analytics now let us understand how we
achieve these with the use of big data
tools our next topic will be the various
tools used in big data analytics these
are few of the tools that i will be
talking about today we have hadoop
mongodb talindi kafka cassandra spark
and storm we will look into each one of
them one by one we will first start off
with hadoop when you speak of big data
the first framework that comes into
everyone's mind is hadoop isn't it as i
mentioned earlier apache hadoop is used
to store and process big data in a
distributed and parallel fashion it
allows us to process data very fast
hadoop uses mapreduce big and high for
analyzing this big data hadoop is easily
one of the most famous big data tools
now let us move on to the next one that
is mongodb mongodb is a cross-platform
document oriented database it has the
ability to deal with large amount of
unstructured data processing of data
which is unstructured and processing of
data sets that change very frequently is
done using mongodb talendi provides
software and services for data
integration data management and cloud
storage it specializes in big data
integration talandi open studio is a
free open source tool for processing
data easily on a big data environment
cassandra is used widely for an
effective management of large amounts of
data it is similar to hadoop in its
feature of fault tolerance where data is
automatically replicated to multiple
nodes cassandra is preferred for
real-time processing spark is another
tool that is used for data processing
this data processing engine is developed
to process data way faster than hadoop
mapreduce this is done in a way because
spark does all the processing in the
main memory of the data nodes and thus
it prevents unnecessary input output
overheads with the disk whereas
mapreduce is disk based and hence spark
proves to be faster than hadoop
mapreduce storm is a free big data
computational system which is done in
real time it is one of the easiest tools
for big data analysis it can be used
with any programming language this
feature makes storm very simple to use
finally we will look into another big
data tool which is known as kafka kafka
is a distributed streaming platform
which was developed by linkedin and
later given to apache software
foundation it is used to provide
real-time analytics result and it is
also used for fault tolerant storage
these were few of the big data analytics
tools now let us move on to our last
topic for today that is big data
application domains here we will look
into the various sectors where big data
analytics is actively used the first
sector is e-commerce merely 45 percent
of the world is online and they create a
lot of data every second big data can be
used smartly in the field of e-commerce
by predicting customer trend forecasting
demands adjusting the price and so on
online retailers have the opportunity to
create better shopping experience and
generate higher sales if big data
analytics is used correctly having big
data doesn't automatically lead to a
better marketing strategy meaningful
insights need to be derived from it in
order to make right decisions by
analyzing big data we can have
personalized marketing campaigns which
can result in better and higher sales in
the field of education depending on the
market requirements new courses are
developed the market requirement needs
to be analyzed correctly with respect to
the scope of a course and accordingly a
scope needs to be developed there is no
point in developing a course which has
no scope in the future hence to analyze
the market requirement and to develop
new courses we use big data analytics
here there are a number of uses of big
data analytics in the field of health
care and one of it is to predict a
patient's health issue that is with the
help of their previous medical history
big data analytics can determine how
likely they are to have a particular
health issue in the future the example
of spotify that we saw previously showed
how big data analytics is used to
provide a personalized recommendation
list to all its users similarly in the
field of media and entertainment big
data analytics is used to understand the
demands of shows songs movies and so on
to deliver personalized recommendation
list as we saw with spotify big data
analytics is used in the field of
banking as we saw previously with a few
use cases big data analytics was used
for risk management in addition to risk
management
it is also used to analyze a customer's
income and spend patterns and to help
the bank predict if a particular
customer is going to choose any of the
bank offers such as loans credit card
schemes and so on this way the bank is
able to identify the right customer who
is interested in its offers it has
noticed that telecom companies have
begun to embrace big data to gain profit
big data analytics helps in analyzing
network traffic and call data records it
can also improve its service quality and
improve its customer experience let us
now look into how big data analytics is
used by governments across the world in
the field of law enforcement big data
analytics can be applied to analyze all
the available data to understand crime
patterns intelligence services can use
predictive analytics to focus the crime
which could be committed
in durham the police department was able
to reduce the crime rate using big data
analytics with the help of data police
could identify whom to target where to
go when to petrol and how to investigate
crimes big data analytics help them to
discover patterns of crime emerging in
the area before we move on to the
applications let's have a quick look at
the big data market revenue forecast
worldwide from 2011 to 2027.
so here's a graph in which the y-axis
represents the revenue in billion us
dollars and the x-axis represents the
years as it is seen clearly from the
graph big data has grown until 2019 and
statistics predict that this growth will
continue even in the future this growth
is made possible as numerous companies
use big data in various domains to boost
their revenue we will look into few of
such applications the first big data
application we will look into is weather
forecast imagine there is a sudden storm
and you're not even prepared that would
be a terrifying situation isn't it
dealing with any calamities such as
hurricane storms floods would be very
inconvenient if we are caught off guard
the solution is to have a tool that
predicts the weather of the coming days
well in advance this tool needs to be
accurate and to make such a tool big
data is used so how does big data help
here well it allows us to gather all the
information required to predict the
weather information such as the climate
change details wind direction
precipitation previous weather reports
and so on after all this data is
collected it becomes easier for us to
spot a trend and identify what's going
to happen next by analyzing all of this
big data a weather prediction engine
works on this analysis it predicts the
weather of every region across the world
for any given time by using such a tool
we can be well prepared to face any
climate change or any natural calamity
let's take an example of a landslide and
try to understand how big data is used
to tackle such a situation predicting a
landslide is very difficult with just
the basic warning signs lack of this
prediction can cause a huge damage to
life and property this challenge was
studied by the university of melbourne
and they developed a tool which is
capable of predicting a landslide this
tool predicts the boundary where a
landslide is likely to occur two weeks
before this magical tool works on both
big data and applied mathematics an
accurate prediction like this which is
made two weeks before can save lives and
help in relocating people in that
particular region it also gives us an
insight into the magnitude of the
upcoming destruction this is how big
data is used in weather forecast and in
predicting any natural calamities across
the world let us now move on to our next
application that is big data application
in the field of media and entertainment
the media and the entertainment industry
is a massive one leveraging big data
here can produce sky-high results and
boost the revenue for any company let us
see the different ways in which big data
is used in this industry have you ever
noticed that you come across relevant
advertisements in your social media
sites and in your mailboxes well this is
done by analyzing all your data such as
your previous browsing history and your
purchase data publishers then display
what you like in the form of ads which
will in turn catch your interest in
looking into it next up is customer
sentiment analysis customers are very
important for a company the happier the
customer the greater the company's
revenue big data helps in gathering all
the emotions of a customer through their
posts messages conversations etc these
emotions are then analyzed to arrive at
a conclusion regarding the customer
satisfaction if the customer is unhappy
the company strives to do better the
next time and provides their customers a
better experience while purchasing an
item from an e-commerce site or while
watching videos on an entertainment site
you might have noticed a segment which
says most recommended list for you this
list is a personalized list which is
made available to you by analyzing all
the data such as your previous watch
history your subscriptions your likes
and so on recommendation engine is a
tool that filters and analyzes all this
data and provides you with a list that
you would most likely be interested in
by doing so the site is able to retain
and engage its customer for a longer
time next is customer churn analysis in
simple words customer churn happens when
a customer stops a subscription with a
service predicting and preventing this
is of paramount importance to any
organization by analyzing the behavioral
patterns of previously churned customers
an organization can identify which of
their current customers are likely to
churn by analyzing all of this data the
organization can then implement
effective programs for customer
retention let us now look into an use
case of starbucks big data is
effectively used by the starbucks app 17
million users use this app and you can
imagine how much data they generate data
in the form of their coffee buying
habits the store they visit and to the
time they purchase all of this data is
fed into the app so when a customer
enters a new starbucks location the
system analyzes all their data and they
are provided with their preferred order
this app also suggests new products to
the customer in addition to this they
also provide personalized offer and
discounts on special occasions moving on
to our next sector which is healthcare
it is one of the most important sectors
big data is widely used here to save
lives with all the available big data
medical researchers are done very
effectively they are performed
accurately by analyzing all the previous
medical histories and new treatments and
medicines are discovered cure can be
found out even for few of the incurable
diseases there are cases when one
medication need not be effective for
every patient hence personal care is
very important personal care is provided
to each patient depending on their past
medical history and individuals medical
history along with their body parameters
are analyzed and personal attention is
given to each of them as we all know
medical treatments are not very pocket
friendly every time a medical treatment
is taken the amount increases this can
be reduced if readmissions are brought
down analyzing all the data precisely
will deliver a long-term efficient
result which will in turn prevent a
patient's readmission frequently with
globalization came an increase in the
ease for infectious diseases to spread
widely based on geography and
demographics big data helps in
predicting where an outbreak of epidemic
viruses are most likely to occur an
american healthcare company united
healthcare uses big data to detect any
online medical fraud activities such as
payment of unauthorized benefits
intentional misrepresentation of data
and so on the healthcare company runs
disease management programs the success
rates of these programs are predicted
using big data depending on how patients
respond to it the next sector we will
look into is logistics logistics looks
into the process of transportation and
storage of goods the movement of a
product from its supplier to a consumer
is very important big data is used to
make this process faster and efficient
the most important factor in logistics
is the time taken for the products to
reach their destination to achieve
minimum time sensors within the vehicle
analyze the fastest route this analysis
is based on various data such as the
weather traffic the list of orders and
so on by doing so the fastest route is
obtained and the delivery time is
reduced capacity planning is another
factor which needs to be taken into
consideration details regarding the
workforce and the number of vehicles are
analyzed thoroughly and each vehicle is
allocated a different route this is done
as there is no need for many trucks to
travel in the same direction which will
be pointless depending on the analysis
of the available workforce and resources
this decision is taken big data
analytics also finds its use in managing
warehouses efficiently this analysis
along with tracking sensors provide
information regarding the underutilized
space which results in efficient
resource allocation and eventually
reduces the cost customer satisfaction
is important in logistics just like it
is in any other sector customer
reactions are analyzed from the
available data which will eventually
create an instant feedback loop a happy
customer will always help the company
gain more customers let us now look into
a use case of ups as you know ups is one
of the biggest shipping company in the
world they have a huge customer database
and they work on data every minute ups
uses big data to gather different kinds
of data regarding the weather the
traffic jams the geography the locations
and so on after collecting all this data
they analyze it to discover the best and
the fastest route to the destination in
addition to this they also use big data
to change the routes in real time this
is how efficiently ups leverages big
data next up we have a very interesting
sector that is the travel and tourism
sector the global tourism market is
expected to grow in the near future big
data is used in various ways in this
sector let us look into a few of them
hotels can increase their revenue by
adjusting the room tariffs depending on
the peak seasons such as holiday seasons
festive seasons and so on the tourism
industry uses all of this data to
anticipate the demand and maximize their
revenue big data is also used by resorts
and hotels to analyze various details
regarding their competitors this
analysis result helps them to
incorporate all the good facilities
their competitors are providing and by
doing so the hotel is able to flourish
further a customer always comes back if
they are offered good packages which are
more than just the basic ones looking
into a customer's past travel history
likes and preferences hotels can provide
its customers with personalized
experiences which will interest them
highly investing in an area which could
be the hub of tourism is very wise few
countries use big data to examine the
tourism activities in their country and
this in turn helps them discover new and
fruitful investment opportunities let us
look into one of the best online
homestay networks airbnb and see how big
data is used by them airbnb undoubtedly
provides its customers with the best
accommodation across the world big data
is used by it to analyze the different
kinds of available properties depending
on the customer's preferences the
pricing the keywords previous customers
ratings and experiences airbnb filters
out the best result big data works its
magic yet again now we will move on to
our final sector which is the government
and law enforcement sector maintaining
law and order is of utmost importance to
any government it is a huge task by
itself big data plays an active role
here and in addition to this it also
helps governments bring in new policies
and schemes for the welfare of its
citizens the police department is able
to predict criminal activities way
before it happens by analyzing big data
information such as the previous crime
records in a particular region the
safety aspect in that region and so on
by analyzing these factors they are able
to predict any activity which breaks the
law and order of the region governments
are able to tackle unemployment to a
great extent by using big data by
analyzing the number of students
graduating every year to the number of
relevant job openings the government can
have an idea of the unemployment rate in
the country and then take necessary
measures to tackle it our next factor is
poverty in large countries it is
difficult to analyze which area requires
attention and development big data
analytics makes it easier for
governments to discover such areas
poverty gradually decreases once these
areas begin to develop governments have
to always be on the lookout for better
development a public survey voices the
opinion of a country's citizens
analyzing all the data collected from
such surveys can help governments build
better policies and services which will
benefit its citizens let us now move on
to our use case did you know that the
new york police department uses big data
analytics to protect its citizens the
department prevents and identifies
crimes by analyzing a huge amount of
data which includes fingerprints certain
emails and records from previous police
investigations and so on after analyzing
all of this data meaningful insights are
drawn from it which will help the police
in taking the required preventive
measures against crimes now when we talk
about evolution of big data we have
known that data has evolved in last five
years like never before now in fact
before going to big data or before
understanding these solutions and the
need and why there is a rush towards big
data technology and solution i would
like to ask a question take a couple of
minutes and think why are organizations
interested in big data why is there
certain rush in industry where everyone
would want to ramp up their current
infrastructure or would want to be
working on technologies which allow them
to use this big data think about it what
is happening and why are organizations
interested in this and if you think on
this
you will start thinking about what
organizations have been doing in past
what organizations have not done and why
are organizations interested in big data
now before we learn on big data we can
always look into internet and check for
use cases where organizations have
failed to use legacy systems or
relational databases to work on their
data requirements now over in recent or
over past five years or in recent decade
what has happened is organizations have
started understanding the value of data
and they have decided
not to ignore any data as being
uneconomical now we can talk about
different platforms through which data
is generated take an example of social
media like twitter facebook instagram
whatsapp youtube you have e-commerce and
various portals say ebay amazon flipkart
alibaba.com and then you have various
tech giants such as google oracle sap
amazon microsoft and so on so lots of
data is getting generated every day in
every business sector the point here is
that organizations have slowly started
realizing that they would be interested
in working on all the data now the
question which i asked was why are
organizations interested in big data and
some of you might have already answered
or thought about that organizations are
interested in doing precise analysis or
they want to work on different formats
of data such as structured unstructured
semi-structured data organizations are
interested in gaining insights or
finding the hidden treasure in the
so-called big data and this is the main
reason where organizations are
interested in big data now there are
various use cases there are various use
cases we can compare that organizations
from past 50 or more than 50 years have
been handling huge amount of data they
have been working on huge volume of data
but the question here is have they
worked on all the data or have they
worked on some portion of it what have
they used to store this data and if they
have used something to store this data
what is happening what is what is
changing now when we talk about the
businesses we cannot avoid talking about
the dynamism involved now any
organization would want to have a
solution which allows them to store data
and store huge amount of data capture it
process it analyze it and also look into
the data to give more value to the data
organizations have then been looking for
solutions now let's look at some facts
that can convince you or that would
convince you that data is exploding and
needs your attention right 55 billion
messages and 4.5 billion photos are sent
each day on whatsapp 300 hours of video
are uploaded every minute on youtube did
you guys know that youtube is the second
largest search engine after google every
minute users send
31.25 million messages and watch 2.77
million videos on facebook walmart
handles more than 1 million customer
transactions every hour google 40 000
search queries are performed on google
per second that is 3.46 million searches
a day in fact you could also say that a
lot of times people when they are
loading up the google page is basically
just to check their internet connection
however that is also generating data idc
reports that by 2025 real-time data will
be more than a quarter of all the data
and by 2025 the volume of digital data
will increase to 163 zeta bytes that is
we are not even talking about gigabytes
or terabytes anymore we are talking
about petabytes exabytes and zeta bytes
and zeta bytes means 10 to the power 21
bytes so this is how data has evolved
now you can talk about different
companies which would want to use their
data to take business decisions they
would want to collect the data store it
and analyze it and that's how they would
be interested in drawing insights for
the business now this is just a simple
example about facebook and what it does
to work on the data now before we go to
facebook you could always check in
google by just typing in companies using
big data and if we say companies using
big data we should be able to find a
list of different companies which are
using big data for different use cases
there are various sources from where you
can find we could also search for
solution that is hadoop which we'll
discuss later but you could always say
companies using hadoop and that should
take you to the wiki page which will
basically help you know what are the
different companies which are using this
so so-called solution called hadoop okay
now coming back to what we were
discussing about so organizations are
interested in big data as we discussed
in gaining insights they would want to
use the data to find hidden information
which probably they ignored earlier now
take an example of rdbms what is biggest
drawback in using an rdbms now you might
think that rdbms is known for stability
and consistency and organizations would
be interested in storing their data in
oracle or db2 or mysql or microsoft sql
server and they have been doing that for
many years now so what has changed now
now when we talk about rdbms the first
question which i would ask is do we have
access to 100 of data being online in
rdbms the answer is no we would only
have 10 or 20 or 30 percent of data
online and rest of the data would be
archived which means that if an
organization is interested in working on
all the data they would have to move the
data from the archived storage to the
processing layer and that would involve
bandwidth consumption now this is one of
the biggest drawbacks of rdbms you do
not have access to 100 of data online in
many of the cases organizations started
realizing that the data which they were
ignoring as being uneconomical had
hidden value which they had never
exploited i had read a presentation
somewhere which said torture the data
and it will confess to anything now
that's the value of data which
organizations have realized in recent
past take an example of facebook now
this shows what facebook does with its
big data and we'll come to what is big
data but let's understand the use case
now facebook collects huge volumes of
user data whether that is sms whether
that is likes whether that is
advertisements whether that is features
which people are liking or photographs
or even user profiles now by collecting
this data and providing a portal which
people can use to connect facebook is
also accumulating huge volume of data
and that's way beyond petabytes they
would also be interested in analyzing
this data and one of the reasons would
be they would want to personalize the
experience take an example of
personalized news feed depending on a
user behavior depending on what a user
likes what a user would want to know
about they can recommend a personalized
news feed to every particular user
that's just one example of what facebook
does with its data take an example of
photo tag suggestions now when you log
into facebook account you could also get
suggestions on different friends whom
you would like to connect to or you
would want to tag so that they could be
known by others some more examples which
show how facebook uses its data are as
follows so the flashback collection of
photos and posts that receive the most
comments and likes okay there was
something called as i voted that was
used for 2016 elections with reminders
and directions to tell users their time
and place of polling also something
called as safety checks in incidents
such as earthquake hurricane or mass
shooting facebook gives you safety
checks now these are some examples where
facebook is using big data and that
brings us to the question what is big
data this was just an example where we
discussed about one company which is
making use of that data which has been
accumulated and it's not only for
companies which are social media
oriented like facebook where data is
important take an example of ibm take an
example of jpmorgan chase take an
example of ge or any other organization
which is collecting huge amount of data
they would all want to gather insights
they would want to analyze the data they
would want to be more precise in
building their services or solutions
which can take care of their customers
so what is big data big data is
basically a term it is used to describe
the data that is too large and complex
to store in traditional databases and as
i gave an example it's not just about
storing the data it is also about what
you can do with the data it also means
that if there is a lot of dynamism
involved can you change the underlying
storage and handle any kind of data that
comes in now before we get into that
let's just understand what is big data
so big data is basically a term which
has been given to categorize the data if
it has different characteristics
organizations would want to have the big
data stored processed and then analyzed
to get whatever useful information they
can get from this data now there are
five v's of big data volume velocity
variety value velocity although these
are five v's but then there are other
v's which also categorize the data as
big data such as volatility validity
viscosity virality of data okay so these
are five v's of big data and if the data
has one or all of these characteristics
then it can be considered as big data
including the other ways which i just
mentioned so volume basically means
incredible amount of data huge volumes
of data data generated every second now
that could be used for batch processing
that could be used for real-time stream
processing okay you might have data
being generated from different kind of
devices like your cell phones your
social media websites online
transactions variable devices servers
and these days with iot we are also
talking about data of getting generated
via internet of things that is you could
have different devices which could be
communicating to each other you could be
getting data from radars or leaders or
even camera sensors so there is a huge
volume of data which is getting
generated and if we are talking about
data which has huge volume which is
getting generated constantly or has been
accumulated over a period of time we
would say that is big data velocity now
this is one more important aspect of big
data speed with which the data is
getting generated think about stock
markets think about social media
websites think about online surveys or
marketing campaigns or airline industry
so if the data is getting generated with
a lot of speed where it becomes
difficult to capture collect process
cure
mine or analyze the data then we are
certainly talking about big data the
next aspect of big data is variety now
this is where we talk about structured
data semi-structured data or
unstructured data and here i would like
to ask a question what is the difference
when do you call the data is structured
semi-structured or unstructured now
let's look at an example before we
theoretically discuss about this i
always would like to use some examples
let's look at a log file and let's see
what is it so if i look at this log file
and if i would say what kind of data is
this which is the highlighted one the
answer would be
it is structured data it has specific
delimiters such as space it has data
which is separated by space and if i had
a hundred or thousand or million rows
which had similar kind of data i could
certainly store that in a table i could
have a predefined schema to store this
data so i would call the one which is
highlighted and structured but if i look
at this portion where i would look at a
combination of this kind of data where
some data has a pattern and some data
doesn't now this is an example of
semi-structured data so if i would have
a predefined structure to store this
data probably the pattern of data would
break the structure and if i look at all
the data then i would certainly call it
unstructured data because there is no
clear schema which can define this data
now this is what i mean by variety of
data that is structured data which
basically has a schema or has a format
which could be easily understood you
have semi-structured which could be like
an xml or json or even your excel sheets
where you could have some data which is
structured and the other is unstructured
and when we talk about unstructured we
are talking about absence of schema it
does not have a format it does not have
a schema and it is hard to analyze which
brings its own challenges the next
aspect is value now value refers to the
ability to turn your data useful for
business you would have lot of data
which is being collected as we mentioned
in previous slides right there would be
lot of data wrangling or data
pre-processing or cleaning up of data
happening and then finally you would
want to draw value from that data but
from all the data collected what
percentage of data gives us value and if
all my data can give me value then why
wouldn't i use it this is an aspect of
big data right veracity now this means
the quality of data billions of dollars
are lost every year by organizations
because the data which was collected was
not of good quality or probably they
collected a lot of data and then it was
erroneous take an example of autonomous
driving projects which are
happening in europe or u.s where there
are car fleets which are on the road
collecting data via radar sensors and
camera sensors and when this data has to
be processed to train algorithms it has
realized that sometimes the data which
was collected was missing in some values
might be was not appropriate or had a
lot of errors and all this process of
collecting the data becomes a repetitive
task because the quality of data was not
good this is just one example we can
take example from healthcare industry or
stock markets or financial institutions
and so on so extracting loads of data is
not useful if the data is messy or poor
in quality and that basically means that
velocity is a very important v of big
data now apart from veracity volume
variety velocity and value we have the
other v such as viscosity how dense the
data is
validity is the data still valid
volatility is my data volatile or
virality is the data viral now all of
these different v's categorize the data
as big data now here we would like to
talk on a big data case study and we
have taken an example of google which
obviously is one of the companies which
is
churning and working on huge amount of
data now it's actually said that if you
compare one grain of sand with one byte
of data then google is processing or
google is handling whole worlds sand
every week that is the kind of data
which google is processing now in early
2000 and since then when the number of
internet users started growing google
also faced lot of problems in storing
increasing user data and
using the traditional servers to manage
that now that was a challenge which
google started facing could they use
traditional data server to store the
data well yes they could right storage
devices have been getting cheaper day by
day but then how much time does it take
to retrieve that data what is the seek
time what is the time taken to read and
process that data thousands of search
queries were raised per second no doubt
now we could say millions and billions
of queries are raised per second every
query read 100 mbs
of data and consumed tens of billions of
cpu cycles based on these queries so the
requirement was that they wanted to have
a large
distributed highly fault tolerant file
system large to store to capture process
huge amount of data distributed because
they could not rely just on one server
even if that had multiple disks stacked
up that was not an efficient choice what
would happen if this particular machine
failed what would happen if the whole
server was down so they needed a
distributed storage and a distributed
computing environment they needed
something which can be highly fault
tolerant right so this was the
requirement which google had and the
solution which came out as a result was
gfs google file system now let's look at
how gfs works so normally in any
particular linux system or linux server
you would have a file system you would
have set of processes you would have set
up files and directories which could
store the data gfs was different so to
facilitate gfs which could store huge
amount of data there was an architecture
an architecture which had one master and
multiple chunk servers or you could say
slave servers or slave machines
master machine was
to contain metadata was to contain data
about data when we say metadata we are
talking about information about data and
then you have the chung servers or the
slave machines which could be storing
data in a distributed fashion now any
client or an api or an application which
would want to read the data would first
contact the master server it would
contact the machine where the master
process was running and client would
place a request of reading the data or
showing an interest of reading the data
internally what it is doing is it is
requesting for metadata your api or an
application would want to know from
where it can read the data master server
which has metadata whether that is in
ram or disk we can discuss that later
but then master server would have the
metadata and it would know which are the
chunk servers or the slave machines
where the data was stored in a
distributed fashion master would respond
back with the metadata information to
the client and then client could use
that information to read or write to
these slave machines where actually the
data was stored now this is what the
process or set of processes work
together to make gfs so when you say a
chunk server we would basically have the
files getting divided into fixed size
chunks now how would they get divided so
there would be some kind of chunk size
or a block size which would determine
that if the file is bigger than the
pre-decided chunk size then it would be
split into smaller chunks and be
distributed across the chunk servers or
the slave machines if the file was
smaller then it would still use one
chunk or a block to get stored on the
underlying slave machines so these junk
servers or slave machines are the ones
which actually store the data on local
disks as your linux files client which
is interacting with master for metadata
and then interacting with chunk servers
for read write operations would be the
one which would be externally connecting
to the cluster so this is how it would
look so you have a master which would
obviously be receiving some kind of
heartbeats from the chunk servers to
know their status and receive
information in the form of packets which
would let the master know which machines
were available for storage which
machines already had data and master
would build up the metadata within
itself the files would be broken down
into chunks for example we can look at
file one it is broken down into chunk
one and chunk two and file two has one
chunk which is one portion of it and
then you have file two residing on some
other chunk server which also lets us
know that there is some kind of auto
replication for this file system right
and the data which is getting stored in
the chunk could have a data of 64 mb now
that chunk size could be changed based
on the data size but google file system
had the basic size of the chunk as 64 mb
each chunk would be replicated on
multiple servers the default replication
was 3 and that could again be increased
or decreased as per requirement this
would also mean that if a particular
slave machine or a chunk server would
die or would get killed or would crash
there would never be any data loss
because a replica of data residing on
the failed machine would still be
available on some other slave server
chunk server or slave machine now this
helped google to store and process huge
volumes of data in a distributed manner
and does have a fault tolerant
distributed scalable storage which could
allow them to store a huge amount of
data now that was just one example which
actually led to the solution which today
we call as hadoop now when we talk about
big data here i would like to ask you
some questions that if we were talking
about the rdbms case take an example of
something like nasa which was working on
a project called set eye search of
extraterrestrial intelligence now this
was a project where they were looking
for a solution to take care of their
problem the problem was that they would
roughly send some waves in space capture
those waves back and then analyze this
data to find if there was any
extraterrestrial object in space now
they had two options for it they could
either have a huge server built which
could take care of storing the data and
processing it or they could go for
volunteer computing now volunteer
computing basically means that you could
have a lot of people volunteering and
being part of this project and what they
would in turn do is they would be
donating their ram and storage from
their machines when they are not using
it how would that happen basically
download some kind of patch on their
machine which would run as a screen
saver and if the user is not using his
machine some portion of data could be
transferred to these machines for
intermittent storage and processing
using ram now this sounds very
interesting and this sounds very easy
however it would have its own challenges
right think about security think about
integrity but those those problems are
not bigger as much as is the requirement
of bandwidth and this is the same thing
which happens in rdbms if you would have
to move data from archived solution to
the processing layer that would consume
huge amount of bandwidth big data brings
its own challenges
huge amount of data is getting generated
every day now the biggest challenge is
storing this huge volume of data and
especially when this data is getting
generated with a lot of variety where it
can have different kind of formats where
it could be viral it could be having a
lot of value and nobody has looked into
the veracity of data but the primary
problem would be handling this huge
volume of data variety of the data would
bring in challenges of storing it in
legacy systems if processing of the data
was required now here again i would
suggest you need to think what is the
difference between reading a data and
processing a data so reading might just
mean bringing in the data from disk and
doing some io operations and processing
would mean reading the data probably
doing some transformations on it
extracting some useful information from
it and then storing it in the same
format or probably in a different format
so processing this massive volume of
data is the second challenge
organizations don't just store their big
data they would eventually want to use
it to process it to gather some insights
now processing and extracting insights
from big data would take huge amount of
time unless and until there was an
efficient solution to handle and process
this big data securing the data that's
again a concern for organizations right
encryption of big data is difficult to
perform if you would think about
different compression mechanisms then
that would also mean decompressing of
data which would also mean that you
could take a hit on the cpu cycles or on
disk usage providing user authentication
for every team member now that could
also be dangerous so that
led to hadoop as a solution so big data
brings its own challenges big data
brings its own benefits and here we have
a solution which is hadoop now what is
hadoop it's an open source framework for
storing data and running applications on
clusters of commodity hardware hadoop is
an open source framework and before we
discuss on two main components of hadoop
it would be good to look into the link
which i was suggesting earlier that is
companies using hadoop and any person
who would be interested in learning big
data should start somewhere here where
you could list down different companies
what kind of setup they have why are
they having hadoop what kind of
processing they are doing and how are
they using these so called hadoop
clusters to process and in fact store
capture and process huge amount of data
another link which i would suggest is
looking at different distributions
of hadoop any person who is interested
in learning in big data should know
about different distributions of hadoop
now in linux we have different
distributions like ubuntu centos red hat
susie debian in the same way you have
different distributions of hadoop which
we can look on the wiki page and this is
the link which talks about products that
include apache hadoop or derivative
works and commercial support which
basically means that apache hadoop the
sole products that can be called a
release of apache hadoop come from
apache.org that's an open source
community and then you have various
vendor-specific distributions like
amazon web services you have cloud era
you have hortonworks you have ibm's big
inside you have mapper all these are
different distributions of hadoop so
basically all of these vendor-specific
distributions are depending on using on
core apache hadoop in brief we can say
that these are the vendors which take up
the apache hadoop package it within a
cluster management solution so that
users who intend to use apache hadoop
would not have difficulties of setting
up a cluster setting up a framework they
could just use a vendor-specific
distribution with its cluster
installation solutions cluster
management solution and easily plan
deploy install and manage your cluster
let's rewind to the days before the
world turned digital
back then miniscule amounts of data were
generated at a relatively sluggish pace
all the data was mostly documents and in
the form of rows and columns storing or
processing this data wasn't much trouble
as a single storage unit and processor
combination would do the job but as
years passed by the internet took the
world by storm giving rise to tons of
data generated in a multitude of forms
and formats every microsecond
semi-structured and unstructured data
was available now in the form of emails
images audio and video to name a few
all this data became collectively known
as big data
although fascinating it became nearly
impossible to handle this big data and a
storage unit processor combination was
obviously not enough
so what was the solution
multiple storage units and processors
were undoubtedly the need of the hour
this concept was incorporated in the
framework of hadoop that could store and
process vast amounts of any data
efficiently using a cluster of commodity
hardware hadoop consisted of three
components that were specifically
designed to work on big data in order to
capitalize on data the first step is
storing it the first component of hadoop
is its storage unit the hadoop
distributed file system or hdfs
storing massive data on one computer is
unfeasible hence data is distributed
amongst many computers and stored in
blocks
so if you have 600 megabytes of data to
be stored hdfs splits the data into
multiple blocks of data that are then
stored on several data nodes in the
cluster 128 megabytes is the default
size of each block
hence 600 megabytes will be split into
four blocks a b c and d of 128 megabytes
each and the remaining 88 megabytes in
the last block e
so now you might be wondering what if
one data node crashes
do we lose that specific piece of data
well
no that's the beauty of hdfs
hdfs makes copies of the data and stores
it across multiple systems
for example when block a is created it
is replicated with a replication factor
of three and stored on different data
nodes
this is termed the replication method by
doing so data is not lost at any cost
even if one data node crashes making
hdfs fault tolerant after storing the
data successfully it needs to be
processed this is where the second
component of hadoop mapreduce comes into
play
in the traditional data processing
method entire data would be processed on
a single machine having a single
processor this consumed time and was
inefficient especially when processing
large volumes of a variety of data to
overcome this mapreduce splits data into
parts and processes each of them
separately on different data nodes
the individual results are then
aggregated to give the final output
let's try to count the number of
occurrences of words taking this example
first the input is split into five
separate parts based on full stops the
next step is the mapper phase where the
occurrence of each word is counted and
allocated a number
after that depending on the words
similar words are shuffled sorted and
grouped following which in the reducer
phase all the grouped words are given
account
finally the output is displayed by
aggregating the results all this is done
by writing a simple program
similarly mapreduce processes each part
of big data individually and then sums
the result at the end
this improves load balancing and saves a
considerable amount of time
now that we have our mapreduce job ready
it is time for us to run it on the
hadoop cluster
this is done with the help of a set of
resources such as ram network bandwidth
and cpu
multiple jobs are run on hadoop
simultaneously and each of them needs
some resources to complete the task
successfully
to efficiently manage these resources we
have the third component of hadoop which
is yarn
yet another resource negotiator or yarn
consists of a resource manager node
manager application master and
containers the resource manager assigns
resources node managers handle the nodes
and monitor the resource usage in the
node the containers hold a collection of
physical resources
suppose we want to process the mapreduce
job we had created
first the application master requests
the container from the node manager
once the node manager gets the resources
it sends them to the resource manager
this way yarn processes job requests and
manages cluster resources in hadoop
in addition to these components hadoop
also has various big data tools and
frameworks dedicated to managing
processing and analyzing data the hadoop
ecosystem comprises several other
components like hive pig apache spark
flume and scoop to name a few
the hadoop ecosystem works together on
big data management before we dive into
the technical side of hadoop we're going
to take a little detour to try to give
you a visual understanding and relate it
to maybe a more life setup and we're
going to go to the farm in this case so
we have in a farm far away i almost wish
they'd put far far away it does remind
me a little bit of a star wars theme so
we're going to look at fruit at a farm
we have jack who harvests his grapes and
then sells it in the nearby town after
harvesting he stores his produce in a
storage shed or a storage room in this
case we found out though is there was a
high demand for other fruits so he
started harvesting apples and oranges as
well hopefully he has a couple fills
with these different fruit trees growing
and he set up there and you can see that
he's working hard to harvest all these
different fruits but he has a problem
here because there's only one of him so
he can't really do more work so what he
needs to do then is hire two more people
to work with him with this harvesting is
done simultaneously so instead of him
trying to harvest all this different
fruit he now has two more people in
there who are putting their food away
and harvesting it for them now the
storage room becomes a bottleneck to
store and access all the fruits in a
single storage area so they can't fit
all the fruit in one place so jack
decides to distribute the storage area
and give each one of them a separate
storage and you can look at this
computer terms we have our people that
are the processors we have our fruit
that's a data and you can see it's
storing it in the different storage
rooms so you can see me popping up there
getting my hello i want fruit basket of
three grapes two apples and three
oranges i'm getting ready for a
breakfast with family a little large
family my family's not that large to
complete the order on time all of them
work parallelly with their own storage
space so here we have a process of
retrieving or querying the data and you
can see from the one storage space he
pulls out three grapes she pulls out two
apples and then another storage room he
pulls out three oranges and we complete
a nice fruit basket and this solution
helps them to complete the order on time
without any hassle all of them are happy
and they're prepared for an increase in
demand in the future so they now have
this growth system where you can just
keep hiring on new people they can
continue to grow and develop a very
large farm so how does this story relate
to big data and i hinted at that a
little bit earlier the limited data only
one processor one storage unit was
needed i remember back in the 90s they
would just upgrade the computer instead
of having a small computer you would
then spend money for a huge mainframe
with all the flashing lights on it then
the cray computers were really massive
nowadays a lot of the computers that
sits on our desktop are powerful as the
mainframes they had back then so it's
pretty amazing how time has changed but
used to be able to do everything on one
computer and you had structured data and
a database you stored your structured
data in so most of the time you're
acquiring databases sql queries just
think of it as a giant spreadsheet with
rows and columns where everything has a
very specific size and fits neatly in
that rows and columns and back in the
90s this was a nice setup you just
upgraded your computer you would get
yourself a nice big sun computer or
mainframe if you had a lot of data and a
lot of stuff going on and it was very
easy to do soon though the data
generation increased leading to high
volume of data along with different data
formats and so you can imagine in
today's world this year we will generate
more data than all the previous years
summed together we will generate more
data just this year than all the
previous years some together and that's
the way it's been going for some time
and you can see we have a variety of
data we have our structured data which
is what we're you think about a database
with rows and columns and easy to look
at nice spreadsheet we have our
semi-structured data they have emails as
an example here that would be one
example your xml your html web pages and
we have unstructured data if you ever
look through your folder on photos i
have photos that were taken on my phone
with high quality i've got photos from a
long time ago i got web photos low
quality so just in my pictures alone
none of them are the same you know there
certainly are groups of them that are
but overall there are a lot of variety
in size and setup so a single processor
was not enough to process such high
volume of different kinds of data as it
was very time consuming you can imagine
that if you are twitter with millions of
twitter feeds you're not going to be
able to do a query across one server
there's just no way that's going to
happen unless people don't mind waiting
a year to get the history of their
tweets or look something up hence we
start doing multiple processors so
they're used to process high volume of
data and this saved time so we're moving
forward we got multiple processors the
single storage unit became the
bottleneck due to which network overhead
was generated so now you have your
network coming in and each one of these
servers has to wait before it can grab
the data from the
single stored unit maybe you have a sql
server there with a nice setup or a file
system going the solution was to use
distributed storage for each processor
this enabled easy access to storage and
access to data so this makes a lot of
sense you have multiple workers multiple
storage units just like we had our
storage room and the different fruit
coming in your variety you can see that
nice parallel to working on a farm now
we're dealing with a lot of data it's
all about the data now this method
worked and there were no network
overhead generated you're not getting a
bottleneck somewhere where people are
just waiting for data being pulled or
being processed this is known as
parallel processing with distributed
storage so parallel processing
distributed storage and you can see here
the parallel processing is your
different computers running the
processes and distributed storage here
is a quick demo on setting up cloudera
quick start vm in case you are
interested in working on a standalone
cluster you can download the cloudera
quick start vm so you can just type in
download cloudera quick start vm and you
can search for package now this can be
used to set up a quick start vm which
would be a single node cloudera based
cluster so you can click on this link
and then basically based on the platform
which you would be choosing to install
such as using a vm box or which version
of cloudera you would install so here i
can select a platform so i can choose
box and then you can click on get it now
so give your details and basically then
it should allow you to download the
quick start vm which would look
something like this and once you have
the zip file which is downloaded you can
unzip it which can then be used to set
up a single node cloud error cluster so
once you have downloaded the zip file
that would look something like this so
you would have a quick start virtual box
and then a virtual boss disk now this
can be used to set up a cluster ignore
these files which are related to amazon
machines and we you don't need to have
that so you would just have this and
this can be used to set up a cloud error
cluster so for this to be set up you can
click on file import appliance and here
you can choose your quick start vm by
looking into downloads quick start vm
select this and click on open now you
can click on next and that shows you the
specifications of cpu ram which we can
then change later and click on import
this will start importing virtual disk
image dot vmdk file into your vm box
once this is done we will have to change
the specifications or machines to use
two cpu cores minimum and give a little
more ram because cloudera quickstart vm
is very cpu intensive and it needs good
amount of ram so to survive i will give
two cpu cores and 5gb ram and that
should be enough for us to bring up a
quick start vm which gives us a cloudera
distribution of hadoop in a single node
cluster setup which can be used for
working learning about different
distributions in cloudera clusters
working with sdfs and other hadoop
ecosystem components let's just wait for
this importing to finish and then we
will go ahead and set up a quick start
vm for our practice here the importing
of appliance is done and we see cloudera
quickstart machine is added to my list
of machines i can click on this and
click on settings as mentioned i would
like to give it more ram and more cpu
cores so click on system and here let's
increase the ram to at least
five and click on processor and let's
give it two cpu cores which would at
least be better than using one cpu core
network it goes for nat and that's fine
click on ok and we would want to start
this machine so that it uses two cpu
cores 5gb ram and it should bring up my
cloudera quick start vm now let's go
ahead and start this machine which has
our quick start vm it might take
initially some time to start up because
internally there will be various
cloudera services which will be starting
up and those services need to be up for
our cloud era quick start vm to be
accessible so unlike your apache hadoop
cluster where we start our cluster and
we will be starting all our processes in
case of cloudera it is your cloudera scm
server and agents which take care of
starting up of your services and
starting up of your different roles for
those services i explained in my
previous session that for a cloud era
cluster it would be these services let
me just show you that so in case of
apache cluster we start our services
that is we start our cluster by running
script and then basically those scripts
will individually start the different
processes on different nodes in case of
cloud era we would always have a
cloudera scm server which would be
running on one machine and then
including that machine we would have
clouded icm agents which would be
running on multiple machines similarly
if we had a hortonworks cluster we would
have ambari server starting up on the
first machine and then embody agents
running on other machines so your server
component knows what are the services
which are set up what are their
configurations and agents running on
every node are responsible to send
heartbeats to the server receive
instructions and then take care of
starting and stopping off of individual
roles on different machines in case of
our single node cluster setup in quick
start vm we would just have one scm
server and one scm agent which will
start on the machine which will then
take care of all the roles which need to
be started for your different services
so we will just wait for our machine to
come up and basically have cloud sem
server and agent running and once we
have that we need to follow few steps so
that we can have the cloudera admin
console accessible which allows you to
browse the cluster look at different
services look at the roles for different
services and also work with your cluster
either using command line or using the
web interface that is
now that my machine has come up and it
already is connected to the internet
which we can see here we need to do
certain things so that we can have our
admin console accessible at this point
of time you can click on terminal and
check if you have access to the cluster
so here type in host name and that shows
you your host name which is
quickstart.cloudera we can also type in
hdfs command to see if we have access
and if my cluster is working these
commands are same as you would give them
in a apache hadoop cluster or in any
other distribution of a loop sometimes
when your cluster is up and you have
access to the terminal it might take few
seconds or few minutes before there is a
connection established between cloudera
cm server and cloudera cm agent running
in the background which takes care of
your cluster i have given a sdfs dfs
list command which basically should show
me what by default exists on my sdfs
let's just give it a couple of seconds
before it shows us the output we can
also check by giving a service cloudera
scm server status and here it tells me
that if you would want to use cloudera
express free run this command it needs 8
gb of ram and it leads to virtual cpu
cores and it also mentions it may take
several minutes before cloudera manager
has started i can login as root here and
then give the command service cloud
error scm server status remember the
password for root is cloudera so it
basically says that if you would want to
check the settings it is good to have
express edition running so we can close
this my sdfs access is working fine
let's close the terminal and here we
have launch cloud error express click on
this and that will give you that you
need to give a command which is force
let's copy this command let's open a
different terminal and let's give this
command like this which will then go
ahead and shut down your cloudera based
services and then it will restart it
only after which you will be able to
access your admin console so let's just
give it a couple of minutes before it
does this and then we will have access
to our admin console here if you see it
is starting the cloudera manager server
again it is waiting for cloudera manager
api then starting the cloudera manager
agents and then configuring the
deployment as per the new settings which
we have given as to use the express
edition of cloudera once all this is
done it will say the cluster has been
restarted and the admin console can be
accessed by id and password as cloudera
we'll give it a couple of more minutes
and once this is done we are ready to
use our admin console now that
deployment has been configured client
configurations have also been deployed
and it has restarted the cloudera
management service it gives you an
access to quick start admin console
using username and password as cloud
error let's try accessing it so we can
open up the browser here and let's
change this to 7180
that's the default port and that shows
the admin console which is coming up now
here we can log in as cloud error cloud
error and then let's click on login now
as i said cloudera is very cpu intensive
and memory intensive so it would slow
down since we have not given enough gb
ram to our cloud error cluster and thus
it will be advisable to stop or even
remove the services which we don't need
now as of now if we look at the services
all of them look in a stop status and
that's good in one way because we can
then go ahead and remove the services
which we will not use in the beginning
and later we can anytime add services to
the cluster so for example i can click
on key value store here and then i can
scroll down where it says delete to
remove this service from the admin
console now anytime you are removing a
particular service it will only remove
the service from the management by
cloudera manager all the role groups
under this service will be removed from
host templates so we can click on delete
now if this service was depending on
some other service it would have
prompted me with a message that remove
the relevant services on which this
particular service depends if the
service was already running then it
would have given me a message that the
service has to be stopped before it can
be deleted from the cloudera admin
console now this is my admin console
which allows you to click on services
look at the different roles and
processes which are running for this
service we anyways have access to our
cloudera cluster from the terminal using
our regular sdfs or yarn or maplet
commands now i removed a service i will
also remove solar which we will not be
using for the beginning but then it
depends on your choice so we can here
scroll down to delete it and that says
that before deleting the solar service
you must remove the dependencies on the
service from the configuration of
following services that is hue now hue
is a web interface which allows you to
work with your sdfs and that is
depending on this so click on configure
service dependency and here we can make
sure that our hue service does not
depend on a particular service we are
removing so that then we can have a
clean removal of the service so i'll
click on none and i will say save
changes once this is done then we can go
ahead and try removing the solar service
from our admin console which will reduce
some load on my management console which
will also allow me to work faster on my
cluster now here we have removed the
dependency of hue on solar so we can
click on this and then we can delete it
remember i'm only doing this so that my
cluster becomes little lighter and i can
work on my focus services at any point
of time if you want to add more services
to your cluster you can anytime do that
you can fix different configuration
issues like what we see here with
different warning messages and here we
have these services which are already
existing now if we don't need any of the
service i can click on the drop down and
click on delete again this says that
scoop 2 also has
relevance to hue so hue as a web
interface also depends on scope 2. as of
now we'll make it none at any point of
time later you can add the services by
clicking the add service option now this
is a cluster to which you have admin
access and this is a quick start vm
which gives you a single node cloud
error cluster which you can use for
learning and practicing so here we will
click on scope 2 and then we will say
delete as we have configured the
dependency now and we will remove scope
2 also from the list of services which
your admin console is managing right so
once this is done we have removed three
services which we did not need we can
even remove scope as a client and if we
need we can add that later now there are
various other alerts which your cloudera
admin console shows and we can always
fix them by clicking on the health
issues or configuration issues we can
click here and see what is the health
issue it is pointing to if that is a
critical one or if that can be ignored
so it says there is an issue with a
clock offset which basically relates to
an ntp service network time protocol
which makes sure that one or multiple
machines are in the same time zone and
are in sync so for now we can click on
suppress and we can just say suppress
for all hosts and we can say look into
it later and confirm so now we will not
have that health issue reported that
probably the ntp service and the
machines might not be in sync now that
does not have an impact for our use case
as of now but if we have a kerberos kind
of setup which is for security then
basically this offset and time zone
becomes important so we can ignore this
message and we are still good to use the
cluster we also have other configuration
issues and you can click on this which
might talk about the heap size or the
ram which is available for machines it
talks about zookeeper should be in odd
numbers q does not have a load balancer
sdfs only has one data node but all of
these issues are not to be worried upon
because this is a single node cluster
setup so if you want to avoid all of
these warnings you can always click on
suppress and you can avoid and let your
cluster be in all green status but
that's nothing to worry so we can click
on cluster and basically we can look at
the services so we have removed some
services which we don't intend to use
now i have also suppressed a offset
warning which is not very critical for
my use case and basically i am good to
start the cluster at any point of time
as i said if you would want to add
services this is the actions button
which you can use to add service so we
will just say restart my cluster which
will restart all the services one by one
starting from zookeeper as the first
service to come up we can always click
on this arrow mark and see what is
happening in the services what services
are coming up and in which order if you
have any issues you can always click on
the link next to it which will take you
to the logs and we can click on close to
let it happen in the background so this
will basically let my services restart
one by one and my cluster will then
become completely accessible either
using hue as a web interface or quick
start terminal which allows you to give
your commands now while my machines are
coming up you can click on hosts and you
can have a look at all the hosts we have
as of now only one which will also tell
you how many roles or processes are
running on this machine so that is 25
rolls it tells you what is the disk
usage it tells you what is the physical
memory being used and using this host
tab we can add new host to the cluster
we can check the configuration we can
check all the hosts in diagnostics you
can look at the logs which will give you
access to all the logs you can even
select the sources from which you would
want to have the logs or you can give
the host name you can click on search
you can build your own charts you can
also do the admin stuff by adding
different users or enabling security
using the administration tab so since we
have clicked on restart of a cluster we
will slowly start seeing all the
services one by one coming up starting
with zookeeper to begin with and once we
have our cluster up and running whether
that is showing all services in green or
in a different status we still should be
able to access the service now as we saw
in apache hadoop cluster even here we
can click on sdfs and we can access the
web ui once our sdfs service is up by
clicking on quick links so the service
is not yet up once it is up we should be
able to see the web ui link which will
allow you to check things from sdfs web
interface similarly yarn as a service
also has a web interface so as soon as
the service comes up under your quick
links we will have access to the yarn ui
and similarly once the service comes up
we will have access to hue which will
give you the web interface which allows
you to work with your sdfs which allows
you to work with your different other
components within the cluster without
even using the command line tools or
command line options so we will have to
give it some time while the cloud error
scm agent on every machine will be able
to restart the roles which are
responsible for your cluster to come up
we can always click here with tells that
there are some running commands in the
background which are trying to start my
cluster we can go to the terminal and we
can switch as hdfs user remember sdfs
user is the admin user and it does not
have a password unless you have set one
so you can just log in as sdfs which
might ask you for a password initially
which we do not have so the best way to
do this is by logging in as root where
the password is cloud error and then you
can log in as hdfs so that then onwards
you can give your sdfs commands to work
with your file system now since my
services are coming up right now when i
try to give a sdfs dfs command it might
not work or it might also say that it is
trying to connect to the name node which
is not up yet so we will have to give it
some time and only once the name node is
up we will be able to access our sdfs
using commands so this is how you can
quickly set up your quick start and then
you can be working using the command
line options from the terminal like what
you would do in apache hadoop cluster
you could use the web interfaces which
allow you to work with your cluster now
this usually takes more time so you will
have to give it some time before your
services are up and running and for any
reason if you have issues it might
require you to restart your cluster
several times in the beginning before it
gets accustomed to the settings what you
have given and it starts up the services
at any point of time if you have any
error message then you can always go
back and look in logs and see what is
happening and try starting your cluster
so this is how we set up a quick start
vm and you can be using this to work
with your cloud error clusters we'll
start with the big data challenges and
the first thing with the big data is you
can see here we have a nice chaotic
image with all these different inputs
server racks all over the place graphs
being generated just about everything
you can imagine and so the problems that
come up with big data is one storing it
how do you store this massive amount of
data and we're not talking about a
terabyte or 10 terabytes we're talking a
minimal of 10 terabytes up to petabytes
of data and then the next question is
processing and so the two go hand in
hand because when you're storing the
data that might take up a huge amount of
space or you might have a small amount
of data that takes a lot of processing
and so either one will drive a series of
data or processing into the big data
arena so with storing data storing big
data was a problem due to its massive
volume just straight up people would
have huge backup tapes and then you'd
have to go through the backup tapes for
hours to go find your data and a simple
query could take days and then
processing processing big data consumed
more time and so the hadoop came up with
a cheap way to process the data it used
to be like i've had some processes that
if i ran on my computer without trying
to use multiple cores and multiple
threads would take years to process just
a simple data analysis can get that
heavy in the data processing and so
processing can be as big of a problem as
the size of the data itself so hadoop as
a solution this is the solution to big
data and big data storage storing big
data was a problem due to its massive
volume so we take the hadoop file system
or the hdfs and now we're able to store
huge data across a large number of
machines and access it like this one
file system and processing big data
consumed more time we talked about some
processes you can't even do on your
computer because it would take years now
the hadoop with the map reduce
processing big data was faster and i'm
going to add a little notation right
here that's really important to note
that hadoop is the beginning when we
talk about data processing they've added
new processes on top of the map reduce
that even accelerate it your spark setup
and some other different functionalities
but really the basis of all of it where
it all starts with the most basic
concept is your hadoop mapreduce let us
now look into the hdfs in detail in the
traditional approach all the data was
stored in a single central database with
the rise of big data a single database
was not enough for storage and i
remember the old sun computers or the
huge ibm machines with all the flashing
lights now all the data on one of those
can be stored on your phone it's almost
a bit of humor how much this has
accelerated over the years the same
thing with our rise of big data no
longer can you just store it on one
machine no longer can you go out and buy
a sun computer and put it on that one
sun computer no more can you buy a craig
machine or an enterprise ibm server it's
not going to work you're not going to
fit it all into one server the solution
was to use distributed approach to store
the massive amount of data data was
divided and distributed amongst many
individual databases and you can see
here where we have three different
databases going on so you might actually
saw this in one where they divided up
the user accounts a through g so on by
the letter and so the first query would
say what's the first letter of this uh
whatever id it was and then it would go
into that database to find it so i had a
database telling it which database to
look for stuff that was a long time ago
and to be honest it didn't work really
well nowadays so that was a distributed
database you'd have to track which
database you put it in so what is hdfs
hadoop distributed file system hdfs is a
specially designed file system for
storing huge data sets in commodity
hardware and commodities an interesting
term because i mentioned enterprise
versus commodity and i'll touch back
upon that it has two core components
name node and data node name node is the
master
daemon there's only one active name node
it manages the data nodes and stores all
the metadata so it stores all the
mapping of where the data is on your
hadoop file system now the name node is
usually an enterprise machine you spend
a lot of extra money on it so you have a
very solid name known machine and so
then we have our data nodes our data
node data node data node we have three
here the data node is the slave there
can be multiple data nodes and it stores
the actual data and this is where your
commodity hardware comes in the best
definition i've heard of commodity
hardware is the cheap knockoffs this is
where you buy you can buy 10 of these
and you expect one of them not to work
because you know when they come in
they're going to break right away so
you're looking at hardware it's not as
high-end so where you might have your
main master node is your enterprise
server then your data nodes are just as
cheap as you can get them with all the
different features you need on them as
said earlier name node stores the
metadata metadata gives information
regarding the file location block size
and so on so our metadata in the hdfs is
maintained by using two files it has the
edit log and the fs image the edit log
keeps track of the recent changes made
on the hadoop file system only recent
changes are tracked here the fs image
keeps track of every change made on the
hdfs since the beginning now what
happens when the edit log file size
increases the name node fails these are
big ones so what happens we get our edit
log it just keeps so big until it's too
big or our main enterprise computer that
we spent all that money on so it would
break actually fails because they still
fail the solution we make copies of the
edit log and the fs image files so
that's pretty straightforward you just
copy them over so you have both the most
recent edits going on and the long term
image of your file system and then we
also create a secondary name node is a
node that maintains a copies of the edit
log and the fs image it combines them
both to get an updated version of the fs
image now the secondary name node only
came in the last oh i guess two three
years where it became as part of the
main system and usually your secondary
name node is also an enterprise computer
and you'll put them on separate racks so
if you have three racks of computers you
would have maybe the first two racks
would have the name node and the second
rack would have the secondary name note
and the reason you put them on different
racks is you can have a whole rack go
down you could have somebody literally
trip over the power cable or the switch
that goes between the racks is most
common goes down well if the switch goes
down you can easily switch to the
secondary name node and while you're
getting your switch replaced and
replacing that hardware because of the
way the hdfs works it still is
completely functional so let's take a
look at the name node we have our edit
log our fs image and we have our
secondary name node and you take that it
copies the edit log over and it copies
the fs image and you can see right here
you have all the different contents on
your main name node now also on your
secondary name node and then your
secondary name node will actually take
these two your edit log and your fs
image and it will make a copy so you
have a full fs image that contains its
current it's up to date the secondary
name node creates a periodic checkpoint
of the files and then it updates the new
fs image into the name node now used to
be this all occurred on the name node
before you had a secondary name note so
now you can use your secondary node to
both back up everything going on the
name node and it does that lifting in
the back where you're combining your
edit log and bringing your fs image so
it's current and then you end up with a
new edit log and a new you have your fs
image updated and you start a fresh edit
log this process of updating happens
every hour and that's how it's scheduled
you can actually change those schedules
but that is the standard is to update
every hour so let's we took a look at
the the master node and the you know the
name node and the secondary name node
let's take a look at the cluster
architecture of our hadoop file system
the hdfs cluster architecture so we have
our name node and it stores the metadata
and we have our block location so we
have our fs image plus our edit log and
then we have the backup fs image and
edit log and then we have so you have
your rack we have our switch on top
remember i was talking about the switch
that's the most common thing to go in
the rack is the switches and underneath
the rack you have your different data
nodes you have your data node 1 2
four five maybe have 10 15 on this rack
you can stack them pretty high nowadays
uh used to be you only get about 10
servers on there but now you see racks
that contain a lot more and then you
have multiple racks so we're not talking
about just one rack we also have you
know rack 2 rack 3 4 5 6 and so on until
you have rack in so if you had a 100
data nodes we would be looking at 10
racks of 10 data nodes each and that is
literally 10 commodity server computers
hardware and we have a core switch which
maintains network bandwidth and connects
the name node to the data nodes so just
like each rack has a switch that
connects all your nodes on the rack you
now have core switches that connect all
the racks together and these also
connect into our name node setup so now
i can look up your fs image and your
edit log and pull that information your
metadata out so we've looked at the
architecture from the name node coming
down and you have your metadata your
block locations this then sorts it out
you have your core switches which
connect everything all your different
racks and then each individual rack has
their own switches which connect all the
different nodes and to the core switches
so now let's talk about the actual data
blocks what's actually sitting on those
commodity machines and so the hadoop
file system splits massive files into
small chunks these chunks are known as
data blocks each file in the hadoop file
system is stored as a data block and we
have a nice picture here where it looks
like a lego if you ever played with the
legos as a kid it's a good example we
just stack that data right on top of
each other but each block has to be the
same symmetry has to be the same size so
that it can track it easily and the
default size of one data block is
usually 128 megabytes now you can go in
and change that this standard is pretty
solid as far as most data is concerned
when we're loading up huge amounts of
data and there's certainly reasons to
change it 128 megabytes is pretty
standard block so why 128 megabytes if
the block size is smaller then there
will be too many data blocks along with
lots of metadata which will create
overhead so that's why you don't really
want to go smaller on these data blocks
unless you have a very certain kind of
data similarly if the block size is very
large then the processing time for each
block increases then as i pointed out
earlier each block is the same size just
like your lego blocks are all the same
but the last block can be the same size
or less so you might only be storing 100
megabytes in the last block and you can
think of this as if you had a terabyte
of data that you're storing on here it's
not going to be exactly divided into 128
megabytes we just store all of it 128
megabytes except for the last one which
could have anywhere between one and 128
megabytes depending on how evenly your
data is divided now let's look into how
files are stored in the hadoop file
system so we have a file a text let's
say it's 520 megabytes we have block a
so we take 128 megabytes out of the 520
and we store it in block a and then we
have block b again we're taking 128
megabytes out of our 520 storing it
there and so on block c block d and then
block e we only have eight megabytes
left so when you add up 128 plus 128
plus 128 plus 128 you only get 512. and
so the last eight megabytes goes into
its own block the final block uses only
the remaining space for storage data
node failure and replication and this is
really where hadoop shines this is what
makes it this is why you can use it with
commodity computers this is why you can
have multiple racks and have something
go down all the data blocks are stored
in various data notes you take each
block you store it at 128 megabytes and
then we're gonna put it on different
nodes so here's our block a block b
block c from our last example and we
have node one node two node three node
four node five node six and so each one
of these represents a different computer
it literally splits the data up into
different machines so what happens if
node five crashes well that's a big deal
i mean we might not even have just node
five you might have a whole rack go down
and if you're a company that's building
your whole business off of that you're
going to lose a lot of money so what
does happen when node 5 crashes or the
first rack goes down the data stored in
node 5 will be unavailable as there is
no copy stored elsewhere in this
particular image so the hadoop file
system overcomes the issue of data node
failure by creating copies of the data
this is known as the replication method
and you can see here we have our six
nodes here's our block a but instead of
storing it just on the first machine
we're actually going to store it on the
second and fourth nodes so now it's
spread across three different computers
and in this if these are on a rack one
of these is always on a different rack
so you might have two copies on the same
rack but you never have all three on the
same rack and you always have you never
have more than two copies on one node
there's no reason to have more than one
copy per node and you can see we do the
same thing with block b block c is then
also spread out across the different
machines and same with block d and block
e node five crashes will the data blocks
b d and e be lost well in this example
no because we have backups of all three
of those on different machines the
blocks have their copies in the other
nodes due to which the data is not lost
even if the node 5 crashes and again
because they're also stored on different
racks even if the whole rack goes down
you are still up and live with your
hadoop file system the default
replication factor is three in total
we'll have three copies of each data
block now that can be changed for
different reasons or purposes but you
got to remember when you're looking at a
data center this is all in one huge room
these switches are connecting all these
servers so they can shuffle the data
back and forth really quick and that is
very important when you're dealing with
big data and you can see here each block
is by default replicated three times
that's the standard there is very rare
occasions to do four and there's even
fewer reasons to do two blocks i've only
seen four used once and it was because
they had two data centers and so each
data center kept two different copies
rack awareness in the hadoop file system
rack is a collection of 30 to 40 data
nodes rack awareness is a concept that
helps to decide where the replica of the
data block should be stored so here we
have rack one we have our data node one
to four remember saying that it used to
be only put ten machines and then it
went to twenty now it's thirty to forty
so you can have a rack with forty
servers on it then we have rack two and
rack three and we put block one on there
replicas of block a cannot be in the
same rack and so i'll put the replicas
onto a different rack and notice that
these are actually these two are on the
same rack but you'll never have all
three stored on the same rack in case
the whole rack goes down and replicas of
block a are created in rack two and they
actually do they do by default create
the replicas onto the same rack and that
has to do with the data exchange and
maximizing your processing time and then
we have of course our block b and it's
replicated onto rack 3 and block c which
will then replicate onto rack 1 and so
on for all of your data all the way up
to block d or whatever how much ever
data you have on there hdfs architecture
so let's look over the architecture as a
bigger picture we looked at the name
node and we store some metadata names
replicas home food data three so it has
all your different infra your metadata
stored on there and then we have our
data nodes and you can see our data
nodes are each on different racks with
our different machines and we have our
name node and you're going to see we
have a heartbeat or pulse here and a lot
of times one of the things that confuses
people sometimes in classes they talk
about nodes versus machines so you could
have a data node that's a hadoop data
node and you could also have a spark
node on there sparks a different
architecture and these are each daemons
that are running on these computers
that's why you refer to them as nodes
and not just always as servers and
machines so even though i use them
interchangeable be aware that these
nodes you can even have virtual machines
if you're testing something out it
doesn't make sense to have 10 virtual
nodes on one machine and deploy it
because you might as well just run your
code on the machine so we have our
heartbeat going on here and the
heartbeat is a signal that data nodes
continuously send to the name nodes this
signal shows the status of the data node
so there's a continual pulse going up
and saying hey i'm here i'm ready for
whatever instructions or data you want
to send me and you can see here we've
divided up into rack 1 and rack 2 and
our different data nodes and it also
have the replications we talked about
how to replicate data and replicate it
in three different locations and then we
have a client machine and the client
first requests the name node to read the
data now if you're not familiar with the
client machine the client is you the
programmer the client is you've logged
in external to this hadoop file system
and you're sending it instructions and
so the client whatever instructions or
script you're sending is first request
the name node to read the data the name
node allows the client to read the
requested data from the data nodes the
data is read from the data nodes and
sent to the client and so you can see
here that it basically the the name node
connects the client up and says here
here's a data stream and now you have
the query that you sent out returning
the data you asked for and then of
course it goes and finishes it and says
oh metadata operations and it goes in
there and finalizes your request the
other thing the name node does is you're
sending your information because the
client sends the information in there is
your block operations so your block
operations are performs creation of data
so you're going to create new files and
folders you're going to delete the
folders and also it covers the
replication of the folders which goes on
in the background and so we can see here
that we have a nice full picture you can
see where the client machine comes in it
cues the metadata the metadata goes into
it stores a metadata and then it goes
into block operations and maybe you're
sending the data to the hadoop file
system maybe you're querying maybe
you're asking it to delete if you're
sending data in there it then does the
replication on there it goes back so you
have your data client which is writing
the data into the data node and of
course replicating it and that's all
part of the block operations and so
let's talk a little bit about read
mechanisms in the hadoop file system the
hadoop file system read mechanism we
have our hadoop file system client
that's you on your computer and the
client jvm on the client node so we have
our client jvm or the java virtual
machine that is going through and then
your client node and we're zooming in on
the read mechanism so we're looking at
this picture here as you can guess your
client is reading the data and i also
have another client down here writing
data we're going to look a little closer
at that and so we have our name node up
here we have our racks of your data
nodes and your racks of computers down
here and so our client the first thing
it does is it opens a connection up with
the distributed file system to the hdfs
and it goes hey can i get the block
locations and so it goes by using the
rpc remote procedure call it gets those
locations and the name node first checks
if the client is authorized to access
the requested file and if yes it then
provides a block location and a token to
the client which is showing to the slave
for authentication so here's the name
node it tells a client hey here's the
token the client's going to come in and
get this information from you and it
tells the client oh hey here's where the
information is so this is what is
telling your script you sent to query
your data whether you're writing your
script in one of the many setups that
you have available through the hadoop
file system or a connection through your
code and so you have your client machine
at this point then reads so your fs data
input stream comes through and you have
and you can see right here we did one
and two which is verify who you are and
give you all the information you need
then three you're going to read it from
the input stream and then the input
stream is going to grab it from the
different nodes where it's at and it'll
supply the tokens to those machines
saying hey this client needs this data
here's a token for that we're good to go
let me have the data the client will
show the authentication token to the
data nodes for the read process to begin
so after reaching the end of the data
block the connection is closed and we
can see here where we've gone through
the different steps get block locations
we have step one you open up your
connection you get the block locations
by using the rpc then you actively go
through the fs data input stream to grab
all those different data brings it back
into the client and then once it's done
it closes down that connection and then
once the client or in this case the
programmer you know manager has gone in
and pig script you can do that there's
an actual coding in each in hadoop we're
pulling data called pig or hive once you
get that data back we close the
connection delete all those randomly
huge series of tokens so they can't be
used anymore and then it's done with
that query and we can go ahead and zoom
in just a little bit more here and let's
look at this even a little closer here's
our hadoop file system client and our
client jvm our java virtual machine on
the client node and we have the data to
be read block a block b and so we
request to read block a and b and it
goes into the name node two then it
sends a location in this case um ip
addresses of the blocks for the dn1 and
dn2 where those blocks are stored then
the client interacts with the data nodes
through the switches and so you have
here the core switch so your client node
comes in three and it goes to the core
switch and that then goes to rack switch
1 rack switch 2 and rack switch 3. now
if you're looking at this you'll
automatically see a point of failure in
the core switch and certainly you want a
high end switch mechanism for your core
switch you want to use enterprise
hardware for that and then when you get
to the racks that's all commodity all
your rack switches so if one of those
goes down you don't care as much you
just have to get in there and swap it in
and out really quick you can see here we
have block a which is replicated three
times and so is block b and it'll pull
from there so we come in here and here
the data is read from the dn1 and dn2 as
they are the closest to each other and
so you can see here that it's not going
to read from two different racks it's
going to read from one rack whatever the
closest setup is for that query the
reason for this is if you have 10 other
queries going on you want this one to
pull all the data through one setup and
it minimizes that traffic so the
response from the data nodes to the
client that read the operation was
successful it says ah we've read the
data we're successful which is always
good we like to be successful i don't
know about you i like to be successful
so if we look at the read mechanism
let's go ahead and zoom in and look at
the write mechanism for the hadoop file
system so our hdfs write mechanism and
so when we have the hdfs write mechanism
here's our client machine this is again
the programmer on their in computer and
it's going through the client java
machine or java virtual machine the jvm
this is all occurring on the client node
somebody's office or maybe it's on the
local server for the office so we have
our name node we have data nodes and we
have the distributed file system so the
client first executes create file on the
distributed file system says hey i'm
going to create this file over here then
it goes through the rpc call just like
our read did the client first executes
create file on the distributed file
system then the dfs interacts with the
name node to create a file name node
then provides a location to write the
data and so here we have our hdfs client
and the fs data output stream so this
time instead of the data going to the
client it's coming from the client and
so here the client writes the data
through the fs data output stream keep
in mind that this output stream the
client could be a streaming code it
could be i mean you know i always refer
to the client as just being this
computer that your programmer is writing
on it could be you have your sql server
there where your data is that's current
with all your current sales and it's
archiving all that information through
scoop one of the tools in the hadoop
file system it could be streaming data
it could be a connection to the stock
servers and you're pulling stock data
down from those servers at a regular
time and that's all controlled you can
actually set that code up to be
controlled in many of the different
features in the hadoop file system and
some of the different resources you have
that sit on top of it so here the client
writes the data through the fs data
output stream and the fs data output
stream as you can see goes into right
packet so it divides it up into packets
128 megabytes and the data is written
and the slave further replicates it so
here's our data coming in and then if
you remember correctly that's part of
the fs data setup is it tells it where
to replicate it out but the data node
itself is like oh hey okay i've got the
data coming in and it's also given the
tokens of where to send the replications
to and then acknowledgement is sent
after the required replicas are made so
then that goes back up saying hey
successful i've written data and made
three replications on this as far as our
you know going through the pipeline of
the data nodes and then that goes back
and says after the date is written the
client performs the close method so the
client's done it says okay i'm done
here's the end of the data we're
finished and after the date is written
the client performs a close method and
we can see here just a quick reshape we
go in there just like we did with the
read we create the connection this
creates a name node which lets it know
what's going on step two step three that
also includes uh the tokens and
everything and then we go into step
three where we're now writing through
the fs data output stream and that sorts
it out into
whatever data node it's going to go to
and which also tells it how to replicate
it so that data node then sends it to
other data nodes so we have a
replication and of course you finalize
it and close everything up marks it
complete to the name node and it deletes
all those magical tokens in the
background so that they can't be reused
and we can go ahead and just do this
with an example the same setups and
whether you're doing a read or write
they're very similar as we come in here
from our client and our name node and
you can see right here we actually
depicting these as the actual rack and
the switch is going on and so as the
data comes in you have your request like
we saw earlier it sends the location of
the data nodes and this actually turns
your your ip addresses your dynamic node
connections they come back to your
client your hdfs client and at that
point with the tokens it then goes into
the core switch and the core switch says
hey here it goes the client interacts
with the data nodes through the switches
and you can see here where you're
writing in block a replication of block
a and a second replication of block a on
the second server so blocking is
replicated on the second server and the
third server at this point you now have
three replications of block a and it
comes back and says it acknowledges and
says hey we're done and that goes back
into your hadoop file system to the
client and says okay we're done and
finally the
success written to the name node and it
just closes everything down a quick
recap of the hadoop file system and the
advantages and so the first one is
probably one of the all of these are
huge one you have multiple data copies
are available so it's very fault
tolerant whole racks can go down
switches can go down even your main name
node could go down if you have a
secondary name node something we didn't
talk too much about is how scalable it
is because it uses distributed storage
you run into then you're oh my gosh i'm
out of space or i need to do some
heavier processing let me just add
another rack of computers so you can
scale it up very quickly it's a linear
scalability where it used to be if you
bought a server you would have to pay a
lot of money to get that the craig
computer remember the big craig
computers coming out the craig computer
runs 2 million a year just the
maintenance to liquid cool it that's
very expensive compared to just adding
more racks of computer and extending
your data center so it's very cost
effective since commodity hardware is
used we're talking cheap knockoff
computers you still need your high-end
enterprise uh for the name node but the
rest of them literally it is a tenth of
the cost of storing data on more
traditional high-end computers and then
the data is secure so it has a very
high-end data security provides data
security for your data so all theory and
no play doesn't make for much fun so
let's go ahead and show you what it
looks like as far as some of the
dimensions when you're getting into
pulling data or putting data into the
hadoop file system and you can see here
i have oracle virtual machine virtual
box manager i have a couple different
things loaded on there cloudera is one
of them so we should probably explain
some of these things if you're new to
virtual machines the oracle virtualbox
allows you to spin up a machine as if it
is a separate computer so in this case
this is running i believe centos linux
and it creates like a box on my computer
so the centos is running on my machine
while i'm running my windows 10 this
happens to be a windows 10 computer and
then underneath here i can actually go
under let me just open up the general
might be hard to see there and you can
see i can actually go down to system
processor i happen to be on an 8 core it
has 16 dedicated threads registers are
16 cpus but 8 cores and i've only
designated this for one cpu so it's only
going to use one of my dedicated threads
on my computer and this the oracle
virtual machine is open source you can
see right here we're on the oracle
www.oracle.com i usually just do a
search for downloading virtualbox if you
search for virtualbox all one word it
will come up with this page and then you
can download it for whatever operating
system you're working with there
certainly are a number of different
options and let me go and point those
out if you're setting this up as a for
demoing for yourself the first thing to
note for doing a virtual box and doing a
cloudera or horton setup on that virtual
box for doing the hadoop system to try
it out you need a minimum of 12
gigabytes it cannot be a windows 10 home
edition because you'll have problems
with your virtual setup and sometimes
you have to go turn on the virtual
settings so it knows it's in there so if
you're on a home setup there are other
sources there's cloudera and we'll talk
a little bit about clare dara here in
just a second but they have the cloudera
online live we can go try the cloudera
setup i've never used it but cloudera is
a pretty good company cloudera and
hortonworks are two of the common ones
out there and we'll actually be running
a cloudera hadoop cluster on on our demo
here so you have oracle virtual machine
you also have the option of doing it on
different vmware that's another one like
virtual machine this is more of a paid
service there is a free setup for just
doing it for yourself which will work
fine for this and then in the cloudera
like again they have the new online
setup where you can go in there to the
online and for cloudera you want to go
underneath the cloudera quick start if
you type in a search for cloudera
quickstart it'll bring you to this
website and then you can select your
platform in this case i did virtualbox
there's vmware we just talked about
docker docker is a very high-end virtual
setup unless you already know it you
really don't want to mess with it then
your kvm is if you're on a linux
computer that sets up multiple systems
on that computer so the two you really
want to use are usually the virtual box
or do an online setup and you can see
here with the download if you're going
into the horton version it's called
hortonworks and they call it sandbox so
you'll see the term hortonworks sandbox
and these are all test demos you're not
going to deploy a single node hadoop
systems that would just be kind of
ridiculous and defeat the whole purpose
of having a horton or having a hadoop
system if it's only installed on one
computer in a virtual node so a lot of
different options if you're not on a
professional windows version or you
don't have at least 12 gigabytes ram to
run this
you'll want to try and see if you can
find an online version and of course
simplylearn has our own labs if you sign
up for classes we set you up i don't
know what it is now but last time i was
in there was a five node uh setup so you
can get around and see what's going on
whether you're studying for the admin
side or for the programming side in
script writing and if i go into my
oracle virtual box and i go under my
cloudera and i start this up and each
one has their own flavors um horton uses
just a login so you log everything in
through
a local host through your internet
explorer or i might use chrome cloudera
actually opens up a full interface so
you actually are in that setup and you
can see when i uh started it let me go
back here once i downloaded this this is
a big download by the way i had to
import the appliance in virtualbox the
first time i ran it it takes a long time
to configure the setup and the second
time it comes up pretty quick and with
the cloudera quick start again this is a
pretend single node it opens up and
you'll see that it actually has firefox
here so here's my web browser i don't
have to go to localhost i'm actually
already in the quickstart for cloudera
and if we come down here you can see
getting started i have some information
analyze your data manage your cluster
your general information on there and
what i always want to start to do is to
go ahead and open up a terminal window
so we'll open up a terminal widen this a
little bit let me just maximize this out
here so you can see so we are now in a
virtual machine this virtual machine is
centos linux so i'm on a linux computer
on my windows computer and so when i'm
on this terminal window this is your
basic terminal if i do list you'll see
documents eclipse these are the
different things that are installed with
the quick start guide on the linux
system so this is a linux computer and
then hadoop is running on here so now i
have hadoop single node so it has both
the name node and the data node and
everything squished together in one
virtual machine we can then do let's do
hdfs telling it that it's a hadoop file
system dfs minus ls now notice the ls is
the same i have ls for list and ls for
list and i click on here it'll take you
just a second reading the hadoop file
system and it comes up with nothing so a
quick recap let's go back over this
three different environments i have this
one out here let's just put this in a
bright red so you can actually see it i
have this environment out here which is
my slides i have this environment here
or i did a list that's looking at the
files on the linuxcentos computer and
then we have this system here which is
looking at the files on the hadoop file
system so three completely separate
environments and then we connect them
and so right now we have i have whatever
files i have my personal files and the
um of course we're also looking at the
screen for my windows 10 and then we're
looking at the screen here uh here's our
list there let's look at the files and
this is the screen for centos linux and
then this is looking at the files right
here for the hadoop file system so three
completely separate files this one here
which is the linux is running in a
virtual box
so this is a virtual box i'm using one
core to run it or one cpu and everything
in there is it has its own file system
you can see we have our desktop and
documents and whatever in there and then
you can see here we right now have no
files and our hadoop file system and
this hadoop file system currently is
stored on the linux machine but it could
be stored across 10 linux machines 20
100 this could be stored across in
petabytes i mean it could be really huge
or it could just be in this case just a
demo where we're putting it on just one
computer and then once we're in here let
me just see real quick if i can go under
view zoom in view zoom in this is just a
standard browser so i can use any like
the control plus and stuff like that to
zoom in and this is very common to be in
a browser window with the hadoop file
system so right now i'm in a linux and
i'm going to do oh let's just create a
file go file my new file and i'm going
to use vi and this is a vi editor just a
basic editor and we go and type
something in here
one two three four maybe it's columns 44
66 77. of course a new file system just
like your regular computer can also so
in our vi editor you hit your colon i
actually work with a lot of different
other editors and we'll write quit vi so
let's take a look and see what happened
here i'm in my linux system i type in ls
for list and we should see my new file
and sure enough we do over here there it
is let me just highlight that my new
file and if i then go into the hadoop
system hdfs dfs minus ls for list we
still show nothing it's still empty so
what i can simply do is i can go hdfs
dfs
minus put and i'm going to put my new
file and this is just going to move it
from the linux system because i'm in
this file folder into the hadoop file
system and now if we go in and we type
in our list for a new file system you
will see in here that i now have just
the one file on there which is my new
file and very similar to linux we can do
cat and the cat command simply uh evokes
reading the file so hdfs dfs minus cat
and i had to look it up remember
cloudera the the format is going to be a
user uh then of course the path location
and the file name and in here when we
did the list here's our list so you can
see it lists our file here and we
realize that this is under uh user
cloudera and so i can now go user
cloudera my new file and the minus cat
and we'll be able to read the file in
here and you can see right here this is
the file that was in the linux system is
now copied into the cloudera system and
it's one three four five that what i
entered in there and if we go back to
the linux and do list you'll still see
it in here my new file and we can also
do something like this in our hdfs
minus mv i will do my new file and we're
going to change it to my
new new file and if we do that
underneath our hadoop file system the
minus mv will rename it so if i go back
here to our hadoop file system ls you'll
now see instead of my new file it has my
new new file coming up and there it is
my new new files we've renamed it we can
also go in here and
delete this so i can now come in here so
in our hdfs dfs we can also do a remove
and this will remove the file and so if
we come in here we run this we'll see
that when i come back and do the list
the file is gone and now we just have
another empty
folder with our hadoop file system and
just like any file system we can take
this and we can go ahead and make
directory create a new directory so mk
for make directory we'll call this my
dir so we're going to make a directory
my dir it'll take it just a second and
of course if we do
the list command you'll see that we now
have the directory in there give it just
a second there it comes mydir and just
like we did before i can go in here and
we're going to put the file and if you
remember correctly from our files in the
setup i called it my new file so this is
coming from the linux system and we're
going to put that into my dir that's the
target in my hadoop setup and so if i
hit enter on there i can now do
the hadoop list and that's not going to
show the file because remember i put it
in a sub-folder so if i should do the
kadroop just this will show my directory
and i can do list and then i can do my
dur for my directory and you'll see
underneath the my directory in the
hadoop file system it now has my new
file put in there and with any good
operating system we need a minus help so
just like you can type in help in your
linux you can now come in here and type
in hdfs help and it shows you a lot of
the commands in there underneath the
hadoop file system most of them should
be very similar to the linux on here and
we can also do something like this a
hadoop version and the hadoop version
shows up that we're in hadoop 2.60
cdh is it we're cloudera 5 and compiled
by jenkins and it has a date and all the
different information on our hadoop file
system so this is some basics in the
terminal window let me go ahead and
close this out because if you're going
to play with this you should really come
in here let me just maximize the cloud
data it opens up in a browser window and
so once we're in here again this is a
browser window which you could access
might look like any access for a hadoop
file system one of the fun things to do
when you're first starting is to go
under hue you'll see it up here at the
top has cloudera hue hadoop your hbase
your impala your spark these are
standard installs now and hue is
basically an overview of the file system
and so come up here and you can see
where you can do queries as far as if
you have a hbase or a hive the hive
database we go over here to the top
where it says file browser and if we go
under file browser now this is a hadoop
file system we're looking at and once we
open up the file browser you can now see
there's my directory which we created
and if i click on my directory there's
my new file which is in here and if i
click on my new file it actually opens
it up and you can see from our hadoop
file system this is in the hadoop file
system the file that we created so we
covered the terminal window you can see
here's a terminal window up here it
might be if you were in a web browser
it'll look a little different because it
actually opens up as a web browser
terminal window and we've looked a
little bit at hue which is one of the
most basic components of hadoop one of
the original components for going
through and looking at your data and
your databases of course now they're up
to the hue4 it's gone through a number
of changes and you can see there's a lot
of different choices in here for other
different tools in the hadoop file
system and i'll go ahead and just close
out of this and one of the cool things
with the virtual uh box i can either
save the machine state send the shutdown
signal or power off the machine i'll go
and just power off the machine
completely now suppose you have a
library that has a collection of huge
number of books on each floor and you
want to count the total number of books
present on each floor what would be your
approach you could say i will do it
myself but then don't you think that
will take a lot of time and that's
obviously not an efficient way of
counting the number of books in this
huge collection on every floor by
yourself now there could be a different
approach or an alternative to that you
could think of asking three of your
friends or three of your colleagues and
you could then say if each friend could
count the books on every floor then
obviously that would make your work
faster and easier to count the books on
every floor now this is what we mean by
parallel processing so when you say
parallel processing in technical terms
you are talking about using multiple
machines and each machine would be
contributing its ram and cpu cores for
processing and your data would be
processed on multiple machines at the
same time now this type of process
involves parallel processing in our case
or in our library example where you
would have person 1 who would be taking
care of books on floor 1 and counting
them person 2 on floor 2 then you have
someone on floor 3 and someone on floor
4. so every individual would be counting
the books on every floor in parallel so
that reduces the time consumed for this
activity and then there should be some
mechanism where all these counts from
every floor can be aggregated so what is
each person doing here each person is
mapping the data of a particular floor
or you can say each person is doing a
kind of activity or basically a task on
every floor and the task is counting the
books on every floor now then you could
have some aggregation mechanism that
could basically reduce or summarize this
total count and in terms of map reduce
we would say that's the work of reducer
so when you talk about hadoop map reduce
it processes data on different node
machines now this is the whole concept
of hadoop framework right that you not
only have your data stored across
machines but you would also want to
process the data locally so instead of
transferring the data from one machine
to other machine or bringing all the
data together into some central
processing unit and then processing it
you would rather have the data processed
on the machines wherever that is stored
so we know in case of hadoop cluster we
would have our data stored on multiple
data nodes on their multiple disks and
that is the data which needs to be
processed but the requirement is that we
want to process this data as fast as
possible and that could be achieved by
using parallel processing now in case of
mapreduce we basically have the first
phase which is your mapping phase so in
case of mapreduce programming model you
basically have two phases one is mapping
and one is reducing now who takes care
of things in mapping phase it is a
mapper class and this mapper class has
the function which is provided by the
developer which takes care of these
individual map tasks which will work on
multiple nodes in parallel your reducer
class belongs to the reducing phase so a
reducing phase basically uses a reducer
class which provides a function that
will aggregate and reduce the output of
different data nodes to generate the
final output now that's how your
mapreduce works using mapping and then
obviously reducing now you could have
some other kind of jobs which are map
only jobs wherein there is no reducing
required but we are not talking about
those we are talking about our
requirement where we would want to
process the data using mapping and
reducing especially when data is huge
when data is stored across multiple
machines and you would want to process
the data in parallel so when you talk
about mapreduce you could say it's a
programming model you could say
internally it's a processing engine of
hadoop that allows you to process and
compute huge volumes of data and when we
say huge volumes of data we can talk
about terabytes we can talk about
petabytes exabytes and that amount of
data which needs to be processed on a
huge cluster we could also use mapreduce
programming model and run a mapreduce
algorithm in a local mode but what does
that mean if you would go for a local
mode it basically means it would do all
the mapping and reducing on the same
node using the processing capacity that
is ram and cpu cores on the same machine
which is not really efficient in fact we
would want to have our map reduce work
on multiple nodes which would obviously
have mapping phase followed by a
reducing phase and intermittently there
would be data generated there would be
different other phases which help this
whole processing so when you talk about
hadoop map reduce you are mainly talking
about two main components or two main
phases that is mapping and reducing
mapping taking care of map tasks
reducing taking care of reduced tasks so
you would have your data which would be
stored on multiple machines now when we
talk about data data could be in
different formats we could or the
developer could specify what is the
format which needs to be used to
understand the data which is coming in
that data then goes through the mapping
internally there would be some shuffling
sorting and then reducing which gives
you your final output so the way we
access data from sdfs or the way our
data is getting stored on sdfs we have
our input data which would have one or
multiple files in one or multiple
directories and your final output is
also stored on sdfs to be accessed to be
looked into and to see if the processing
was done correctly so this is how it
looks so you have the input data which
would then be worked upon by multiple
map tasks now how many map tasks that
basically depends on the file that
depends on the input format so normally
we know that in a hadoop cluster you
would have a file which is broken down
into blocks depending on its size so the
default block size is 128 mb which can
then still be customized based on your
average size of data which is getting
stored on the cluster so if i have
really huge files which are getting
stored on the cluster i would certainly
set a higher block size so that my every
file does not have huge number of blocks
creating a load on name nodes ram
because that's tracking the number of
elements in your cluster or number of
objects in your cluster so depending on
your file size your file would be split
into multiple chunks and for every chunk
we would have a map task running now
what is this map task doing that is
specified within the mapper class so
within the mapper class you have the
mapper function which basically says
what each of these map tasks has to do
on each of the chunks which has to be
processed this data intermittently is
written to sdfs where it is sorted and
shuffled and then you have internal
phases such as partitioner which decides
how many reduce tasks would be used or
what data goes to which reducer you
could also have a combiner phase which
is like a mini reducer doing the same
reduce operation before it reaches
reduce then you have your reducing phase
which is taken care by a reducer class
and internally the reducer function
provided by developer which would have
reduced task running on the data which
comes as an output from map tasks
finally your output is then generated
which is stored on sdfs now in case of
hadoop it accepts data in different
formats your data could be in compressed
format your data could be in part k your
data could be in afro text csv psv
binary format and all of these formats
are supported however remember if you
are talking about data being compressed
then you have to also look into what
kind of split ability the compression
mechanism supports otherwise when
mapreduce processing happens it would
take the complete file as one chunk to
be processed so sdfs accepts input data
in different formats this data is stored
in sdfs and that is basically our input
which is then passing through the
mapping phase now what is mapping phase
doing as i said it reads record by
record depending on the input format it
reads the data so we have multiple map
tasks running on multiple chunks once
this data is being read this is broken
down into individual elements and when i
say individual element i could say this
is my list of key value pairs so your
records based on some kind of delimiter
or without delimiter are broken down
into individual elements and thus your
mac creates key value pairs now these
key value pairs are not my final output
these key value pairs are basically a
list of elements which will then be
subjected to further processing so you
would have internally shuffling and
sorting of data so that all the relevant
key value pairs are brought together
which basically benefits the processing
and then you have your reducing which
aggregates the key value pairs into set
of smaller tuples or tuples as you would
say finally your output is getting
stored in the
designated directory as a list of
aggregated key value pairs which gives
you your output so when we talk about
mapreduce one of the key factors here is
the parallel processing which it can
offer so we know that we have a data is
getting stored across multiple data
nodes and you would have huge volume of
data which is split and randomly
distributed across data nodes and this
is the data which needs to be processed
and the best way would be parallel
processing so you could have your data
getting stored on multiple data nodes or
multiple slave nodes and each slave node
would have again one or multiple disks
to process this data basically we have
to go for parallel processing approach
we have to use the mapreduce now let's
look at the mapreduce workflow to
understand how it works so basically you
have your input data stored on sdfs now
this is the data which needs to be
processed it is stored in input files
and the processing which you want can be
done on one single file or it can be
done on a directory which has multiple
files you could also later have multiple
outputs merged which we achieve by using
something called as chaining of mappers
so here you have your data getting
stored on sdfs now input format is
basically something to define the input
specification and how the input files
will be split so there are various input
formats now we can search for that so we
can go to google and we can basically
search for
hadoop map reduce
yahoo tutorial this is one of the good
links and if i look into this link i can
search for different input formats and
output formats so let's search for input
format so when we talk about input
format you basically have something to
define how input files are split so
input files are split up and read based
on what input format is specified so
this is a class that provides following
functionality it selects the files or
other objects that should be used for
input it defines the input split that
break a file into tasks provides a
factory for record reader objects that
read the file so there are different
formats if you look in the table here
and you can see that the text input
format is the default format which reads
lines of a text file and each line is
considered as a record here the key is
the byte offset of the line and the
value is the line content it says you
can have key value input format which
passes lines into key value pairs
everything up to the first tab character
is the key and the remainder is the line
you could also have sequence file input
format which basically works on binary
format so you have input format and in
the same way you can also search for
output format which takes care of how
the data is handled after the processing
is done so the key value pairs provided
to this output collector are then
written to output files the way they are
written is governed by output format so
it functions pretty much like input
format as described in earlier right so
we could set what is the output format
to be followed and again you have text
output sequence file output format null
output format and so on so these are
different classes which take care of how
your data is handled when it is being
read for processing or how is the data
being written when the processing is
done so based on the input format the
file is broken down into splits and this
logically represents the data to be
processed by individual map tasks or you
could say individual mapper functions so
you could have one or multiple splits
which need to be processed depending on
the file size depending on what
properties have been set now once this
is done you have your input splits which
are subjected to mapping phase
internally you have a record reader
which communicates with the input split
and converts the data into key value
pairs suitable to be read by mapper and
what is mapper doing it is basically
working on these key value pairs the map
task giving you an intermittent output
which would then be forwarded for
further processing now once that is done
and we have these key value pairs which
is being worked upon my map your map
tasks as a part of your mapper function
are generating your key value pairs
which are your intermediate outputs to
be processed further now you could have
as i said a combiner face or internally
a mini radio surface now combiner does
not have its own class so combiner
basically uses the same class as the
reducer class provided by the developer
and its main work is to do the reducing
or its main work is to do some kind of
mini aggregation on the key value pairs
which were generated by map so once the
data is coming in from the combiner then
we have internally a partitioner phase
which decides how outputs from combiners
are sent to the reducers or you could
also say that even if i did not have a
combiner partitioner would decide based
on the keys and values based on the type
of keys how many reducers would be
required or how many reduced tasks would
be required to work on your output which
was generated by map task now once
partitioner has decided that then your
data would be then sorted and shuffled
which is then fed into the reducer so
when you talk about your reducer it
would basically have one or multiple
reduced tasks now that depends on what
or what partitioner decided or
determined for your data to be processed
it can also depend on the configuration
properties which have been set to decide
how many radio stars should be used now
internally all this data is obviously
going through sorting and shuffling so
that your reducing or aggregation
becomes an easier task once we have this
done we basically have the reducer which
is the code for the reducer is provided
by the developer and all the
intermediate data has then to be
aggregated to give you a final output
which would then be stored on sdfs and
who does this you have an internal
record writer which writes these output
key value pairs from reducer to the
output files now this is how your
mapreduce works wherein the final output
data can be not only stored but then
read or accessed from sdfs or even used
as an input for further mapreduce kind
of processing so this is how it overall
looks so you basically have your data
stored on sdfs based on input format you
have the splits then you have record
reader which gives your data to the
mapping phase which is then taken care
by your mapper function and mapper
function basically means one or multiple
map tasks working on your chunks of data
you could have a combiner phase which is
optional which is not mandatory then you
have a partitioner phase which decides
on how many reduced tasks or how many
reducers would be used to work on your
data internally there is sorting and
shuffling of data happening and then
basically based on your output format
your record reader will write the output
to sdfs directory now internally you
could also remember that data is being
processed locally so you would have the
output of each task which is being
worked upon stored locally however we do
not access the data directly from data
nodes we access it from sdfs so our
output is stored on sdfs so that is your
mapreduce workflow when you talk about
mapreduce architecture now this is how
it would look so you would have
basically a edge node or a client
program or an api which intends to
process some data so it submits the job
to the job tracker or you can say
resource manager in case of hadoop yarn
framework right now before this step we
can also say that an interaction with
name node would have already happened
which would have given information of
data nodes which have the relevant data
stored then your master processor so in
hadoop version 1 we had job tracker and
then the slaves were called task
trackers in hadoop version 2 instead of
job tracker you have resource manager
instead of task trackers you have node
managers so basically your resource
manager has to assign the job to the
task trackers or node managers so your
node managers as we discussed in yarn
are basically taking care of processing
which happens on every note so
internally there is all of this work
happening by resource manager node
managers and application master then you
can refer to the yarn based tutorial to
understand more about that so here your
processing master is basically breaking
down the application into tasks what it
does internally is once your application
is submitted your application to be run
on yarn processing framework is handled
by resource manager now forget about the
yarn part as of now i mean who does the
negotiating of resources who allocates
them how does the processing happen on
the nodes right so that's all to do with
how yarn handles the processing request
so you have your data which is stored in
sdfs broken down into one or multiple
splits depending on the input format
which has been specified by the
developer your input splits are to be
worked upon by your one or multiple map
tasks which will be running within the
container on the nodes basically you
have the resources which are being
utilized so for each map task you would
have some amount of ram which will be
utilized and then further the same data
which has to go through reducing phase
that is your reduced task will also be
utilizing some ram and cpu cores now
internally you have these functions
which take care of deciding on number of
reducers doing a mini reduce and
basically reading and processing the
data from multiple data nodes now this
is how your mapreduce programming model
makes parallel processing work or
processes your data which is stored
across multiple machines finally you
have your output which is getting stored
on its dfs
so let's have a quick demo on mapreduce
and see how it works on a hadoop cluster
now we have discussed briefly about
mapreduce which contains mainly two
phases that is your mapping phase and
your reducing phase and mapping phase is
taken care by your mapper function and
your reducing phase is taken care by
your reducer function now in between we
also have sorting and shuffling and then
you have other phases which is
partitioner and combiner and we will
discuss about all those in detail in
later sessions but let's have a quick
demo on how we can run a mapreduce which
is already existing as a package jar
file within your apache hadoop cluster
or even in your cloudera cluster now we
can build our own mapreduce programs we
can package them as jar transfer them to
the cluster and then run it on a hadoop
cluster on yarn or we could be using
already provided default program so
let's see where they are now these are
my two machines which i have brought up
and basically this would have my apache
hadoop cluster running now we can just
do a simple start hyphen all dot sh now
i know that this script is deprecated
and it says instead use start dfs and
start yarn but then it will still take
care of starting off my cluster on these
two nodes where i would have one single
name node two data nodes one secondary
name node one resource manager and two
node managers now if you have any doubt
in how this cluster came up you can
always look at the previous sessions
where we had a walkthrough in setting up
a cluster on apache and then you could
also have your cluster running using
less than 3 gb of your total machine ram
and you could have apache cluster
running on your machine now once this
cluster comes up we will also have a
look at the web ui which is available
for name node and resource manager now
based on the settings what we have given
our uis will show us details of our
cluster but remember the ui is only to
browse now here my cluster has come up i
can just do a jps to look at java
related processes and that will show me
what are the processes which are running
on c1 which is your data node resource
manager node manager and name node and
on my m1 machine which is my second
machine which i have configured here i
can always do a jps and that shows me
the processes running which also means
that my cluster is up with two data
nodes with two node managers and here i
can have a look at my web ui so i can
just do a refresh and the same thing
with this one just to refresh so i had
already opened the web pages so you can
always access the web ui using your name
notes hostname and 570 port it tells me
what is my cluster id what is my block
pull id it gives you information of what
is the space usage how many live nodes
you have and you can even browse your
file system so i have put in a lot of
data here i can click on browse the file
system and this basically shows me
multiple directories and these
directories have one or multiple files
which we will use for our mapreduce
example now if you see here these are my
directories which have some sample files
although these files are very small like
8.7 kilobytes if you look into this
directory if you look into this i have
just pulled in some of my hadoop logs
and i have put it on my sdfs these are a
little bigger files and then we also
have some other data which we can see
here and this is data which i have
downloaded from web now we can either
run a mapreduce on a single file or in a
directory which contains multiple files
let's look at that before looking at
demon mapreduce also remember mapreduce
will create a output directory and we
need to have that directory created plus
we need to have the permissions to run
the mapreduce job so by default since
i'm running it using admin id i should
not have any problem but then if you
intend to run map reduce with a
different user then obviously you will
have to ask the admin or you will have
to give the user permission to read and
write from sdfs so this is the directory
which i have created which will contain
my output once the mapreduce job
finishes and this is my cluster file
system if you look on this ui this shows
me about my yarn which is available for
taking care of any processing it as of
now shows that i have total of 8 gb
memory and i have 8 v cores now that can
be depending on what configuration we
have set or how many nodes are available
we can look at nodes which are available
and that shows me i have two node
managers running each has 8 gb memory
and 8 v cores now that's not true
actually but then we have not set the
configurations for node managers and
that's why it takes the default
properties that is 8gb laminate vcos now
this is my yarn ui we can also look at
scheduler which basically shows me the
different cues if they have been
configured where you will have to run
the jobs we'll discuss about all these
in later in detail now let's go back to
our terminal and let's see where we can
find some sample applications which we
can run on the cluster so once i go to
the terminal i can well submit the
mapreduce job from any terminal now here
i know that my hadoop related directory
is here and within hadoop you have
various directories we have discussed
that in binaries you have the commands
which you can run in s bin you basically
have the startup scripts and here you
also notice there is a share directory
in the end if you look in the shared
directory you would find hadoop and
within hadoop you have various sub
directories in which we will look for
map reduce now this mapreduce directory
has some sample jar files which we can
use to run a mapreduce on the cluster
similarly if you are working on a
cloudera cluster you would have to go
into opt cloudera parcel cdh slash lib
and in that you would have directories
for sdfs mapreduce or sdfs yarn where
you can still find the same jars it is
basically a package which contains your
multiple applications now how do we run
a mapreduce we can just type in hadoop
and hit enter and that shows me that i
have an option called jar which can be
used to run a jar file now at any point
of time if you would want to see what
are the different classes which are
available in a particular
jar you could always do a jar minus xvf
for example i could say jar xv f and i
could say user local hadoop
share hadoop mapreduce and then list
down your jar file so i'll say hadoop
mapreduce examples and if i do this this
should basically unpack it to show me
what classes are available within this
particular jar and it has done this it
has created a meta file and it has
created a org directory we can see that
by doing a ls and here if you look in ls
org since i ran the command from your
phone directory i can look into org
patchy hadoop
examples which shows me the classes
which i have and those classes contain
which mapper or reducer classes so it
might not be just mapper and reducer but
you can always have a look so for
example i am targeting to use word count
program which does a word count on files
and gives me a list of words and how
many times they occur in a particular
file or in set of files and this shows
me that what are the classes which
belong to word count so we have a int
sum reducer so this is my reducer class
i have tokenizer mapper that is my
mapper class right and basically this is
what is used these classes are used if
you run a word code now there are many
other programs which are part of this
jar file and we can expand and see that
so i can say hadoop jar and give your
path so i'll say hadoop jar user local
hadoop share hadoop mapreduce hadoop
mapreduce examples and if i hit on enter
that will show me what are the inbuilt
classes which are already available now
these are certain things which we can
use now there are other jar files also
for example i can look at hadoop and
here we can look at the jar files which
we have in this particular path so this
is one hadoop mapreduce examples which
you can use you can always look in other
jar files like you can look for
hadoop mapreduce client job client and
then you can look at the test one so
that is also an interesting one so you
can always look into hadoop mapreduce
client job client and then you have
something ending with this so if i would
have tried this one using my hadoop jar
command so in my previous example when
we did this it was showing me all the
classes which are available and that
already has a word count now there are
other good programs which you can try
like teragen to generate dummy data
terasort to check your sorting
performance and so on and terra validate
to validate the results similarly we can
also do a hadoop jar as i said on hadoop
mapreduce i think that was client and
then we have
job client and then test star now this
has a lot of other classes which can be
used or programs which can be used for
doing a stress testing or checking your
cluster status and so on one of them
interesting one is test dfs io but let's
not get into all the details in first
instance let's see how we can run a
mapreduce now if i would want to run a
mapreduce i need to give hadoop jar and
then my jar file and if i hit on enter
it would say it needs the input and
output it needs which class you want to
run so for example i would say word
count and again if i hit on enter it
tells me that you need to give me some
input and output to process and
obviously this processing will be
happening on cluster that is our yarn
processing framework unless and until
you would want to run this job in a
local mode so there is a possibility
that you can run the job in local mode
but let's first try how it runs on the
cluster so how do we do that now here i
can do a hdfs
ls slash command to see what i have on
my sdfs now through my ui i was already
showing you that we have set of files
and directories which we can use to
process now we can take up one single
file so for example if i pick up new
data and i can look into the files here
what we have and we can basically run a
mapreduce on a single file or multiple
files so let's take this file whatever
that contains and i would like to do a
word count so that i get a list of words
and their occurrence in this file so let
me just copy this now i also need my
output to be written and that will be
written here so here if i want to run a
mapreduce i can say hadoop which we can
pull out from history so hadoop jar word
count now i need to give my input so
that will be new data and then i will
give this file which we just copied now
i am going to run the word count only on
a single file and i will basically have
my output which will be stored in this
directory the directory which i have
created already mr output so let's do
this
output and this is fair enough now you
can give many other properties you can
specify how many map jobs you want to
run how many reduced jobs you want to
run do you want your output to be
compressed do you want your output to be
merged or many other properties can be
defined when you are specifying word
count and then you can pass in an
argument to pass properties from the
command line which will affect your
output now once i go ahead and submit
this this is basically running a simple
inbuilt mapreduce job on our hadoop
cluster now obviously internally it will
be looking for name node now we have
some issue here and it says the output
already exists what does that mean so it
basically means that hadoop will create
an output for you you just need to give
a name but then you don't need to create
it so let's give let's append the output
with number one and then let's go ahead
and run this so i've submitted this
command now this can also be done in
background if you would want to run
multiple jobs on your cluster at the
same time so it takes total input paths
to process one so that is there is only
one split on which your job has to work
now it will internally try to contact
your resource manager and basically this
is done so here we can have a look and
we can see some counters here now what i
also see is for some property which it
is missing it has run the job but it has
run in a local mode it has run in a
local mode so although we have submitted
so this might be related to my yarn
settings and we can check that
so if i do a refresh when i have run my
application it has completed it would
have created an output but the only
thing is it did not interact with your
yarn it did not interact with your
resource manager we can check those
properties and here if we look into the
job it basically tells me that it went
for mapping and reducing it would have
created an output it worked on my file
but then it ran in a local mode it ran
in a local mode so mapreduce remember is
a programming model right now if you run
it on yarn you get the facilities of
running it on a cluster where yarn takes
care of resource management if you don't
run it on yarn and run it on a local
mode it will use your machines ram and
cpu cores for processing but then we can
quickly look at the output and then we
can also try running this on yarn so if
i look into my hdfs and if i look into
my output mr output that's the directory
which was not used actually let's look
into the other directory which is ending
with one and that should show me the
output created by this mapreduce
although it ran in the local mode it
fetched an input file from usdfs and it
would have created output in hdfs now
that's my part file which is created and
if you look at part minus r minus these
zeros if you would have more than one
reducer running then you would have
multiple such files created we can look
into this what does this file contain
which should have my word count and here
i can say cat which basically shows me
what is the output created by my
mapreduce let's have a look into this so
the file which we gave for processing
has been broken down and now we have the
list of words which occur in the file
plus a count of those words so if there
is some word which is in is more then it
shows me the count so this is a list of
my words and the count for that so this
is how we run a sample mapreduce job i
will also show you how we can run it on
yeah now let's run mapreduce on yarn and
initially when we tried running a
mapreduce it did not hit yarn but it ran
in a local mode and that was because
there was a property which had to be
changed in mapreduce hyphen site file so
basically if you look into this file the
error was that i had given a property
which says mapred dot framework dot name
and that was not the right property name
and it was ignored and that's why it ran
in a local mode so i changed the
property to mapreduce.framework.name
restarted my cluster and everything
should be fine now and that map red
hyphen site file has also been copied
across the nodes now to run a mapreduce
on a hadoop cluster so that it uses yarn
and yarn takes care of resource
allocation on one or multiple machines
so i'm just changing the output here and
now i will submit this job which should
first connect to the resource manager
and if it connects to the resource
manager that means our job will be run
using yarn on the cluster rather than in
a local mode so now we have to wait for
this application to internally connect
to resource manager and once it starts
there we can always go back to the web
ui and check if our application has
reached yarn so it shows me that there
is one input part to be processed that's
my job id that's my application id which
you can even monitor status from the
command line now here the job has been
submitted so let's go back here and just
do a refresh on my yarn ui which should
show me the new application which is
submitted it tells me that it is an
accepted state application master has
already started and if you click on this
link it will also give you more details
of how many map and reduce tasks would
run so as of now it says the application
master is running it would be using this
node which is m1 we can always look into
the logs we can see that there is a one
task attempt which is being made and now
if i go back to my terminal i will see
that it is waiting to get some resources
from the cluster and once it gets the
resources it will first start with the
mapping phase where the mapper function
runs it does the map tasks one or
multiple depending on the splits so
right now we have one file and one split
so we will have just one map task
running and once the mapping phase
completes then it will get into reducing
which will finally give me my output so
we can be toggling through these
sessions so here i can just do a refresh
to see what is happening with my
application is it proceeding is it still
waiting for resource manager to allocate
some resources now just couple of
minutes back i tested this application
on yarn and we can see that my first
application completed successfully and
here we will have to give some time so
that yarn can allocate the resources now
if the resources were used by some other
application they will have to be freed
up now internally yan takes care of all
that which we will learn more detail in
yarn or you might have already followed
the yarn based session now here we will
have to just give it some more time and
let's see if my application proceeds
with the resources what yarn can
allocate to it sometimes you can also
see a slowness in what web ui shows up
and that can be related to the amount of
memory you have allocated to your nodes
now for apache we can have less amount
of memory and we can still run the
cluster and as i said the memory which
shows up here 16 gb and 16 cores is not
the true one those are the default
settings right but then my yarn should
be able to facilitate running of this
application let's just give it a couple
of seconds and then let's look into the
output here again i had to make some
changes in the settings because our
application was not getting enough
resources and then basically i restarted
my cluster now let's submit the
application again to the cluster which
first should contact the resource
manager and then basically the map and
reduce process should start so here i
have submitted an application it is
connecting to the resource manager and
then basically it will start internally
in app master that is application master
it is looking for the number of splits
which is one it's getting the
application id and it basically then
starts running the job it also gives you
a tracking url to look at the output and
now we should go back and look at our
yarn ui if our application shows up here
and we will have to give it a couple of
seconds when it can get the final status
change to running and that's where my
application will be getting resources
now if you closely notice here i have
allocated specific amount of memory that
is 1.5 gb for node manager on every node
and i have basically given two cores
each which my machines also have and my
yarn should be utilizing these resources
rather than going for default now the
application has started moving
and we can see the progress bar here
which basically will show what is
happening and if we go back to the
terminal it will show that first it went
in deciding map and reduce it goes for
map once the mapping phase completes
then the reducing phase will come into
existence and here my job has completed
so now it has basically used we can
always look at how many map and reduce
sas were run it shows me that there was
one map and one reduced task now with
the number of map tasks depends on the
number of splits and we had just one
file which is less than 128 mb so that
was one split to be processed and
reduced task is internally decided by
the reducer or depending on what kind of
property has been set in hadoop config
files now it also tells me how many
input records were read which basically
means these were the number of lines in
the file it tells me output records
which gives me the number of total words
in the file now there might be
duplicates and that which is processed
by internal combiner further processing
or forwarding that information to
reducer and basically reducer works on
335 records gives us a list of words and
their account now if i do a refresh here
this would obviously show my application
is completed it says succeeded you can
always click on the application to look
for more information it tells me where
it ran now we do not have a history
server running as of now otherwise we
can always access more information so
this leads to history server where all
your applications are stored but i can
click on this attempt tasks and this
will basically show me the history url
or you can always look into the logs so
this is how you can submit a sample
application which is inbuilt which is
available in the jar on your hadoop
cluster and that will utilize your
cluster to run now you could always as i
said when you are running a particular
job remember to change the output
directory and if you would not want it
to be processing is a single individual
file you could also point it to a
directory that basically means it will
have multiple files and depending on the
file sizes there would be multiple
splits and according to that multiple
map tasks will be selected so if i click
on this this would submit my second
application to the cluster which should
first connect to resource manager then
resource manager has to start an
application master now here we are
targeting 10 splits now you have to
sometimes give couple of seconds in your
machines so that the resources which
were used are internally already freed
up so that your cluster can pick it up
and then your yarn can take care of
resources so right now my application is
an undefined status but then as soon as
my yarn provides it the resources we
will have the application running on our
yarn cluster so it has already started
if you see it is going further then it
would launch 10 map tasks and it would
the number of reduced stars would be
decided on either the way your data is
or based on the properties which have
been set at your cluster level let's
just do a quick refresh here on my yarn
ui to show me the progress also take
care that when you are submitting your
application you need to have the output
directory mentioned however do not
create it hadoop will create that for
you now this is how you run a mapreduce
without specifying properties but then
you can specify more properties you can
look into what are the things which can
be changed for your mapper and reducer
or basically having a combiner class
which can do a mini reducing and all
those things can be done so we will
learn about that in the later sessions
now we will compare hadoop version one
that is with mapreduce version one we
will understand and learn about the
limitations of hadoop version one what
is the need of yarn what is yarn what
kind of workloads can be running on yarn
what are yarn components what is yarn
architecture and finally we will see a
demo on yarn so hadoop version one or
mapreduce version one well that's
outdated now and nobody is using hadoop
version one but it would be good to
understand what was in hadoop version
one and what were the limitations of
hadoop version one which brought in the
thought for the future processing layer
that is yarn now when we talk about
hadoop we already know that hadoop is a
framework and hadoop has two layers one
is your storage layer that is your sdfs
hadoop distributed file system which
allows for distributed storage and
processing which allows fault tolerance
by inbuilt replication and which
basically allows you to store huge
amount of data across multiple commodity
machines when we talk about processing
we know that mapreduce is the oldest and
the most mature processing programming
model which basically takes care of your
data processing on your distributed file
system so in hadoop version 1 mapreduce
performed both data processing and
resource management and that's how it
was problematic in mapreduce we had
basically when we talked about the
processing layer we had the master which
was called job tracker and then you had
the slaves which were the task records
so your job tracker was taking care of
allocating resources it was performing
scheduling and even monitoring the jobs
it basically was taking care of
assigning map and reduced tasks to the
jobs running on task trackers and task
trackers which were co-located with data
nodes were responsible for processing
the jobs so task trackers were the
slaves for the processing layer which
reported their progress to the job
tracker so this is what was happening in
hadoop version 1. now when we talk about
hadoop version 1 we would have say
client machines or an api or an
application which basically submits the
job to the master that is job tracker
now obviously we cannot forget that
there would already be an involvement
from name node which basically tells
which are the machines or which are the
data nodes where the data is already
stored now once the job submission
happens to the job tracker job tracker
being the master demon for taking care
of your processing request and also
resource management job scheduling would
then be interacting with your multiple
task trackers which would be running on
multiple machines so each machine would
have a task tracker running and that
task tracker which is a processing slave
would be co-located with the data nodes
now we know that in case of hadoop you
have the concept of moving the
processing to wherever the data is
stored rather than moving the data to
the processing layer so we would have
task trackers which would be running on
multiple machines and these task
trackers would be responsible for
handling the tasks what are these tasks
these are the application which is
broken down into smaller tasks which
would work on the data which is
respectively stored on that particular
node now these were your slave demons
right so your job tracker was not only
tracking the resources so your task
trackers were sending heartbeats they
were sending in packets and information
to the job tracker which would then be
knowing how many resources and when we
talk about resources we are talking
about the cpu cores we are talking about
the ram which would be available on
every node so task trackers would be
sending in their resource information to
job tracker and your job tracker would
be already aware of what amount of
resources are available on a particular
node how loaded a particular node is
what kind of work could be given to the
task tracker so job tracker was taking
care of resource management and it was
also breaking the application into tasks
and doing the job scheduling part assign
different tasks to these slave demons
that is your task trackers so job
tracker was
eventually overburdened right because it
was managing jobs it was tracking the
resources from multiple task trackers
and basically it was taking care of job
scheduling so job tracker would be
overburdened and in a case if job
tracker would fail then it would affect
the overall processing so if the master
is killed if the master demand dies then
the processing cannot proceed now this
was one of the limitations of hadoop
version one so when you talk about
scalability that is the capability to
scale due to a single job tracker
scalability would be hitting a
bottleneck you cannot have a cluster
size of more than 4000 nodes and cannot
run more than 40 000 concurrent tasks
now that's just a number we could always
look into the individual resources which
each machine was having and then we can
come up with an appropriate number
however with a single job tracker there
was no horizontal scalability for the
processing layer because we had single
processing master now when we talk about
availability job tracker as i mentioned
would be a single point of failure now
any failure kills all the queued and
running jobs and jobs would have to be
resubmitted now why would we want that
in a distributed platform in a cluster
which has hundreds and thousands of
machines we would want a processing
layer which can handle huge amount of
processing which could be more scalable
which could be more available and could
handle different kind of workloads when
it comes to resource utilization now if
you would have a predefined number of
map and reduce slots for each task
tracker you would have issues which
would relate to resource utilization and
that again is putting a burden on the
master which is tracking these resources
which has to assign jobs which can run
on multiple machines in parallel so
limitations in running non-map reduce
applications now that was one more
limitation of hadoop version one and
mapreduce that the only kind of
processing you could do is mapreduce and
mapreduce programming model although it
is good it is oldest it has matured over
a period of time but then it is very
rigid you will have to go for mapping
and reducing approach and that was the
only kind of processing which could be
done in hadoop person one so when it
comes to doing a real time analysis or
doing ad hoc query or doing a graph
based processing or massive parallel
processing there were limitations
because that could not be done in hadoop
version 1 which was having mapreduce
version 1 as the processing component
now that brings us to the need for yarn
so yarn it stands for yet another
resource negotiator so as i mentioned
before yarn in hadoop version one well
you could have applications which could
be written in different programming
languages but then the only kind of
processing which was possible was
mapreduce we had the storage layer we
had the processing but then kind of
limited processing which could be done
now this was one thing which brought in
a thought that why shouldn't we have a
processing layer which can handle
different kind of workloads as i
mentioned might be graph processing
might be real-time processing might be
massive parallel processing or any other
kind of processing which would be a
requirement of an organization now
designed to run map-reduce jobs only and
having issues in scalability resource
utilization job tracking etc that led to
the need of something what we call as
yarn now from hadoop version 2 onwards
we have the two main layers have changed
a little bit you have the storage layer
which is intact that is your hdfs and
then you have the processing layer which
is called yarn yet another resource
negotiator now we will understand how
yarn works but then yarn is taking care
of your processing layer it does support
mapreduce so mapreduce processing can
still be done but then now you can have
a support to other processing frameworks
yarn can be used to solve the issues
which hadoop version 1 was posing
something like resource management
something like different kind of
workload processing something like
scalability resource utilization all
that is now taken care by yarn now when
we talk about yarn we can have now a
cluster size of more than 10 000 nodes
and can run more than 100 000 concurrent
tasks that's just to take care of your
scalability when you talk about
compatibility applications which were
developed for hadoop version 1 which
were primarily map reduce kind of
processing can run on yarn without any
disruption or availability issues when
you talk about resource utilization
there is a mechanism which takes care of
dynamic allocation of cluster resources
and this basically improves the resource
utilization when we talk about
multi-tenancy so basically now the
cluster can handle different kind of
workloads so you can use open source and
proprietary data access engines you can
perform real-time analysis you can be
doing graph processing you can be doing
ad hoc querying and this can be
supported for multiple workloads which
can run in parallel so this is what yarn
offers so what is yarn as i mentioned
yarn stands for yet another resource
negotiator so it is the cluster resource
management layer for your apache hadoop
ecosystem which takes care of scheduling
jobs and assigning resources now just
imagine when you would want to run a
particular application you would
basically be telling the cust cluster
that i would want resources to run my
applications that application might be a
mapreduce application that might be a
hive query which is triggering a
mapreduce that might be a big script
which is triggering a mapreduce that
could be hive with days as an execution
engine that could be a spark application
that could be a graph processing
application in any of these cases you
would still you as in in sense client or
basically an api or the application
would be requesting for resources yan
would take care of that so yarn would
provide the desired resources now when
we talk about resources we are mainly
talking about the network related
resources we are talking about the cpu
cores or as in terms of yarn we say
virtual cpu course we would talk about
ram that is in gb or mb or in terabytes
which would be offered from multiple
machines and yarn would take care of
this so with yarn you could basically
handle different workloads now these are
some of the workloads which are showing
up here you have the traditional
mapreduce which is
mainly batch oriented you could have an
interactive execution engine something
as space you could have hbase which is a
column oriented or a four dimensional
database and that would be not only
storing data on sdfs but would also need
some kind of processing you could have
streaming functionalities which would be
from storm or kafka or spark you could
have graph processing you could have
in-memory processing such as spark and
its components and you could have many
others so these are different frameworks
which could now run and which can run on
top of yarn so how does the undo that
now when we talk about yarn this is how
a overall yarn architecture looks so at
one end you have the client now client
could be basically your edge node where
you have some applications which are
running it could be an api which would
want to interact with your cluster it
could be a user triggered application
which wants to run some jobs which are
doing some processing so this client
would submit a job request now what is
resource manager doing resource manager
is the master of your processing layer
in hadoop version 1 we basically had job
tracker and then we had task trackers
which were running on individual nodes
so your task trackers were sending your
heart beats to the job tracker your task
trackers were sending it their resource
information and job tracker was the one
which was tracking the resources and it
was doing the job scheduling and that's
how as i mentioned earlier job tracker
was overburdened so job tracker is now
replaced by your resource manager which
is the master for your processing layer
your task trackers are replaced by node
managers which would be then running on
every node and we have a temporary demon
which you see here in blue and that's
your app master so this is what we
mentioned when we say yet another
resource negotiator so appmaster would
be existing in a hadoop version 2. now
when we talk about your resource manager
resource manager is the master for
processing layer so it would already be
receiving heartbeats and you can say
resource information from multiple node
managers which would be running on one
or multiple machines and these node
managers are not only updating their
status but they are also giving an
information of the amount of resources
they have now when we talk about
resources we should understand that if
i'm talking about this node manager then
this has been allocated some amount of
ram for processing and some amount of
cpu cores and that is just a portion of
what the complete node has so if my node
has say imagine my node has around 100
gb ram and i have saved 60 cores all of
that cannot be allocated to node manager
so node manager is just one of the
components of hadoop ecosystem it is the
slave of the processing layer so we
could say keeping in all the aspects
such as different services which are
running might be cloudera or hortonworks
related services running system
processes running on a particular node
some portion of this would be assigned
to node manager for processing so we
could say for example say 60 gb ram per
node and say 40 cpu cores so this is
what is allocated for the node manager
on every machine similarly we would have
here similarly we would have here so
node manager is constantly giving an
update to resource manager about the
resources what it has probably there
might be some other applications running
and node manager is already occupied so
it gives an update now we also have a
concept of containers which is basically
we will we will talk about which is
about these resources being broken down
into smaller parts so resource manager
is keeping a track of the resources
which every node manager has and it is
also responsible for taking care of the
job request how do these things happen
now as we see here resource manager at a
higher level you can always say this is
the processing master which does
everything but in reality it is not the
resource manager which is doing it but
it has internally different services or
components which are helping it to do
what it is supposed to do now let's look
further now as i mentioned your resource
manager has these
services or components which basically
helps it to do the things it is
basically a an architecture where
multiple components are working together
to achieve what yarn allows so resource
manager has mainly two components that
is your scheduler and applications
manager and these are at high level four
main components here so we talk about
resource manager which is the processing
master you have node managers which are
the processing slaves which are running
on every nodes you have the concept of
container and you have the concept of
application master how do all these
things work now let's look at yarn
components so resource manager basically
has two main components you can say
which assist resource manager in doing
what it is capable of so you have
scheduler and applications manager now
there is when you talk about
resources there is always a requirement
for the applications which need to run
on cluster of resources so your
application which has to run which was
submitted by client needs resources and
these resources are coming in from
multiple machines wherever the relevant
data is stored and a node manager is
running so we always know that node
manager is co-located with data nodes
now what does the scheduler do so we
have different kind of schedulers here
we have basically a capacity scheduler
we have a fair scheduler or we could
have a fifo scheduler so there are
different schedulers which take care of
resource allocation so your scheduler is
responsible for allocating resources to
various running applications now imagine
a particular environment where you have
different teams or different departments
which are working on the same cluster so
we would call the cluster as a
multi-tenant cluster and on the
multi-tenant cluster you would have
different applications which would want
to run simultaneously accessing the
resources of the cluster how is that
managed so there has to be some
component which has a concept of pooling
or queuing so that different departments
or different users can get dedicated
resources or can share resources on the
cluster so scheduler is responsible for
allocating resources to various running
applications now it does not perform
monitoring or tracking of the status of
applications that's not the part of
scheduler it does not offer any
guarantee about restarting the failed
tasks due to hardware or network or any
other failures scheduler is mainly
responsible for allocating resources now
as i mentioned you could have different
kind of schedulers you could have a fifo
scheduler which was mainly in older
version of hadoop which stands for first
in first out you could have a fair
scheduler which basically means
multiple applications could be running
in the cluster and they would have a
fair share of the resources you could
have a capacity scheduler which would
basically have dedicated or fixed amount
of resources across the cluster now
whichever scheduler is being used
scheduler is mainly responsible for
allocating resources then it's your
applications manager now this is
responsible for accepting job
submissions now as i said at higher
level we could always say resource
manager state doing everything it is
allocating the resources it is
negotiating the resources it is also
taking care of listening to the clients
and taking care of job submissions but
who is doing it in real it is these
components so you have applications
manager which is responsible for
accepting job submissions it negotiates
the first container for executing the
application specific application master
it provides the service for restarting
the application master now how does this
work how do these things happen in
coordination now as i said your node
manager is the slave process which would
be running on every machine slave is
tracking the resources what it has it is
tracking the processes it is taking care
of running the jobs and basically it is
tracking each container resource
utilization so let's understand what is
this container so normally when you talk
about a application request which comes
from a client so let's say this is my
client which is requesting or which is
coming up with an application which
needs to run on the cluster now this
application could be anything it first
contacts your master that's your
resource manager which is the master for
your processing layer now as i mentioned
and as we already know that your name
node which is the master of your cluster
has the metadata in its ram which is
aware of the data being split into
blocks the blocks when stored on
multiple machines and other information
so obviously there was a interaction
with the master which has given this
information of the relevant nodes where
the data exists now for the processing
need your client basically the
application which needs to run on the
cluster so your resource manager which
basically has the scheduler which takes
care of allocating resources resource
manager has mainly these two components
which are helping it to do its work now
for a particular application which might
be needing data from multiple machines
now we know that we would have multiple
machines where we would have node
manager running we would have a data
node running and data nodes are
responsible for storing the data on disk
so your resource manager has to
negotiate the resources now when i say
negotiating the resources it could
basically ask each of these node
managers for some amount of resources
for example it would be saying can i
have 1 gb of ram and 1 cpu core from you
because there is some data residing on
your machine and that needs to be
processed as part of my application can
i again have one gb and one cpu core
from you and this is again because some
relevant data is stored and this request
which resource manager makes of holding
the resources of total resources which
the node manager has your resource
manager is negotiating or is asking for
resources from the processing slave so
this request of holding resources can be
considered as a container so resource
manager now we know it is not actually
the resource manager but it is the
application manager which is negotiating
the resources so it negotiates the
resources which
are called container so this request of
holding resource can be considered as a
container so basically a container can
be of different sizes we will talk about
that so resource manager negotiates the
resources with node manager now node
manager which is already giving an
update of the resources it has
what amount of resources it holds how
much busy it is can basically approve or
deny this request so node manager would
basically approve in saying yes i could
hold these resources i could give you
this container of this particular size
now once the container has been approved
or allocated or you can say granted by
your node manager resource manager now
knows that resources to process the
application are available and guaranteed
by the node manager so resource manager
starts a temporary demon called
appmaster so this is a piece of code
which would also be running in one of
the containers it would be running in
one of the containers which would then
take care of execution of tasks in other
containers so your application master is
per application so if i would have 10
different applications coming in from
the client then we would have 10 app
masters one app master being responsible
for per application now what does this
app master do it basically is a piece of
code which is responsible for execution
of the application so your app master
would run in one of the containers and
then it would use the other containers
which node manager is guaranteed that it
will give when the request application
request comes to it and using these
containers the app master will run the
processing tasks within these designated
resources so it is mainly the
responsibility of application master to
get the execution done and then
communicate it to the master so resource
manager is tracking the resources it is
negotiating the resources and once the
resources have been negotiated it
basically gives the control to
application master application master is
then running within one of the
containers on one of the nodes and using
the other containers to take care of
execution this is how it looks so
basically container as i said is a
collection of resources like cpu memory
your disk which would be used or which
already has the data and network so your
node manager is basically looking into
the request from application master
and it basically is granting this
request or basically is allocating these
containers now again we could have
different sizing of the containers let's
take an example here so as i mentioned
from the total resources which are
available for a particular node some
portion of resources are allocated to
the node manager so let's imagine this
is my node where node manager as a
processing slave is running so from the
total resources which the node has some
portion of ram and cpu cores is
basically allocated to the node manager
so i could say out of total 100 gb ram
we can say around
60 cores which the particular node has
so this is my ram which the node has and
these are the cpu cores which the node
has some portion of it right so we can
say might be
70 or 60 percent of the total resources
so we could say around 60 gb ram and
then we could say around 40 v cores have
been allocated to node manager so there
are these settings which are given in
the yarn hyphen site file now apart from
this allocation that is 60 gb ram and
40v cores we also have some properties
which say what will be the container
sizes so for example we could have a
small container setting which could say
my every container could have 2gb ram
and say one virtual cpu core so this is
my smallest container so based on the
total resources you could calculate how
many such small containers could be
running so if i say 2gb ram then i could
have around 30 containers but then i am
talking about one virtual cpu core so
totally i could have around 30
small
containers which could be running in
parallel on a particular node and as of
that calculation you would say 10 cpu
cores are not being utilized you could
have a bigger container size which could
say i would go for 2 cpu cores and 3gb
ram
so 3gb ram and 2 cpu cores so that would
give me around 20 containers of bigger
size so this is the container sizing
which is again defined in the yarn
hyphen site file so what we know is on a
particular node which has this kind of
allocation either we could have 30 small
containers running or we could have 20
big containers running and same would
apply to multiple nodes so node manager
based on the request from application
master can allocate these containers now
remember it is within this one of these
containers you would have an application
master running and other containers
could be used for your processing
requirement application master which is
per application it is the one which uses
these resources it basically manages or
uses these resources for individual
application so remember if we have 10
applications running on yarn then it
would be 10 application masters one
responsible for each application your
application master is the one which also
interacts with the scheduler to
basically know how much amount of
resources could be allocated for one
application and your application master
is the one which uses these resources
but it can never negotiate for more
resources to node manager application
master cannot do that application master
has to always go back to resource
manager if it needs more resources so it
is always the resource manager an
internally resource manager component
that is application manager which
negotiates the resources at any point of
time due to some node failures or due to
any other requirements if application
master
needs
more resources on one or multiple nodes
it will always be contacting the
resource manager internally the
applications manager for more containers
now this is how it looks so your client
submits the job request to resource
manager now we know that resource
manager internally has scheduler an
applications manager node managers which
are running on multiple machines are the
ones which are tracking their resources
giving this information to the source
manager so that resource manager or i
would say its component applications
manager could request resources from
multiple node managers when i say
request resources it is these containers
so your resource manager basically will
request for the resources on one or
multiple nodes node manager is the one
which approves these containers and once
the container has been approved your
resource manager triggers a piece of
code that is application master which
obviously needs some resources so it
would run in one of the containers and
will use other containers to do the
execution so your client submits an
application to resource manager resource
manager allocates a container or i would
say this is at a high level right
resource manager is negotiating the
resources and internally who is
negotiating the resources it is your
applications manager who is granting
this request it is node manager and
that's how we can say resource manager
locates a container application master
basically contacts the related node
manager because it needs to use the
containers node manager is the one which
launches the container or basically
gives those resources within which an
application can run an application
master itself will then accommodate
itself in one of the containers and then
use other containers for the processing
and it is within these containers the
actual execution happens now that could
be a map task that could be a reduced
task that could be a spark executor
taking care of spark tasks and many
other processing
so before we look into the demo on how
yarn works i would suggest looking into
one of the blogs from cloudera so you
can just look for yarn untangling and
this is really a good blog which
basically talks about the overall
functionality which i explained just now
so as we mentioned here so you basically
have the master process you have the
worker process which basically takes
care of your processing your resource
manager being the master and node
manager being the slave this also talks
about the resources which each node
manager has
it talks about the yarn configuration
file where you give all these properties
it basically shows you node manager
which reports the amount of resources it
has to resource manager now remember if
worker node shows 18 to 8 cpu cores and
128 gb ram and if your node manager says
64 v cores and ram 128 gb then that's
not the total capacity of your node it
is some portion of your node which is
allocated to node manager now once your
node manager reports that your resource
manager is requesting for containers
based on the application what is a
container it is basically a logical name
given to a combination of vcore and
ram
it is within this container where you
would have basically the process running
so once your application starts and once
node manager is guaranteed these
containers your application or your
resource manager has basically already
started an application master within the
container and what does that application
master do it uses the other containers
where the tasks would run so this is a
very good blog which you can refer to
and this also talks about mapreduce if
you have already followed the mapreduce
tutorials in past then you would know
about the different kind of tasks that
is map and reduce and these map and
reduce tasks could be running within the
container in one or multiple as i said
it could be map task it could be reduced
task it could be a spark based task
which would be running within the
container now once the task finishes
basically that resources can be freed up
so the container is released and the
resources are given back to yarn so that
it can take care of further processing
if you'll further look in this blog you
can also look into the part two of it
where you talk mainly about
configuration settings you can always
look into this which talks about why and
how much resources are allocated to the
node manager it basically talks about
your operating system overhead it talks
about other services it talks about
clouded our hotend works related
services running and other processes
which might be running and based on that
some portion of ram and cpu cores would
be allocated to node manager so that's
how it would be done in the yarn hyphen
site file and this basically shows you
what is the total amount of memory and
cpu cores which is allocated to node
manager then within every machine where
you have a node manager running on every
machine in the yarn hyphen site file you
would have such properties which would
say what is the minimum container size
what is the maximum container size in
terms of ram what is the minimum for cpu
cores what is the maximum for cpu cores
and what is the incremental size in
where ram and cpu cores can increment so
these are some of the properties which
define how containers are allocated for
your application request so have a look
at this and this could be a good
information which talks about different
properties now you can look further
which talks about scheduling if you look
in this particular blog which also talks
about scheduling where it talks about
scheduling in yarn which talks about
fair scheduler or you basically having
different cues in which allocations can
be done you also have different ways in
which queues can be managed and
different schedulers can be used so you
can always look at this series of blog
you can also be checking for yarn
schedulers and then search for a
hadoop
definitive
guide and that could give you some
information on how it looks when you
look for hadoop definitive guide so if
you look into this book which talks
about the different resources as i
mentioned so you could have a fee for
scheduler that is first in first out
which basically means if a long running
application is submitted to the cluster
all other small running applications
will have to wait there is no other way
but that would not be a preferred option
if you look in fifo scheduler if you
look for capacity scheduler it basically
means that you could have different
queues created and those queues would
have resources allocated so then you
could have a production queue where
production jobs are running in a
particular queue which has fixed amount
of resources allocated you could have a
development queue where development jobs
are running and both of them are running
in parallel you could then also look
into fair scheduler which basically
means again multiple applications could
be running on the cluster however they
would have a fair share so when i say
fair share in brief what it means is
if i had given 50 percent of resources
to a queue for production and 50 percent
of resources for a queue of development
and if both of them are running in
parallel then they would have access to
50 percent of cluster resources however
if one of the queue is unutilized then
second queue can utilize all cluster
resources so look into the fair
scheduling part it also shows you about
how allocations can be given and you can
learn more about schedulers and how cues
can be used for managing multiple
applications now we will spend some time
in looking into few ways or few quick
ways in interacting with yarn in the
form of a demo to understand and learn
on how
yarn works we can look into a particular
cluster now here we have a designated
cluster which can be used you could be
using the similar kind of commands on
your apache based cluster or a cloudera
quick start vm if you already have or if
you have a cloud error or a hortonworks
cluster running there are different ways
in which we can interact with yarn and
we can look at the information one is
basically looking into the admin console
so if i would look into cloud data
manager which is basically an admin
console for a cloudera's distribution of
hadoop similarly you could have a
hortonworks cluster than access to the
admin console so if you have even read
access for your cluster and if you have
the admin console then you can search
for yarn as a service which is running
you can click on yarn as a service and
that gives you different tabs so you
have the instances which tells basically
what are the different roles for your
yarn service running so we have here
multiple node managers now some of them
showing stop status but that's nothing
to worry so we have three and six node
managers we have resource manager which
is one but then that can also be in a
high availability where you can have
active and standby you also have a job
history server which would show you the
applications once they have completed
now you can look at the yarn
configurations and as i was explaining
you can always look for the properties
which are related to the allocation so
you can here search for
course and that should show you the
properties which talk about the
allocations so here if we see we can be
looking for
yarn app mapreduce application master
resource cpu course what is the cpu
course allocated for mapreduce map task
reduce task you can be looking at yarn
node manager resource cpu course which
basically says every node manager on
every node would be allocated with six
cpu cores and the container sizing is
with minimum allocation of one cpu core
and the maximum could be two cpu cores
similarly you could also be searching
for memory allocation and here you could
then scroll down to see what kind of
memory allocation has been done for the
node manager so if we look further it
should give me information of node
manager which basically says here that
the container minimum allocation is 2 gb
the maximum is 3 gb and we can look at
node manager which has been given 25 gb
per node so it's a combination of this
memory and cpu cores which is the total
amount of resources which have been
allocated to every node manager now we
can always look into applications tab
that would show us different
applications which are submitted on yarn
for example right now we see there is a
spark application running which is
basically a user who is using spark
shell which has triggered a application
on spark and that is running on yarn you
can look at different applications
workload information you can always do a
search based on the number of days how
many applications have run and so on you
can always go to the web ui and you can
be searching for the resource manager
web ui and if you have access to that it
will give you overall information of
your cluster so this basically says that
here we have 100 gb memory allocated so
that could be say 25 gb per node and if
we have four node managers running and
we have 24 cores which is six cores per
node if we look further here into nodes
i could get more information so this
tells me that i have four node managers
running and node managers basically have
25 gb memory allocated per node and six
cores out of which some portion is being
utilized we can always look at the
scheduler here which can give us
information what kind of scheduler has
been allocated so we basically see that
there is just a root cue and within root
you have default queue and you have
basically user's queue based on
different users we can always scroll
here and that can give us information if
it is a fair share so here we see that
my root dot default has 50 percent of
resources and the other queue also has
50 percent of resources which also gives
me an idea that a fair scheduler is
being used we can always confirm that if
we are using a fair scheduler or a
capacity scheduler which takes care of a
location so search for scheduler
and that should give you some
understanding of what kind of scheduler
is being used and what are the
allocations given for that particular
scheduler so here we have fair scheduler
it shows me you have under root you have
the root q which has been given hundred
100 capacity and then you have within
that default which also takes 100
so this is how you can understand about
yarn by looking into the yarn web ui you
can be looking into the configurations
you can look at applications you can
always look at different actions now
since we do not have admin access the
only information we have is to download
the client configuration we can always
look at the history server which can
give us information of all the
applications which have successfully
completed now this is from your yarn ui
what i can also do is i can be going
into hue which is the web interface and
your web interface also basically allows
you to look into the jobs so you can
click on hue web ui and if you have
access to that it should show up or you
should have a way to get to your hue
which is a graphical user interface
mainly comes with your cloud error you
can also configure that with apache
hortonworks has a different way of
giving you the web ui access you can
click and get into hue and that is also
one way where you can look at yarn you
can look at the jobs which are running
if there are some issues with it and
these these are your web interfaces so
either you look from
yarn web ui or here in hue you have
something called as job browser which
can also give you information of your
different applications which might have
run so here i can just remove this one
which would basically give me a list of
all the different kind of jobs or
workflows which were run so either it
was a spark based application or it was
a map reduce or it was coming from hive
so here i have list of all the
applications and it says this was a
mapreduce this was a spark something was
killed something was successful
and this was basically a probably a hive
query which triggered a mapreduce job
you can click on the application and
that tells you how many tasks were run
for it so there was a map task which ran
for it you can get into the metadata
information which you can obviously you
can also look from the yarn ui to look
into your applications which can give
you a detailed information of if it was
a map reduce how many map and reduce
tasks were run what were the different
counters if it was a spark application
it can let you follow through spark
history server or job history server so
you can always use the web ui to look
into the jobs you can be finding in lot
of useful information here you can also
be looking at how many resources were
used and what happened to the job was it
successful did it fail and what was the
job status now apart from
web ui which always you might not have
access to so in a particular cluster in
a production cluster there might be
restrictions and the organization might
not have
access given to all the users to
graphical user interface like you or
might be you would not have access to
the cloud era manager or admin console
because probably organization is
managing multiple clusters using this
admin console so the one way which you
would have access is your web console or
basically your edge node or client
machine from where you can connect to
the cluster and then you can be working
so let's log in here and now here we can
give different commands so this is the
command line from where you can have
access to different details you can
always check by just typing in map red
which gives you different options where
you can look at the map reduce related
jobs you can look at different queues if
there are queues configured you can look
at the history server or you can also be
doing some admin stuff provided you have
access so for example if i just say map
red and q here this basically gives me
an option says what would you want to do
would you want to list all the queues do
you want information on a particular
queue so let's try a list
and that should give you different
queues which were being used now here we
know that per user a queue dynamically
gets created which is under root dot
users and that gives me what is the
status of the queue what is the capacity
has there been any kind of maximum
capacity or capping done so we get to
see a huge list of queues which
dynamically get configured in this
environment and then you also look at
your root dot default i could have also
picked up one particular queue and i
could have said show me the jobs so i
could do that now here we can also give
a yarn command so let me just clear the
screen and i will say yarn and that
shows me different options so apart from
your web interface
something like web ui apart from your
yarn's web ui you could also be looking
for information using yarn commands here
so these are some list of commands which
we can check now you can just type in
yarn and version if you would want to
see the version which basically gives
you information of what is the hadoop
version being used and what is the
vendor-specific distribution version so
here we see we are working on cloudera's
distribution 5.14 which is internally
using hadoop 2.6 now similarly you can
be doing a yarn application list so if
you give this that could be an
exhaustive list of all the applications
which are running or applications which
have completed so here we don't see any
applications because right now probably
there are no applications which are
running it also shows you you could be
pulling out different status such as
submitted accepted or running now you
could also say i would want to see the
services that i finished running so i
could say yarn application list and app
state says finished so here we could be
using our command so i could say yarn
list
and then i would want to see the app
states which gives me the applications
which have finished and we would want to
list all the applications which finished
now there that might be applications
which succeeded right and there is a
huge list of application which is coming
in from the history server which is
basically showing you the huge list of
applications which have completed so
this is one way and then you could also
be searching for one particular
application if you would want to search
a particular application if you have the
application id you could always be doing
a grip that's a simple way i could say
basically let's pick up this one and if
i would want to search for this if i
would want more details on this i could
obviously do that
by calling in my previous command and
you could do a grip if that's what you
want to do and if you would want to
search is there any application which is
in the list of my applications that
shows my application i could pull out
more information about my application so
i could look at the log files for a
particular application by giving the
application id so i could say yarn logs
now that's an option and every time
anytime you have a doubt just hit enter
it will always give you options what you
need to give with a particular command
so i can say yarn logs application
id now we copied an application id and
we could just give it here we could give
other options like app owner or if you
would want to get into the container
details or if you would want to check on
a particular node now here i am giving
yarn logs and then i'm pointing it to
an application id and it says the log
aggregation has not completed might be
this was might be this was an
application which was triggered based on
a particular interactive shell or based
on a particular query so there is no log
existing for this particular application
you can always look at the status of an
application you can kill an application
so here you can be saying yan yan
application and then what would you want
to do with an application hit and enter
it shows you the different options so we
just tried app states you could always
look at the last one which says status
and then for my status i could be giving
my application id so that tells me what
is the status of this application it
connects to the resource manager it
tells me what's the application id what
kind of application it was who ran it
which was the queue where the job was
running what was the start and end time
what is the progress the status of it if
it is finished or if it has succeeded
and then it basically gives me also an
information of where the application
master was running it gives me the
information where you can find this job
details in history server if you are
interested in looking into it also gives
you a aggregate resource allocation
which tells how much gb memory and how
many c core seconds it used so this is
basically looking out at the application
details now i could kill an application
if the application was already running i
could always do a yarn application
minus skill and then i could be giving
my application now i could try killing
this however it would say the
application is already finished if i had
an application running and if my
application was already given an
application id by resource manager i
could just kill it i can also say yarn
node list which should give me a list of
the node managers now this is what we
were looking from the yarn web ui and we
were pulling out the information so we
can get this and kind of information
from your command line always remember
and always try to be well accustomed
with the command line so you can do
various things from the command line and
then obviously you have the web uis
which can help you with a graphical
interface easily able to access things
now you could be also starting the
resource manager which we would not be
doing here because we are already
running in a cluster so you could give a
yarn resource manager you could get the
logs of resource manager if you would
want by giving yarn demon so we can try
that so you can say yarn and then demon
so it says it does not find the demon so
you can give something like this get
level and here i will have to give the
node and the ip address where you want
to check the logs of resource manager so
you could be giving this for which we
will have to then get into cloud error
manager to look into the nodes and the
ip address you could be giving a command
something like this which basically
gives you the level of the log which you
have and i got this resource manager
address from the web ui now i can be
giving in this command to look into the
demand log and it basically says you
would want to look at the resource
manager related log and you have the log
4j which is being used for logging the
kind of level which has been set as info
which can again be changed in the way
you're logging the information now you
can try any other commands also from
yarn for example looking at the yarn rm
admin so you can always do a yarn rm
admin and this basically gives you a lot
of other informations like refreshing
the cues or refreshing the nodes or
basically looking at the admin acls or
getting groups so you could always get
group names for a particular user now we
could search for a particular user such
as yarn or hdfs itself so i could just
say here i would want
get
groups and then i could be searching for
say username hdfs so that tells me sdfs
belongs to a hadoop group similarly you
could search for say map red or you
could search for yarn so these are
service related users which
automatically get created and you can
pull out information related to these
you can always do a refresh nodes kind
of command and that is mainly done
internally this can be useful when
you're doing commissioning
decommissioning but then in case of
cloudera or hortonworks kind of cluster
you would not be manually giving this
command because if you are doing a
commissioning decommissioning from an
admin console and if you are an
administrator then you could just
restart the services which are affected
and that will take care of this but if
you were working in an apache cluster
and if you were doing commissioning
decommissioning then you would be using
in two commands refresh nodes and
basically that's for refreshing the
notes which should not be used for
processing and similarly you could have
a command refresh notes which comes with
sdfs so these are different options
which you can use with your yarn on the
command line you could also be using
curl commands to get more information
about your cluster by giving curl minus
x and then basically pointing out to
your resource manager web ui address now
here i would like to print out the
cluster related metrics and i could just
simply do this which basically gives me
a high level information of how many
applications were submitted how many are
pending what is the reserved resources
what is the available amount of memory
or cpu cores and all the information
similarly you can be using the same curl
commands to get more information like
scheduler information so you would just
replace the metrics with scheduler and
you could get the information of the
different queues now that's a huge list
we can cancel this and that would give
me a list of all the queues which are
allocated and what are the resources
allocated for each queue you could also
get cluster information on application
ids and status running of applications
running in yarn so you would have to
replace the last bit of it and you would
say i would want to look at the
applications and that gives me a huge
list of applications then you can do a
grip and you can be filtering out
specific application related information
similarly you can be looking at the
nodes so you can always be looking at
node specific information which gives
you how many nodes you have but this
could be mainly used when you have an
application which wants to or a web
application which wants to use a curl
command and would want to get
information about your cluster from an
http interface now when it comes to
application we can basically try running
a simple or a sample mapreduce job which
could then be triggered on yarn and it
would use the resources now i can look
at my application here and i can be
looking into my specific directory which
is this one which should have lot of
files and directories which we have here
now i could pick up one of these and i
could be using a simple example to do
some processing let's take up this file
so there is a file and i could run a
simple word count or i could be running
a hive query which triggers a mapreduce
job i could even run a spark application
which would then show that the
application is running on the cluster so
for example if i would say spark to
shell now i know that this is an
interactive way of working with spark
but this internally triggers a spark
submit and this runs an application so
here when you do a spark to shell by
default it will contact yarn so it gets
an application id it is running on yarn
with the master being yarn and now i
have access to the interactive way of
working with spark now if i go and look
into applications i should be able to
see my application which has been
started here and it shows up here so
this is my application 3827
which has been started on yarn and as of
now we can also look into the yarn ui
and that shows me the application which
has been started which basically has one
running container which has one cpu core
allocated 2gb ram and it's in progress
although we are not doing anything there
so we can always look at our application
from the yarn ui or as i mentioned from
your applications tab within yarn
services which gives us the information
and you can even click on this
application to follow and see more
information but you should be given
access to that now this is just a simple
application which i triggered using
spark shell similarly i can basically be
running a mapreduce now to run a
mapreduce i can say hadoop jar and that
basically needs a class so we can look
for the default path which is opt cloud
error parcels cdh
lib hadoop mapreduce hadoop mapreduce
examples and then we can look at this
particular jar file and if i hit on
enter it shows me the different classes
which are part of this jar and here i
would like to use word count so i could
just give this i could say word count
now remember i could run the job in a
particular queue by giving in an
argument here so i could say minus d map
red dot job dot q
dot name and then i can point my job to
a particular queue i can even give
different arguments in saying i would
want my mapreduce output to be
compressed or i want it to be stored in
a particular directory and so on so here
i have the word count and then basically
what i can be doing is i can be pointing
it to a particular input path
and then i can have my output which can
be getting stored here again a directory
which we need to choose and i will say
output
new and i can submit my job now once i
have submitted my job it connects to
resource manager it basically gets a job
id it gets an application id it shows
you from where you can track your
application you can always go to the
yarn ui and you can be looking at your
application and the resources it is
using so my application was not a big
one and it has already completed it
triggered one map task it launched one
reduced task it was working on around 12
466 records where you have then the
output of map which is these many number
of output records which was then taken
by a combiner and finally by a reducer
which basically gives you the output so
this is my on application which has
completed now i could be looking into
the yarn ui and if my job has completed
you might not see your application here
so as of now it shows up here the word
count which i ran it also shows me my
previous spark shell job it shows me my
application is completed and if you
would want further information on this
you can click and go to the history
server if you have been given access to
it or directly go to the history server
web ui where your application shows up
it shows how many map and reduce tasks
it was running you can click on this
particular application which basically
gives you information of your map and
reduce tasks you can look at different
counters for your application right you
can always look at map specific tasks
you can always look into one particular
task what it did on which node it was
running or you can be looking at the
complete application log so you can
always click on the logs and here you
have click here for full log which gives
you the information and you can always
look for your application which can give
you information of app master being
launched or you could have
search for the word container so you
could see a job which needs one or
multiple containers and then you could
say container is being requested then
you could see container is being
allocated then you can see what is the
container size and then basically your
task moves from initializing to running
in the container and finally you can
even search for release which will tell
you that the container was released so
you can always look into the log for
more information so this is how you can
interact with yarn this is how you can
interact with your command line to look
for more information or using your yarn
web ui or you can also be looking into
your hue for more information welcome to
scoop tutorial one of the many features
of the hadoop ecosystem for the hadoop
file system what's in it for you today
we're going to cover the need for scoop
what is scoop scoop features scoop
architecture scoop import scoop export
scoop processing and then finally we'll
have a little hands-on demo on scoop so
you can see what it looks like so where
does the need for scoop come in in our
big data hadoop file system processing
huge volumes of data requires loading
data from diverse sources into hadoop
cluster you can see here we have our
data processing and this process of
loading data from the heterogeneous
sources comes with a set of challenges
so what are the challenges maintaining
data consistency ensuring efficient
utilization of resources especially when
you're talking about big data we can
certainly use up the resources when
importing terabytes and petabytes of
data over the course of time loading
bulk data to hadoop was not possible
it's one of the big challenges that came
up when they first had the hadoop file
system going and loading data using
script was very slow in other words
you'd write a script in whatever
language you're in and then it would
very slowly load each piece and parse it
in so the solution scoop scooped helped
in overcoming all the challenges to
traditional approach and could lead bulk
data from rdbms to hadoop very easily so
thank your enterprise server you want to
take the from mysql or your sql and you
want to bring that data into your hadoop
warehouse your data filing system and
that's where scoop comes in so what
exactly is scoop scoop is a tool used to
transfer bulk of data between hadoop and
external data stores such as relational
databases and my sql server or the
microsoft sql server or my sql server so
scoop equals sql plus hadoop and you can
see here we have our rdbms all the data
we have stored on there and then your
scoop is the middle ground and brings
the import into the hadoop file system
it also is one of the features that goes
out and grabs the data from hadoop and
exports it back out into an rdbms let's
take a look at scoop features sku
features has parallel import and export
it has import results of sql query
connectors for all major rdbms databases
kerberos security integration provides
full and incremental load so we look at
parallel import and export scoop uses
yarn yet another resource negotiator
framework to import and export data this
provides fault tolerance on a top of
parallelism scoop allows us to import
the result returned from an sql carry
into the hadoop file system or the hdfs
and you can see here where the import
results of sql query come in scoop
provides connectors for multiple
relational database management system
rdbms's databases such as mysql and
microsoft sql server and has connectors
for all major rdbms databases scoop
supports kerberos computer network
authentication protocol that allows
nodes communicating over a non-secure
network to prove their identity to one
another in a secure manner scoop can
load the whole table or parts of the
table by a single command hence it
supports full and incremental load let's
dig a little deeper into the scoop
architecture we have our client in this
case a hooded wizard behind his laptop
you never know who's going to be
accessing the hadoop cluster and the
client comes in and sends their command
which goes into scoop the client submits
the import export command to import or
export data data from different
databases is fetched by scoop and so we
have
enterprise data warehouse document based
systems you have connect connector for
your data warehouse a connector for
document based systems which reaches out
to those two entities and we have our
connector for the rdbms so connectors
help in working with a range of popular
databases multiple mappers perform map
tasks to load the data onto hdfs the
hedo file system and you can see here we
have the map task if you remember from
hadoop hadoop is based on map reduce
because we're not reducing the data
we're just mapping it over it only
accesses the mappers and it opens up
multiple mappers to do parallel
processing and you can see here the hdfs
hbase hive is where the target is for
this particular one similarly multiple
map tests will export the data from hdfs
onto rdbms using scoop export command so
just like you can import it you can now
export it using the multiple map
routines scoop import so here we have
our dbms data store and we have the
folders on there so maybe it's your
company's database maybe it's an archive
at google with all the searches going on
whatever it is usually you think with
scoop you think sql you think mysql
server or microsoft sql server that kind
of setup
so it gathers the metadata and you see
the scoop import so introspect database
together metadata primary key
information and then it submits uh so
you can see submits map only job
remember we talked about mapreduce it
only needs the map side of it because
we're not reducing the data we're just
mapping it over scoop divides the input
data set into splits and uses individual
map tests to push the splits into hdfs
so right into the hadoop file system and
you can see down on the right is kind of
a small depiction of a hadoop cluster
and then you have scoop export so we're
going to go the other direction and with
the other direction you have your hadoop
file system storage which is your hadoop
cluster you have your scoop job and each
one of those clusters then gets a map
mapper comes out to each one of the
computers that has data on it
so the first step is you've got to
gather the metadata so step one you
gather the metadata step two submits map
only job introspect database together
metadata primary key information scoop
divides the input data set into splits
and uses individual map tests to push
the splits to rdbms scoop will export
hadoop files back to rdms tables you can
think of this in a number of different
manners one of them would be if you're
restoring a backup from the hadoop file
system into your enterprise machines
there's certainly many others as far as
exploring data and data science so as we
dig a little deeper into scoop input we
have our connect our jdbc and our url so
specify the jdbc connect string
connecting manager we specify the
connection manager class to use you can
see here driver with the class name
manually specify the jdbc driver class
to use hadoop mapreduce home directory
override hadoop mapped home username set
authentication username and of course
help print usage instructions and with
the export you'll see that we can
specify the jdbc connect string specify
the connection manager class to use
manually specify jdbc driver class to
use you do have to let it know to
override the hadoop map reduce home and
that's true on both of these and set
authentication username and finally you
can print out all your help setup so you
can see the format for scoop is pretty
straightforward both import and export
so let's uh continue on our path and
look at scoop processing and what the
computer goes through for that and we
talk about scoop processing first scoop
runs in the hadoop cluster it imports
data from the rdbms the nosql database
to the hadoop file system so remember we
might not be importing the data from a
rdbms it might actually be coming from
an osql sql there's many out there it
uses mappers to slice the incoming data
into multiple formats and load the data
into hdfs it exports data back into an
rdbms while making sure that the schema
of the data in the database is
maintained so now that we've looked at
the basic commands in our scoop in the
scoop processing or at least the basics
as far as theory is concerned let's just
jump in and take a look at a demo on
scoop
for this demo i'm going to use our
cloudera quick start if you've been
watching our other demos we've done
you'll see that we've been using that
pretty consistently certainly this will
work in any of your
your horton sandbox which is also a
single node testing machine cloudera is
one of um there's a docker version
instead of virtualbox and you can also
set up your own hadoop cluster plan a
little extra time if you're not an admin
it's actually a pretty
significant endeavor for an admin if
you've been admitting linux machines for
a very long time and you know a lot of
the commands i find for most admins it
takes them about two to four hours the
first time they go in and create a
virtual machine and set up their own
hadoop in this case though when you're
just learning and getting set up best to
start with cloudera cloudera also
includes an installed version of mysql
that way you don't have to install the
the sql version for importing data from
and 2. once you're in the cloudera quick
start you'll see it opens a nice centos
linux
interface and it has the desktop setup
on there this is really nice for
learning so you're not just looking at
command lines and from in here it should
open up by default to hue if not you can
click on hue here's a kind of a fun
little uh web-based interface under hue
i can go under query i can pick an
editor and we'll go right down to scoop
so now i'm just going to load the scoop
editor inner hue now i'm going to switch
over and do this all in command line i
just want to show that you can actually
do this in a hue through the web-based
interface the reason i like to do the
command line is specifically on my
computer it runs much quicker or if i do
the command line here and i run it it
tends to have an extra lag or an added
layer in it so for this we're going to
go ahead and open our command line the
second reason i do this is we're going
to need to go ahead and edit our
mysql so we have something to scoop in
otherwise i don't have anything going in
there and of course we zoom in we'll
zoom in this and increase the size of
our screen so for this demo our hands-on
i'm going to use oracle virtualbox
manager and the cloudera quick start if
you're not familiar with this we do have
another tutorial we put out and you can
send a note in the youtube video below
and let our team know and they'll send
you a link or come visit
www.simplylearn.com now this creates a
linux box on my windows computer so
we're going to be in linux and it'll be
the cloudera version
with scoop and we'll also be using mysql
mysql server once inside the cloudera
virtualbox we'll go under the hue editor
now we're going to do everything in
terminal window but i just want you to
be aware that under the hue editor you
can go under query editor and you'll see
as we come down here here's our scoop on
this so you can run your scoop from in
here now before we do this we have to do
a little exploration in my sql and my
sql server that way we know what data is
coming in so let me go ahead and open up
a terminal window in cloudera you have a
terminal window at the top here that you
can just click on it open it up and let
me just go ahead and zoom in on here go
view and zoom in now to get into my sql
server you simply type in mysql and this
part will depend on your setup now the
cloudera quickstart comes up that the
username is root and the password is
cloudera kind of a strange quirk is that
you can put a space between the minus u
and the root but not between the minus p
and the cloudera usually you'd put in a
minus capital p and then it prompts you
for your password on here for this demo
i don't worry too much about you knowing
the password on that so we'll just go
right into my sql server since this is
the standard password for this quick
start and you can see we're now into
mysql and we're going to do just a
couple of quick
commands in here there's show databases
and you follow by the semicolon that's
standard in most of these shell commands
so it knows it's the end of your shell
command and you'll see in here in the
quick start cloudera quickstart the
mysql comes with a standard set of
databases these are just
some of these have to do like with the
uzi which is the uzi part of hadoop
where others of these like customers and
employees and stuff like that those are
just for demo purposes they come as a
standard setup in there so that people
going in for the first time have a
database to play with which is really
good for us so we don't have to recreate
those databases and you will see in the
list here we have a retail underscore db
and then we can simply do uh use
retail underscore db this will set that
as a default in mysql and then we want
to go ahead and show the tables and if
we show the tables you can see under the
database the retail db database we have
categories customers departments order
items orders products so there's a
number of tables in here and we're going
to go ahead and just use a standard
sql command and if you did our hive
language you'll note remember it's the
same for hql also on this we're just
going to select star everything from
departments
so there's our departments table and
we're going to list everything on the
department's table and you'll see we've
got six lines in here and it has a
department id and a department name
two for fitness three for footwear so on
and so forth now at this point i can
just go ahead and exit but it's kind of
nice to have this data up here so we can
look at it and flip back and forth
between the screens so i'm going to open
up another terminal window and we'll go
ahead and zoom in on this also and it
isn't too important for this particular
setup but it's always kind of fun fun to
know what your setup you're working with
what is your host name and so we'll go
ahead and just type that in this is a
linux command and it's a
host name minus f and you see we're on
quick start cloudera no surprise there
now this next command is going to be a
little bit longer because we're going to
be doing our first scoop command and i'm
going to do two of them we're going to
list databases and list tables it's
going to take just a moment to get
through this
because there's a bunch of stuff going
on here so we have scoop we have list
databases we have connect and under the
connect command we need to let it know
how we're connecting we're going to use
the jdbc this is a very standard one
jdbc mysql so you'll see that if you're
doing an sql database that's how you
started off with and then the next part
this is where you have to go look it up
it's however it was created so if your
admin created a mysql server with a
certain setup that's what you have to go
by and you'll see that usually they list
this as localhost so you'll see
something like localhost sometimes
there's a lot of different formats but
the most common is either localhost or
the actual connection so in this case we
want to go ahead and do quickstart 3306.
and so quick start use the name of the
local host database and how it's hosted
on here and when you set up the quick
start for um for hadoop under cloudera
it's port 3306 is where that's coming in
so that's where all that's coming from
and so there's our path for that and
then we have to put in our password we
typically type password if you look it
up password on the cloudera quick start
is cloudera and we have to also let it
know the username and again if you're
doing this you'd probably put in a minus
capital you can actually just do it for
a prompt
for the password so if you leave that
out it'll prompt you but for this
doesn't really matter i don't care if
you see my password it's the default one
for cloudera quickstart and then the
username on here is simply root and then
we're going to put our semicolon at the
end and so we have here our full setup
and we go ahead and list the databases
and you'll see you might get some
warnings on here i haven't run the
updates on the quick start i suggest
you're not running the updates either if
you're doing this for the first time
because it'll do some reformatting on
there and it quickly pass up and you can
see here's all of our the tables we went
in there and if we go back to
on the previous window we should see
that these tables match so here we come
in and here we have our databases and
you can see back up here where we had
the cm customers employees and so on so
the databases match and then we want to
go ahead and list the
tables for a specific database so let's
go ahead and do that i'm a very lazy
typist so i'll put the up arrow in and
you can see here scoop list databases
we're just going to go back and change
this from databases to list tables so we
want to list the tables in here same
connection so most the connection is the
same except we need to know which tables
we're listing an interesting fact is you
can create a table without being under a
database so if you left this blank it
will show the open tables that aren't
connected directly to a database or
under a database but what we want to do
is right past this last slash on the
3306 we want to put that retail
underscore db because that's the
database we're going to be working with
and this will go in there and show the
tables listed under that database and
here we go we got categories customers
departments order items and products if
we flip back here real quick there it is
the same thing we had we had categories
customers departments order items and so
on and so let's go ahead and run our
first import command and again i'm that
lazy typer so we're going to do scoop
and instead of list tables we want to go
ahead and import so there's our import
command and so once we have our import
command in there then we need to tell it
exactly what we're going to import so
everything else is the same we're
importing from the retail db so we keep
that and then at the very end we're
going to tag on dash dash table that
tells us we can tell it what table we're
importing from and we're going to import
departments there we go so this is
pretty straightforward because it what's
nice about this is you can see the
commands are the same i got the same
connection um i change it for the
whatever database i'm in
then i come in here our password the
username are going to be the same that's
all under the mysql server setup and
then we let it know what table we're
entering in we run this and this is
going to actually go through the mapper
process in hadoop so this is a mapping
process it takes the data and it maps it
up to different parts in the setup in
hadoop on there and then saves that data
into the hadoop file system and it does
take it a moment to zip through which i
kind of skipped over for you since it is
running a you know it's designed to run
across the cluster not on a single node
so when you're running on a single node
it's going to run slow even if you
dedicate a couple cores to it i think i
put dedicated four cores to this one uh
and so you can see right down here we
get to the end it's now mapped in that
information and then we can go in here
we can go under can flip back to our hue
and under hue on the top i have there's
databases and the second icon over is
your hadoop file system and we can go in
here and look at the hadoop file system
and you'll see it show up underneath our
documents there it is departments
cloudera departments and you can see
there's always a delay when i'm working
in hue which i don't like
and that's the quick start issue that's
not necessarily running out on a server
when i'm running it on a server you
pretty much have to run through some
kind of server interface i still prefer
the terminal window it still runs a lot
quicker but we'll flip back on over here
to the command line and we can do the
hadoop type in the hadoop fs and then
list minus ls and if we run this you'll
see underneath our hadoop file system
there is our departments which has been
added in and we can also do uh hadoop
fs and this is kind of interesting for
those who've gone through the hadoop
file system everything you'll you'll
recognize this on here i'm going to list
it the contents of departments and
you'll see underneath departments uh we
have part part
m0001002003 and so this is interesting
because this is how hadoop saves these
files this is in the file system this is
not in hive so we didn't directly import
this into hive we put this in the hadoop
file system depending on what you're
doing you would then write the schema
for hive to look at the hadoop file
system certainly visit our hive tutorial
for more information on hive specific
so you can see in here are different
files that it forms that are part of
departments and we can do something like
this we can look at the contents of one
of these files fs minus ls or a number
of the files and we'll simply do the
full path which is user cloudera and
then we already know the next one is
departments
and then after departments we're going
to put slash part star so this is going
to say anything that has part in it
so we have part dash m 0 0 0 and so on
we can go ahead and cat use that cut
command or that list command to bring
those up and then we can use the cat
command to actually display the contents
and that's a linux command hadoop linux
command the cat captinate not to be
confused with catatonic catastrophic
there's a lot of cat got your tongue and
we see here fitness footwear apparel
that should look really familiar because
that's what we had in our mysql server
we went in here we did a select all on
here there it is fitness footwear
apparel golf outdoors and fan shop and
then of course it's really important
let's look back on over here to be able
to tell it where to put the data so we
go back to our import command so here's
our scoop import we have our connect we
have the db underneath our connection
our my sql server we have our password
our username the table going where it's
going to i mean the table where it's
coming from uh and then we can add a
target on here we can put in uh target
dash directory and you do have to put
the full path that's a hadoop thing it's
a good practice to be in and we're gonna
add it to department uh we'll just do
department one and so here we now add a
target directory in here and user
cloudera department one and this will
take just a moment before so i'll go
ahead and skip over the process since
it's going to run very slowly it's only
running on like i said a couple cores
and it's also on a single node and now
we can do the
hadoop let's just do the up arrow file
system list we want just straight list
and when we do the hadoop file system
minus ls or list you'll see that we now
have department one and we can of course
do list department one and you can see
we have the files inside department one
and they mirrored what we saw before
with the same files in there and the
part m o zero zero and so on if we want
to look at them it'd be the same thing
we did before with the cat so except
instead of departments
we'd be department one there we go
something that's going to come up with
the same data we had before now one of
the important things when you're
importing data and it's always a
question to ask is do you filter the
data before it comes in do we want to
filter this data as it comes in so we're
not storing everything in our file
system you would think hadoop big data
put it all in there i know from
experience that putting it all in there
can turn a couple hundred terabytes into
a petabyte very rapidly and suddenly
you're having to really add on to that
data store and you're storing duplicate
data sometimes so you really need to be
able to filter your data out and so
let's go ahead and use our up arrow to
go to our last import since it's still a
lot the same stuff
so we have all of our commands under
import we have the target
we're going to change this to department
2 so we're going to create a new
directory for this one and then after
departments there's another command that
we didn't really slide in here and
that's our mapping and i'll show you
what this looks like in a minute but
we're going to put m3 in there that
doesn't have nothing to do with the
filtering i'll show you that in a second
though what that's for and we just want
to put in where uh so where and what is
the where in this case we want to know
where department
id and if you want to know where that
came from we can flip back on over here
we have department underscore ids this
is where that's coming from that's just
the name of the column on here so we
come in here to department id
is greater than four simple um logic
there you can see where you'd use that
for maybe creating buckets for ages uh
you know age from 10 to 15 20 to 30. you
might be looking for i mean there's all
kinds of reasons why you could use the
where command on here and filter
information out maybe you're doing word
counting and you want to know words that
are used less than 100 times you want to
get rid of the and is and and all the
stuff that's used over and over again uh
so we'll go ahead and put the where and
then department id is greater than four
we'll go ahead and hit enter on here and
this will create our department two set
up on this uh and i'll go ahead and skip
over some of the runtime again it runs
really slow on a single node real quick
page through our commands
let's see here we go
our list and we should see underneath
the list the department 2 on here now
and there it is department 2 and then i
can go ahead and do list department two
you'll see the contents in here and
you'll see that there is only three maps
and it could be that the data created
three maps but remember i set it up to
only use three mappers uh so there's
zero one and two and we can go ahead and
do a cat on there remember this is
department two so we want to look at all
the contents of these three different
files and there it is it's greater than
four so we have golf is five outdoor six
uh fan shop is seven so we've
effectively filtered out our data and
just storing the data we want on our
file system so if you're going to store
data on here the next stage is to export
the data remember a lot of times you
have my sql server and we're continually
dumping that data into our long term
storage and access a hadoop file system
but what happens when you need to pull
that data out and
restore a database or
maybe you have
you just merged with a new company a
favorite topic merging companies and
merging databases that's listed under
nightmare and how many different names
for company can you have so you can see
where being able to export is also
equally important and let's go ahead and
do that and i'm going to flip back over
to my sql server here and we'll need to
go ahead and create our database we're
going to export into now i'm not going
to go too much in detail on this command
we're simply creating a table and the
table is going to have
it's pretty much the same table we
already have in here from departments
but in this case we're going to create a
table called dept
so it's the same setup but it's it's
just going to we're just giving a
different name a different schema and so
we've done that and we'll go ahead and
do a select star from e p t
there we go and it's empty that's what
we expect a new database a new data
table and it's empty in there uh so now
we need to go ahead and export our data
that we just filtered out into there so
let's flip back on over here to our
scoop setup which is just our linux
terminal window and let's go back up to
one of our commands here's scoop import
in this case instead of import we're
going to take the scoop and we're going
to export so we're going to just change
that export and the connection is going
to remain the same so same connect same
database we're also we're still doing
the retail db uh we have the same
password so none of that changes uh the
big change here is going to be the table
instead of departments uh remember we
changed it and gave it a new name and so
we want to change it here also d-e-p-t
so department we're not going to worry
about the mapper count and the where was
part of our import there we go and then
finally it needs to know where to export
from so instead of target directory we
have an export directory that's where
it's coming from uh still user cloudera
and we'll keep it as department 2. just
so you can see how that data is coming
back with that we filtered in and let's
go ahead and run this it'll take it just
a moment to go through with steps and
again because it's low i'm just going to
go and skip this so you don't have to
sit through it and once we've wrapped up
our export we'll flip back on over here
to mysql use the up arrow and this time
we're going to select star from
department and we can see that there it
is it exported the golf outdoors and fan
shop and you can imagine also that you
might have to use the where command in
your export also so there's a lot of
mixing the command line for scoop is
pretty straightforward you're changing
the different variables in there whether
you're creating a table listing a table
listing databases very powerful tool for
bringing your data into the hadoop file
system and exporting it so now that
we've wrapped up our demo on scoop and
gone through a lot of basic commands
let's dive in with a brief history of
hive so the history of hive begins with
facebook facebook began using hadoop as
a solution to handle the growing big
data and we're not talking about a data
that fits on one or two or even five
computers we're talking due to the fits
on if you've looked at any of our other
hadoop tutorials you'll know we're
talking about very big data and data
pools and facebook certainly has a lot
of data it tracks as we know the hadoop
uses mapreduce for processing data
mapreduce required users to write long
codes and so you'd have these really
extensive java codes very complicated
for the average person to use not all
users were versed in java and other
coding languages this proved to be a
disadvantage for them users were
comfortable with writing queries in sql
sql has been around for a long time the
standard sql query language hive was
developed with the vision to incorporate
the concepts of tables columns just like
sql so why hive well the problem was for
processing and analyzing data users
found it difficult to code as not all of
them were well-versed with the coding
languages you have your processing ever
analyzing and so the solution was
required a language similar to sql which
was well known to all the users and thus
the hive or hql language evolved what is
hive hive is a data warehouse system
which is used for querying and analyzing
large data sets stored in the hdfs or
the hadoop file system hive uses a query
language that we call hive ql or hql
which is similar to sql so if we take
our user the user sends out their hive
queries and then that is converted into
a map reduce tasks and then accesses the
hadoop mapreduce system let's take a
look at the architecture of hive
architecture of hive we have the hive
client
so that could be the programmer or maybe
it's a manager who knows enough sql to
do a basic query to look up the data
they need the hive client supports
different types of client applications
in different languages prefer for
performing queries and so we have our
thrift application in the hive thrift
client thrift is a software framework
hive server is based on thrift so it can
serve the request from all programming
language that support thrift and then we
have our jdbc application and the hive
jdbc driver jdbc java database
connectivity jdbc application is
connected through the jdbc driver and
then you have the odbc application or
the hive odbc driver the odbc or open
database connectivity the odbc
application is connected through the
odbc driver with the growing development
of all of our different scripting
languages python c plus plus spar
java you can find just about any
connection in any of the main scripting
languages and so we have our hive
services as we look at deeper into the
architecture hive supports various
services
so you have your hive server basically
your thrift application or your hive
thrift client or your jdbc or your hive
jdbc driver your odbc application or
your hive odbc driver they all connect
into the hive server and you have your
hive web interface you also have your
cli now the hive web interface is a gui
is provided to execute hive queries and
we'll actually be using that later on
today so you can see kind of what that
looks like and get a feel for what that
means commands are executed directly in
cli and then the cli is a direct
terminal window and i'll also show you
that too so you can see how those two
different interfaces work these then
push the code into the hive driver hive
driver is responsible for all the
queries submitted so everything goes
through that driver let's take a closer
look at the hive driver the hive driver
now performs three steps internally one
is a compiler hive driver passes query
to compiler where it is checked and
analyzed then the optimizer kicks in and
the optimize logical plan in the form of
a graph of mapreduce and hdfs tasks is
obtained and then finally in the
executor in the final step the tasks are
executed we look at the architecture we
also have to note the meta store
metastore is a repository for hive
metadata stores metadata for hive tables
and you can think of this as your schema
and where is it located and it's stored
on the apache derby db processing and
resource management is all handled by
the mapreduce v1 you'll see mapreduce v2
the yarn and the tez these are all
different ways of managing these
resources depending on what version of
hadoop you're in hive uses mapreduce
framework to process queries and then we
have our distributed storage which is
the hdfs and if you looked at our hadoop
tutorials you'll know that these are on
commodity machines and are linearly
scalable that means they're very
affordable a lot of time when you're
talking about big data you're talking
about a tenth of the price of storing it
on enterprise computers and then we look
at the data flow and hive
so in our data flow and hive we have our
hive in the hadoop system and underneath
the user interface or the ui we have our
driver our compiler our execution engine
and our meta store that all goes into
the mapreduce and the hadoop file system
so when we execute a query you see it
coming in here goes into the driver step
one step two we get a plan what are we
going to do refers to the query
execution uh then we go to the metadata
it's like well what kind of metadata are
we actually looking at where is this
data located what is the schema on it
then this comes back with the metadata
into the compiler then the compiler
takes all that information and the syn
plan returns it to the driver the driver
then sends the execute plan to the
execution engine once it's in the
execution engine the execution engine
acts as a bridge between hive and hadoop
to process the query and that's going
into your mapreduce in your hadoop file
system or your hdfs and then we come
back with the metadata operations it
goes back into the metastore to update
or let it know what's going on which
also goes to the between it's a
communication between the execution
engine and the meta store execution
engine communications is
bi-directionally with the metastore to
perform operations like create drop
tables metastore stores information
about tables and columns so again we're
talking about the schema of your
database and once we have that we have a
bi-directional
send results communication back into the
driver and then we have the fetch
results which goes back to the client so
let's take a little bit look at the hive
data modeling hive data modeling so you
have your high data modeling you have
your tables you have your partitions and
you have buckets the tables in hive are
created the same way it is done in rdbms
so when you're looking at your
traditional sql server or mysql server
where you might have enterprise
equipment and a lot of
people pulling and removing stuff off of
there the tables are going to look very
similar and this makes it very easy to
take that information and let's say you
need to keep current information but you
need to store all of your years of
transactions back into the hadoop hive
so you match those those all kind of
look the same the tables are the same
your databases look very similar and you
can easily import them back you can
easily store them into the hive system
partitions here tables are organized
into partitions for grouping same type
of data based on partition key this can
become very important for speeding up
the process of doing queries so if
you're looking at dates as far as like
your employment dates of employees if
that's what you're tracking you might
add a partition there because that might
be one of the key things that you're
always looking up as far as employees
are concerned and finally we have
buckets uh data present in partitions
can be further divided into buckets for
efficient querying again there's that
efficiency at this level a lot of times
you're taught you're working with the
programmer and the admin of your hadoop
file system to maximize the efficiency
of that file system so it's usually a
two-person job but we're talking about
hive data modeling you want to make sure
that they work together and you're
maximizing your resources hive data
types so we're talking about hive data
types we have our primitive data types
and our complex data types a lot of this
will look familiar because it mirrors a
lot of stuff in sql in our primitive
data types we have the numerical data
types string data type date time data
type and
miscellaneous data type and these should
be very they're kind of self-explanatory
but just in case numerical data is your
floats your integers your short integers
all of that numerical data comes in as a
number a string of course is characters
and numbers and then you have your date
time stamp and then we have kind of a
general way of pulling your own created
data types in there that's our
miscellaneous data type and we have
complex data types so you can store
arrays you can store maps you can store
structures
and even units in there as we dig into
hive data types
and we have the primitive data types and
the complex data types so we look at
primitive data types and we're looking
at numeric data types data types like an
integer a float a decimal those are all
stored as numbers in the hive data
system a string data type data types
like characters and strings you store
the name of the person you're working
with uh you know john doe the city
memphis the state tennessee maybe it's
boulder colorado usa or maybe it's hyper
bad
india that's all going to be string and
stored as a string character and of
course we have our date time data type
data types like timestamp date interval
those are very common as far as tracking
sales anything like that you just think
if you can type a stamp of time on it or
maybe you're dealing with the race and
you want to know the interval how long
did the person take to complete whatever
task it was all that is date time data
type and then we talk miscellaneous data
type these are like boolean and binary
and when you get into boolean binary you
can actually almost create anything in
there but your yes knows zero one now
let's take a look at complex data types
a little closer uh we have arrays so
your syntax is of data type and it's an
array and you can just think of an array
as a collection of same
entities one two three four if they're
all numbers and you have maps this is a
collection of key value pairs
so understanding maps is so central to
hadoop
so we store maps you have a key which is
a set you only have one key per mapped
value and so you in hadoop of course you
collect uh the same keys and you can add
them all up or do something with all the
contents of the same key but this is our
map as a primitive type data type in our
collection of key value pairs and then
collection of complex data with comment
so we can have a structure we have a
column name data type comment call a
column comment so you can get very
complicated structures in here with your
collection of data and your commented
setup and then we have units and this is
a collection of heterogeneous data types
so the syntax for this is union type
data type data type and so on so it's
all going to be the same a little bit
different than the arrays where you can
actually mix and match different modes
of hive hive operates in two modes
depending on the number and size of data
nodes we have our local mode and our map
reduce mode we talk about the local mode
it is used when hadoop is having one
data node and the data is small
processing will be very fast on a
smaller data sets which are present in
local machine and this might be that you
have a local file stuff you're uploading
into the hive and you need to do some
processes in there you can go ahead and
run those high processes and queries on
it usually you don't see much in the way
of a single node hadoop system if you're
going to do that you might as well just
use like an sql database or even a java
sqlite or something python and sqlite so
you don't really see a lot of single
node hadoop databases but you do see the
local mode in hive where you're working
with a small amount of data that's going
to be integrated into the larger
database and then we have the map reduce
mode this is used when hadoop is having
multiple data nodes and the data is
spread across various data nodes
processing large data sets can be more
efficient using this mode and this you
can think of instead of it being one two
three or even five computers we're
usually talking with the hadoop file
system we're looking at 10 computers 15
100 where this data is spread across all
those different hadoop nodes difference
between hive and
rdbms remember rdbms stands for the
relational database management system
let's take a look at the difference
between hive and the rdbms with hive
hive enforces schema on read and it's
very important that whatever is coming
in that's when hive's looking at it and
making sure that it fits the model
the rdbms enforces a schema when it
actually writes the data into the
database so it's read the data and then
once it starts to write it that's where
it's going to give you the error tell
you something's incorrect about your
scheme hive data size is in petabytes
that is hard to imagine um you know
we're looking at your personal computer
on your desk maybe you have 10 terabytes
if it's a high-end computer but we're
talking petabytes so that's hundreds of
computers grouped together when a rdbms
data size is in terabytes very rarely do
you see an rdbms system that's spread
over more than five computers and
there's a lot of reasons for that with
the rdbms it actually has a high end
amount of writes to the hard drive
there's a lot more going on there you're
writing and pulling stuff so you really
don't want to get too big with an rd bms
or you're going to run into a lot of
problems with hive you can take it as
big as you want hive is based on the
notion of write once and read many times
this is so important and they call it
worm which is write w wants o read are
many times m they refer to it as worm
and that's true of any of a lot of your
hadoop setup it's it's altered a little
bit but in general we're looking at
archiving data that you want to do data
analysis on we're looking at pulling all
that stuff off your rd bms from years
and years and years of business or
whatever your company does or scientific
research and putting that into a huge
data pool so that you can now do queries
on it and get that information out of it
with the rdbms it's based on the notion
of read and write many times so you're
continually updating this database
you're continually bringing up new stuff
new sales
the account changes because they have a
different licensing now whatever
software you're selling all that kind of
stuff where the data is continually
fluctuating and then hive resembles a
traditional database by supporting sql
but it is not a database it is a data
warehouse this is very important it goes
with all the other stuff we've talked
about that we're not looking at a
database but a data warehouse to store
the data and still have fast and easy
access to it for doing queries you can
think of
twitter and facebook they have so many
posts that are archived back
historically those posts aren't going to
change they made the post they're posted
they're there and they're in their
database but they have to store it in a
warehouse in case they want to pull it
back up with the rdbms it's a type of
database management system which is
based on the relational model of data
and then with hive easily scalable at a
low cost again we're talking maybe a
thousand dollars per terabyte um the
rdbms is not scalable at a low cost when
you first start on the lower end you're
talking about 10 000 per terabyte of
data including all the backup on the
models and all the added necessities to
support it as you scale it up you have
to scale those computers and hardware up
so you might start off with a basic
server and then you upgrade to a sun
computer to run it and you spend you
know tens of thousands of dollars for
that hardware upgrade with hive you just
put another computer into your hadoop
file system so let's look at some of the
features of hive
when we're looking at the features of
hive we're talking about the use of sql
like language called hive ql a lot of
times you'll see that as hql which is
easier than long codes this is nice if
you're working with your shareholders
you come to them and you say hey you can
do a basic sql query on here and pull up
the information you need this way you
don't have to take off have your
programmers jump in every time they want
to look up something in the database
they actually now can easily do that if
they're not
skilled in programming and script
writing tables are used which are
similar to the rdbms hence easier to
understand and one of the things i like
about this is when i'm bringing tables
in from a mysql server or sql server
there's almost a direct reflection
between the two so when you're looking
at one which is the data which is
continually changing and then you're
going into the archive database it's not
this huge jump where you have to learn a
whole new language
you mirror that same schema into the
hdfs into the hive making it very easy
to go between the two and then using
hive ql multiple users can
simultaneously query data so again you
have multiple clients in there and they
send in their query that's also true
with the rdbms which kind of queues them
up because it's running so fast you
don't notice the lag time well you get
that also with the hql as you add more
computers and the query can go very
quickly depending on how many computers
and how much resources each machine has
to pull the information and hive
supports a variety of data types
so with hive it's designed to be on the
hadoop system which you can put almost
anything into the hadoop file system so
with all that let's take a look at a
demo on hive ql or hql before i dive
into the hands-on demo let's take a look
at the website hive.apache.org
that's the main website since apache
it's an apache open source
software this is the main software for
the main site for the build and if you
go in here you'll see that they're
slowly migrating hive into beehive and
so if you see beehive versus hive note
the beehive as the new release is coming
out that's all it is it reflects a lot
of the same functionality of hive it's
the same thing and then we like to pull
up some kind of documentation on
commands and for this i'm actually going
to go to hortonworks hive cheat sheet
and that's because hortonworks and
cloudera are two of the most common used
builds for hadoop and four which include
hive and all the different tools in
there and so hortonworks has a pretty
good pdf you can download cheat sheet on
there i believe cloudera does too but
we'll go ahead and just look at the
horton one because it's the one that
comes up really good and you can see
when we look at the query language it
compares my sql server to hive ql or hql
and you can see the basic select we
select from columns from table where
conditions exist the most basic command
on there and they have different things
you can do with it just like you do with
your sql and if you scroll down you'll
see
data types so here's your integer your
flow your binary double string timestamp
and all the different data types you can
use some different semantics different
keys features functions uh for running a
hive query command line setup and of
course a hive shell uh set up in here so
you can see right here if we loop
through it has a lot of your basic stuff
and it is we're basically looking at sql
across a horton database we're going to
go ahead and run our hadoop cluster hive
demo and i'm going to go ahead and use
the cloudera quick start this is in the
virtual box so again we have an oracle
virtual box which is open source and
then we have our cloudera quick start
which is the hadoop setup on a single
node now obviously hadoop and hive are
designed to run across a cluster of
computers so we talk about a single node
is for education testing that kind of
thing and if you have a chance you can
always go back and look at our demo we
had on
setting up a hadoop system in a single
cluster just set a note down below in
the youtube video and our team will get
in contact with you and send you that
link if you don't already have it or you
can contact us at the
www.simplylearn.com now in here it's
always important to note that you do
need
on your computer if you're running on
windows because i'm on a windows machine
you're going to need probably about 12
gigabytes to actually run this it used
to be goodbye with a lot less but as
things have evolved they take up more
and more resources and you need the
professional version if you have the
home version i was able to get that to
run but boy did it take a lot of extra
work to get the home version to let me
use the virtual
setup on there and we'll simply click on
the cloudera quick start and i'm going
to go and just start that up and this is
starting up our linux so we have our
windows 10 which is a computer i'm on
and then i have the virtual box which is
going to have a linux operating system
in it and we'll skip ahead so you don't
have to watch the whole install
something interesting to know about the
cloudera is that it's running on
linuxcentos and for whatever reason i've
always had to click on it and hit the
escape button for it to spin up and then
you'll see the dos come in here now that
our cloudera spun up on our virtual
machine with the linux on uh we can see
here we have our it uses the thunderbird
browser on here by default and
automatically opens up a number of
different tabs for us and a quick note
because i mentioned like the
restrictions on getting set up on your
own computer if you have a home edition
computer and you're worried about
setting it up on there you can also go
in there and spin up a one month free
service on amazon web service to play
with this so there's other options
you're not stuck with just doing it on
the quick start menu you can spin this
up in many other ways now the first
thing we want to note is that we've come
in here into cloudera and i'm going to
access this in two ways
the first one is we're going to use hue
and i'm going to open up hue and i'll
take it a moment to load from the setup
on here and hue is nice if i go in and
use hue as an editor into hive or into
the hadoop setup usually i'm doing it as
a
from an admin side because it has a lot
more information a lot of visuals less
to do with you know actually diving in
there and just executing code and you
can also write this code into files and
scripts and there's other things you can
otherwise you can upload it into hive
but today we're going to look at the
command lines and we'll upload it into
hue and then we'll go into and actually
do our work in a terminal window under
the hive shell now in the hue browser
window if you go under query and click
on the pull down menu and then you go
under editor and you'll see hive there
we go there's our hive setup i go and
click on hive and this will open up our
query down here and now it has a nice
little b that shows our hive going and
we can go something very simple down
here like show
databases and we follow it with the
semicolon and that's the standard in
hive is you always add our
punctuation at the end there and i'll go
ahead and run this and the query will
show up underneath and you'll see down
here since this is a new quick start i
just put on here you'll see it has the
default down here for the databases
that's the database name i haven't
actually created any databases on here
and then there's a lot of other like
assistant function tables
your databases up here there's all kinds
of things you can research you can look
at through hue as far as a bigger
picture the downside of this is it
always seems to lag for me whenever i'm
doing this i always seem to run slow so
if you're in cloudera you can open up a
terminal window they actually have an
icon at the top you can also go under
applications and under applications
system tools and terminal either one
will work it's just a regular terminal
window and this terminal window is now
running underneath our linux so this is
a linux terminal window or on our
virtual machine which is resting on our
regular windows 10 machine and we'll go
ahead and zoom this in so you can see
the text better on your own video i
simply just clicked on view and zoom in
and then all we have to do is type in
hive and this will open up the shell on
here and it takes it just a moment to
load when starting up hive i also want
to note that depending on your rights on
the computer you're on in your action
you might have to do pseudohyme and put
in your password and username most
computers are usually set up with the
hive login again it just depends on how
you're accessing the linux system and
the hive shell once we're in here we can
go ahead and do a simple uh hql command
show databases and if we do that we'll
see here that we don't have any
databases so we can go ahead and create
a database and we'll just call it office
for today for this moment now if i do
show we'll just do the up arrow up arrow
is a hotkey that works in both linux and
in hive so i can go back and paste
through all the commands i've typed in
and we can see now that i have my
there's of course a default database and
then there's the office database so now
we've created a database it's pretty
quick and easy and we can go ahead and
drop the database we can do drop
database
office now this will work on this
database because it's empty if your
database was not empty you would have to
do cascade
and that drops all the tables in the
database and the database itself now if
we do show database and we'll go ahead
and recreate our database because we're
going to use the office database for the
rest of this hands-on demo a really
handy command now
set with the sql or hql is to use office
and what that does is that sets office
as a default database so instead of
having to reference the database every
time we work with a table it now
automatically assumes that's the
database being used whatever tables
we're working on the difference is you
put the database name period table and
i'll show you in just a minute what that
looks like and how that's different if
we're going to have a table and a
database we should probably load some
data into it so let me go ahead and
switch gears here and open up a terminal
window you can just open another
terminal window and it'll open up right
on top of the one that you have hive
shell running in and when we're in this
terminal window first we're going to go
ahead and just do a list which is of
course a linux command you can see all
the files i have in here this is the
default load we can change directory to
documents we can list in documents and
we're actually going to be looking at
employee.csv a linux command is the cat
you can use this actually to combine
documents there's all kinds of things
that cat does but if we want to just
display the contents of our employee.csv
file we can simply do cat employee csv
and when we're looking at this we want
to know a couple things one there's a
line at the top okay so the very first
thing we notice is that we have a header
line the next thing we notice is that
the data is comma separated and in this
particular case you'll see a space here
generally with these you've got to be
real careful with spaces there's all
kinds of things you got to watch out for
because it can cause issues these spaces
won't because these are all strings that
the space is connected to if this was a
space next to the integer you would get
a null value that comes into the
database without doing something extra
in there now with most of hadoop that's
important to know that you're writing
the data once reading it many times and
that's true of almost all your hadoop
things coming in so you really want to
process the data before it gets into the
database and for those who of you have
studied uh data transformation that's
the etyl where you extract transfer form
and then load the data so you really
want to extract and transform before
putting it into the hive then you load
it into the hive with the transform data
and of course we also want to note the
schema we have an integer string string
integer integer so we kept it pretty
simple in here as far as the way the
data is set up the last thing that
you're going to want to look up
is the source since we're doing local
uploads we want to know what the path is
we have the whole path in this case it's
home slash cloudera slash documents and
these are just text documents we're
working with right now we're not doing
anything fancy so we can do a simple get
edit employee.csv
and you'll see it comes up here it's
just a text document so i can easily
remove these added spaces there we go
and then we go and just save it and so
now it has a new setup in there we've
edited it the g edit is usually one of
the default that loads into linux so any
text editor will do back to the hive
shell so let's go ahead and create a
table employee and what i want you to
note here is i did not put the semicolon
on the end here semicolon tells it to
execute that line so this is kind of
nice if you're you can actually just
paste it in if you have it written on
another sheet and you can see right here
where i have create table employee and
it goes into the next line on there so i
can do all of my commands at once now
just so i don't have any typo errors i
went ahead and just pasted the next
three lines in and the next one is our
schema if you remember correctly from
the other side we had uh the different
values in here which was id name
department year of joining and salary
and the id is an integer name is a
string department string air joining
energy salary an integer and they're in
brackets we put close brackets around
them and you could do this all as one
line and then we have row format
delimited fields terminated by comma and
this is important because the default is
tabs so if i do it now it won't find any
terminated fields so you'll get a bunch
of null values loaded into your table
and then finally our table properties we
want to skip the header line count
equals one now this is a lot of work for
uploading a single file it's kind of
goofy when you're uploading a single
file that you have to put all this in
here but keep in mind hive and hadoop is
designed for writing many files into the
database you write them all in there and
then you can they're saved it's an
archive it's a data warehouse and then
you're able to do all your queries on
them so a lot of times we're not looking
at just the one file coming up we're
loading hundreds of files you have your
reports coming off of your main database
all those reports are being loaded and
you have your log files you have i mean
all this different data is being dumped
into hadoop and in this case hive on top
of hadoop and so we need to let it know
hey how do i handle these files coming
in and then we have the semicolon at the
end which lets us know to go ahead and
run this line and so we'll go ahead and
run that and now if we do a show tables
you can see there's our employee on
there we can also describe if we do
describe employee
you can see that we have our id integer
name string department string year of
joining integer and salary integer and
then finally let's just do a select star
from employee very basic sql nhql
command selecting data it's going to
come up and we haven't put anything in
it so as we expect there's no data in it
so if we flip back to our
linux terminal window you can see where
we did the cat
employee.csv and you can see all the
data we expect to come into it and we
also did our pwd and right here you see
the path you need that full path when
you are loading data you know you can do
a browse and if i did it right now with
just the employee.csv as a name it will
work but that is a really bad habit in
general when you're loading data because
it's you don't know what else is going
on in the computer you want to do the
full path almost in all your data loads
so let's go ahead and flip back over
here to our hive shell we're working in
and the command for this is load data so
that says hey we're loading data that's
a hive command hql and we want local
data so you got to put down local in
path so now it needs to know where the
path is now to make this more legible
i'm just going to go ahead and hit enter
then we'll just paste the full path in
there which i have stored over on the
side like a good prepared demo and
you'll see here we have home cloudera
documents employee.csv so it's a whole
path for this text document in here and
we go ahead and hit enter in there and
then we have to let it know where the
data is going so now we have a source
and we need a destination and it's going
to go into the table and we'll just call
it employee we'll just match the table
in there and because i want it to
execute we put the semicolon on the end
it goes ahead and executes all three
lines now if we go back if you remember
we did the select star from employee
just using the up error to page through
my different commands i've already typed
in you can see right here we have as we
expect we have rows sam mike and nick
and we have all their information
showing in our four rows and then let's
go ahead and do uh select
and count let's look at a couple of
these different select options you can
do we're going to count everything from
employee now this is kind of interesting
because the first one just pops up with
the basic select because it doesn't need
to go through the full map reduce phase
but when you start doing a count it does
go through the full map redo setup in
the hive in hadoop and because i'm doing
this demo on a single node cloudera
virtual box on top of a windows 10 all
the benefits of running it on a cluster
are gone and instead it's now going
through all those added layers so it
takes longer to run you know like i said
when you do a single node as i said
earlier it doesn't do any good as an
actual distribution because you're only
running it on one computer and then
you've added all these different layers
to run it and we see it comes up with
four and that's what we expect we have
four rows we expect four at the end and
if you remember from
our cheat sheet which we brought up here
from hortons it's a pretty good one
there's all these different commands we
can do we'll look at one more command
where we do the uh what they call sub
queries right down here because that's
really common to do a lot of sub queries
and so we'll do select
star or all different columns from
employee now if we weren't using the
office database it would look like this
from office dot employee and either one
will work on this particular one because
we have office set as a default on there
so from office employee and then the
command where creates a subset and in
this case we want to know where the
salary is greater than 25
000. there we go and of course we end
with our semicolon and if we run this
query you can see it pops up and there's
our salaries of people top earners we
have rose and i t and mike and hr kudos
to them of course they're fictional i
don't actually we don't actually have a
rose and a mic in those positions or
maybe we do so finally we want to go
ahead and do is we're done with this
table now remember you're dealing with a
data warehouse so you usually don't do a
lot of dropping of tables and
databases but we're going to go ahead
and drop this table here before we drop
it one more quick note is we can change
it so what we're going to do is we're
going to alter table office employee and
we want to go ahead and rename it
there's some other commands you can do
in here but rename is pretty common and
we're going to rename it to
and it's going to stay in office and
it turns out one of our
shareholders really doesn't like the
word employee he wants employees plural
it's a big deal to him so let's go ahead
and change that name for the table it's
that easy because it's just changing the
metadata on there and now if we do show
tables you'll see we now have employees
not employee and then at this point
maybe we're doing some house cleaning
because this is all practice so we're
going to go ahead and drop table and
we'll drop table employees because we
changed the name in there so if we did
employee just give us an error and now
if we do show tables you'll see all the
tables are gone now the next thing we
want to go and take a look at and we're
going to walk back through the loading
of data just real quick because we're
going to load two tables in here and let
me just float back to our terminal
window so we can see what those tables
are that we're loading and so up here we
have customer we have a customer
file and we have an order file we want
to go ahead and put the customers and
the orders into here so those are the
two we're doing and of course it's
always nice to see what you're working
with
so let's do our cat
customer.csv we could always do g edit
but we don't really need to edit these
we just want to take a look at the data
in customer and important in here is
again we have a header so we have to
skip a line comma separated
nothing odd with the data we have our
schema which is
integer string integer string integer so
you'd want to take that note that down
or flip back and forth when you're doing
it and then let's go ahead and do cat
order.csv and we can see we have oid
which i'm guessing is the order id we
have a date up something new we've done
integers and strings but we haven't done
date when you're importing new and you
never worked with the date date's always
one of the more trickier fields to port
in when that's true of just about any
scripting language i've worked with all
of them have their own idea of how
date's supposed to be formatted what the
default is this particular format or its
year and it has all four
digits dash month two digits dash day is
the standard import for the hive so
you'll have to look up and see what the
different formats are if you're going to
do a different format in there coming in
or you're not able to pre-process the
data but this would be a pre-processing
of the data thing coming in if you
remember correctly from our edel which
is uh e just in case you weren't able to
hear me last time etl which stands for
extract transform then load so you want
to make sure you're transforming this
data before it gets into here and so
we're going to go ahead and bring
both this data in here and really we're
doing this so we can show you the basic
join there is if you remember from our
setup merge join all kinds of different
things you can do but joining different
data sets is so common so it's really
important to know how to do this we need
to go ahead and bring in these two data
sets and you can see where i just
created a table customer here's our
schema the integer name age address
salary here's our eliminated by commas
and our table properties where we skip a
line well let's go ahead and load the
data first and then we'll do that with
our order and let's go ahead and put
that in here and i've got it split into
three lines so you can see it easily
we've got load data local in path so we
know we're loading data we know it's
local and we have the path here's the
complete path for
oops this is supposed to be order csv
grab the wrong one of course it's going
to give me errors because you can't
recreate the same table on there and
here we go create table here's our
integer date customer the basic setup
that we had coming in here for our
schema row format commas table
properties skip header line and then
finally let's load the data into
our order table load data local in path
home cloudera documents order.csv into
table order now if we did everything
right we should be able to do select
star from customer and you can see we
have all seven customers and then we can
do select star from order and we have uh
four orders uh so this is just like a
quick frame we have a lot of times when
you have your customer databases in
business you have thousands of customers
from years and years and some of them
you know they move they close their
business they change names all kinds of
things happen uh so we want to do is we
want to go ahead and find just the
information connected to these orders
and who's connected to them and so let's
go ahead and do it's a select because
we're going to display information so
select and this is kind of interesting
we're going to do c dot id
and i'm going to define c as customer as
a customer table in just a minute then
we're going to do c dot name and again
we're going to define the c c dot age so
this means from the customer we want to
know their id their name their age and
then you know i'd also like to know the
order amount uh so let's do o for dot
amount and then this is where we need to
go ahead and define uh what we're doing
and i'm going to capitalize from
customer so we're going to take the
customer table in here and we're going
to name it c that's where the c comes
from so that's the customer table c and
we want to join order as o that's where
our o comes from so the o dot amount is
what we're joining in there and then we
want to do this on we got to tell it how
to connect the two tables c dot id
equals o dot customer underscore id so
now we know how they're joined and
remember we have seven customers in here
we have four orders and as a processes
we should get a return of four different
names joined together and they're joined
based on of course the orders on there
and once we're done we now have the
order number the person who made the
order their age and the amount of the
order which came from the order table uh
so you have your different information
and you can see how the join works here
very common use of tables and hql and
sql and let's do one more thing with our
database and then i'll show you a couple
other hive commands and let's go ahead
and do a drop and we're going to drop
database office
and if you're looking at this and you
remember from earlier this will give me
an error and let's just see what that
looks like it says fill to execute
exception one or more tables exist so if
you remember from before you can't just
drop a database unless you tell it to
cascade that lets it know i don't care
how many tables are in it let's get rid
of it and in hadoop since it's an art
it's a warehouse a data warehouse you
usually don't do a lot of dropping maybe
at the beginning when you're developing
the schemas and you realize you messed
up you might drop some stuff but down
the road you're really just adding
commodity machines to pick up so you can
store more stuff on it so you usually
don't do a lot of database dropping and
some other fun commands to know is you
can do select round 2.3 is round value
you can do a round off in
hive we can do as floor value which is
going to give us a 2 so it turns it into
an integer versus a float it goes down
you know basically truncates it but it
goes down and we can also do ceiling
which is going to round it up so we're
looking for the next integer above
there's a few commands we didn't show in
here because we're on a single node as
as an admin to help spediate the process
you usually add in partitions for the
data and buckets you can't do that on a
single node because the when you add a
partition it partitions it across
separate nodes but beyond that you can
see that it's very straightforward we
have sql coming in and all your basic
queries that are in sql are very similar
to hql let's get started with pig why
pig what is pig mapreduce versus hive
versus pig hopefully you've had a chance
to do our hive tutorial in our mapreduce
tutorial if you haven't send a note over
to simplylearn and we'll follow up with
a link to you we'll look at pig
architecture working a pig pig latin
data model pig execution modes a use
case twitter and features a pig and then
we'll tag on a short demo so you can see
pig in action so why pig as we all know
hadoop uses mapreduce to analyze and
process big data processing big data
consumed more time so before we had the
hadoop system they'd have to spend a lot
of money on a huge set of computers and
enterprise machines so he introduced the
hadoop map reduce and so afterwards
processing big data was faster using
mapreduce then what is the problem with
map reduce prior to 2006 all mapreduce
programs were written in java
non-programmers found it difficult to
write lengthy java codes they faced
issues in incorporating map sort reduced
to fundamentals of mapreduce while
creating a program you can see here map
face shuffle and sort reduce phase
eventually it became a difficult task to
maintain and optimize a code due to
which the processing time increased you
can imagine a manager trying to go in
there and needing a simple query to find
out data and he has to go talk to the
programmers anytime he wants anything so
that was a big problem not everybody
wants to have a on-call programmer for
every manager on their team yahoo faced
problems to process and analyze large
data sets using java as the codes were
complex and lengthy there was a
necessity to develop an easier way to
analyze large datasets without using
time-consuming complex java modes and
codes and scripts and all that fun stuff
apache pig was developed by yahoo it was
developed with the vision to analyze and
process large datasets without using
complex java codes pig was developed
especially for non-programmers pig used
simple steps to analyze data sets which
was time efficient so what exactly is
pik pig is a scripting platform that
runs on hadoop clusters designed to
process and analyze large data sets and
so you have your pig which uses sql like
queries they're definitely not sql but
some of them resemble sql queries and
then we use that to analyze our data pig
operates on various types of data like
structured semi-structured and
unstructured data let's take a closer
look at mapreduce versus hive versus pig
so we start with a compiled language
your mapreduce and we have hive which is
your sql like query and then we have pig
which is a scripting language it has
some similarities to sql but it has a
lot of its own stuff remember sql like
query which is what hive is based off
looks for structured data and so we get
into scripting languages like pig now
we're dealing more with semi-structured
and even unstructured data with a hadoop
map reduced we have a need to write long
complex codes with hive no need to write
complex codes you could just put it in a
simple sql query or hql hive ql and in
pig no need to write complex codes as we
have piglet now remember in the map
reduce it can produce structured
semi-structured and unstructured data
and as i mentioned before hive can
process only structured data think rows
and columns where pig can process
structured semi-structured and
unstructured data you can think of
structured data as rows and columns
semi-structured as your html xml
documents like you have on your web
pages and unstructured could be anything
from groups of documents and written
format twitter tweets any of those
things come in as very unstructured data
and with our hadoop map reduce we have a
lower level of abstraction with both
hive and pig we have a higher level
abstraction so it's much more easy for
someone to use without having to dive in
deep and write a very lengthy map reduce
code and those map and reduce codes can
take 70 80 lines of code when you can do
the same thing in one or two lines with
high ever pig this is the advantage pig
has over hive it can process only
structured data and hive while in pig it
can process structured semi-structured
and unstructured data some other
features to know that separates the
different query languages as we look at
map and reduce mapreduce supports
partitioning features as does hive pig
no concept of partitioning in pix it
doesn't support your partitioning
feature your partitioning features allow
you to partition the data in such a way
that it can be queried quicker you're
not able to do that in pig mapreduce
uses java and python while hive uses an
sql like query language known as hive ql
or hql pig latin is used which is a
procedural data language mapreduce is
used by programmers pretty much as
straightforward on java hive is used by
data analysts pig is used by researchers
and programmers certainly there's a lot
of mix between all three programmers
have been known to go in and use a hive
for quick query and anybody's been able
to use pig for quick query or research
under map and reduce code performance is
really good under hive code performance
is lesser than map and reduce in pig
under pig code performance is lesser
than mapreduce but better than hive so
if we're going to look at speed and time
the map reduce is going to be the
fastest performance on all of those
where pig will have second and high
follows in the back let's look at
components of pig pig has two main
components we have pig latin pig latin
is the procedural data flow language
used in pig to analyze data it is easy
to program using piglet and it is
similar to sql and then we have the
runtime engine runtime engine represents
the execution environment created to run
pig latin programs it is also a compiler
that produces mapreduce programs uses
hdfs or your hadoop file system for
storing and retrieving data and as we
dig deeper into the pig architecture
we'll see that we have pig latin scripts
programmers write a script in piglet to
analyze data using pig then you have the
grunt shell and it actually says grunt
when we start it up and we'll show you
that here in a little bit which goes
into the pig server and this is where we
have our parser parser checks the syntax
of the pig script after checking the
output will be a dag directed acylic
graph and then we have an optimizer
which optimizes after your dag your
logical plan is passed to the logical
optimizer where an optimization takes
place finally the compiler converts the
dag into mapreduce jobs and then that is
executed on the map reduce under the
execution engine the results are
displayed using dump statement and
stored in hdfs using store statement and
again we'll show you that
the kind of end you always want to
execute everything once you've created
it and so dump is kind of our execution
statement and you can see right here as
we were talking about earlier once we
get to the execution engine and it's
coded into mapreduce then the mapreduce
processes it onto the hdfs
working of pig pig latin script is
written by the users so you have low
data and write pig script and pig
operations so when we look at the
working of pig pig latin script is
written by the users there's step one we
load data and write pig script and step
two in this step all the pig operations
are performed by parser optimizer and
compiler so we go into the pig
operations and then we get to step three
execution of the plan in this days the
results are shown on the screen
otherwise stored in the hdfs as per the
code so it might be of a small amount of
data you're reducing it to and you want
to put that on the screen or you might
be converting a huge amount of data
which you want to put back into the
hadoop file system for other use let's
take a look at the pig latin data model
the data model of pig latin helps pig to
handle various types of data for example
we have adam rob or 50. atom represents
any single value of primitive data type
in pig latin like integer float string
it is stored as a string tuple so we go
from our atom which are most basic
things so if you look at just rob or
just 50 that's an atom that's our most
basic object we have in pig latin then
you have a tuple tuple represents
sequence of fields that can be of any
data type it is the same as a row in
rdbms for example a set of data from a
single row and you can see here we have
rob comma five and you can imagine with
many of our other examples we've used
you might have the id number the name
where they live their age their date of
starting the job that would all be one
row and stored as a tuple and then we
create a bag a bag is a collection of
tuples it is the same as a table in
rdbms and is represented by brackets and
you can see here we have our table with
rob5 mic 10 and we also have a map a map
is a set of key value pairs key is of
character array type and a value can be
of any type it is represented by the
brackets and so we have name and age
where the key value is mic in 10. pig
latin has a fully nestable data model
that means one data type can be nested
within another here's a diagram
representation of pig latin data model
and in this particular example we have
basically an id number a name and age
and a place and we break this apart we
look at this model from pig latin
perspective we start with our field and
if you remember a field contains
basically an atom it is one particular
data type and the atom is stored as a
string which then converts it into
either an integer or number or character
string next we have our tuple and in
this case you can see that it represents
a row so our tuple would be three comma
joe comma 29 comma california and
finally we have our bag which contains
three rows in it in this particular
example let's take a quick look at pig
execution modes pig works in two
execution modes depending on where the
data is reciting and where the pig
script is going to run we have local
mode here the pig engine takes input
from the linux file system and the
output is stored in the same file system
local mold local mode is useful in
analyzing small data sets using pig and
we have the map reduce mode here the pig
engine directly interacts and executes
in hdfs and mapreduce in the map reduce
mode queries written in pig latin are
translated into mapreduce jobs and are
run on a hadoop cluster by default pig
runs in this mode there are three modes
in pig depending on how a pig latin code
can be written we have our interactive
mode batch mode and embedded mode the
interactive mode means coding and
executing the script line by line when
we do our example we'll be in the
interactive mode in batch mode all
scripts are coded in a file with the
extension.pig
and the file is directly executed and
then there's embedded mode pig lets its
users define their own functions udfss
in a programming language such as java
so let's take a look and see how this
works in a use case in this case use
case twitter users on twitter generate
about 500 million tweets on a daily
basis the hadoop mapreduce was used to
process and analyze this data analyzing
the number of tweets created by a user
in the tweet table was done using
mapreduce and java programming language
and you can see the problem it was
difficult to perform map reduce
operations as users were not well versed
with written complex java codes so
twitter used apache pig to overcome
these problems and let's see how let's
start with the problem statement analyze
the user table and tweet table and find
out how many tweets are created by a
person and here you can see we have a
user table we have alice tim and john
with their id numbers one two three and
we have a tweet table in the tweet table
you have your um the id of the user and
then what they tweeted
google was a good whatever it was tennis
dot spacecraft olympics politics
whatever they're tweeting about the
following operations were performed for
analyzing given data first the twitter
data is loaded into the pig storage
using load command and you can see here
we have our data coming in and then
that's going into pig storage and this
data is probably on an enterprise
computer so this is actually active
twitter's going on and then it goes into
hadoop file system remember the hadoop
file system is a data warehouse for
storing data and so the first step is we
want to go ahead and load it into the
pig storage into our data storage system
the remaining operations performed are
shown below in join and group operation
the tweet and user tables are joined and
grouped using co-group command and you
can see here where we add a whole column
when we go from
user names and tweet to the id link
directly to the name so alice was user 1
10 was 2 and john 3. and so now they're
listed with their actual tweet the next
operation is the aggregation the tweets
are counted according to the names the
command used is count so it's very
straightforward we just want to count
how many tweets each user is doing and
finally the result after the count
operation is joined with the user table
to find out the username and you can see
here where alice had three tim two and
john 1. pig reduces the complexity of
the operations which would have been
lengthy using mapreduce in joining group
operation the tweet and user tables are
joined and grouped using co-group
command the next operation is the
aggregation the tweets are counted
according to the names the command used
is count the result after the count
operation is joined with the user table
to find out the username and you can see
we're talking about three lines of
script versus a mapreduce code of about
80 lines finally we could find out the
number of tweets created by a user in a
simple way so let's go quickly over some
of the features of pig that we already
went through most of these
first ease of programming as pig latin
is similar to sql lesser lines of code
need to be written short development
time as the code is simpler so we can
get our queries out rather quickly
instead of having to have a programmer
spend hours on it handles all kinds of
data like structured semi-structured and
unstructured pig lets us create user
defined functions pig offers a large set
of operators such as join filter and so
on it allows for multiple queries to
process on parallel and optimization and
compilation is easy as it is done
automatically and internally
so
enough theory let's dive in and show you
a quick demo on some of the commands you
can do in pick today's setup will
continue as we have in the last three
demos to go and use cloudera quick start
and we'll be doing this in virtual box
we do have a tutorial in setting that up
you can send a note to our simply learn
team and then get that linked to you
once your cloudera quickstart has spun
up and remember this is virtualbox we've
created a virtual machine and this
virtual machine is centos linux once
it's spun up you'll be in a full linux
system here and as you can see we have
thunderbird browser which opens up to
the hadoop basic system browser and we
can go underneath the hue where it comes
up by default if you click on the pull
down menu and go under editor you can
see there's our impala our hive a pig
along with a bunch of other query
languages you can use and we're going
under pig and then once you're in pig we
can go ahead and use our command line
here and just click that little blue
button to start it up and running we
will actually be working in terminal
window and so if you're in the cloudera
quick start you can open up the terminal
window up top or if you're in your own
setup and you're logged in you can
easily use all of your commands here in
terminal window and we'll zoom in that
way you get a nice view of what's going
on there we go now for our first command
we're going to do a hadoop command and
import some data into the hadoop system
in this case a pig input and let's take
a look at this we have a hadoop that
listen no it's going to be a hadoop
command dfs there's actually four
variations of dfs so if you have hdfs or
whatever that's fine all four of them
point used to be different setups
underneath different things and now they
all do the same thing and we want to put
this file which in this case is under
home cloudera documents and sample and
we just want to take that and put it
into the pig input now let's take a look
at that file if i go under my document
browsers and open this up you'll see
it's got a simple id name profession and
age we have one jack engineer 25 and
that was in one of our earlier things we
had in there and so let's go ahead and
hit enter and execute this and now we've
uploaded that data and it's gone into
our pig input and then a lot of the
hadoop commands mimic the linux commands
and so you'll see we have cat as one of
our commands or it has a hyphen before
it so we execute that with hadoop dfs
hyphen cat slash pig input because
that's what we called it that's where we
put our sample csv at and we execute
this you can see from our hadoop system
it's going to go in and pull that up and
sure enough it pulls out the data file
we just put in there and then we can
simply enter the pig latin or pig editor
mode by typing in pig and we can see
here uh by our grunt i told you that's
how it was going to tell you you were in
pig latin there's our grunt command line
so we are now in the pig shell and then
we'll go ahead and put our load command
in here and the way this works is i'm
going to have office equals load and
here's my load in this case it's going
to be pig input we have that in single
brackets you remember that's where the
data is in the hadoop file system where
we dumped it into there we're going to
using pig storage our data was separated
as with a comma so there's our comma
separator and then we have as in this
case we have an id character array name
character array profession character a
and age character ray and we're just
going to do them all as character arrays
just to keep this simple for this one
and then when i hit put this all in here
you can see that's our full command line
going in and we have our semicolon at
the end so when i hit enter it's now set
office up but it hasn't actually done
anything yet it doesn't do anything
until we do dump office so there's our
command to execute whatever we've loaded
or whatever setup we have in here and we
run that you can see it go through the
different languages and this is going
through the map reduce remember we're
not doing this locally we're doing this
on the hadoop setup and once we finished
our dump you can see we have id name
profession age and all the information
that we just dumped into our pick oh we
can now do let's say oh let's say we
have a request just for we'll keep it
simple in here but just for the name and
age and so we can go office we'll call
it each as our variable underscore each
and we'll say for each office generate
name comma h and for each means that
we're going to do this for each row and
if you're thinking map reduce you know
that this is a map function because it's
mapping each row and generating name and
age on here and of course we want to go
ahead and close it with a semicolon and
then once we've created our query or the
command line in here let's go ahead and
dump office underscore each in with our
semicolon and this will go through our
map reduce
setup on here and if we were on a large
cluster the same processing time would
happen in fact it's really slow because
i have multiple things on this computer
and this particular virtual box is only
using a quarter of my processor it's
only dedicated to this and you can see
here there it is name and age and it
also included the top row since we
didn't delete that out of there or tell
it not to and that's fine for this
example but you need to be aware of
those things when you're processing a
significantly large amount of data or
any data and we can also do office and
we'll call this dsc for descending so
maybe the boss comes to you and says hey
can we order office by id
descending and of course your boss
you've taught him how to uh your
shareholder it sounds a little
druggatory and say boss you've talked to
the shareholder and you said and you've
taught them a little bit of pig latin
and they know that they can now create
office description and we can order
office by id description and of course
once we do that we have to dump office
underscore description so that it'll
actually execute and there goes into our
map reduce we'll take just a moment for
it to come up because again i'm running
on only a quarter of my processor and
you can see we now have our ids in
descending order returned let's also
look at and this is so important with
anytime you're dealing with big data
let's create office with a limit and you
can of course do any of this instead of
with office we could do this with office
descending so you get just the top two
ids on there we're going to limit just
to two and of course to execute that we
have to dump office underscore limit you
can just think of dumping your garbage
into the pig pen for the pig to eat
there we go dump office limit two and
that's going to just limit our office to
the top two and for our output we get
our first row which had our id name
profession and age and our second row
which is jack who's an engineer now
let's do an filter we'll call it office
underscore
filter you guessed it equals filter
office by profession equals and keep
note this is uh similar to how python
does it with the double equal signs for
equal for doing a true false statement
so for your logic statement remember to
use two equal signs in pig and we're
going to say it equals doctor so we want
to find out how many doctors do we have
on our list and we'll go ahead and do
our dump we're dumping all our garbage
into the pig pen and we're letting pig
take over and see what it can find out
and see who's a doctor on our list and
we find uh employee id number two bob is
a doctor 30 years old for this next
section we're going to cover something
we see it a lot nowadays in data
analysis and that's word counting
tokenization that is one of the next big
steps as we move forward in our data
analysis where we go from say stock
market analysis of highs and lows and
all the numbers to what are people
saying about companies on twitter what
are they saying on the web pages and on
facebook suddenly you need to start
counting words and finding out how many
words are totaled how many are in the
first part of the document and so on
we're going to cover a very basic word
count example and in this case i've
created a document called wordrose.txt
and you can see here we have simplylearn
is a company supporting online learning
simplylearn helps people attain their
certifications simplylearn is an online
community i love simply learn i love
programming i love data analysis and i
went and saved this into my documents
folder so we could use it and let me go
ahead and open up a new terminal window
for our word count let me go and close
the old one so we're going to go in here
and instead of doing this as pig we're
going to do pig minus x local and what
i'm doing is i'm telling the pig to
start the pig shell but we're going to
be looking at files local to our virtual
box or this centos machine and let me go
ahead and hit enter on there just
maximize this up there we go and it will
load pig up and it's going to look just
the same as the pig we were doing which
was defaulted to hi to our hadoop system
to our hdfs this is now defaulted to the
local system now we're going to create
lines we're going to load it straight
from the file remember last time we took
the hdfs and loaded it into there and
then loaded it into pig since we're
going to local we're just going to run a
local script we have lines equals load
home the actual full path home cloud
area documents and i called it
wordrose.txt
and as line is a character array so each
line and i've actually you can change
this to read each document i certainly
have done a lot of document analysis and
then you go through and do word counts
and different kind of counts in there so
once we go ahead and create our line
instead of doing the dump we're going to
go ahead and start entering all of our
different setups for each of our steps
we want to go through and let's just
take a look at this next one because the
load is straightforward we're loading
from this particular file since we're
locals loading it directly from here
instead of going into the hadoop file
system and it says as and then each line
is read as a character array now we're
going to do words equal for each of the
lines generate flat tokenize line space
as word now there's a lot of ways to do
this this is if you're a programmer
you're just splitting the line up by
spaces there's actual ways to tokenize
it you gotta look for periods
capitalization there's all kinds of
other things you play with with this but
for the most basic word count we're just
going to separate it by spaces the
flatten takes the line and just creates
a
it flattens each of the words out so
this is uh we're just going to generate
a bunch of words for each line and then
each each of those words is as a word a
little confusing in there but if you
really think about it we're just going
down each line separating it out and
we're generating a list of words one
thing to note is the default for
tokenize you can just do tokenized line
without the space in there if you do
that it'll automatically tokenize it by
space you can do either one and then
we're going to do group we're going to
group it by words so we're going to
group words by word so when we we split
it up each token is a word and it's a
list of words and so we're going to
grouped equals group words by word so
we're going to group all the same words
together and if we're going to group
them then we want to go ahead and count
them and so for count we'll go ahead and
create a word count variable and here's
our four each so for each group grouped
is our line where we group all the words
in the line that are similar we're going
to generate a group and then we're going
to count the words for each group so for
each line we group the words together
we're going to generate a group and
that's going to count the words we want
to know the word count in each of those
and that comes back in our word count
and finally we want to take this and we
want to go ahead and dump word count and
this is a little bit more what you see
when you start looking at grunt scripts
you'll see right here these these lines
right here we have each of the steps you
take to get there so we load our file
for each of our
lines we're going to generate and
tokenize it into words then we're going
to take the words and we're going to
group them by same words
for each group we're going to generate a
group and we're just going to count the
words so we're going to summarize all
the words in here and let's go ahead and
do our dump word count which executes
all this and it goes through our
mapreduce it's actually a local runner
you'll see down here you start seeing
where they still have mapreduce but as a
special runner we're mapping it that's a
part of each row being counted and
grouped and then when we do the word
count that's a reducer the reducer
creates these keys and you can see i is
used three times a came up once and came
up once is to continue on down here to
attain online people company analysis
simply learn they took the top rating
with four certification so all these
things are encountered in the how many
words are used uh in in data analysis
this is probably the very the beginnings
of data analysis where you might look at
it and say oh they mentioned love
three times so whatever's going on in
this post it's about love and uh what do
they love and then you might attach that
to the different objects in here so you
can see that uh pig latin is fairly easy
to use there's nothing really you know
might it takes a little bit to learn the
script uh depending on how good your
memory is as i get older my memory leaks
a little bit more so i don't memorize it
as much but that was pretty
straightforward the script we put in
there and then it goes through the full
map reduce localized run comes out and
like i said it's very easy to use that's
why people like pig latin is because
it's intuitive one of the things i like
about pig latin is when i'm
troubleshooting when we're
troubleshooting a lot of times you're
working with a small amount of data and
you start doing one line at a time and
so i can go lines equal load and there's
my loaded text and maybe i'll just dump
lines and then it's going to run it's
going to show me all the lines that i'm
working on in the small amount of data
and that way i can test that if i got an
error on there that said oh this isn't
working maybe they'll be oh my gosh i'm
in map reduce or i'm in the basic grunt
shell instead of the local path grunt so
maybe it'll generate an error on there
and you can see here it just shows each
of the lines going down hive versus pig
on one side we'll have our sharp stinger
on our black and yellow friend and on
the other side our thick hide on our pig
let's start with an introduction to
hbase back in the days data used to be
less and was mostly structured you see
we have structured data here we usually
had it like in a database where you had
uh every field was exactly the correct
length so if you had a name field that
is exactly 32 characters remember the
old access database in microsoft the
files are small if we had you know
hundreds of people in one database that
was considered big data this data could
be easily stored in relational database
or rdbms when we talk about relational
database you might think of oracle you
might think of sql microsoft sql mysql
all of these have evolved even from back
then to do a lot more today than they
did but they still fall short in a lot
of ways and they're all examples of an
rdms or relationship database then
internet evolved and huge volumes of
structured and semi-structured data got
generated and you can see here with the
semi-structured data we have email if
you look at my spam filter you know
we're talking about all the html pages
xml which is a lot of time is displayed
on our html and help desk pages json all
of this really has just even in the last
each year it almost doubles from the
year before how much of this is
generated so storing and processing this
data on an rdbms has become a major
problem and so the solution is we use
apache hbase apache hbase was the
solution for this let's take a look at
the history the hbase history and we
look at the hbase history we're going to
start back in 2006 november google
released the paper on big table and then
in 2017 just a few months later hbase
prototype was created as a hadoop
contribution later on in the year 2007
in october first usable hbase along with
the hadoop 0.15 was released and then in
january of 2008 hbase became the
subproject of hadoop and later on that
year in october all the way into
september the next year hbase was
released the 0.81 version the 0.19
version and 0.20 and finally in may of
2010 hbase became apache top level
project and so you can see in the course
of about four years hbase started off as
just an idea on paper and has evolved
all the way till 2010 as a solid project
under the apache and since 2010 has
continued to evolve and grow as a major
source for storing data in
semi-structured data so what is hbase
hbase is a column-oriented database
management system derived from google's
nosql database big table that runs on
top of the hadoop file system or the
hdfs it's an open source project that is
horizontally scalable and that's very
important to understand that you don't
have to buy a bunch of huge expensive
computers you're expanding it by
continually adding commodity machines
and so it's a linear cost expansion as
opposed to being exponential no sql
database written in java which permits
faster querying so java is the backend
for the hbase setup and it's well suited
for sparse data sets so it can contain
missing or n a values and this doesn't
boggle it down like it would another
database companies using hbase so let's
take a look and see who is using this
nosql database for their servers and for
storing their data and we have
hortonworks which isn't a surprise
because they're one of the like cloudera
hortonworks they are behind hadoop and
one of the big developments and backing
of it and of course apache hbase is the
open source behind it and we have
capital one as banks you also see bank
of america where they're collecting
information on people and tracking it so
their information might be very sparse
they might have one bank way back when
they collected information as far as the
person's family and what their income
for the whole family is and their
personal income and maybe another one
doesn't collect the family income as you
start seeing where you have data that is
very difficult to store or it's missing
a bunch of data hubspot's using it
facebook
certainly all of your facebook twitter
most of your social medias are using it
and then of course there's jpmorgan
chase and company another bank that uses
the hbase as their data warehouse for
nosql let's take a look at an hbase use
case so we can dig a little bit more
into it to see how it functions
telecommunication company that provides
mobile voice and multimedia services
across china the china mobile and china
mobile they generate billions of call
detailed records or cdr and so these
cdrs and all these records are these
calls and how long they are and
different aspects of the call maybe the
tower they're broadcasted from all that
is being recorded so they can track it a
traditional database systems were unable
to scale up to the vast volumes of data
and provide a cost-effective solution no
good so storing and real-time analysis
of billions of call records was a major
problem for this company solution apache
hbase hbase stores billions of rows of
detailed call records hbc performs fast
processing of records using sql queries
so you can mix your sql and no sql
queries and usually just say no sql
queries because of the way the query
works applications of hbase one of them
would be in the medical industry hbase
is used for storing genome sequences
storing disease history of people of an
area and you can imagine how sparse that
is as far as both of those a genome
sequence might be only have pieces to it
that each person is unique or is unique
to different people and the same thing
with disease you really don't need a
column for every possible disease a
person could get you just want to know
what those diseases those people have
had to deal with in that area e-commerce
hbase is used for storing logs about
customer search history performs
analytics and target advertisement for
better business insights sports hba
stores match details in the history of
each match uses this data for better
prediction so when we look at hbase we
all want to know what's the difference
between hbase versus rdbms that is a
relational database management system
hbase versus rdbms so the hbase does not
have a fixed schema it's schema-less
defines only column families and we'll
show you what that means later on rdbms
has a fixed schema which describes the
structure of the tables and you can
think of this as you have a row and you
have columns and each column is a very
specific structure how much data can go
in there and what it does with the hbase
it works well with structured and
semi-structured data with the rdbms it
works only well with structured data
with the hbase it can have denormalized
data it can contain missing or null
values with the rdbms it can store only
normalized data now you can still store
a null value in the rdbms but it still
takes up the same space as if you're
storing a regular value in many cases
and it also for the hbase is built for y
tables it can be scaled horizontally for
instance if you were doing a tokenizer
of words and word clusters you might
have 1.4 million different words that
you're pulling up and combinations of
words so with an rdbms it's built for
thin tables that are hard to scale you
don't want to store 1.4 million columns
in your sql it's going to crash and it's
going to be very hard to do searches
with the age base it only stores that
data which is part of whatever row
you're working on let's look at some of
the features of the hbase it's scalable
data can be scaled across various nodes
as it is stored in the hdfs and i always
think about this it's a linear add-on
for each terabyte of data i'm adding on
roughly a thousand dollars in commodity
computing with an enterprise machine
we're looking at about 10 000 at the
lower end for each terabyte of data that
includes all your backup and redundancy
so it's a big difference it's like a
tenth of the cost to store it across the
hbase it has automatic failure support
right ahead log across clusters which
provides automatic support against
failure consistent read and write hbase
provides consistent read and write of
the data it's a java api for client
access provides easy to use java api for
clients block cache and bloom filters so
the hbase supports block caching and
bloom filters for high volume query
optimization let's dig a little deeper
into the hbase storage hbase column
oriented storage and i told you we're
going to look into this to see how it
stores the data and here you can see you
have a row key this is really one of the
important references is each row has to
have its own key or your row id and then
you have your column family and in here
you can see we have column family one
column family two column family three
and you have your column qualifiers so
you can have in column family one you
can have three columns in there and
there might not be any data in that so
when you go into column family one and
do a query for every column that
contains a certain thing that row might
not have anything in there and not be
queried where in column family two maybe
you have column 1 filled out and column
3 filled out and so on and so forth and
then each cell is connected to the row
where the data is actually stored let's
take a look at this and what it looks
like when you fill the data in so in
here we have a row key with a row id and
we have our employee id one two three
that's pretty straightforward you
probably would even have that on an sql
server and then you have your column
family this is where it starts really
separating out your column family you
might have personal data and under
personal data you would have name city
age you might have a lot more than just
that you might have number of children
you might have degree all those kinds of
different things that go into personal
data and some of them might be missing
you might only have the name and the age
of an employee you might only have the
name the city and how many children and
not the age and so you can see with the
personal data you can now collect a
large variety of data and store it in
the hbase very easily and then maybe you
have a family of professional data your
designation your salary all the stuff
that the employee is doing for you in
that company let's dig a little deeper
into the hbase architecture and so you
can see here what looks to be a
complicated chart it's not as
complicated as you think from the apache
a space we have the zookeeper which is
used for monitoring what's going on and
you have your h master this is the hbase
master assigns regions and load
balancing and then underneath the region
or the hbase master then under the h
master or hbase master you have your
reader server serves data for read and
write and the region server which is all
your different computers you have in
your hadoop cluster you'll have a region
an h log you'll have a store memory
store and then you have your different
files for h file that are stored on
there and those are separated across the
different computers and that's all part
of the hdfs storage system so we look at
the architectural components or regions
and we're looking at we're drilling down
a little bit hbase tables are divided
horizontally by a row so you have a key
range into regions so each of those ids
you might have ids 1 to 20 21 to 50 or
whatever they are regions are assigned
to the nodes in the cluster called
region servers a region contains all
rows in the table between the region's
start key and the end key again 1 to 10
11 to 20 and so forth these servers
serve data for read and write and you
can see here we have the client and the
get and then git sends it out and it
finds out where that start if it's
between which start keys and n keys and
then it pulls the data from that
different region server and so the
region sign data definition language
operation create delete are handled by
the h master so the h-master is telling
it what are we doing with this data
what's going out there assigning and
reassigning regions for recovery or load
balancing and monitoring all servers so
that's also part of it so you know if
your ids if you have 500 ids across
three servers you're not going to put
400 ids on server 1 and 100 on the
server 2 and leaves region 3 and region
4 empty you're going to split that up
and that's all handled by the h master
and you can see here monitors region
servers assigns regions to region
servers assigns regions to recent
servers and so forth and so forth hbase
has a distributed environment where
h-master alone is not sufficient to
manage everything hence zookeeper was
introduced it works with h-master so you
have an active h-master which sends a
heartbeat signal to zookeeper indicating
that it's active and the zookeeper also
has a heartbeat to the region servers so
the region servers send their status to
zoo keeper indicating they are ready for
read and write operation inactive server
acts as a backup if the active hmaster
fails it'll come to the rescue active
hmaster and region servers connect with
a session to zookeeper so you see your
active hmaster selection region server
session they're all looking at the
zookeeper keeping that pulse an active
h-master region server connects with a
session to the zoo keeper and you can
see here where we have ephemeral nodes
for active sessions via heartbeats to
indicate that the region servers are up
and running so let's take a look at
hbase read or write going on there's a
special hbase catalog table called the
meta table which holds the location of
the regions in the cluster here's what
happens the first time a client reads or
writes data to hbase the client gets the
region server the host the meta table
from zookeeper and you can see right
here the client it has a request for
your region server and goes hey
zookeeper can you handle this the
zookeeper takes a look at it and goes ah
middle location is stored in zookeeper
so it looks at his meta data on there
and then the metadata table location is
sent back to the client the client will
query the meta server to get the region
server corresponding to the row key if
it wants to access the client caches
this information along with the minute
table location and you can see here the
client going back and forth to the
region server with the information and
it might be going across multiple region
servers depending on what you're
querying so we get the region server for
row key from the meta table that's where
that row key comes in and says hey this
is where we're going with this and so
once it gets a row key from the
corresponding region server we can now
put row or git row from that region
server let's take a look at the hbase
meta table special hbase catalog table
that maintains a list of all the region
servers in the hbase storage system so
you see here we have the meta table we
have a row key and a value table key
region region server so the meta table
is used to find the region for the given
table key and you can see down here you
know meta table comes in is going to
fire out where it's going with the
region server and we look a little
closer at the right mechanism in hbase
we have right ahead log or wall as you
abbreviate it kind of a way to remember
wall is right ahead log is a file used
to store new data that is yet to be put
on permanent storage it is used for
recovery in the case of failure so you
can see here where the client comes in
and it literally puts the new data
coming in into this kind of temporary
storage or the wall on there once it's
gone into the wall then the memory store
memstor is the right cache that stores a
new data that's not yet been written to
disk there is one mems store per column
family per region and once we've done
that we have three ack once the data is
placed in mems store the client then
receives the acknowledgement when the
mems store reaches the threshold it
dumps or commits the data into h file as
you can see right here we've taken our
gun into the wall the wall then source
it into the different memory stores uh
and then the memory stores it says hey
we've reached we're ready to dump that
into our h files and then it moves it
into the h files h files store the rows
as data as stored key value on disk so
here we've done a lot of theory let's
dive in and just take a look and see
what some of these commands look like
and what happens in our age base when
we're manipulating a nosql setup
[Music]
so if you're learning a new setup it's
always good to start with where is this
coming from it's open source by apache
and you can go to
hbase.apache.org and you'll see that it
has a lot of information you can
actually download the hbase separate
from the hadoop although most people
just install the hadoop because it's
bundled with it and if you go in here
you'll find a reference guide and you
can go through the apache reference
guide and there's a number of things to
look at but we're going to be going
through apache hbase shell that's what
we're going to be working with and
there's a lot of other interfaces on the
setup and you can look up a lot of the
different commands on here so we go into
the apache hbase reference guide we can
go down to read hbase shell commands
from a command file you can see here
where it gives you different options of
formats for putting the data in and
listing the data certainly can also
create files and scripts to do this too
but we're going to look at the basics
we're going to go through this on a
basic hbase shell and one last thing to
look at is of course if you continue
down the setup you can see here where
they have more detail as far as how to
create and how to get to your data on
your hbase now i will be working in a
virtual box and this is by oracle you
can download the oracle virtual box you
can put a note in below for the youtube
as we did have a previous session on
setting up virtual setup to run your
hadoop system in there i'm using the
cloudera quick start installed in here
there's hortons you can also use the
amazon web service there's a number of
options for trying this out in this case
we have cloudera on the oracle
virtualbox the virtual box has linux
centos installed on it and then the
hadoop that has all the different hadoop
flavors including hbase and i bring this
up because my computer is a windows 10
the operating system of the virtual box
is linux and we're looking at the hbase
data warehouse and so we have three very
different entities all running on my
computer and that can be confusing if
it's the first time in and working with
this kind of setup now you'll notice in
our cloudera setup they actually have
some hbase monitoring so i can go
underneath here and click on hbase and
master and it'll tell me what's going on
with my region servers it'll tell me
what's going on with our backup tables
right now i don't have any user tables
because we haven't created any and this
is only a single node and a single hbase
tour so you're not gonna expect anything
too extensive in here since this is for
practice and education and perhaps
testing out package you're working on
it's not for really you can deploy
cloudera of course but when you talk
about a quick start or a single node
setup that's what it's really for so we
can go through all the different hbase
and you'll see all kinds of different
information with zookeeper if you saw it
flash by down here what version we're
working in since zookeeper is part of
the hbase setup where we want to go is
we want to open up a terminal window and
in cloudera it happens to be up at the
top and when you click on here you'll
see your cloudera terminal window open
and let me just expand this we have a
nice full screen and then i'm also going
to zoom in that way you have a nice big
picture and you can see what i'm typing
what's going on and to open up your
hbase shell simply type hbase shell to
get in and hit enter and you'll see it
takes just a moment to load and we'll be
in our age based shell for doing hbase
commands once we've gotten into our
hbase shell you'll see it'll have the
hbase prompt information ahead of it we
can do something simple like list this
is going to list whatever tables we have
it so happens that there's a base table
that comes with hbase now we can go
ahead and create and i'm going to type
in just create what's nice about this is
it's going to throw me kind of a it's
going to say hey there's no just
straight create but it does come up and
tell me all these different formats we
can use for create so we can create our
table and one of our families and add
splits names versions all kinds of
things you can do with this let's just
start with a very basic one on here and
let's go ahead and create and we'll call
it new
table now let's just call it new tbl for
table new table and then we also want to
do let's do knowledge so let's take a
look at this i'm creating a new table
and it's going to have a family of
knowledge in it and let me hit enter
it's going to come up it's going to take
it a second to go ahead and create it
now we have our new table in here so if
i go list you'll now see table and new
table so you can now see that we have
the new table and of course the default
table that's set up in here and we can
do something like uh describe we can
describe and then we're going to do new
tbl and when we describe it it's going
to come up it's going to say hey name i
have knowledge data block encoding none
bloom filter row or replication go
version all the different information
you need new minimum version zero
forever deleted cells false block size
in memory you can look this stuff up on
apache.org to really track it down one
of the things that's important to note
is versions so you have your different
versions of the data that's stored and
that's always important to understand
that we might talk about that a little
bit later on and then we have to
describe it we can also do a status the
status says i have one active master
going on that's our hbase as a whole we
can do status
summary it should do the same thing as
status so we got the same thing coming
up and now that we've created let's go
ahead and put something in it so we're
going to put new tbl and then we want
row one you know what before i even do
this let's just type in put and you can
see when i type in put it gives us like
a lot of different options of how it
works and different ways of formatting
our data as it goes in and all of them
usually begin with the new table new tbl
then we have in this case we'll call it
row one and then we'll have knowledge
remember we created knowledge already
and we'll do knowledge
sports and then in knowledge and sports
we're gonna set that equal to cricket so
we're gonna put underneath this uh our
knowledge setup that we have a thing
called sports in there and we'll see
what this looks like in just a second
let's go ahead and put in we'll do a
couple of these let's see let's do
another row one and this time set of
sports let's do
science you know this person not only
you know we have row one which is both
knowledgeable and cricket and also in
chemistry so it's a chemist who plays
cricket in row one and uh let's see if
we have let's do another row one just to
keep it going and we'll do science in
this case let's do physics not only in
chemistry but also a physicist i have
quite a joy in physics myself so here we
go we have uh row one there we go and
then let's do uh row two let's see what
that looks like we start putting in row
two and in row two this person is has
knowledge in economics this is a master
of business and how or maybe it's global
economics maybe it's just for the
business and how it fits in with the
country's economics and that we call it
macro economics so i guess it is for the
whole country there so we have knowledge
economics macroeconomics and then let's
just do one more we'll keep it as row
two and this time our economist is also
a musician so we'll put music and they
happen to have knowledge and they enjoy
oh let's do pop music they're into the
current pop music going on so we've
loaded our database and you'll see we
have two rows row one and row two in
here and we can do is we can list the
contents of our database by simply doing
scan scan and then let's just do scan by
itself so you can see how that looks you
can always just type in there and it
tells you all the different setups you
can do with scan and how it works in
this case we want to do scan new tbl and
in our scan new tbl we have row one row
one row two row two and you'll see row
one has a column called knowledge
science time step value crickets value
physics so it has information as when it
was created when the time stamp is row
one also has knowledge sports and a
value of cricut so we have sports and
science and this is interesting because
if you remember up here we also gave it
originally we told it to come in here
and have chemistry we had science
chemistry and science physics and we
come down here i don't see the chemistry
why because we've now replaced chemistry
with physics so the new value is physics
on here let me go ahead and clear down a
little bit and in this we're going to
ask the question is enabled new
table when i hit enter in here you're
going to see it comes out true and then
we'll go ahead and disable it let's go
ahead and disable new
table make sure i have our quotes around
it and now that we've disabled it what
happens when we do the scan when we do
the scan new table and hit enter you're
gonna see that we get an error coming up
so once it's disabled you can't do
anything with it until we re-enable it
now before we enable the table let's do
an alteration on it and here's our new
table and this should look a little
familiar because it's very similar to
create we'll call this test info we'll
hit enter in there it'll take just a
moment for updating and then we want to
go ahead and enable it so let's go ahead
and enable our new table so it's back up
and running and then we want to describe
describe
new table and we come in here you'll now
see we have name knowledge and under
there we have our data encoding and all
the information under knowledge and then
we also have down below test info so now
we have the name test info and all the
information concerning the test info on
here and we'll simply enable it new
table so now it's enabled oops already
did that i guess we'll enable it twice
and so let's start looking at well we
had scan new table and you can see here
where it brings up the information like
this what if we want to go ahead and get
a row so we'll do r1 and when we do
hbase r1 you can see we have knowledge
science and it has a timestamp value
physics and we have knowledge sports and
it has a time stamp on it and value
cricket and then let's see what happens
when you put into our
new
table and in here we want row one and if
you can guess from earlier because we
did something similar uh we're going to
do knowledge economics and then it's
going to be instead of i think it was
what macroeconomics is now market
economics and we'll go back and do our
get command and now see what it looks
like and we can see here where we have
knowledge economics it has a timestamp
value market economics physics and
cricket and this is because we have
economics science and sports those are
the three different columns that we have
and then each one has different
information in it and so if you managed
to go through all these commands and
look at basics on here you'll now have
the ability to create a very basic hbase
setup nosql setup based on your columns
and your rows and just for fun we'll go
back to the cloudera where they have the
website up for the hbase master status
and i'll go ahead and refresh it and
then we can go down here and you'll see
user tables table set one and we can
click on details and here's what we just
did it goes through uh so if you're the
admin looking at this and go oh someone
just created new tbl and this is what
they have underneath of it and their new
table in there here we will learn on
apache spark history of spark what is
spark hadoop which is a framework again
wes spark components of apache spark
that is spark core spark sql spark
streaming spark ml lab and graphics then
we will learn on spark architecture
applications of spark spark use cases so
let's begin with understanding about
history of apache spark it all started
in 2009 as a project at uc berkeley amp
labs by mate
in 2010 it was open source under a bsd
license in 2013 spark became an apache
top level project and in 2014 used by
data bricks to sort large-scale data
sets and it set a new world record so
that's how apache spark started and
today it is one of the most in demand
processing framework or i would say in
memory computing framework which is used
across the big data industry so what is
apache spark let's learn about this
apache spark is a open source in-memory
computing framework or you could say
data processing engine which is used to
process data in batch and also in real
time across various cluster computers
and it has a very simple programming
language behind the scenes that is scala
which is used although if users would
want to work on spark they can work with
python they can work with scala they can
work with java and so on even r for that
matter so it supports all these
programming languages and that's one of
the reasons that it is called polyglot
wherein you have good set of libraries
and support from all the programming
languages and developers and data
scientists incorporate spark into their
applications or build spark based
applications to process analyze query
and transform data at a very large scale
so these are key features of apache
spark now if you compare hadoop west
spark we know that hadoop is a framework
and it basically has map reduce which
comes with hadoop for processing data
however processing data using mapreduce
in hadoop is quite slow because it is a
batch oriented operation and it is time
consuming if you if you talk about spark
spark can process the same data 100
times faster than mapreduce as it is a
in-memory computing framework well there
can always be conflicting ideas saying
what if my spark application is not
really efficiently coded and my
mapreduce application has been very
efficiently coded well then it's a
different case however
normally if you talk about code which is
efficiently written for mapreduce or for
spark based processing spark will win
the battle by doing almost 100 times
faster than mapreduce so as i mentioned
hadoop performs batch processing and
that is one of the paradigms of map
reduced programming model which involves
mapping and reducing and that's quite
rigid so it performs batch processing
the intermittent data is written to sdfs
and written red back from sdfs and that
makes hadoop's map reduce processing
slower in case of spark it can perform
both batch and real-time processing
however lot of use cases are based on
real-time processing take an example of
macy's take an example of retail giant
such as walmart and there are many use
cases who would prefer to do real time
processing or i would say near real time
processing so when we say real time or
near real time it is about processing
the data as it comes in or you are
talking about streaming kind of data now
hadoop or hadoop's mapreduce obviously
was started to be written in java now
you could also write it in scala or in
python however if you talk about
mapreduce it will have more lines of
code since it is written in java and it
will take more times to execute you have
to manage the dependencies you have to
do the right declarations you have to
create your mapper and reducer and
driver classes however if you compare
spark it has few lines of code as it is
implemented in scala and scala is a
statically typed dynamically inferred
language it's very very concise and the
benefit is it has features from both
functional programming and
object-oriented language and in case of
scala whatever code is written that is
converted into byte codes and then it
runs in the jvm now hadoop supports
kerberos authentication there are
different kind of authentication
mechanisms kerberos is one of the
well-known ones and it can really get
difficult to manage now spark supports
authentication via a shared secret it
can also run on yarn leveraging the
capability of kerberos so what are spark
features which really makes it unique or
in demand processing framework when we
talk about spark features one of the key
features is fast processing so spark
contains resilient distributed data sets
so rdds are the building blocks for
spark and we'll learn more about rdds
later so spark contains rdds which saves
huge time taken in reading and writing
operations so it can be 100 times or you
can say 10 to 100 times faster than
hadoop when we say in memory computing
here i would like to make a note that
there is a difference between caching
and in memory computing think about it
caching is mainly to support read ahead
mechanism where you have your data
pre-loaded so that it can benefit
further queries however when we say in
memory computing we are talking about
lazy evaluation we are talking about
data being loaded into memory only and
only when a specific kind of action is
invoked so data is stored in ram so here
we can say ram is not only used for
processing but it can also be used for
storage and we can again decide whether
we would want that ram to be used for
persistence or just for computing so it
can access the data quickly and
accelerate the speed of analytics now
spark is quite flexible it supports
multiple languages as i already
mentioned and it allows the developers
to write applications in java scala r or
python it's quite fault tolerance so
spark contains these rdds or you could
say execution logic or you could say
temporary data sets which initially do
not have any data loaded
and the data will be loaded into rdds
only when execution is happening so
these can be fault tolerant as
these rdds are distributed across
multiple nodes so failure of one worker
node in the cluster will really not
affect the rdds because that portion can
be recomputed so it ensures loss of data
it ensures that there is no data loss
and it is absolutely fault tolerant it
is for better than analytics so spark
has
rich set of sql queries machine learning
algorithms complex analytics all of this
supported by various par components
which we will learn in coming slides
with all these functionalities analytics
can be performed better in terms of
spark so these are some of the key
features of spark however there are many
more features which are related to
different components of spark and we
will learn about them so what are these
components of spark which i'm talking
about spark core so this is the core
component which basically has rdds which
has a core engine which takes care of
your processing now you also have spark
sql so people who would be interested in
working on structured data or data which
can be structuralized would want to
prefer using spark sql and spark sql
internally has components or features
like data frames and data sets which can
be used to process your structured data
in a much much faster way you have spark
streaming now that's again an important
component of spark which allows you to
create your spark streaming applications
which not only works on data which is
being streamed in or data which is
constantly getting generated but you
would also or you could also transform
the data you could analyze or process
the data as it comes in in smaller
chunks you have sparks mlib now this is
basically a set of libraries which
allows developers or data scientists to
build their machine learning algorithms
so that they can do predictive analytics
or prescriptive descriptive pre-emptive
analytics or they could build their
recommendation systems or bigger smarter
machine learning algorithms using these
libraries and then you have graphics so
think about organizations like linkedin
or say twitter where you have data which
naturally has a network kind of flow so
data which could be represented in the
form of graphs now here when i talk
about graphs i'm not talking about pie
charts or bar charts but i'm talking
about network related data that is data
which can be networked together which
can have some kind of relationship think
about facebook think about linkedin
where you have one person connected to
other person or one company connected to
other companies so if we have our data
which can be represented in the form of
network graphs then spark has a
component called graphics which allows
you to do graph based processing so
these are some of the components of
apache spark spark core spark sql spark
streaming spark mlib and graphics so to
learn more about components of spark
let's learn here about spark core now
this is the base engine and this is used
for large scale parallel and distributed
data processing so when you work with
spark at least and the minimum you would
work with a spark core which has rdds as
the building blocks of your spark so it
is responsible for your memory
management your fault recovery
scheduling distributing and monitoring
jobs on a cluster and interacting with
storage systems so here i would like to
make a key point that spark by itself
does not have its own storage
it relies on storage now that storage
could be your sdfs that is hadoop's
distributed file system it could be
a database like nosql database such as
hbase or it could be any other database
say rdbms from where you could connect
your spark and then fetch the data
extract the data process it analyze it
so let's learn a little bit about your
rdds resilient distributed data sets now
spark core which is the base engine or
the core engine is embedded with the
building blocks of spark which is
nothing but your resilient distributed
data set so as the name says it is
resilient so it is existing for a
shorter period of time distributed so it
is distributed across nodes and it is a
data set where the data will be loaded
or where the data will be existing for
processing so it is immutable fault
tolerant distributed collection of
objects so that's what your rdd is and
there are mainly two operations which
can be performed on an rdd now to take
an example of this
say i want to process a particular file
now here i could write a simple code
in
scala and that would basically mean
something like this so if i say val
which is to declare a variable i would
say val x and then i could use what we
call a spark context which is basically
the most important entry point of your
application so then i could use a method
of spark context for example that is
text file and then i could point it to a
particular file so this is just a method
of your spark context and spark context
is the entry point of your application
now here i could just give a path in
this method so what does this step do it
does not do any evaluation so when i say
val x i'm creating an immutable variable
and to that variable i'm assigning a
file now what this step does is it
actually creates a rdd resilient
distributed data set so we can imagine
this as a simple execution logic a empty
data set which is created in memory of
your node so if i would say i have
multiple nodes in which my data is split
and stored imagining that your yarn your
spark is working with hadoop so i have
hadoop which is using say two nodes and
this is my distributed file system sdfs
which basically means my file is written
to htfs and it also means that the file
related blocks are stored in the
underlying disk of these machines so
when i say val x equals sc.text file
that is using a method of spark context
now there are various other methods like
hold text files parallel eyes and so on
this step will create an rdd so you can
imagine this as a logical data set which
is created in memory across these nodes
because these nodes have the data
however no data is loaded here so this
is the first rdd and i can say first
step in what we call as a tag a dag
which will have series of steps which
will get executed at later stage now
later i could do further processing on
this i could say val y and then i could
do something on x so i could say x dot
map and i would want to apply a function
to every record or every element in this
file and i could give a logic here x dot
map now this second step is again
creating an rdd a resilient distributed
data set you can say second step in my
dag okay and here you have a external
rdd one more rdd created which depends
on the first rtd so my first rdd becomes
the base rdd or parent rtd and the
resultant rtd becomes the child rdd then
we can go further and we could say val
zed and i would say okay now i would
want to do some filter on y so this
filter which i am doing here and then i
could give a logic might be i'm
searching for a word i am searching for
some pattern so i could say val z equals
y dot filter which again creates one
more rdd a resilient distributed data
set in memory and a you can say this is
nothing but one more step in the dag so
this is my tag which is a series of
steps which will be executed now here
when does the execution happen when the
data get when will the data get loaded
into these rdds so all of this that is
using a method using a transformation
like map using a transformation like
filter or flat map or anything else
these are your
transformations
so the operations such as map filter
join union and many others will only
create rdds which basically means it is
only creating execution logic no data is
evaluated no operation is happening
right now only and only when you invoke
an action that is might be you want to
print some result might be you want to
take some elements and see that might be
you want to do a count so those are
actions which will actually trigger the
execution of this dag right from the
beginning so if i here say z
dot count where i would want to just
count the number of words which i am
filtering this is an action which is
invoked and this will trigger the
execution of dag right from the
beginning so this is what happens in a
spark now if i do a z dot count again
it will start the whole execution of dag
again right from the beginning so my z
dot count second time in action is
invoked again the data will be loaded in
the first rtd then you will have map
then you will have filter and finally
you will have result
so this is the core concept of your rdds
and this is how rtd works so mainly in
spark there are two kind of operations
one is your transformations and one is
your actions transformations or using a
method of spark context will always and
always create an rtd or you could say a
step in the tag actions are something
which will invoke the execution which
will invoke the execution from the first
rdd till the last rdd where you can get
your result so this is how your rdds
work now when we talk about components
of spark let's learn a little bit about
spark sql so spark sql is a component
type processing framework which is used
for structured and semi-structured data
processing so usually people might have
their structured data stored in rdbms or
in files where data is structured with
but particular delimiters and has a
pattern and if one wants to process this
structured data if one wants to
use spark to do in-memory processing and
work on this structured data they would
prefer to use spark sql so you can work
on different data formats say csv json
you can even work on smarter formats
like avro parquet even your binary files
or sequence files you could have your
data coming in from an rdbms which can
then be extracted using a jdbc
connection so at the bottom level when
you talk about spark sql it has a data
source api which basically allows you to
get the data in whichever format it is
now spark sql has something called as
data frame api so what are data frames
data frames in short you can visualize
or imagine as rows and columns or if
your data can be represented in the form
of rows and columns with some column
headings so data frame api allows you to
create data frames so like my previous
example when you work on a file when you
want to process it you would convert
that into an rdd using a method of smart
context or by doing some transformations
so in the similar way when you use data
frames or when you want to use spark sql
you would use sparks context which is
sql context or hive context or spark
which allows you to work with data
frames so like in my earlier example we
were saying val x equals sc dot text
file now in case of data frames instead
of sc you would be using say spark dot
something so spark context is available
for your data frames api to be used in
older versions like spark 1.6 and so on
we were using hive context or sql
context so if you were working with
spark 1.6 you would be saying val x
equals sql context dot here we would be
using spark dot so data frame api
basically allows you to create data
frames out of your structured data which
also lets spark know that data is
already in a particular structure it
follows a format and based on that your
sparks back-end dag scheduler right so
when i say about that i talk about your
sequence of steps so spark is already
aware of
what are the different steps involved in
your application so your data frame api
basically allows you to create data
frames out of your data and data frames
when i say i'm talking about rows and
columns with some headings
and then you have your data frame dsl
language or you can use spark sql or
hive query language any of these options
can be used to work with your data
frames so to learn more about data
frames follow in the next sessions when
you talk about spark streaming now this
is very interesting for organizations
who would want to work on streaming data
imagine a store like macy's where they
would want to have machine learning
algorithms now what would these machine
learning algorithms do suppose you have
a lot of customers walking in the store
and they are
searching for particular product or
particular item so there could be
cameras placed in the store and this is
being already done there are cameras
placed in the store which will keep
monitoring in which corner of the store
there are more customers now once camera
captures this information this
information can be streamed in to be
processed by algorithms and those
algorithms will see which product or
which series of product customers might
be interested in and if this algorithm
in real time can process based on the
number of customers based on the
available product in the store it can
come up with a attractive alternative
price so that which the price can be
displayed on the screen and probably
customers would buy the product now this
is a real-time processing where the data
comes in algorithms work on it do some
computation and give out some result and
which can then result in customers
buying a particular product so the whole
essence of this machine learning and
real-time processing will really hold
good if and when customers are in the
store or this could relate to even an
online shopping portal where there might
be machine learning algorithms which
might be doing real time processing
based on the clicks which customer is
doing based on the clicks based on
customer history based on customer
behavior algorithms can come up with
recommendation of products or better
altered price so that the sale happens
now in this case we would be
seeing the essence of real time
processing only in a fixed or in a
particular duration of time and this
also means that you should have
something which can process the data as
it comes in so spark streaming is a
lightweight api that allows developers
to perform batch processing and also
real-time streaming and processing of
data so it provides secure reliable fast
processing of live data streams so what
happens here in spark streaming in brief
so you have a input data stream now that
data stream could be a file which is
constantly getting appended it could be
some kind of metrics it could be some
kind of events based on the clicks which
customers are doing or based on the
products which they are choosing in a
store this input data stream is then
pushed in through a spark streaming
application now spark streaming
application will broke break this
content into smaller streams what we
call as disk criticized streams or
batches of smaller data on which
processing can happen in frames so you
could say process my file every five
seconds for the latest data which has
come in now there are also some windows
based uh
options like when i say windows i mean a
window of past three events window of
past three events each event being of
five seconds so your batches of smaller
data is processed by spark engine and
this process data can then be stored or
can be used for further processing so
that's what spark streaming does when
you talk about mlib it's a low level
machine learning library that is simple
to use scalable and compatible with
various programming languages now hadoop
also has some libraries like you have
apache mahout which can be used for
machine learning algorithms however in
terms of spark we are talking about
machine learning algorithms which can be
built using ml labs libraries and then
spark can be used for processing so mlib
eases the deployment and development of
scalable machine learning algorithms i
mean think about your clustering
techniques
so think about your classification where
you would want to classify the data
where you would want to do supervised or
unsupervised learning think about
collaborative filtering and many other
data science related techniques or
techniques which are required to build
your recommendation engines or machine
learning algorithms can be built using
sparks mlip graphics is spark's own
graph computation engine so this is
mainly if you are interested in doing a
graph based processing think about
facebook think about linkedin where you
can have your data which can be stored
and that data
has some kind of network connections or
you could say it is well networked i
could say x is connected to y y is
connected to z z is connected to a so x
y z a all of these are in terms of graph
terminologies we call as vertices or
vertex which are basically being
connected and the connection between
these
are called edges so i could say a is
friend to b so a and b are vertices and
friend a relation between them is the
edge now if i have my data which can be
represented in the form of graphs if i
would want to do a processing in such
way this could be not only for social
media it could be for your network
devices it could be a cloud platform it
could be about different applications
which are connected in a particular
environment so if you have data which
can be represented in the form of graph
then graphics can be used to do etl that
is extraction transformation load to do
your data analysis and also do
interactive graph computation so
graphics is quite powerful now when you
talk about spark your spark can work
with your different clustering
technologies so it can work with apache
mesos that's how spark came in where it
was initially to prove the credibility
of apache mesos spark can work with yarn
which is usually you will see in
different working environments spark can
also work as standalone that means
without hadoop spark can have its own
setup with master and worker processes
so usually or you can say technically
spark uses a master slave architecture
now that consists of a driver program
that can run on a master node it can
also run on a client node it depends on
how you have configured or what your
application is
and then you have multiple executors
which can run on worker nodes so your
master node has a driver program and
this driver program internally has the
spark context so your spark every spark
application will have a driver program
and that's driver program has a inbuilt
or internally used spark context which
is basically your entry point of
application for any spark functionality
so your driver or your driver program
interacts with your cluster manager now
when i say interacts with cluster
manager so you have your spark context
which is the entry point that takes your
application request to the cluster
manager now as i said your cluster
manager could be say apache mesos it
could be yarn it could be spark
standalone master itself so your cluster
manager in terms of yarn is your
resource manager so your spark
application internally runs as series or
set of tasks and processes your driver
program wherever that is run will have a
spark context and spark context will
take care of your application execution
how does that do it spark context will
talk to cluster manager so your cluster
manager could be on and in terms of when
i say cluster manager for yarn would be
resource manager so at high level we can
say a job is split into multiple tasks
and those tasks will be distributed over
the slave nodes or worker nodes so
whenever you do some kind of
transformation or you use a method of
spark context and rdd is created and
this rdd is distributed across multiple
nodes as i explained earlier worker
nodes are the slaves that run different
tasks so this is how a spark
architecture looks like now we can learn
more about spark architecture and its
interaction with yarn so usually what
happens when your spark context
interacts with the cluster manager so in
terms of yarn i could say resource
manager now we already know about yarn
so you would have say node managers
running on multiple machines and each
machine has some ram and cpu cores
allocated for your node manager on the
same machine you have the data nodes
running which obviously are there to
have the hadoop related data so whenever
the application wants to process the
data your application via spark context
contacts the cluster managers that is
resource manager now what does resource
manager do resource manager
makes a request so resource manager
makes requests to the node manager of
the machines wherever the relevant data
resides asking for containers so your
resource manager is negotiating or
asking for containers from node manager
saying hey can i have a container of 1gb
ram and one cpu core can i have a
container of 1gb ram and 1 cpu core and
your node manager based on the kind of
processing it is doing will approve or
deny it so node manager would say fine i
can give you the container and once this
container is allocated or approved by
node manager resource manager will
basically start an extra piece of code
called appmaster so appmaster is
responsible for execution of your
applications whether those are spark
applications or mapreduce so your
application master which is a piece of
code will run in one of the containers
that is it will use the ram and cpu core
and then it will use the other
containers which were allocated by node
manager to run the tasks so it is within
this container which can take care of
execution so what is a container a
combination of ram and cpu core so it is
within this container we will have a
executable process which would run and
this executor process is taking care of
your application related tasks so that's
how overall spark works in integration
with yarn now let's learn about this
spark cluster managers as i said spark
can work in a standalone mode so that is
without hadoop so by default application
submitted to spark standalone mode
cluster will run in fifo order and each
application will try to use all the
available nodes so you could have a
spark standalone cluster which basically
means you could have multiple nodes on
one of the nodes you would have the
master process running and on the other
nodes you would have the spark worker
processes running so here we would not
have any distributed file system because
spark is standalone and it will rely on
an external storage to get the data or
probably the file system of the nodes
where the data is stored and processing
will happen across the nodes where your
worker processes are running you could
have spark working with apache mesos now
as i said apache mesos is an open source
project to manage your computer clusters
and can also run hadoop applications
apache mesos was introduced earlier and
spark came in and as existence to prove
the credibility of apache missiles you
can have spark working with hadoop's
yarn this is something which widely you
will see in different working
environments so yarn which takes care of
your processing and can take care of
different processing frameworks also
supports spark you could have kubernetes
now that is something which is making a
lot of news in today's world it is an
open source system for automating
deployment scaling and management of
containerized applications so where you
could have multiple docker based images
which can be connecting to each other so
spark also works with kubernetes now
let's look at some applications of spark
so jpmorgan chase and company uses spark
to detect fraudulent transactions
analyze the business spends of an
individual to suggest offers and
identify patterns to decide how much to
invest and where to invest so this this
is one of the examples of banking a lot
of banking environments are using spark
due to its real-time processing
capabilities and in-memory faster
processing where they could be working
on fraud detection or credit analysis or
pattern identification and many other
use cases alibaba group that uses also
spark to analyze large data sets of data
such as real-time transaction details
now that might be based online or in the
stores of looking at the browsing
history in the form of spark jobs and
then provides recommendations to its
users so alibaba group is using spark in
its e-commerce domain you have iq here
now this is a leading healthcare company
that uses spark to analyze patients data
identify possible health issues and
diagnose it based on their medical
history so there is a lot of work
happening in healthcare industry where
real time processing is finding a lot of
importance and real time and faster
processing is what is required so health
care industry and iqvi is also using
spark you have netflix which is known
and you have riot games so entertainment
and gaming companies like netflix and
ride games use apache spark to showcase
relevant advertisements to their users
based on the videos that they have
watched shared or liked so these are few
domains which find use cases of spark
that is banking e-commerce health care
entertainment and then there are many
more which are using spark in their day
to day activities for real time in
memory faster processing now let's
discuss about the sparks use case and
let's talk about conviva which is
world's leading video streaming
companies so video streaming is a
challenge now if you talk about youtube
which has data you could always read
about it so youtube has data which is
worth watching 10 years so there is huge
amount of data where people are
uploading their videos or companies are
doing advertisements and this
videos are streamed in or can be watched
by users so video streaming is a
challenge and especially with increasing
demand for high quality streaming
experiences conviva collects data about
video streaming quality to give their
customers visibility into the end user
experience they are delivering now
how do they do it apache spark again
using apache spark conviva delivers a
better quality of service to its
customers by removing the screen
buffering and learning in detail about
network conditions in real time this
information is then stored in the video
player to manage live video traffic
coming in from 4 billion video feeds
every month to ensure maximum retention
now using apache spark conviva has
created an auto diagnostics alert it
automatically detects anomalies along
the video streaming pipeline and
diagnoses the root cause of the issue
now this really makes it one of the
leading video streaming companies based
on auto diagnostic alerts it reduces
waiting time before the video starts it
avoids buffering and recovers the video
from a technical error and the whole
goal is to maximize the viewer
engagement so this is sparks use case
where conviva is using spark in
different ways to stay ahead in video
streaming related deliveries if we have
understood and learned about your spark
components your spark architecture we
can also see running a spark application
now a spark application can run in a
standalone mode that is you could set up
your ide such as eclipse with a scala
plug-in and then you could have your
coded application which is written in
eclipse to be run in local mode now here
i have an example of application which
can be run in a local mode or on a
cluster so this application is importing
some packages that is spark context
spark conf i have created an object
which is first app it is the main class
of your project and other classes can
just be extending app rather than having
main here we declare a variable called x
which is pointing to a file in my
project directory it looks for a file
which is abc1.txt
and this file basically has some content
what are we doing in the application so
we create a variable where we assign the
file then we define or initialize our
spark context so remember whenever you
work with ide you don't have spark
context or spark available implicitly
that has to be defined so here we create
a configuration object we set our
application name we set the master as
local if you want to run it in a local
mode if you want to run it say on your
windows machine or if you would want to
run on a spark standalone cluster if i
would be running it on yarn then i would
remove this property that is set master
now once you have defined your
configuration object you can be
basically using spark context you can
use method of it which will result in
rdp that is what is happening in line 13
val y and then finally i can create a
variable where i would want to do a flat
map transformation on y which would
result in an internal rdd followed by a
map transformation which would again
result in an rdd and finally reduce by
key which is doing an aggregation once
all these steps are done i can decide to
display the result on the screen or i
can even use save as text file point it
to a particular location and then have
my application run now this is my
eclipse refer to other sessions where
i've explained how you can set up ide on
windows with different environment
variables and then you can run your
applications on a particular cluster if
i would want to run this application on
a cluster then i will have to give a
particular path so here in this case i
can say let's do this and i will say my
file is
abc1.txt let's save it and i'll also say
my output will be getting stored in a
default location as i intend to run it i
intend to run this application on a
cluster now in that case the cluster
would usually be set up on linux
machines would have a hadoop cluster
where you can run this application so if
i would want to run this application on
a cluster but not locally on the machine
i can just delete this part i can keep
my application now if you see my
application already compiles and does
not show any error message and that is
because in my project's build path i
have added all the spark related jars
all the spark related jars you can get
from your spark directory or you can be
getting in manually all the dependencies
some people would prefer to use maven or
say sbt for packaging your application
as jar and that can also be done so here
my code compiles code is fine it is
pointing to a file and then it is also
creating an output which will have word
count now what i can do is since i have
my code already written i know that i
have sbt installed on this machine
because i would want to package this
code as jar and run it on a cluster so
for that we can look in
our command prompt and here i can go
into workspace i can go into my scala
project and if you see here we have your
build dot sbt file you have your
binaries and you have your source so you
might not have these spark related
directories now these exist in my case
because i have been using spark and i've
done some previous runs now this is what
we have within my spark apps so to build
my package i need a build dot sbt file
we can see what does that contain so
your build.sbt contains your name
version of your package jar scala
version spark version and then
repository which spark will refer to
when it wants to have the dependencies
for all of your components such as
parkour spark sql mlib and so on so this
is my build.spd file which exists in the
project folder and if you are intending
to use sbt to package your code as jar
and then run it on the cluster in that
case i can even skip adding spark
related charge to the build path so that
is only done to make sure that your code
compiles now once i have my code written
i have sbt installed i have made the
file path changes i can just go to the
command line within my project folder
and i can say sbt package
now this will basically resolve all the
dependencies based on whatever you have
given in the code it will create a jar
file and place it in a particular
location and then we can use the same
jar file to run on a particular cluster
so sbd package is busy in creating the
jar now meanwhile what i can do is i can
open up a lab content and what i can do
is
i can just say for example
simply learn
and here i already have a lab set up so
you could have your own spark standalone
cluster where you could also run this
jar file you could have spark with
hadoop which is what i have here and i
will use that to submit an application
on the yarn cluster and let's go to the
web console let me copy my link i'll
close this i'll say launch lab and then
i can log in here i can just to paste my
password
and i'm logged in so i can just say
spark 2 shell now that's how it has been
configured here to work with your spark
version 2. so this is an interactive way
of bringing your spark shell and running
your application but what we are
interested in is running the application
as a jar file so let's go and see here
where we have our code and let's see if
sbt has done the packaging yes it has
done and it has created a jar file in
this location so what i can do is i need
to get this jar file from this location
onto my cluster so what i can do is i
can come in here i can do a ftp
so this basically allows me to push
whatever jars i have on my web console
so i'll go in here i'll say connect now
i'll search if there is already existing
jar file which might create a conflict
so i have something here
so i can for now just delete it it's
done i will say upload file and i am
interested in getting the jar file so
here we can
click on users win10 i have my workspace
project i can get into target scala 2.11
and take my jar file and say open so
this will upload my jar file on the web
console or the terminal wherein i can
connect to my cluster now let's go in
here let's quit from spark shell as we
want to run an application on the
cluster how do i do it so i can search
if i have my jar file existing it's here
so i'll say spark to submit and then i
will point to my jar file and then i can
simply say class and i know my code has
a package and a class name so this is
package and this is my object or class
name so i can say main dot scala dot
first app now it will be good if we
check if the file exists which our code
points to so i'll just for now comment
it out i will check in my htfs ls in my
default user directory this is where it
will search for a file and here we can
search if i have a file called abc so i
don't see anything here so let's do this
what i can do is i can again go to ftp
and basically i can do a upload file
like what we did earlier and this time
i'll pick up this existing abc1 file
which i showed you and upload it once
this is done i can put it on my cluster
by just saying sdfs dfs put let's take
the abc1 file and let's put it in my
directory so this will be my input so
i'm putting in a file there and now i
can do a spark submit to submit the
application on the cluster so if you see
here it has basically started the
application it contacts the resource
manager it gets an application id and
now it is doing the processing of my
file where i would want to get once this
is done it will be completed and the
temporary directory will be deleted so
this is how i run a spark application on
a cluster now once this is done i can
also go to spark's history server by
saying this is the path for my spark
history server it shows an application
which was run today which was doing a
word count you can click on the
application it says it ended with save
as text file you can click on this and
then it shows you the dag visualization
it says we started with text file we did
a flat map we did a map and then there
was some shuffling because we wanted to
do reduce by key so as i said every rdd
by default has two partitions and if you
want to do some aggregate or wider
transformations like reduce by key sort
by key group by key count by key and so
on in that case
similar key related data has to be
shuffled and brought into one partition
that's where we see shuffling happening
here and it also tells what are the
number of tasks which have run per
partition so here we ran a spark
application by packaging it as jar using
your sbt so sbt created the jar file and
then basically we brought our jar file
onto the cluster and then submitted it
using spark submit so this is how a
spark application runs on the cluster so
as i said your application has a driver
program now your spark applications run
as independent processes
and they can run on a cluster across the
nodes so we just saw how we can run a
spark application on a cluster now we
can always look at spark applications
progress or after it has completed by
looking into the spark ui your spark
application as i mentioned has a driver
program and when you run your
application on the
cluster you can always specify where
would you want your driver program to
run so in our case when we ran our spark
application here we basically just did a
simple spark submit and we gave our jar
and the class name i could also say
master and then i could specify if i
would want my application to run in a
local mode or i could say yarn but that
is default or if it was a spark
standalone cluster then i could be
giving something like this your host
name and then your port so you could do
all of these options by specifying minus
minus master i could also specify how
many executors i need how much memory
per executor how much course per
executor i need and i could also say
deploy mode as client which basically
means my driver will run on this machine
however my execution of application will
happen on cluster nodes i can also say
deploy mode as cluster which basically
means my driver will run on one of the
nodes of the cluster you could submit
your application and then based on
whatever arguments you have given your
application will be submitted on the
cluster and it will run so you can have
your application running so as i said
you have an application which has a
driver and it also has either spark
session or spark context which takes
your application request to the resource
manager now if your application is
completed you can always come back and
look into the spark history server or
spark ui if i choose this as my
application which i have run i can go to
executors and that shows me that there
was
one for your driver now that was running
on this particular node which is my
client node then i have my executors on
my other nodes which are nodes of my
cluster which used one core which ran
two tasks for the partitions which they
were working on and there was some
shuffling involved as we were doing a
word count which uses reduce by key so
when you run your application your yarn
or your cluster manager such as resource
manager negotiates the resources to the
slave processes your worker node
basically will have the resources
available for any kind of execution now
as i said your resource manager will
request for containers your worker nodes
will approve those containers and then
within those containers you will have
the executor which will run which will
take care of the task to process the
data so what is a task it is a unit of
work for the data set which has to be
worked upon so your rdds which get
created have partitions and for every
partition you have a task which is taken
care by the executor so the data is
loaded into the rdd when the action is
invoked and then your task is worked
upon by the executor so what does it do
it basically gets the data into the
partition of rdd and then does the
execution as a task on that particular
partition results are then sent back to
the driver and you can also have your
output saved on the disk so this is how
your application run whenever you run a
particular application you can always go
to your web console and scroll or look
into the logs for more information so
here our application was run and we can
see right from the beginning here when
we talk about spark submit which is done
here it says running spark version 2.2
it basically then will see that there
will be a driver which will be started
you can further see that it does some
memory calculations it then starts a
spark ui and here we can see that
requesting a new application from
cluster with four node managers verify
our application has not requested more
than maximum memory capability of the
cluster so the container sizing at the
cluster level is 3 gb per container and
your application should not be
requesting for a container bigger than
that it starts a application master
container with specific amount of memory
and then finally your execution starts
if we scroll down and look into the logs
we will see where my driver runs it will
also see show you how much memory was
utilized and it will talk about back
scheduler which is taking care of
execution of your tag that is series of
your rdds and finally you will see the
result getting generated or saved so
this is how you run your spark
application this is how you can see your
spark applications in history server or
spark ui and this is how overall apache
spark works utilizing your cluster
manager help getting the resources from
the worker processes and then running
the executors within those here we will
learn on what is spark streaming spark
streaming data sources
features of spark streaming working of
spark streaming disk criticized streams
caching or persistence as we call check
pointing in spark streaming and we will
then have a demo on spark streaming so
let's learn on what is spark streaming
and what it is capable of so it's an
extension of core spark api that
basically enables scalable high
throughput fault tolerant stream
processing of live data streams now data
can be ingested from different sources
like kafka flume kinases or tcp sockets
and then it can be processed using
complex algorithms expressed with
different kind of functions such as map
reduce join in window and when we have
the data processed that data can be
pushed out to your file systems
databases and live dashboards so if you
look on this image we can clearly see
that we would be working on a input data
stream which goes into spark streaming
component of spark which gives us
batches of input data or you could say
the streaming data is broken down into
smaller patches which would then be
worked upon by spark core engine and you
have finally batches of processed data
now when we talk about spark streaming
and the data sources you could have
streaming data sources coming in from
kafka or flume or say twitter api or
also with different formats such as
parquet you could also have static data
sources coming in from mongodb hbase
mysql and postgres so when we talk about
spark streaming it receives the input
data streams divides the data into
patches which can then be processed by
spark engine to generate your final
stream of results again in batches so
your spark streaming actually provides a
high level abstraction called disk
criticize stream and we will learn about
that or what we call as d stream which
represents a continuous stream of data
now when we look at your different data
sources from where the data can come in
spark streaming would take in this input
and then you could have even your mlib
component which could be used that is
sparks component to build machine
learning algorithms wherein you can
train your models with live data and you
can even use your trained model you
could be also going for structured
processing or processing the data which
is structuralized and that could be done
by using sparks components that is spark
sql which has data frames and data sets
so you could process your data with data
frames interactively query with sql when
spark streaming is working on the data
which is constantly flowing in finally
the data which is processed can be
stored in your distributed file system
such as sdfs or any other nosql or sql
based database now when we talk about
spark streaming it is good to know some
of the features of spark streaming and
here you have some of the features so it
enables fast recovery from failures
while it is working on streaming data
you have better load balancing and
resource usage and you can also combine
the streaming data with static data sets
and perform interactive queries now your
spark streaming also supports native
integration with advanced processing
libraries and that is one of the
benefits users can have when they are
using spark streaming let's learn about
working of spark streaming so as i
mentioned earlier at one end you have
your data streams now those data streams
are then caught or perceived by your
receivers which we have to enable in our
application your data streams or
streaming data which is constantly
getting generated and flowing in is
broken down into smaller patches which
will then be processed by spark so you
would have your final processed results
now if we look at the bigger picture
here we will talk about live input data
streams that could be divided into
smaller batches and when we say batches
these are batches of input data as rdds
so spark streaming performs computation
expressed using these streams it
generates rdd transformations so you
would have your spark pad jobs to
execute rdd transformations which would
give you your final processed result now
there are various examples and we'll
look at examples later so once your
spark streaming works on breaking the
input into smaller streams it can then
process the data finally giving you
batches of your result and that is again
on the streaming data now what is these
d streams let's understand about these
streams or disk criticized streams so
that's the basic abstraction provided by
spark streaming now it represents a
continuous stream of data either the
input data stream received from the
source or the process data stream
generated by transforming the input
stream now here if we look at the d
stream we would say you would have
series of rdds or series of
transformations applied on the data
which is flowing in for a particular
time frame now here we say data from
time 0 to 1 and that would result in
some of the transformations which you
would perform on the data when it has
come in between this time zone or time
frame you would have again data from
time 1 to 2 and so on so that's how your
spark streaming works so if we look at
your different transformations now there
could be various transformations which
could be applied on your data so this is
something like your streaming data which
comes in you would want to say have a
receiver which monitors a particular
socket or a particular port and looks
for data coming in we would also define
the time interval and for that time
interval the data is taken so that's a
smaller batch or a d stream on which you
could have your processing done now
within your application you would have
series of steps which are nothing but
transformations which would be performed
on this data within this time frame
giving you a result which could be
stored which could be seen on your
console or which could just be pushed
further for processing and this keeps
happening at regular time intervals
whatever you have specified till the
spark streaming application continues
now when we talk about spark we already
know that there are different kind of
transformations which can be applied so
you have map transformation wherein you
have map and then you pass in a function
which basically says you would want to
perform a function on every element so
when we say map function that would
return a new d stream by passing each
element of the source d stream through a
function which is passed similarly it is
for flat map where you would be passing
in a function you would want to perform
a flat map transformation on the data
stream or t stream which comes in so
each input item can be mapped to zero or
more output elements
you could be doing a filter wherein you
return a d stream by selecting only the
records of the source d stream on which
the function returns true so filtering
is used when you want to run a
transformation where you would want to
look at the input data for a particular
time interval as i mentioned earlier and
you would want to filter that data as
per whatever your function is applied
now you could be doing a union where you
could basically be having a union of
multiple d streams so that this would
return a new d stream that contains
union of elements in the source tree
stream and a other d string you could be
doing a transform function that contains
the union of elements you could be doing
a count you could be doing a join so
these are some of the transformations
which can be performed on your d streams
now there is also a concept of windowing
and that is basically to process the
data for a series of time intervals so
when i mention windowed stream
processing i'm saying spark streaming
would allow you to apply transformations
over a sliding window of data now this
operation is called as windowed
computation let's see how it looks like
so if you have your original d stream
which is being which is basically your
data coming in now that would be looked
upon for specific time intervals such as
time one time two and then you could be
doing a windowed computation which could
basically mean that i could have a
window which is a series of these time
intervals on which you would want to
perform series of your rdd
transformations so you have a window d
stream at time one then at time two and
time three so that could be one window
wherein you would want to get an output
so here we see window at time three now
you could also have a another sliding
window which would take your time series
and we have time 3 time 4 and time 5
where you could be performing the series
of transformations so this is usually
helpful where you would not only want to
process the data at particular time
interval but you would want a
consolidated processing for series of
intervals and that's what we mean by
windowed computation now before we
understand about caching and persistence
we can talk a little bit more on
windowing so if one would want to
understand the window stream processing
or as we say spark streaming's feature
of windowed computations we need to
think it as applying transformations
over a sliding window of data now as we
see here every time the window slides
over a source d stream the source rdds
that fall within the window are combined
and operated upon to produce the rdds of
windowed stream now in this specific
case we can say the operation is applied
over last three time units of data and
slides by two time units this shows that
any window operation needs to specify
two parameters one is the window length
which is basically the duration of
window so for example we can say three
as we see in the figure here and then
you have a sliding interval which is
basically the interval at which window
operation is performed so these two
parameters must be multiples of the
batch interval of source d stream so
that's what we do when we talk about
window now there are various other
transformations which can be applied or
window based operations which can be
done on your d streams here to talk a
little bit more on these streams which
is as i said it's a basic abstraction
provided by spark streaming it
represents a just remember it has a
continuous stream of data now either the
input data stream received from source
or the process data stream which is
generated by transforming the input
stream so a d stream is represented by
you could say a continuous series of
rdds which is sparks abstraction of a
immutable distributed data set so any
operation applied on a d stream it is
basically translating to operations on
the underlying rdds now for example we
can say converting a stream of lines to
word the flat map operation is applied
on each rdd in the lines now d stream to
generate the rtds of your words t stream
so when we talk about your discretized
streams understand that you would have a
series of transformations which would be
applied for this time interval whatever
has been specified now when you talk
about your streaming or spark streaming
architecture as i mentioned here that is
your receivers now that plays a very
important role here so your input d
streams or data streams are representing
the stream of input data that is
received from your streaming sources now
we could have different kind of data and
we could be doing different kind of
transformations so your receiver is
basically an object which receives the
data from a source and stores it in
sparks memory for processing and that's
the main role of your receiver now spark
streaming provides two categories of
building streaming sources so you have
basic sources that is sources directly
available in streaming context which is
a class we learn about it such as your
file systems or socket connections so
those could be your basic sources from
where the data is coming in you could
have advanced sources like your kafka
flume kinases etc and they would be
available through extra utility classes
so your receiver is going to be looking
into the data which is constantly
getting generated and then basically
forwarding it for processing by your
spark streaming you know when we talk
about your spark streaming one more
important aspect is basically
understanding the caching and
persistence now as we know from the spar
core engine or as you should know that
rdds are say your logical steps or rdds
are created when you perform some
transformations and these
transformations or these computations or
these rdds can be cached so that it can
improve the performance of your
application so the computed rdds or the
rdds which are result of some performing
some transformations they can be cached
so that they can be reutilized down your
application for your further processing
so when we talk about your caching and
persistence these streams also allows
developers to persist the stream data in
memory so similar to your concept of
rdds these streams can allow you to
persist the particular streams data in
memory now that is by doing or using
your persist method on a d stream which
will automatically persist every rdd of
that d stream in memory it could be
every rdd or it could be specifically
chosen rdds now this is really useful if
the data in d stream has to be or would
be computed multiple times say in your
application so for example if we say
window based operations like reduce by
window reduce by key and window wherein
you have group of operations being done
or you could have state based operations
like update state by key now in any of
these cases your d streams generated by
say window based operations are
automatically persistent in memory
without the developer calling for the
persist method now for input streams
that receive data over networks such as
kafka flume sockets etc the default
persistence level is set to replicate
the data to two nodes for fault
tolerance now one thing which we should
remember is unlike your rdds the default
persistence level of d streams keeps the
data data serialized in memory and that
we can discuss again further about your
serializations or deserialization now
one important aspect which takes care of
your fault recovery is check pointing
mechanism in spark streaming now when i
say check pointing a streaming
application as uh in real scenario we
would want must operate 24 bar 7 and if
the streaming application is constantly
running then there has to be a mechanism
which can make your streaming
application resilient to failures which
can be unrelated to your application
logic so spark streaming needs to do the
check pointing it needs to checkpoint
enough information to a fault tolerant
underlying storage system such that it
can recover from failures so your check
pointing is the process to make
streaming applications more fault
tolerant or resilient to your failures
now this is usually used when you would
want to recover from failure of a node
running the driver of streaming
application now we know driver is
existing for every application and it is
basically one which knows the flow of
your application driver also has the
context in case of streaming application
we would have say the spark streaming
context which is the entry point of your
application now when we talk about your
check pointing to ensure your streaming
application is more fault tolerant you
have two kinds of checkpointing here so
you could have a metadata checkpointing
and you could have data checkpointing
now when we talk about metadata what
does that include so metadata includes
configuration d stream operations or
even incomplete batches so when we talk
about metadata it has configurations
configuration that was used to create
the streaming application you could have
d stream operations that is set of d
stream operations that define the
streaming application that is your
series of rdds and then you have
incomplete batches or batches whose jobs
are queued but not have completed so
this would have to be check pointed so
metadata check pointing is used for
recovering from a node failure running
the streaming application driver now
your metadata which has your
configuration incomplete batches and d
stream operations need to be saved in an
underlying storage system now when you
talk about data check pointing it is
mainly about saving the generated rtds
to reliable storage that is whatever
rdds are computed so saving the
information which is saving the
computations to a storage like sdfs now
that is used in stateful transformations
combining data across various batches so
when we talk about transformations
whatever rtds are generated that depend
on rdds of previous batches if we are
talking about stateful and that can
cause the length of dependency chain to
increase or keep increasing with time
now to avoid any kind of increase in the
recovery time intermediate rdds can be
periodically checkpointed and that could
be done to a reliable storage to
basically cut off the growing dependency
changes so if we would want to summarize
we would say metadata checkpointing is
primarily needed for recovery from
driver failures whereas data or rtd
checkpointing is necessary even for
basic functioning if stateful
transformations are used and we should
remember we are talking about stateful
transformations here so when we talk
about check pointing now the question is
when would you enable checkpointing or
what would you do to enable
checkpointing so checkpointing must be
enabled for applications with different
kind of requirements so for example if
you are using stateful transformations
where one series of rdds depend on the
result of your previous batches so
something like update state by key or
reduce by key in window now if these
kind of operations are used in your
application then checkpoint directory
must be provided to allow for periodic
rdd checkpoint when we say about
requirements then recovering from
failures of the driver which is taking
care of your application metadata
checkpoints should be used when we talk
about simple streaming applications
without the stateful transformations
they could be run without enabling
checkpointing because your one batch of
rdds really does not depend on the
previous set of rdds which were done in
the previous time frame now recovery
from driver failures will also be
partial in that case when you talk about
your stateless so some might be received
and your unprocessed data might be lost
but then that's pretty much acceptable
when you talk about spark streaming
applications so here we look at your
checkpointing so we say start now you
have a checkpointing now whenever your
application is creating a streaming
context it would create it would set a
checkpoint path and then you would
define your d stream which is nothing
but series of your rdd transformations
your streaming context starts which is
basically your application entry point
into the cluster for processing and at
any point of time if there is any
failure you could always recover using
the checkpoint which was created in case
of uh spark streaming one more thing we
need to remember is that your
checkpointing can be enabled by setting
it directly in a fault tolerant reliable
file system such as sdfs wherein the
checkpointing information will be saved
so we will have to add
some methods within your application
like streaming context with a checkpoint
and then pointing it to a checkpoint
directory and in that way we can have
our stateful transformations or metadata
information stored in the underlying
storage whichever we have chosen now
that we have discussed about spark
streaming some basics of spark streaming
let's also understand about shared
variables or what we call as accumulator
and broadcast variables so normally when
you talk about your spark operations
such as your map or reduce these are
executed on one of the node of your
cluster and what happens is when you
talk about your operations they work on
separate copies of all variables used in
the function now in this case variables
are copied to each machine and no
updates to the variables on remote
machines are propagated back to the
driver program now when we talk about
read write shared variables across tasks
that would be inefficient so spark
actually provides two limited types of
shared variables for common usage
patterns and those are your broadcast
variables and your accumulators now when
you talk about your accumulators these
are variables that are only added
through an associative or commutative
operation so spark natively supports
accumulators of numeric types and
programmers can add support for your new
types so when we talk about accumulators
they can be used to implement counters
such as your mapreduce or sums so as a
user you can create named or unnamed
accumulators now as we see in the image
here in named accumulator in this
instance counter will display in web ui
for the stage that modifies that
accumulator spark displays the value for
each accumulator modified by a task in
the tasks table now tracking
accumulators in the ui can be useful for
understanding the progress of your
running stages but we should remember
that as of now this is not supported in
python might be in future the support
for python will also be added now when
you talk about your accumulators you can
have say a numeric accumulator created
by calling a spark context and its
method such as long accumulator or you
could have double accumulator to
accumulate values of type long or double
respectively so tasks running on a
cluster can then add to it using the add
method now we cannot i mean in this case
the value cannot be read but driver
program can read the accumulator's value
using its value method we can look at
some examples to understand this later
now when you talk about your broadcast
variables that is one more type of
variables which allows the programmers
to keep a read only variable cached on
each machine rather than shipping a copy
of it with tasks now what we know is
sometimes you might be doing very
costlier operations like joins where you
might be working on multiple rdds they
need to be joined and these rtds could
also be pair rdds which could be key
value pairs now whenever you are
performing a join there would be kind of
two level of shuffling one within a
particular rdd so if you are joining two
rdds the first rdd which might have data
in the form of key value pairs that rdd
would have to have some shuffling where
all the similar keys can be brought into
one partition and this would happen on
the second rdd also which has again key
value pairs and then if you are doing a
join these rtds will be shipped to the
node or basically the data would be
loaded in the memory and then basically
your transformations will happen this
can be a costlier affair so what can be
done is you could create broadcast
variables so for example if we have two
rdds and we want to perform a join
operation and if one rdd is known to be
smaller then we can create a broadcast
variable of the smaller rdd so that this
variable itself can be shipped to each
machine and then this variable can be
used for your join operations with the
other rdd which is existing in the
memory of those nodes so that saves time
and that improves your performance so
spark basically attempts to distribute
the broadcast variable using efficient
broadcast algorithms to reduce the
communication cost now if for example
you have multiple nodes in a cluster and
if you would want to give every node a
copy of large input data set in an
efficient manner so spark actions are
executed through a set of stages now we
know that and stages are separated by
your shuffle operations so whenever we
talk about narrow dependencies such as
map flat map filter you would not have
any shuffling involved but if you go for
group by key reduce by key and such
operations to bring the similar keys
together there would be shuffling
involved and also this applies when
you're doing some join operations so in
that case broadcast variables could be a
really plus where one set of data or rdd
which is already computed that could be
broadcasted to other nodes so the data
broadcasted will be cached in serialized
form and deserialized before running
each task this means that explicitly
creating broadcast variables can be
useful when tasks across multiple stages
need the same data or when caching the
data in the serialized form is important
so we can create broadcast variables
using spark context and its method
called broadcast and your broadcast
variable can then be shipped to other
nodes which can be used for your other
operations now when you talk about smart
streaming it is used in various use
cases i mean you could talk about speech
recognition you could talk about
sentiment analysis you could talk about
streaming applications which would be
performing some kind of
analytics on the data which is coming in
it is also used widely in retail chain
companies now if you look at the example
here so big retail chain companies would
want to build real-time dashboards so
that they can keep a track of their
inventory and operations and for this
they would need one streaming data or
data which is constantly getting
generated at source which needs to be
processed on and this information can
then be populating your dashboards to
give you a real-time scenario or
real-time information of what is
happening so in case of an inventory
dashboard you could use then these
interactive dashboards uh wherein you
could draw insights about the business
and that's what retail companies are
doing so how many products are being
purchased or products that have been
shipped or how many products have been
delivered to customers and this kind of
information would be good to capture in
real time so when the streaming data is
basically being processed so at one end
you have your data which is getting
generated that might be based on the
sales which are happening that might be
based on the products which are being
shipped or that might be based on the
acknowledgement that the products have
been received now while this data is
getting generated at various sources it
can be subjected to a smart streaming
application which will look into the
streaming data perform series of
transformations which you would want to
process the data at regular time
intervals and then pushing it to your
dashboards or to your storage layer
wherein it could then be used to answer
such questions so when we talk about
spark streaming it's an ideal choice to
process this kind of data in real time
and there are various use cases so at
one end if you see you have a input
stream which shows the product status
that is how many products were purchased
or shipped or delivered now this would
be then handled by your spark streaming
and also your sparkcore engine which
would then process the data to give you
an output stream which gives you a
status
such as what was the total count of
products which were purchased products
which were shipped and products which
were delivered so this was a quick and
brief introduction to spark streaming
and how it works now we can also see how
spark streaming works or how we create
an application for that what we can do
is we can basically set up our eclipse
to have your scala based spark
applications and for that what you could
do is you could have your eclipse which
can then be having a scala plug-in added
to it now if somebody would want to look
at the scala plugin then you can always
go to scala.ibe.org
and this is the place where you can
scroll towards the bottom you can click
on stable and that basically also shows
your video how scala plugin can be added
to your eclipse it also tells from where
you can get the scala latest release and
this can be added to your eclipse so in
my case it has already been added to the
eclipse i i'm bringing it up here and
then you can have your applications
built using your ide people would prefer
to use intellij and that's also fine so
you could also look for videos on
setting up intellij with your scala
plugin now there are two ways one you
can build your application run it on
your windows machine when you could have
some kind of utility like netcat which
can be used to send in some messages in
a streaming fashion you could have a
receiver which looks at a particular
socket at a particular port and you
could build a streaming application
within your ide run it on your windows
machine in a local mode which would then
be looking at your source where the data
is getting generated that's one option
the second option is you could build
your application package it as jar and
then run it on a cluster now that could
be a spark standalone cluster or spark
with yarn and then you could be
packaging your application using tools
like sbt and then use spark submit to
submit your application now i'll show
you both the ways in which you can work
with streaming applications so first is
get your eclipse and make sure that
scala plug-in is already added now in my
case on the right top corner i see scala
symbol that says i can be using scholar
perspective now here i have some
projects so what you can do is you can
create a project by saying new scala
project you can give it a name so for
example i could say my apps3 and then
you can say finish so that creates a
project now within your project what you
can do is you can create a package so
for example i could say something like
main dot scala and then say finish so
that creates your package now also one
thing to remember is it would be good to
change your compiler instead of 2.12 to
2.11 normally for different environments
you might have spark with different
versions and scala with two point turner
2.11 so it would be good to have the
compiler change to the bundle 2.11 so we
can select this project i can do a right
click i can go to the build path i can
say configure build path and then i can
click on scala compiler where i will use
project settings and i will choose to
2.11 bundle so that would make sure that
your applications can compile just say
okay it might say the compiler settings
have changed a full rebuild is required
for changes to take effect just hit on
ok so that's the first thing you need to
do the second thing is for your code to
compile it would be good to have your
jars added to your build path now we
could do that or as i said you could be
writing your application which might not
compile within your ide but you could
package it using sbt and then run it as
jar so what i'm doing here is on my
machine within my c drive i already have
spark distribution which i've downloaded
so basically i have downloaded spark and
then untied it so spark 2.4.3 i have
unzipped or untied it i have kept it in
my c and this basically has my spark now
within which i have my jars and this has
all my spark related jars so technically
speaking i can even use windows command
line and i can start working on spark in
an interactive way or packaging my
application and running it in a local
mode so you could also do this so
basically have your spark and then if
you see on my desktop i have a hadoop
folder within which i have a bin folder
and within which i have a win utils.exe
and this will be basically required when
you want to try out your spark based
applications whether that is streaming
or data frames to be tested on your
windows machine so you can always search
and download the winnutils.exe
place it in a hadoop folder within the
bin folder on your machine so once you
get your winnutels.exe
once you have your charts what you can
do is for your project you can just say
right click you can go to the build path
and you can say configure build path and
here you had add external jars so we can
select all of these jars here which i
would want to add to my build path so
that my code can compile and i can test
it on the windows machine itself i can
say open and then just basically do
apply and okay so that has created my
project with a package my compiler has
changed to 2.11 i have added the
external chars the spark related jars
and that is good enough for my code now
what we need is a streaming application
which we need to build so let me show
you from my existing project how it
looks like so within your source the
same way i have main package and here i
have a streaming application so this
streaming application is to test or to
work on capturing the data which is
generated at this particular stream on a
particular ip and a particular port and
i would want to do some series of
transformations on that so this gives me
an example of doing a word count and
then i would want to print the results i
could also be saving the output in a
particular location so for this
application we need basically to import
certain packages that is say spark
streaming spark context and also you
have spark conf so these are the
packages which we need to import now
here i have created an object i have
called this fifth app and i'm saying
extends app and this is because within
my project i already have an application
which has been defined as main so if
your application has been defined as
main one application is already existing
then you can just have your new objects
with extending app so we don't need to
define the main method here now here i'm
saying val conf new spark conf so i'm
creating a configuration object i'm
setting my application name and to test
it on windows we will have to set the
master as local and it is advisable to
give it more than one thread because you
would be creating a receiver within your
application that would utilize one
thread so here i am saying set master
local and then i am saying two threads i
am also creating my spark context which
we need to initialize based on the
configuration object we just created in
the previous step then we need to create
a spark streaming context and this
streaming context depends on spark
context and i've given a time interval
of 10 seconds so this is the time
interval which i am setting for which i
would want to work on the stream of data
which comes in every 10 seconds on a
particular socket now here we are
setting up a receiver so i say stream
rdd which is basically be spark
streaming context and then you use your
socket text stream now there are various
methods of spark streaming context for
example if i just go here and if i just
do a dot it shows me what are the
different options you have file stream
you have q stream you have socket stream
receiver stream and so on so i am using
socket text stream and i would want to
point it to this machine so i will say
127.0.0.1
i will also specify port 2222 okay and
here once i have created my
configuration object my spark context my
spark streaming context with the time
interval and i have set my receiver to
use the socket text stream method on
this particular ip on this particular
port now then i am specifying what i
would want to do on the data which gets
generated on this machine at this
particular port so i am saying val word
count so i would want to work on the
stream rdd that is the d stream i would
want to do a flat map on it to split the
data based on space i would want to map
every word to word comma 1 and then i
would want to do a reduce by key now
reduce by key you can pass in
specifically the function you would want
to do i could do a count of this i could
print the result or i could even save it
with an output using the java method to
create a random string attached to the
output once you're done with this here
i'm mentioning spark streaming context
start now this will basically trigger my
spark streaming context to start and it
will run till we terminate this
application now here to run this on
windows machine you can always look into
your run configuration and what i have
done is in my environment i basically
want to use
let's say okay now let's look at the
configuration what you need to set so
here i have
my streaming application and let's look
at the run configuration which basically
shows my application has started and
it's running on the environment so if
you see here i have added hadoop
underscore home pointing to this hadoop
directory which has been and when utils
x i have also given spark local ip which
is
127.0.0.1 so that is my run
configuration now if you see here my
streaming application has started my
streaming application has not yet
started probably it is running a
different application so we can come
back and check this so we can go to run
as scala application and let's see what
it does so it tries to connect to
127.0.0.1
so receiver is trying to do that but it
does not find anything on that
particular machine on that particular
port so my receiver is not able to find
it is not able to establish a connection
now what i can do is i can go to my
command line and here i will go into
downloads so i've already downloaded the
netcat utility for windows and here we
can basically search for something which
i have on my machine within downloads
and that is your netcat utility so what
i would do is i will come back here and
i would say nc.exe
lvp and then i could say my port which i
have specified in my streaming
application and i can just start this
netcat utility now here it says
listening on 222 it says connection to
127.0.0.1
and then if i look in the background my
receiver will now be able to establish a
connection establish a connection with
this netcat utility now whatever i type
here will be taken for processing every
10 seconds and we would see a word count
while my application is running so let's
test this so i'll say this is a test
test
is
being done and as soon as i pass in this
message we see that there is a word
count happening for the stream of data
which is coming in we can say winters
are coming winters will be cold and once
i given these messages we will see our
streaming application which will try to
work on the data which is coming in and
process it and show us the result so we
can say this is a test
of winters and let's see if it continues
to do the processing and shows us that
right so my streaming application is
running fine it is looking at the words
which we are passing in and we can say
if it is able to process my data and
every 10 seconds the tech stock socket
stream is looking on this machine at
this particular port doing a series of
transformations and these series of
transformations and then are seen within
your console now in my application if i
had used word counts dot save as text
file then i could also have my output
getting generated at every 10 second
interval and that would get saved here i
could also decide to have my output
saved and stored on a sdfs or any other
storage so this is a simple streaming
application what we saw which is using
socket tech stream it is looking at this
machine on a particular port where we
are running a netcat utility it does
series of your rdd transformations that
is flat map map and then you reduce by
key and finally we are invoking an
action such as print which basically
triggers these rdds which work on my
streaming data so this is one example
now what i could also be doing is this
is particularly my application now i
already have sbt for windows installed
so i can be going into my project space
so i could say workspace i could go into
my apps and i'm in my project folder so
i could say sbt package and this will
basically then based on my build file
which i already have within my project
folder so if you see here this is my
build file which says name the version
scala version spark version and the
repository with the spark to manage the
dependencies for all its components like
spark core sql ml streaming and hive so
you need to have this build dot sbt file
within your project folder which can be
used to package your application as jar
now we have done the packaging and it
shows me that it has created a jar of my
applications within this particular
folder now once i have this i can
basically then import this package into
my cluster where i can run it on a
cluster using spark submit now to run
the spark streaming application on a
cluster here i have a two node cluster
which will then have my spark stand
alone cluster you could look at the
previous videos which wherein i explain
how to set up a spark standalone cluster
now here i can go into the spark
directory and then i could just say s
bin start all dot sh which will start by
spark master and worker note now i do
have hadoop cluster also set up on this
but right now i'm running a spark
standalone cluster which shows me i have
a master and worker process on this
machine and i have a worker process on
this machine so my spark standalone
cluster is running we can always bring
up the ui to see how it looks like so
here i can just be giving http
slash um one eight zero eight zero so
that's my spark standalone cluster with
two worker nodes right now there is no
application running we can come back
here and we can check if we have my jar
file so i've already placed my jar here
now at any point of time if you have
your jar which has been packaged you can
always go and do a jar minus xvf and you
can choose your jar to see what is
within your jar which i've already done
on this machine so if i look in the main
folder i have scala and within scala if
you see these are the different classes
what we have so my code was packaged as
a jar it has a fifth app class which we
would want to run here so what i can do
is i can just be saying spark
submit because now i would want my
application to run on the cluster so i
can say class main dot scala and then my
object name so i will say fifth app now
that's my class my jar is this one and
we will also say master which is going
to be spark which is running on um one
and it listens on 7077 port so that
would basically start my streaming
application but what we would also need
is like our windows we would also need
some utility like netcat so basically
what i can do is i can here use a netcat
utility to basically connect or send in
some messages for our streaming
application so let's say let me search
if i have already the netcat which i
might have used here so let's see so we
on your window machine you will have to
install your netcat utility by saying a
apt-get netcat so here i can say nc
minus l and then i can say port which is
two two two two so we can see if this is
working so this is a test and let's see
if it works so let's start our
application streaming application which
then needs the receiver to establish a
connection with the particular machine
and let's see if that is done so here i
could also be canceling this and give it
a particular port so i can say 192 168
0.18 now the only problem is when we
packaged our application when we
packaged our application we should be
specifically giving the ip and also
comment out the local so when i package
this to run on the cluster i commented
out this part and i obviously would not
be giving 127 but the ip where my net
cat is running so right now let's test
it so we will say this
is a test new test for our application
and i'm sending in some messages so it
is already doing the word count as we
expected it to do and if while we are
doing it if you come back here so you
would see your application is now
running on the cluster so it is my
application it is using four cores what
is the memory per executor and you can
basically click on your application now
here you can look at the application
detail ui to see what is being done so
for our application we have streaming
job running receiver which says this is
my application it says it is running you
can basically click at this click on
this and it says your dag visualization
which will say the streaming job which
is running you can look at the stages if
you would want to see if there are
multiple stages which we don't have
because we are not doing any wider
transformation we can look at storage if
we have used some persisting or caching
we can look at the executors which are
being used and one of the important
things when you talk about your
streaming is the streaming tab which
gets activated now that does not show up
when you run your batch applications but
in your streaming applications you have
the ui shows you the streaming tab and
that basically says running batches of
10 seconds for 2 minutes 9 seconds
already now we see the input rate we see
the receivers we see if there is any
delay in scheduling what is the
processing time how many batches it has
completed and it basically shows me what
is the processing time how many tasks
were run and so on so my application is
running fine and unless and until we go
ahead and cancel this my application
will continue to run it will keep
looking for messages which we keep
typing in so for example if i would want
to just copy this and start again where
i would keep passing in this is say test
one test one is this where
we test streaming application right and
i can be seeing that my messages are
being processed i'm getting a word count
so we can say winter winter summer old
winter and you can always look at if
your streaming application is doing the
word count so this is a simple way where
you can run your streaming application
either on a windows machine in a local
mode or you could be running on a spark
standalone cluster or you could also
deploy your application to run on a yarn
based cluster now that we have seen a
streaming application which does a word
count it will be interesting to also see
the window based computation or
windowing operation which is supported
in spark streaming as i explained and
for that we can look at a different
application here which is streaming with
a window option let's look into this
what this application does so here i am
importing some packages that is
streaming streaming context your spark
in spark context spark configuration i
am also using the spark api java
function and then using spark streaming
api and i am also using storage level
because i also intend to have the
persistence or caching done now here we
create an application say streaming app
extends app we create our configuration
object where we say app name and then we
set master with appropriate number of
threads we create the spark streaming
context that's we initialize it and then
we have the spark streaming context
which depends on sc and we have given a
time interval of 10 seconds we then set
up a receiver so we say stream rdd which
will use socket extreme like we did
earlier with which will look for this
particular machine at this port wherein
i'm also using storage level so what i
would want is that the data stream which
would get generated here every 10
seconds should be cached in memory now
we could use different storage levels
that is we could use memory only disk
only memory and disk you could have
memory and disk with replication factor
so you have different storage levels now
here we are then doing some series of
transformations like what we did earlier
but if you see in my previous example we
just had reduce by key and here i am
using a transformation which is reduced
by key and window now this one basically
takes the function as i said the
windowing takes associative or
commutative functions so instead of
using the shortcut wave we will be
specifying our function so we say it
takes a and b and basically it uses this
function now here we have to give the
interval that is 30 seconds that's my
window time frame and then within that
what will be my each interval which we
would want to look at so these are the
two main aspects one is using your
window based transformation and then
also specifying your time interval for
your windowing which basically means we
would still do a word count but then
here we would basically not only be
doing a word count for every 10 seconds
for the data which is coming in here but
we would also want to have a
consolidated set of computation done
every 30 seconds so that is looking at
the last three time intervals now if you
also notice i am also doing a check
pointing here wherein i have not
specified a specific directory but what
i am saying here is i would want to
checkpoint or i would want to basically
save my computations for any kind of
fault recovery now this is a streaming
application with window based
computation we are using storage level
for persistence we are also doing the
check pointing which takes care of fault
recovery now to run this application we
have already set our environment
variables and so on so i can basically
start
this application by just doing a run as
scala application now this would start
my streaming application with window
based computations now we can open up
our command line where we would want to
start a netcat utility so i could go to
downloads let me just minimize this
window here and what i can do is i can
then be starting my netcat utility so i
could say
nc.exe minus lvp and on a port 222. as
soon as i do this in background my
application receiver will be able to
establish connection to this netcat
utility running on this particular port
now that's done so we can see if the
word count happens for our 10 second
interval so let's do that so i'll say
this is my first test and if i do this
it should give me the word count for the
data which i have passed in now i can
say this is my second test this
is my third test and if you see here it
basically is doing this now if i say
this is my first test again so since we
are doing window based operation also we
will see a consolidated set of
transformations which happen for a
window of three intervals so if you see
here now my this is giving me a count
but it is not showing me totally this as
4 or say this because it is only looking
at a window of last 2 or 3 time
intervals so now it is back because it
is looking at the last one so if i say
this is my test test is done test is
done so if you do this it will show you
the word count which is for whatever you
have passed in like test is done is
twice test is thrice but then since
windowing based operation is done you
will look at the time interval of the
messages which were passed within that
particular window now we can also since
my application is running and it is on
windows we can bring up your spark ui so
i can go to http and slash slash i can
be looking at my machine and the port so
for example i could do this this shows
my streaming application which is
running in wherein i can see the window
based application which is running but
what would be interesting is to look at
the stages if there is any kind of
shuffling which is happening looking at
the storage should show me the
persistence which we are doing now if
you see here it shows me that we have
been persisting in the memory what size
it occupies how many partitions were
cached and this is because of the
persistence or the storage level what we
have used as memory only now if we
change that to disk we will see our rdds
will be cached on disk and then you can
look at your streaming tab which gives
you more information about your patches
so this is a very simple example
obviously you can change what kind of
rtd computations you would want to do
here whether you want to do a word count
or something else whether you want to
save your processed output now here we
are able to do that you can always do a
refresh on your project and here what we
see is we see some entries of a folder
getting created right and we can decide
whether we would want our output to be
created we can also see within this what
would be containing and since we have
set check pointing in the project folder
it would also be check pointing
temporarily the information for any kind
of failure so this is a classic example
of streaming application using window
based computations persisting your
computations and also doing the check
pointing simultaneously in this tutorial
here we have some list of questions and
an explanation of those so that you can
be well prepared for your hadoop
interviews now let's look at some
general hadoop questions so what are the
different vendor specific distributions
of hadoop now all of you might be aware
that hadoop or apache hadoop is the core
distribution of hadoop and then you have
different vendors in the market which
have packaged the apache hadoop in a
cluster management solution which allows
everyone to easily deploy manage monitor
upgrade your clusters so here are some
vendor-specific distributions we have
cloudera which is the dominant one in
the market we have hortonworks and now
you might be aware that cloudera and
hortonworks have merged so it has become
a bigger entity you have map r you have
microsoft azure ibm's infosphere and
amazon web services so these are some
popularly known vendor-specific
distributions if you would want to know
more about the hadoop distributions you
should basically look into google and
you should check for hadoop different
distributions wiki page so if i type
hadoop different distributions and then
i check for the wiki page that will take
me to the distributions and commercial
support page and this basically says
that the sold products that can be
called a release of apache hadoop come
from apache.org so that's your open
source community and then you have
various vendor-specific distributions
which basically are running in one or
the other way apache hadoop but they
have packaged it as a solution like an
installer so that you can easily set up
clusters on set of machines so have a
look at this page and read through about
different distributions of hadoop coming
back let's look at our next question so
what are the different hadoop
configuration files now whether you're
talking about apache hadoop cloudera
hortonworks map r or no matter which
other distribution these config files
are the most important and existing in
every distribution of hadoop so you have
hadoop environment dot sh wherein you
will have environment variables such as
your java path what would be your
process id path where will your logs get
stored what kind of metrics will be
collected and so on your core hyphen
site file has the hdfs path
now this has many other properties like
enabling trash or enabling high
availability or discussing or mentioning
about your zookeeper but this is one of
the most important file you have hdfs
hyphen site file now this file will have
other information related to your hadoop
cluster such as your replication factor
where will name node store its metadata
on disk if a data node is running where
would data node store its data if a
secondary name node is running where
would that store a copy of name node's
metadata and so on your mapred hyphen
site file is a file which will have
properties related to your mapreduce
processing you also have masters and
slaves now these might be deprecated in
a vendor-specific distribution and in
fact you would have a yarn hyphen site
file which is based on the yarn
processing framework which was
introduced in hadoop version 2 and this
would have all your resource allocation
and resource manager and node manager
related properties again if you would
want to look at default properties for
any one of these for example let's say
hdfs hyphen site file i could just go to
google and type in one of the properties
for example i would say
dfs.namenode.name.directory and as i
know this property belongs to hdfs
hyphen site file and if you search for
this it will take you to the first link
which says sdfs default xml you can
click on this and this will show you all
the properties which can be given in
your sdfs hyphen site file it also shows
you which version you are looking at and
you can always change the version here
so for example if i would want to look
at 2.6.5
i just need to change the version and
that should show me the properties
similarly you can just give a property
which belongs to say core hyphen site
file for example i would say fs dot
default fs and that's a property which
is in core hyphen site file and
somewhere here you would see core minus
default.xml and this will show you all
the properties so similarly you could
search for properties which are related
to yarn hyphen site file or map red
hyphen site file so i could say yarn dot
resource manager and i could look at one
of these properties which will directly
take me to yarn default xml and i can
see all the properties which can be
given in yarn and similarly you could
say map reduce dot job dot reduces and i
know this property belongs to mapreduce
hyphen site file and this takes you to
the default xml so these are important
config files and no matter which
distribution of hadoop you're working on
you should be knowing about these config
files whether you work as a hadoop admin
or you work as a hadoop developer
knowing these config properties would be
very important and that would also
showcase your internal knowledge about
the configs which drive your hadoop
cluster let's look at the next question
so what are the three modes in which
hadoop can run so you can have hadoop
running in a standalone mode now that's
your default mode it would basically use
a local file system in a single java
process so when you say standalone mode
it is as you downloading hadoop related
package on one single machine but you
would not have any process running that
would just be to test hadoop
functionalities you could have a pseudo
distributed mode which basically means
it's a single node hadoop deployment now
hadoop as a framework has many many
services so it has a lot of services and
those services would be running
irrespective of your distribution and
each service would then have multiple
processes so your pseudo-distributed
mode is a mode of cluster where you
would have all the important processes
belonging to one or multiple services
running on a single node if you would
want to work on a sudo distributed mode
and using a cloudera you can always go
to google and search for cloudera's
quick start vm you can download it by
just saying cloudera quick start vm and
you can search for this and that will
allow you to download a quick start vm
follow the instructions and you can have
a single node cloudera cluster running
on your virtual machines for more
information you can refer to the youtube
tutorial where i have explained about
how to set up a quick start vm coming
back you could have finally a production
setup or a fully distributed mode which
basically means that your hadoop
framework and its components would be
spread across multiple machines so you
would have multiple services such as
sdfs yarn flume scope
kafka hbase hive impala and for these
services there would be one or multiple
processes distributed across multiple
nodes so this is normally what is used
in production environment so you could
say standalone would be good for testing
pseudo distributed could be good for
testing and development and fully
distributed would be mainly for your
production setup now what are the
differences between regular file system
and hdfs so when you say regular file
system you could be talking about a
linux file system or you could be
talking about a windows based operating
system so in regular file system we
would have data maintained in a single
system so the single system is where you
have all your files and directories so
it is having low fault tolerance right
so if the machine crashes your data
recovery would be very difficult unless
and until you have a backup of that data
that also affects your processing so if
the machine crashes or if the machine
fails then your processing would be
blocked now the biggest challenge with
regular file system is the seek time the
time taken to read the data so you might
have one single machine with huge amount
of disks and huge amount of ram but then
the time taken to read that data when
all the data is stored in one machine
would be very high and that would be
with least fault tolerance if you talk
about sdfs your data is distributed so
sdfs stands for hadoop distributed file
system so here your data is distributed
and maintained on multiple systems so it
is never one single machine it is also
supporting reliability so whatever is
stored in hdfs say a file being stored
depending on its size is split into
blocks and those blocks will be spread
across multiple nodes not only that
every block which is stored on a node
will have its replicas stored on other
nodes replication factor depends but
this makes sdfs more reliable in cases
of your slave nodes or data nodes
crashing you will rarely have data loss
because of auto replication feature now
time taken to read the data is
comparatively more
as you might have situations where your
data is distributed across the nodes and
even if you are doing a parallel read
your data read might take more time
because it needs coordination from
multiple machines however if you are
working with huge data which is getting
stored it will still be beneficial in
comparison to reading from a single
machine so you should always think about
its reliability through auto replication
feature its fault tolerance because of
your data getting stored across multiple
machines and its capability to scale so
when you talk about sdfs we are talking
about horizontal scalability or scaling
out when you talk about regular file
system you are talking about vertical
scalability which is scaling up
now let's look at some specific sdfs
questions what is this why is sdfs fault
tolerant now as i just explained in
previous slides your sdfs is fault
tolerant as it replicates data on
different data nodes so you have a
master node and you have multiple slave
nodes or data nodes where actually the
data is getting stored now we also have
a default block size of 128 mb that's
the minimum since hadoop version 2. so
any file which is up to 128 mb would be
using one logical block and if the file
size is bigger than 128 mb then it will
be split into blocks and those blocks
will be stored across multiple machines
now since these blocks are stored across
multiple machines it makes it more fault
tolerant because even if your machines
fail you would still have a copy of your
block existing on some other machine now
there are two aspects here one we talked
about the first rule of replication
which basically means you will never
have two identical blocks sitting on the
same machine and the second rule of
replication is in terms of rack
awareness so if your machines are placed
in racks as we see in the right image
you will never have all the replicas
placed on the same rack even if they are
on different machines so it has to be
fault tolerant and it has to maintain
redundancy so at least one replica will
be placed on some other node on some
other rack that's how sdfs is fault
tolerant now here let's understand the
architecture of sdfs now as i mentioned
earlier you would in a hadoop cluster
the main service is your hdfs
so for your sdfs service you would have
a name node which is your master process
running on one of the machines and you
would have data nodes which are your
slave machines getting stored across or
getting or the processes running across
multiple machines each one of these
processes has an important role to play
when you talk about sdfs whatever data
is written to hdfs
that data is split into blocks depending
on its size and the blocks are randomly
distributed across nodes with auto
replication feature these blocks are
also auto replicated across multiple
machines with the first condition that
no two identical blocks will sit on the
same machine now as soon as the cluster
comes up your data nodes which are part
of the cluster and based on config files
would start sending their heartbeat to
the name node and this would be every
three seconds what does name node do
with that name node will store this
information in its ram so name node
starts building a metadata in its ram
and that metadata has information of
what are the data nodes which are
available in the beginning now when a
data
writing activity starts and the blocks
are distributed across data nodes data
nodes every 10 seconds will also send a
block report to name node so name node
is again adding up this information in
its ram or the metadata in ram which
earlier had only data node information
now name node will also have information
about what are the files the files are
split in which blocks the blocks are
stored on which machines and what are
the file permissions now while name node
is maintaining this metadata in ram name
node is also maintaining metadata in
disk now that is what we see in the red
box which basically has information of
whatever information was written to hdfs
so to summarize your name node has
metadata in ram and metadata in disk
your data nodes are the machines where
your blocks or data is actually getting
stored and then there is a auto
replication feature which is always
existing unless and until you have
disabled it and your read and write
activity is a parallel activity however
replication is a sequential activity now
this is what i mentioned about when you
talk about name node which is the master
process hosting metadata in disk and ram
so when we talk about disk it basically
has a edit log which is your transaction
log and your fs image which is your file
system image right from the time the
cluster was started this metadata in
disk was existing and this gets appended
every time read write or any other
operations happen on sdfs metadata in
ram is dynamically built every time the
cluster comes up which basically means
that if your cluster is coming up name
node in the initial few seconds or few
minutes would be in a safe mode which
basically means it is busy registering
the information from data nodes so name
node is one of the most critical
processes if name node is down and if
all other processes are running you will
not be able to access the cluster name
node's metadata in disk is very
important for name node to come up and
maintain the cluster name node's
metadata in ram is basically for all or
satisfying all your client requests now
when we look at data nodes as i
mentioned data nodes hold the actual
data blocks and they are sending these
block reports every 10 seconds so the
metadata in name nodes ram is constantly
getting updated and metadata in disk is
also constantly getting updated based on
any kind of write activity happening on
the cluster now data node which is
storing the block will also help in any
kind of read activity whenever a client
requests so whenever a client on an
application or an api would want to read
the data it would first talk to name
node name node would look into its
metadata on ram and confirm to the
client which machines could be reached
to get to that data that's where your
client would try to read the data from
sdfs which is actually getting the data
from data nodes and that's how your read
write requests are satisfied now what
are the two types of metadata in name
node server holds as i mentioned earlier
metadata in disk very important to
remember edit log nfs image metadata in
ram which is information about your data
nodes files files being split into
blocks blocks residing on data nodes and
file permissions so i will share a very
good link on this and you can always
look for more detailed information about
your metadata so you can search for sdfs
metadata directories explained now this
is from hortonworks however it talks
about the metadata in disk which name
node manages and details about this so
have a look at this link if you are more
interested in learning about metadata on
disk coming back
let's look at the next question what is
the difference between federation and
high availability now these are the
features which were introduced in hadoop
version 2. both of these features are
about horizontal scalability of name
node so prior to version 2 the only
possibility was that you could have one
single master which basically me
means that your cluster could become
unavailable if name node would crash so
hadoop version 2 introduced two new
features federation and high
availability however high availability
is a popular one so when you talk about
federation it basically means any number
of name nodes so there is no limitation
to the number of name nodes your name
nodes are in a federated cluster which
basically means name nodes still belong
to the same cluster but they are not
coordinating with each other so whenever
a write request comes in one of the name
node picks up that request and it guides
that request for the blocks to be
written on data nodes but for this your
name node does not have to coordinate
with other name node to find out if the
block id which was being assigned was
the same one as assigned by other name
node so all of them belong to a
federated cluster they are linked via a
cluster id so whenever an application or
an api is trying to talk to cluster it
is always going via an cluster id and
one of the name node would pick up the
read activity or write activity or
processing activity so all the name
nodes are sharing a pool of metadata in
which each name node will have its own
dedicated pool and we can remember that
by a term called namespace or name
service so this also provides high fault
tolerance supposed your one name node
goes down it will not affect or make
your cluster unavailable you will still
have your cluster reachable because
there are other name nodes running and
they are available now when it comes to
heartbeats all your data nodes are
sending their heart beats to all the
name nodes and all the name nodes are
aware of all the data nodes when you
talk about high availability this is
where you would only have two name nodes
so you would have an active and you
would have a standby now normally in any
environment you would see a
high availability setup with zookeeper
so zookeeper is a centralized
coordination service so when you talk
about your active and standby name notes
election of a name node to be made as
active and taking care of an automatic
failover is done by your zookeeper high
availability can be set up without
zookeeper but that would mean that the
admins intervention would be required to
make a name node as active from standby
or also to take care of failover
now at any point of time in high
availability a active name node would be
taking care of storing the edits about
whatever updates are happening on sdfs
and it is also writing these edits to a
shared location standby name node is the
one which is constantly looking for
these latest updates and applying to its
metadata which is actually a copy of
whatever your active name node has so in
this way your standby name node is
always in sync with the active name node
and if for any reason active name node
fails your standby name node will take
over and become the active remember
zookeeper plays a very important role
here it's a centralized coordination
service one more thing to remember here
is that in your high availability
secondary name node will not be allowed
so you would have a active name node and
then you will have a standby name node
which will be configured on a separate
machine and both of these will be having
access to a shared location now that
shared location could be nfs or it could
be a quorum of general nodes so for more
information refer to the tutorial where
i have explained about sdfs high
availability in federation now let's
look at some logical question here so if
you have a input file of 350 mb which is
obviously bigger than 128 mb how many
input splits would be created by sdfs
and what would be the size of each input
split so for this you need to remember
that by default the minimum block size
is 128 mb now that's customizable if
your environment has more number of
larger files written on an average then
obviously you have to go for a bigger
block size if your environment has a lot
of files being written but these files
are of smaller size you could be okay
with 128 mb remember in hadoop every
entity
that is your directory on sdfs file on
sdfs and a file having multiple blocks
each of these are considered as objects
and for each object hadoop's name nodes
ram 150 bytes is utilized so if your
block size is very small then you would
have more number of blocks which would
directly affect the name node's ram if
you keep a block size very high that
will reduce the number of blocks but
remember that might affect in processing
because processing also depends on
splits more number of splits more the
parallel processing so
setting of block size has to be done
with consideration about your
parallelism requirement and your name
nodes ram which is available now coming
to the question if you have a file of
350 mb that would be split into three
blocks and here two blocks would have
128 mb data and the third block although
the block size would still be 128 it
would have only 94 mb of data so this
would be the split of this particular
file now let's
understand about rack awareness how does
rack awareness work or why do we even
have racks so organizations always would
want to place their nodes or machines in
a systematic way there can be different
approaches you could have a rack which
would have machines running on the
master processes and the intention would
be that this particular rack could have
higher bandwidth more cooling dedicated
power supply top of rack switch and so
on the second approach could be that you
could have one master process running on
one machine of every rack and then you
could have other slave processes running
now when you talk about your rack
awareness one thing to understand is
that if your machines are placed within
racks and we are aware that hadoop
follows auto replication the rule of
replication in a rack of air cluster
would be that you would never have all
the replicas placed on the same rack so
if we look at this if we have block a in
blue color you will never have all the
three blue boxes in the same rack even
if they are on different nodes because
that makes us that makes it less fault
tolerant so you would have at least one
copy of block which would be stored on a
different track on a different note now
let's look at this so basically here we
are talking about replicas being placed
in such a way now somebody could ask a
question can i have my block and its
replicas spread across three lakhs and
yes you can do that but then in order to
make it more redundant you are
increasing your bandwidth requirement so
the better approach would be two blocks
on the same rack on different machines
and one copy on a different track now
let's proceed how can you restart name
node and all demons in hadoop so if you
were working on an apache hadoop cluster
then you could be doing a start and stop
using hadoop demon scripts so there are
these hadoop demon scripts which would
be used to start and stop your hadoop
and this is when you talk about your
apache hadoop so let's look at one
particular file which i would like to
show you more information here and this
talks about your different clusters so
let's look into this and
so let's look at the start and stop and
here i have a file let's look at this
one and this gives you highlight so if
you talk about apache hadoop this is how
the setup would be done so you would
have it download the adobe tar file you
would have to untie it edit the config
files you would have to do formatting
and then start your cluster and here i
have said using scripts so this is in
case of apache hadoop you could be using
a start all script that internally
triggers start dfs and start yarn and
these scripts start dfs internally would
run hadoop demon multiple times based on
your configs to start your different
processes then your start yarn would run
yarn demon script to start your
processing related processes so this is
how it happens in apache hadoop now in
case of cloud era or hortonworks which
is basically a vendor specific
distribution you would have say multiple
services which would have one or
multiple demons running across the
machines let's take an example here that
you would have machine 1 machine 2 and
machine 3 with your processor spread
across however in case of cloud era and
hortonworks these are cluster management
solutions so you would never be involved
in running a script individually to
start and stop your processes in fact in
case of cloud error you would have a
clouded scm server running on one of the
machines and then clouded scm agents
running on every machine if you talk
about hortonworks you would have ambari
server an ambari agent running so your
agents which are running on every
machine are responsible to monitor the
processes send also their heartbeat to
the master that is your server and your
server is the one or a service which
basically will give instructions to the
agents so in case of vendor specific
distribution your start and stop of
processes is automatically taken care by
these underlying services and these
services internally are still running
these commands however only in apache
hadoop you have to manually follow these
to start and stop coming back
we can look into
some command related questions so which
command will help you find the status of
blocks and file system health so you can
always go for a file system check
command now that can show you the files
for a particular sdfs path it can show
you the blocks and it can also give you
information on
status such as under replicated blocks
over replicated blocks misreplicated
blocks default replication and so on so
your fsck file system check utility does
not repair if there is any problem with
the blocks but it can give you
information of
blocks related to the files on which
machines they are stored if they are
replicated as per the replication factor
or if there is any problem with any
particular replica now what would happen
if you store too many small files in a
cluster and this relates to the block
information which i gave some time back
so remember hadoop is coded in java so
here every directory every file and file
related block is considered as an object
and for every object within your hadoop
cluster name nodes ram gets utilized so
more number of blocks you have more
would be usage of name nodes ram and if
you're storing too many small files it
would not affect your disk it would
directly affect your name nodes ram
that's why in production clusters admin
guys or infrastructure specialist will
take care that everyone who is writing
data to hdfs follows a quota system so
that you could be controlled in the
amount of data you write plus the count
of data and individual rights on hdfs
now how do you copy data from local
system onto sdfs so you can use a put
command or a copy from local and then
given your local path which is your
source and then your destination which
is your sdfs path remember you can
always do a copy from local using a
minus f option that's a flag option and
that also helps you in writing the same
file or a new file to hdfs so with your
minus f you have a chance of overwriting
or rewriting the data which is existing
on sdfs so copy from local or minus put
both of them do the same thing and you
can also pass an argument when you're
copying to control your replication or
other aspects of your file now when do
you use dfs admin refresh nodes or rm
admin refresh nodes so as the command
says this is basically to do with
refreshing the node information so your
refresh nodes is mainly used when say a
commissioning or decommissioning of
nodes is done so when a node is added
into the cluster or when a node is
removed from the cluster you are
actually informing hadoop master that
this particular node would not be used
for storage and would not be used for
processing now in that case you would be
once you are done with the process of
commissioning or decommissioning you
would be giving these commands that is
refresh nodes and rm admin refresh nodes
so internally when you talk about
commissioning decommissioning there are
include and exclude files which are
updated and these include and exclude
files will have entry of machines which
are being added to the cluster or
machines which are being removed from
the cluster and while this is being done
the cluster is still running so you do
not have to restart your master process
however you can just use these refresh
commands to take care of your
commissioning decommissioning activities
now is there any way to change
replication of files on sdfs after they
are already written and the answer is of
course yes so if you would want to set a
replication factor at a cluster level
and if you have admin access then you
could edit your sdfs hyphen site file or
you could say hadoop hyphen site file
and that would take care of replication
factor being set at a cluster level
however if you would want to change the
replication after the data has been
written you could always use a setrep
command so setrep command is basically
to change the replication after the data
is written
you could also
write the data with a different
replication and for that you could use a
minus d dfs dot replication and give
your replication factor when you are
writing data to the cluster so in hadoop
you can let your data be replicated as
per the property set in the config file
you could write the data with a
different replication
you could change the replication after
the data is written so all these options
are available now who takes care of
replication consistency in a hadoop
cluster and what do you mean by under
over replicated blocks now as i
mentioned your fsck command can give you
information of over or under replicated
blocks now in a cluster it is always an
always name node which takes care of
replication consistency so for example
if you have set up a replication of
three and since we know the first rule
of replication which basically means
that you cannot have two replicas
residing on the same node it would mean
that if your replication is three you
would need at least three data nodes
available now say for example you had a
cluster with three nodes and replication
was set to three at one point of time
one of your name node crashed and if
that happens your blocks would be under
replicated that means there was a
replication factor set but now your
blocks are not replicated or there are
not enough replicas as per the
replication factor set this is not a
problem your master process or name node
will wait for some time before it will
start the replication of data again so
if a data road is not responding or if a
disk has crashed and if name node does
not get information of a replica name
node will wait for some time and then it
will start re-replication of those
missing blocks from the available nodes
however while name node is doing it the
blocks are in under replicated situation
now when you talk about over replicated
this is a situation where name node
realizes that there are extra copies of
block now this might be the case that
you had three nodes running with a
replication of three one of the node
went down due to a network failure or
some other issue within few minutes name
node re-replicated the data and then the
failed node is back with its set of
blocks again name node is smart enough
to understand that this is over
replication situation and it will delete
set of blocks from one of the nodes it
might be the node which has been
recently added it might be your old node
which has joined your cluster again or
any node that depends on the load on a
particular node now we discussed about
hadoop we discussed about sdfs now we
will discuss about mapreduce which is
the programming model and you can say
processing framework what is distributed
cache in mapreduce now we know that when
we talk about mapreduce the data which
has to be processed might be existing on
multiple nodes so when you would have
your mapreduce program running it would
basically read the data from the
underlying disks
now this could be a costly operation if
every time the data has to be read from
disk
so distributed cache is a mechanism
wherein
data set or data which is coming from
the disk can be cached
and available for all worker nodes now
how will this benefit so when a map
reduce is running instead of every time
reading the data from disk it would pick
up the data from distributed cache and
this this will benefit your mapreduce
processing so distributed cache can be
set in your jobconf where you can
specify that a file should be picked up
from distributed cache
now let's understand about these roles
so what is a record reader what is a
combiner what is a partitioner and what
kind of roles do they play in a map
reduce processing paradigm or map reduce
operation so record reader communicates
with the input split and it basically
converts the data into key value pairs
and these key value pairs are the ones
which will be worked upon by the mapper
your combiner is an optional face it's
like mini radius so combiner does not
have its own class
it relies on the reducer class
basically your combiner would receive
the data from your map tasks
which would have completed works on it
based on whatever reducer class mentions
and then passes its output to the
reducer phase
partitioner is basically a phase which
decides how many reduced tasks would be
used aggregate or summarize your data so
partitioner is a phase which would
decide based on the number of keys based
on the number of
map tasks your partitioner would decide
if one or multiple reduced tasks would
be used to take care of processing so
either it could be partitioner which
decides on how many reduced tasks would
run or it could be based on the
properties which we have set within the
cluster which will take care of the
number of reduced tasks which would be
used always remember your partitioner
decides how outputs from combiner are
sent to reducer and to how many reducers
it controls the partitioning of keys of
your intermediate map outputs so map
phase whatever output it generates is an
intermediate output and that
has to be taken by your practitioner or
by a combiner and then partitioner to be
sent to one or multiple reduced tasks
this is one of the common questions
which you might face
why is mapreduce lower in processing so
we know mapreduce goes for parallel
processing we know we can have multiple
map tasks running on multiple nodes at
the same time we also know that multiple
reduced tasks could be running now why
does then mapreduce become a slower
approach
first of all your mapreduce is a batch
oriented operation now mapreduce
is very rigid and it strictly uses
mapping and reducing phases so no matter
what kind of processing you would want
to do you would have to still provide
the mapper function and the reducer
function to work on data not only this
whenever your map phase completes the
output of your map face which is an
intermittent output would be written to
hdfs and thereafter underlying disks and
this data would then be shuffled and
sorted and picked up for reducing phase
so every time your data being written to
hdfs and retrieved from sdfs makes
mapreduce a slower approach the question
is for a mapreduce job is it possible to
change the number of mappers to be
created
now
by default you cannot change the number
of map tasks because number of map tasks
depends on the input splits however
there are different ways in which you
can either set a property to have more
number of map tasks which can be used or
you can customize your code or
make it use a different format which can
then control the number of map tasks
by default number of map tasks
are equal to the number of splits of
file you are processing
so if you have a 1gb of file that is
split into 8 blocks of 128 mb there
would be 8 map tasks running on the
cluster these map tasks are basically
running your mapper function
if you have hard coded properties in
your map red hyphen site file to specify
more number of map tasks then you could
control the number of map tasks
let's also talk about some data types so
when you prepare for hadoop when you
want to get into big data field you
should start learning about different
data formats now there are different
data formats such as
avro parquet
you have a sequence file or binary
format and these are different formats
which are used now when you talk about
your data types
in hadoop these are implementation of
your writable and writable comparable
interfaces so for every data type
in java you have a equivalent in hadoop
so ind in java would be intriguable in
hadoop float would be float writable
long would be long writable double
writable boolean writable array writable
map writable and object credible so
these are your different data types that
could be used within your mapreduce
program and these are implementation of
writable and writable comparable
interfaces what is speculative execution
now imagine you have a cluster which has
huge number of nodes and your data is
spread across multiple slave machines or
multiple nodes now at a point of time
due to a disk degrade or network issues
or machine heating up or more load being
on a particular node there can be a
situation where your data node will
execute task in a slower manner now in
this case if speculative execution is
turned on there would be a shadow task
or a another
similar task running on some other node
for the same processing so whichever
task finishes first will be accepted and
the other task would be killed so
speculative execution could be good if
you are working in an intensive workload
kind of environment where if a
particular node is slower you could
benefit from a unoccupied or a node
which has less load to take care of your
processing going further this is how we
can understand so node a which might be
having a slower task you would have a
scheduler which is maintaining or
having knowledge of what are the
resources available so if speculative
execution as a property is turned on
then the task which was running slow a
copy of that task or you can say shadow
task would run on some other node and
whichever task completes first will be
considered this is what happens in your
speculative execution now how is
identity mapper different from chain
mapper now this is where we are getting
deeper into mapreduce concepts so when
you talk about mapper identity mapper is
the default mapper which is chosen when
no mapper is specified in mapreduce
driver class so for every mapreduce
program you would have a map class which
is taking care of your mapping phase
which basically has a mapper function
and which would run one or multiple map
tasks right your programming your
program would also have a reduce class
which would be running a reducer
function which takes care of reduced
tasks running on multiple nodes
now if a mapper is not specified within
your driver class so driver class is
something which has all information
about your flow what's your map class
what is your reduced class what's your
input format what's your output format
what are the job configurations and so
on so identity mapper is the default
mapper which is chosen when no mapper
class is mentioned in your driver class
it basically implements an identity
function which directly writes all its
key pairs into output and it was defined
in old mapreduce api in this particular
package but when you talk about chaining
mappers or chain mapper this is
basically a class to run multiple
mappers in a single map task or
basically you could say multiple map
tasks would run as a part of your
processing the output of first mapper
would become as an input to second
mapper and so on and this can be defined
in the under mentioned class or package
what are the major configuration
parameters required in a mapreduce
program obviously we need to have the
input location we need to have the
output location so input location is
where the files will be picked up from
and this would preferably on sdfs
directory output location is the path
where your job output would be written
by your mapreduce program you also need
to specify input and output formats if
you don't specify the defaults are
considered then we need to also have the
classes which have your map and reduce
functions and if you intend to run the
code on a cluster you need to package
your class in a jar file export it to
your cluster and then this jar file
would have your mapper reducer and
driver classes so these are important
configuration parameters
which you need to consider for a map
reduce program now what is the
difference or what do you mean by map
side join and reduce side join map side
join is basically when the join is
performed at the mapping level or at the
mapping phase or is performed by the
mapper so each input data which is being
worked upon has to be divided into same
number of partitions
input to each map is in the form of a
structured partition and is in sorted
order so map site join you can
understand it in a simpler way that if
you compare it with rdbms concepts where
you had two tables which were being
joined it will always be advisable to
give your bigger table as the left side
table or the first table for your join
condition and it would be your smaller
table on the left side and your bigger
table on the right side which basically
means the smaller table could be loaded
in memory and could be used for joining
so map site drawing is a similar kind of
mechanism where input data is divided
into same number of partitions when you
talk about reduced side join here the
join is performed by the reducer so it
is easier to implement than website join
as all the sorting and shuffling will
send the values or send all the values
having identical keys to the same
reducer so you don't need to have your
data set in a structured form so look
into your map side join or reduce side
join and other joins just to understand
how mapreduce works however i would
suggest not to focus more on this
because mapreduce is still being used
for processing but the amount of
mapreduce based processing has decreased
overall or across the industry now what
is the role of output committer class in
a mapreduce job so output committer as
the name says describes the commit of
task output for a mapreduce job so we
could have this as mentioned or capacity
hadoop mapreduce output committer you
could have a class which extends your
output committer class
so mapreduce relies on this mapreduce
relies on the output committer of the
job to
set up the job initialization cleaning
up the job after the job completion that
means all the resources which were being
used by a particular job setting up the
task temporary output checking whether a
task needs a commit committing the task
output and discarding the task out so
this is a very important class and can
be used within your mapreduce job what
is the process of spilling in mapreduce
what does that mean
so spilling is basically a process of
copying the data from memory buffer to
disk when obviously the
buffer usage reaches a certain threshold
so if there is not enough memory in your
buffer in your memory then the content
which is stored in buffer or memory has
to be flushed out so by default a
background thread starts spilling the
content from memory to disk after eighty
percent of buffer size is filled now
when is the buffer being used so when
your mapreduce processing is happening
the data from data is being read from
the disk loaded into the buffer and then
some processing happens
same thing also happens when you are
writing data to the cluster so you can
imagine for a 100 megabyte size buffer
the spilling will start after the
content of buffer reaches 80 megabytes
this is customizable how can you set the
mappers and reducers for a mapreduce job
so these are the properties so number of
mappers and reducers as i mentioned
earlier can be customized so by default
your number of map tasks depends on the
split and number of reduced tasks
depends on the partitioning phase which
decides number of reduced tasks which
would be used depending on the keys
however we can set these properties
either in the config files or provide
them on the command line or also make
them part of our code and this can
control the number of map tasks or
reduce tasks which would be run for a
particular job let's look at one more
interesting question what happens when a
node running a map task fails before
sending the output to the reducer
so there was a node which was running a
map task and we know that there could be
one or multiple map tasks running on one
or multiple nodes and all the map tasks
have to be completed before the further
stages that such as combiner or reducer
come into existence so in a case if a
node crashes where a map task was
assigned to it the whole task will have
to be run again on some other note so in
hadoop version 2 yarn framework has a
temporary demon called application
master so your application master is
taking care of execution of your
application
and if a particular task on a particular
node failed due to unavailability of
node it is the role of application
master to have this task scheduled on
some other node now can we write the
output of mapreduce in different formats
of course we can so hadoop supports
various input and output formats so you
can write the output of mapreduce in
different formats so you could have the
default format that is text output
format wherein records are written as
line of text you could have sequence
file which is basically to write
sequence files or your binary format
files where your output files need to be
fed into another mapreduce jobs you
could go for a map file output format to
write output as map files you could go
for a sequence file as a binary output
format so that's again a variant of your
sequence file input format it basically
writes keys and values to a sequence
file so when we talk about binary format
we are talking about a non-human
readable format db output format now
this is basically used when you would
want to write data to say relational
databases or say no sql databases such
as hbase so this format also sends the
reduce output to a sql table now let's
learn a little bit about yarn yarn which
stands for yet another resource
negotiator it's the processing framework
so what benefits did yan bring in hadoop
version 2 and how did it solve the
issues of mapreduce version 1. so
mapreduce version 1 had major issues
when it comes to scalability or
availability because sorry in hadoop
version 1 you had only one master
process for processing layer and that is
your job tracker so your job tracker was
listening to all the task trackers which
were running on multiple machines so
your job tracker was responsible for
resource tracking and job scheduling in
yarn you still have a processing master
but that's called resource manager
instead of job tracker and now with
hadoop version 2 you could even have
resource manager running in high
availability mode you have node managers
which would be running on multiple
machines and then you have a temporary
demon called application master so in
case of hadoop version 2 your resource
manager or master is only handling the
client connections and taking care of
tracking the resources the jobs
scheduling or basically taking care of
execution across multiple nodes is
controlled by application master till
the application completes
so in yarn you can have different kind
of resource allocations that could be
done and there is a concept of container
so container is basically a combination
of ram and cpu cores
yarn can run different kind of workloads
so it is not just mapreduce kind of
workload which can be run on adobe
person 2 but you would have graph
processing massive parallel processing
you could have
real time processing and huge processing
applications could run on a cluster
based on yarn so when we talk about
scalability
in case of your hadoop version 2 you can
have a cluster size of more than 10 000
nodes and can run more than 100 000
concurrent tasks and this is because for
every application which is launched you
have this temporary demon called
application master so if i would have 10
applications running i would have 10 app
masters running taking care of execution
of these applications across multiple
nodes compatibility so hadoop version 2
is fully compatible with whatever was
developed as per hadoop version 1 and
all your processing needs would be taken
care by yarn
so dynamic allocation of cluster
resources taking care of different
workloads
allocating resources across multiple
machines and using them for execution
all that is taken care by yarn multi
tenancy which basically means you could
have multiple users or multiple teams
you could have open source and
proprietary data access engines and all
of these could be basically hosted using
the same cluster now how does yarn
allocate resources to an application
with help of its architecture so
basically you have a client or an
application or an api which talks to
resource manager resource manager is as
i mentioned managing the resource
allocation in the cluster when you talk
about resource manager you have its
internal two components one is your
scheduler and one is your applications
manager so when we say resource manager
being the master is tracking the
resources the source manager is the one
which is negotiating the resources with
slave it is not actually resource
manager who is doing it but these
internal components
so you have a scheduler which allocates
resources to various running
applications so scheduler is not
bothered about tracking your resources
or basically tracking your applications
so we can have different kind of
schedulers such as fifo which is first
in first out you could have a fair
scheduler or you could have a capacity
scheduler and these schedulers basically
control how resources are allocated to
multiple applications when they are
running in parallel so there is a queue
mechanism so scheduler will schedule
resources based on requirements of
application but it is not monitoring or
tracking the status of applications
your applications manager is the one
which is accepting the job submissions
it is monitoring and restarting the
application masters so its application
manager which is basically then
launching a application master which is
responsible for an application so this
is how it looks
so whenever a job submission happens we
already know that resource manager is
aware of the resources which are
available with every node manager so on
every node which has fixed amount of ram
and cpu cores
some portion of resources that is your
ram and cpu cores are allocated to node
manager now resource manager is already
aware of how much resources are
available across nodes so whenever a
client request comes in resource manager
will make a request to node manager it
will basically request node manager to
hold some resources for processing node
manager would basically approve or
disapprove this request of holding the
sources
and these resources that is a
combination of ram and cpu cores are
nothing but containers we can allocate
containers of different sizes within
yarn hyphen site file so your node
manager based on a request from resource
manager guarantees the container which
would be available for processing that's
when your resource manager starts a
temporary demon called application
master to take care of your execution so
your app master which was launched by
resource manager or we can say internal
away applications manager will run in
one of the containers because
application master is also a piece of
code so it will run in one of the
containers and then other containers
will be utilized for execution this is
how yarn is basically taking care of
your allocation your application master
is managing resource needs it is the one
which is interacting with scheduler and
if
a particular
node crashes it is the responsibility of
app master to go back to the master
which is resource manager and negotiate
for more resources
so your app master will never ever
negotiate resources with node manager
directly it will always talk to resource
manager and the source manager is the
one which negotiates the resources
container as i said is a collection of
resources like your ram cpu network
bandwidth and your container is
allocated based on the availability of
resources on a particular node so which
of the following has occupied the place
of a job tracker of mapreduce
so it is your resource manager so
resource manager is the name of the
master process in adobe portion 2. now
if you would have to
write yarn commands to check the status
of an application so we could just say
yarn application minus status and then
the application id and you could kill it
also from the command line remember your
yarn has a ui and you can even look at
your applications from the ui you can
even kill your applications from the ui
however knowing the command line
commands would be very useful can we
have more than one resource manager in a
young base cluster
yes we can that is what hadoop version 2
allows us to have so you can have a high
availability yarn cluster where you have
a active and standby and the
coordination is taking care by your
zookeeper at a particular time there can
only be one active resource manager and
if active resource manager fails your
standby resource manager comes
and becomes active however zookeeper is
playing a very important role remember
zookeeper is the one which is
coordinating the server state and it is
doing the election of active to standby
failover what are the different
schedulers available in yarn so you have
a fifo scheduler that is
first in first out and this is not a
desirable option because in this case a
longer running application might block
all other small running applications
your capacity scheduler is basically a
scheduler where dedicated queues are
created and they have fixed amount of
resources so you can have multiple
applications accessing the cluster at
the same time and they would be using
their own cues
and the resources allocated to them if
you talk about fair scheduler you don't
need to have a fixed amount of
resources you can just have a percentage
and you could decide what kind of
fairness is to be followed which
basically means that if you were
allocated 20 gigabytes of memory however
the cluster has 100 gigabytes and the
other team was assigned 80 gigabytes of
memory then you have 20 percent access
to the cluster another team has 80
percent however if the other team does
not come up or does not use the cluster
in a fair scheduler you can go up to
maximum 100
of your cluster to find out more
information about your schedulers you
could either look in hadoop definitive
guide or what you could do is you could
just go to google and you could type for
example
yarn scheduler
let's search for yarn scheduler and then
you can look in
hadoop definitive guide
and so this is your hadoop definitive
guide and it beautifully explains about
your different schedulers how do
multiple applications run and that could
be in your
fifo kind of scheduling it could be in
capacity scheduler or it could be in a
fair scheduling so have a look at this
link it's a very good link you can also
search for yarn untangling and this is a
blog of four or this is a series of four
blocks where it's beautifully explained
about your yarn how it works how the
resource allocation happens what is a
container and what runs within the
container so you can scroll down you can
be reading through this and you can then
also search for part two of it which
talks about allocation and so on so
coming back we basically have these
schedulers what happens if a resource
manager fails while executing an
application in a high availability
cluster so in a high availability
cluster we know that we would have two
resource managers one being active one
being standby and zookeeper which is
keeping a track of the server states so
if a rm fails in case of high
availability the
standby will be elected as active and
then basically your resource manager or
the standby would become the active one
and this one would instruct the
application master to abort in the
beginning then your resource manager
recovers its running state so there is
something called as rm state store where
all the applications which are running
their status is stored so resource
manager recovers
its running state by looking at your
state store
by taking advantage of container
statuses and then continues to take care
of your processing now in a cluster of
10 data nodes each having 16 gb and 10
cores what would be total processing
capacity of the cluster take a minute to
think 10 data nodes 16 gb ram per node
10 cores
so if you mention the answer as 160 gb
ram
and 100 cores then
you went wrong now think of a cluster
which has 10 data nodes each having 16
gb ram and 10 cores remember on every
node in a hadoop cluster you would have
one or multiple processors running those
processes would need ram the machine
itself which has a linux file system
would have its own processes so that
would also be having some ram usage
which basically means that if you talk
about 10 data nodes you should deduct at
least 20 to 30 percent towards the
overheads towards the cloud database
services towards the other processes
which are running and in that case i
could say that you could have 11 or 12
gb available on every machine for
processing and say 6 or 7 cores multiply
that by 10 and that's your processing
capacity remember the same thing applies
to the disk usage also so if somebody
asks you in a 10 data node cluster where
each machine has 20 terabytes of disks
what is my total storage capacity
available for sdfs so the answer would
not be 200 you have to consider the
overheads and this is basically which
gives you your processing capacity now
let's look at one more question so what
happens if requested memory or cpu cores
beyond or goes beyond the size of
container now as i said you can have
your configurations which can say that
in a particular data node which has 100
gb ram i could allocate say 50 gb
for the processing like out of 100 cores
i could say 50 cores for processing so
if you have 100 gb ram and 100 cores you
could ideally allocate 100 for
processing but that's not ideally
possible so if you have 100 gb ram you
would go for 50 gb and if you have 100
cores you would go for 50 cores now
within this ram and cpu course you have
the concept of containers right so
container is a combination of ram and
cpu cores so you could have a minimum
size container and maximum size
container now at any point of time if
your application starts demanding
more memory or more cpu cores
and this cannot fit into a container
location your application will fail your
application will fail because you
requested for a memory or a combination
of memory and cpu cores which is
more than the maximum container size so
look into this yarn tangling website
which i mentioned and look for the
second blog in those series which
explains about these allocations now
here we will discuss on hive peg hbase
and these components of do which are
being used in the industry for various
use cases let's look at some questions
here and let's look how you should
prepare for them so first of all we will
learn on hive which is a data
warehousing package so the question is
what are the different components of a
hive architecture now when we talk about
hive we already know that hive is a data
warehousing package which basically
allows you to work on structured data or
data which can be structuralized so
normally people are well versed with
querying or basically processing the
data using sql queries a lot of people
come from database backgrounds and they
would find it comfortable if they know
structured query language hive is one of
the data warehousing package which
resides within a hadoop ecosystem it
uses hadoop's distributed file system to
store the data and it uses rdbms usually
to store the metadata although metadata
can be stored locally also so what are
the different components of an hive
architecture so it has a user interface
so user interface calls the execute
interface to the driver this creates a
session to the query and then it sends
the query to the compiler to generate an
execution plan for it usually whenever
hive is set up it would have its
metadata stored in an rdbms now to
establish the connection between rdbms
and hadoop we need odbc or jdbc
connector jar file and that connector
jar file has a driver class now this
driver class is mandatory to create a
connection between hive and hadoop so
user interface creates this interface
using the driver now we have metastore
metastore stores the metadata
information so any object which you
create such as database table indexes
their metadata is stored in metastore
and usually this meta store is stored in
an rdbms so that multiple users can
connect to hive so your metastore stores
the metadata information and sends that
to the compiler for execution of a query
what does the compiler do it generates
the execution plan it has a dag now dag
stands for direct cyclic graph so it has
a dag of stages where each stage is
either a metadata operation a map or
reduced job or an operation on sdfs and
finally we have execution engine that
acts as a bridge between hive and hadoop
to process the query so execution engine
communicates bi-directionally with
metastore to perform operations like
create or drop tables so these are four
important components of hive
architecture
now what is the difference between
external table and manage table and
height
so we have various kinds of table in
height such as external table manage
table partition table the major
difference between your managed and
external table is in respect to what
happens to the data if the table is
dropped usually whenever we create a
table in hive it creates a managed table
or we could also call that as an
internal table now this manages the data
and moves it into warehouse directory by
default whether you create a manage
table or external table usually the data
can reside in hive's default warehouse
directory or it could be residing in a
location chosen however when we talk
about manage table if one drops a
managed table not only the metadata
information is deleted but the table's
data is also deleted from his dfs if we
talk about external table it is created
with an external keyword explicitly and
if an external table is dropped nothing
happens to the data which resides in
sdfs so that's the main difference
between your managed and external table
what might be the use case if somebody
asks you there might be a migration kind
of activity or you are interested in
creating a lot of tables
using your queries so in that case you
could dump all the data on sdfs and then
you could create a table by pointing to
a particular directory or multiple
directories now you could then do some
testing of your tables and would decide
that you might not need all the tables
so in that case it would be advisable to
create external tables so that even if
the table is later dropped the data on
sdfs will be intact unlike your manage
table where dropping of table will
delete the data from sdfs also let's
learn a little bit on partition so what
is partition and height and why is
partitioning required in hive if
somebody asks you that now normally in
world of rdbms partition is the process
to group similar type of data together
and that is usually done on basis of a
column or what we call as partitioning
key now each table usually has one
column in context of rdbms which could
be used to partition the data and why do
we do that so that we can avoid scanning
the complete table for a query and
restrict the scan to
set of data or to a particular partition
in hive we can have any number of
partition keys so partitioning provides
granularity in hive table it reduces the
query latency by scanning only relevant
partition data instead of whole data set
we can partition at various levels now
if i compare rdbms with hive in case of
rdbms you could have
one column which could be used for
partitioning and then you could be
squaring the specific partition so in
case of rdbms your partition column is
usually a part of the table definition
so for example if i have an employee
table i might have employee id employee
name employee age and employee salary as
four columns and i would decide to
partition the table based on salary
column now why would i partition it
because i feel that employee table is
growing very fast it is or it will have
huge amount of data and later when we
query the table we don't want to scan
the complete table so i could split my
data into multiple partition based on a
salary column giving some ranges in hive
it is a little different
in hive you can do partitioning and
there is a concept of static and dynamic
partitioning but in hive the partition
column is not part of table definition
so you might have an employee table with
employee id
name age
and that that's it that would be the
table definition but you could then have
partitioning done based on salary column
which will then create a specific folder
on sdfs in that case when we query the
data we can see the partition column
also showing up so we can partition the
transaction data for a bank for example
based on month like chan feb etc and any
operation regarding a particular month
will then allow us to query that
particular folder that is where
partitioning is useful now why does hive
not store metadata information in sdfs
if somebody asks you so we know that
hives data is stored in sdfs which is
hadoop distributed file system however
the metadata is either stored locally
and that mode of hive would be called as
embedded mode or you could have hives
metadata stored in rdbms so that
multiple clients can initiate a
connection now this metadata which is
very important for hive would not be
stored in sdfs so we already know that
sdfs read and write operations are time
consuming it is a distributed file
system and it can accommodate huge
amount of data so hive stores metadata
information in metastore using rdbms
instead of sdfs so this allows to
achieve low latency and faster data
access
now if somebody asks what are the
components used in hive query processor
so usually we have the main components
are your parser your execution engine
logical plan generation optimizer and
type checking so whenever a query is
submitted it will go through a parser
and parser would check the syntax it
would check for objects which are being
queried and other things to see if the
query is fine now internally you have a
semantic analyzer which will also look
at the query you have an execution
engine which basically will work on the
execution part that is the best
generated execution plan which could be
used to get the results for the query
you could also have user defined
functions which a user would want to use
and these are normally created in
java or java programming language and
then basically these user defined
functions are added to the class path
now you would have a logical plan
generation which basically looks at your
query and then generates a logical plan
or the best execution path which would
be required to get to the results
internally there is a physical plan
generated which is then looked in by
optimizer to get the best path to get to
the data and that might also be checking
your different operators which you are
using within your query finally we would
also have type checking so these are
important components in hype so somebody
might ask you if you are querying your
data using hive what are the different
components involved or if you could
explain what are the different
components which
work
when a query is submitted so these are
the components now let's look a scenario
based question suppose there are a lot
of small csv files which are present in
a sdfs directory and you want to create
a single hive table from these files so
data in these files have fields like
registration number name email address
so if this is what needs to be done what
will be your approach to solve it where
will you create a single hive table for
lots of small files without degrading
the performance of the system so there
can be different approaches now we know
that there are a lot of small csv files
which are present in a directory so we
know that when we create a table in hive
we can use a location parameter so i
could say create table give a table name
give the column and their data types i
could specify the delimiters and finally
i could say location and then point it
to a directory on sdfs and this
directory might be the directory which
has lot of csv files so in this case i
will avoid loading the data in the table
because table being point table pointing
to the directory will directly pick up
the data from one or multiple files and
we also know that hive does schema check
on read so it does not do a schema check
on write so in case there were one or
two files which did not follow the
schema of the table it would not prevent
data loading data would anyways be
loaded only when you query the data it
might show you null values if data which
was loaded does not follow the schema of
the table this is one approach what is
the other approach so let's look at that
you can think about sequence file format
which is basically a smart format or a
binary format and you can group these
small files together to form a sequence
file now this could be one other smarter
approach so we could create a temporary
table so we could say create table give
a table name give the column names and
their data types we could specify the
delimiters as it shows here that is row
format and fields terminated by and
finally we can store that as text file
then we can load data into this table by
giving a local file system path and then
we can create a table that will store
data in sequence file format so my point
one is storing the data in text text
file point three would be storing the
data in sequence file format so we say
create table give the specifications we
say row format delimited fields are
terminated by comma stored as sequence
file then we can move the data from test
table into test sequence file table so i
could just say insert overwrite my new
table as select star from other table
remember in hive you cannot do insert
update delete however if the table is
existing you can do a insert overwrite
from an existing table into a new table
so this could be one approach where we
could have lot of csv files or smaller
files club together as one big sequence
file and then store it in the table now
if somebody asks you write a query to
insert a new column that is
integer data type into a hive table and
the requirement might be that you would
want to insert this table at a position
before an existing column now that's
possible by doing an alter table giving
your table name and then specifying
change column giving you a new column
with the data type before an existing
column this is a simple way wherein you
can insert a new column into a hive
table what are the key differences
between hive and pig
now some of you might have heard high
visit data where housing package and pig
is more of a scripting language
both of them are used for data analysis
or trend detection hypothesis testing
data transformation and many other use
cases so if we compare hive and pig hive
uses a declarative language called hive
ql that is hive querying language
similar to sql and it is for reporting
or for data analysis even for data
transformation or for your data
extraction pig uses a high level
procedural language called pig latin for
programming both of them remember use
mapreduce processing framework so when
we run a query in hive to process the
data or when we create and submit a pick
script both of them trigger a mapreduce
job unless and until we have set them to
local mode hive operates on the server
side of the cluster and basically works
on structured data or data which can be
structuralized pig usually works or
operates on the client side of the
cluster and allows both structured
unstructured or even i could say
semi-structured data hive does not
support avro file format by default
however that can be done by using the
write serializer d serializer so we can
have hive table related data stored in
avro format in sequence file format in
part k format or even as a text file
format however when we are working on
smarter formats like avro or sequence
file or par k we might have to use
specific serializers d serializers for
avro this is the package which allows us
to use avro format pig supports avro
format by default hive was developed by
facebook and it supports partitioning
and pig was developed by yahoo and it
does not support partitioning so these
are high level differences there are
lots and lots of differences remember
hive is more of a data housing package
and pig is more of a scripting language
or a
strictly procedural flow following
scripting language which allows us to
process the data now let's get more and
let's get more deeper and learn about
pig which is as i mentioned a scripting
language which can be used for your data
processing it also uses mapreduce
although we can even have pig run in a
local mode let's learn about pig in the
next section now let's learn on some
questions about pig which is a scripting
language and it is extensively used for
data processing and data analysis so the
question is how is apache pig different
from mapreduce now we all know that
mapreduce is a programming model it is
it's quite rigid when it comes to
processing the data because you have to
do the mapping and reducing you have to
write huge code usually mapreduce is
written in java but now it can also be
written in python it can be written in
scala another programming languages so
if we compare pig with mapreduce pig
obviously is very concise it has less
lines of code when compared to mapreduce
now we also know that pig script
internally will trigger a mapreduce job
however user need not know about
mapreduce programming model they can
simply write simple scripts in pig and
that will automatically be converted
into mapreduce however mapreduce has
more lines of code peak is high level
language which can easily perform join
operations or other data processing
operations mapreduce is a low level
language which cannot perform job join
operations easily so we can do join
using mapreduce however it's not really
easy in comparison to pick now as i said
on execution every pig operator is
converted internally into a mapreduce
job so every pick script which is run
which would be converted into mapreduce
job now map reduce overall is a batch
oriented processing so it takes more
time to compile it takes more time to
execute either when you run a mapreduce
job or when it is triggered by
pingscript pig works with all versions
of hadoop and when we talk about
mapreduce program which is written in
one hadoop version may not work with
other versions it might work or it might
not it depends on what are the
dependencies what is the compiler you
are using what programming language you
have used and what version of hadoop you
are working on so these are the main
differences between apache pig and
mapreduce what are the different ways of
executing pig script so you could create
a script file store it in dot pic or dot
text and then you could execute it using
the pic command you could be bringing up
the grunt shell that is pig's shell now
that usually starts with mapreduce mode
but then we can also bring it up in a
local mode and we can also run pic
embedded as an embedded script in other
programming language so these are the
different ways of executing your big
script now what are the major components
of pig execution environment this is
this is a very common question
interviewers would always want to know
different components of hive different
components of pig even different
components which are involved in hadoop
ecosystem so when we want to learn about
major components of big execution
environment here are some so you have
pig scripts now that is written in pig
latin using built-in operators and
user-defined functions and submitted to
the execution environment that's what
happens when you would want to process
the data using pic now there is a parser
which does type checking and checks the
syntax of the script the output of
parser is a tag direct cyclic graph so
block in wikipedia for dag so dag is
basically a sequence of steps which run
in one direction then you have an
optimizer now this optimizer performs
optimization using merge transform split
etc it aims to reduce the amount of data
in the pipeline that's the whole purpose
of optimizer you have a internal
compiler so pic compiler converts the
optimized code into a mapreduce job and
here user need not know the mapreduce
programming model or how it works or how
it is written they all need to know
about running the big script which would
be internally converted into a mapreduce
job and finally we have an execution
engine so mapreduce jobs are submitted
to the execution engine to generate the
desired results so these are major
components of pig execution environment
now let's learn about different complex
data types in pig supports various data
types the main ones are tuple bag and
map what is tuple or tuple as you might
have heard a tuple is an ordered set of
fields which can contain different data
types for each field so in array you
would have multiple elements but that
would be of same types list can also
have different types your tuple is a
collection which has different fields
and each field can be of different type
now we could have an example as one
comma three or one comma three comma a
string or a float element and all of
that form a tuple bag is a set of tuples
so that's represented by curly braces so
you could also imagine this like a
dictionary which has various different
collection elements what is a map map is
a set of key value pairs used to
represent data so when you work in big
data field you need to know about
different data types which are supported
by pig which are supported by hive which
are supported in other components of
hadoop so tuple bag map array array
buffer you can think about list you can
think about dictionaries you can think
about map which is key value pair so
these are your different complex data
types other than the primitive data type
such as integer character string boolean
float and so on now what are the various
diagnostic operators available in apache
pic so these are some of the operators
or options which you can give in a pic
script you can do a dumb now dumb
operator runs the pig latin scripts and
displays the result on the screen so
either i could do it dumb and see the
output on the screen or i can even do a
dump into and i could store my output in
a particular file so we can load the
data using load operator and pick and
then pico also has different internal
storage like json loader or big storage
which can be used if you are working on
specific kind of data and then you could
do a dump either before processing or
after processing and dump would produce
the result the result could be stored in
a file or
seen on the screen you also have a
describe operator now that is used to
view the schema of a relation so you can
load the data and then you can view the
schema of relation using describe
operator explain as we might already
know displays the physical logical and
mapreduce execution plans so normally in
rdbms when we use x-plane we would like
to see what happens behind the scenes
when a particular script or a query runs
so we could load the data using load
operator as in any other case and if we
would want to display the logical
physical and mapreduce execution plans
we could use explain operator there is
also an illustrate operator now that
gives the step-by-step execution of
sequence of statements so sometimes when
we would want to analyze our script to
see how good or bad they are or would
that really serve our purpose we could
use illustrate and again you can test
that by loading the data using load
operator and you could just use a
illustrate operator to have a look at
the step-by-step execution of the
sequence of statements which you would
want to execute so these are different
diagnostic operators available in apache
pic now if somebody asks state the usage
of group order by and distinct keywords
in picscript so as i said pig is a
scripting language so you could use
various operators so group basically
collects various records with the same
key and groups the data in one or more
relations here is an example you could
do a group data so that is basically a
variable or you can give some other name
and you can say group relation name by h
now say i have a file where i have field
various fields and one of the field is
relation name so i could group that by a
different field order by is used to
display the contents of relation in a
sorted order whether ascending or
descending so i could create a variable
called relation 2 and then i could say
order relation name 1 by ascending or
descending order distinct basically
removes the duplicate records and it is
implemented only on entire records
not on individual records so if you
would like want to find out the distinct
values and relation name field i could
use distinct what are the relational
operators in pig so you have various
relational operators which help data
scientists or data analysts or
developers who are analyzing the data
such as co-group which joins two or more
tables and then performs group operation
on the join table result you have cross
it is used to compute the cross product
that is a cartesian product of two or
more relations
for each is basically to do some
iteration so if it will iterate through
tuples of a relation generating a data
transformation so for example if i say
variable a equals and then i load a file
in a and then i could create a variable
called b where i could say for each a i
would want to do something say group
join is to join two or more tables in a
relation limit is to limit the number of
output tuples or output results split is
to split the relation into two or more
relations union is to get a combination
that's it will merge the contents of two
or more relations and order is to get a
sorted result so these are some
relational operators which are
extensively used in pig for analysis
what is the use of having filters in
apache pic
now say for example i have some data
which has three fields year product
quantity and this is my phone sales data
so filter operator could be used to
select the required values from a
relation based on a condition it also
allows you to remove unwanted records
from data file so for example filter the
products where quantity is greater than
thousand so i see that i have one row
wherein or multiple rows where the
quantity is greater than thousand such
as 1500 1700 1200 so i could create a
variable called a i would load my file
using pix storage as i explained earlier
pick storage is an internal parameter
which can be used to
specify the delimiters now here my
delimiter is comma so i could say using
pick storage as and then i could specify
the data type for each field so here
being integer product being character
array and quantity being integer then b
i could say filter a whatever we have in
a by quantity greater than thousand so
it's very concise it's very simple and
it allows us to extract and process data
in a simpler way now suppose there is a
file called test.txt
having 150 records in his dfs so this is
a file which is stored on his dfs and it
has 150 records where we can consider
every record being one line and if
somebody asks you to write a pick
command to retrieve the first 10 records
of the file first we will have to load
the data so i could create a variable
called test underscore data and i would
say load my file using pick storage
specifying the delimiter as comma as and
then i could specify my fields whatever
fields our file have and then i would
want to get only 10 records for which i
could use the limit operator so i could
say limit on test data and give me 10
records this is very simple and we can
extract 10 records from 150 records
which are stored in the file on sdfs
now we have learned on pig we have
learned some questions on hive you could
always look more in books like
programming in hive or programming in
pig and look for some more examples and
try out these examples on a existing
hadoop setup now let's learn on hbase
which is a nosql database now hbase is a
four dimensional database in comparison
to your rdbms which usually are two
dimensional so rdbms have rows and
columns but hbase has four coordinates
it has row key which is always unique
column family which can be any number
column qualifiers which can again be any
number per column family and then you
have a version so these four coordinates
make edge base a four dimensional key
value store or a column family store
which is unique for storing huge amount
of data and extracting data from hbase
there is a very good link which i would
suggest everyone can look at if you
would want to learn more on hbase and
you could just say edge base mapper and
this basically brings up a documentation
which is from mapr but then that's not
specific to mapper and you can look at
this link which will give you a detailed
explanation of hbase how it works what
are the architectural components and how
data is stored and how it makes hbase a
very powerful nosql database so let's
learn on some of the important or
critical questions on hbase which might
be asked by the interviewer in an
interview when you are applying for a
big data admin or a developer position
role so what are the key components of
hbase now as i said this is one of the
favorite questions of interviewers where
they would want to understand your
knowledge on different components for a
particular service hbase as i said is a
nosql database and that comes as a part
of service with cloudera or hortonworks
and with apache hadoop you could also
set up hbase as an independent package
so what are the key components of hbase
hbase has a region server now edge base
follows the similar kind of topology
like hadoop now hadoop has a master
process that is named node and slave
processes such as data nodes and
secondary name node in the same way
hbase also has a master which is h
master and the slave processes are
called region servers so these region
servers are usually co-located with data
nodes however it is not mandatory that
if you have 100 data nodes you would
have 100 region servers so it purely
depends on admin so what does this
region server contain so region server
contains hbase tables that are divided
horizontally into regions or you could
say group of rows is called regions so
in edge base you have two aspects one is
group of columns which is called column
family and one is group of rows which is
called regions now these regions or
these rows are grouped based on the key
values or i would say row keys which are
always unique when you store your data
in each base you would have data in the
form of rows and columns so group of
rows are called regions or you could say
these are horizontal partitions of the
table so a region server manages these
regions on the node where a data node is
running a region server can have up to
thousand regions it runs on every node
and decides the size of region so region
server as i said is a slave process
which is responsible for managing hbase
data on the node each region server is a
worker node or a worker process
co-located with data node which will
take care of your read write update
delete request from the clients now when
we talk about more components of edge
base as i said you have hp h master so
you would always have a connection
coming in from a client or an
application what does hmaster do it
assigns regions it monitors the region
servers it assigns regions to region
servers for load balancing and it cannot
do that without the help of zookeeper so
if we talk about components of hbase
there are three main components you have
zookeeper you have hmaster and you have
region server region server being the
slave process your edge master being the
master process which takes care of all
your table operations assigning regions
to the region servers taking care of
read and write requests which come from
client and for all of this edgemaster
will taken help of zookeeper which is a
centralized coordination service so
whenever a client wants to read or write
or change the schema or any other
metadata operations it will contact
hmaster edge master internally will
contact zookeeper so you could have
hbase setup also in high availability
mode where you could have a active edge
master than a backup edge master you
would have a zookeeper quorum which is
the way zookeeper works so zookeeper is
a centralized coordination service which
will always run with a quorum of
processes so zookeeper would always run
with odd number of processes such as 3 5
and 7 because zookeeper works on the
concept of majority consensus now
zookeeper which is a centralized
coordination service is keeping a track
of all the servers which are alive
available and also keeps a track of
their status for every server with
zookeeper is monitoring zookeeper keeps
a session alive with that particular
server h master would always check with
zookeeper which region servers are
available alive so that regions can be
assigned to the region server at one end
you have region server which are sending
their status to the zookeeper indicating
if they are ready for any kind of read
or write operation and at other end edge
master is querying the zookeeper to
check the status now zookeeper
internally manages a meta table now that
meta table will have information of
which regions are residing on which
region server and what row keys those
regions contain so in case of a read
activity hmaster will query zookeeper to
find out the region server which
contains that meta table once edge
master gets the information of meta
table it can look into the meta table to
find out the row keys and the
corresponding region servers which
contain the regions for those row keys
now if we would want to understand row
key and column families in hbase let's
look at this and it would be good if we
could look this on an excel sheet so row
key is always unique it acts as a
primary key for any h base table it
allows a logical grouping of cells and
make sure that all cells with the same
row key are co-located on the same
server so as i said you have four
coordinates for hbase you have a row key
which is always unique you have column
families which is nothing but group of
columns and when i say column families
one column family can have any number of
columns so when i talk about h base h
base is four dimensional and in terms of
edge base it is also called as a column
oriented database which basically means
that every row in one column could have
a different data type now you have a row
key which uniquely identifies the row
you have column families which could be
one or many depending on how the table
has been defined and a column family can
have any number of columns or i could
say for every row within a column family
you could have different number of
columns so i could say for my row one i
could just have two columns such as name
and city within the column family for my
row 2 i could have name city age
designation salary for my third row i
could have thousand columns and all that
could belong to one column family so
this is a horizontally scalable database
so column family consists of group of
columns which is defined during table
creation and each column family can have
any number of column qualifiers
separated by a delimiter now a
combination of row key column family
column qualifier such as name city age
and the value within the cell is makes
the hbase a unique four dimensional
database for more information if you
would want to learn on hbase please
refer this link which is hbase mapper
and this gives a complete hbase
architecture that is three components of
name node
three components that is name node
region servers and zookeeper how it
works how each base edge master
interacts with zookeeper what zookeeper
does in coordination how are the
components working together and how does
hbs take care of read and write coming
back and continuing why do we need to
disable a table so there are different
table operations what you can do in each
base and one of them is disabling a
table now if you would want to check the
status of table you could check that by
is disabled and giving the table name
order is enabled and the table name so
the question is why do we need to
disable a table now if we would want to
modify a table or we are doing some kind
of maintenance activity in that case we
can disable the table
so that we can modify your changes
settings when a table is disabled it
cannot be accessed through the scan
command now if we have to write a code
to open a connection in each base now to
interact with hbase one could either use
a graphical user interface such as hue
or you could be using the command line
hb shell or you could be using hbase
admin api if you are working with java
or say happy base if you're working with
python where you may want to open a
connection with hbase so that you can
work with it based programmatically in
that case we have to create a
configuration object that is
configuration my conf and then create a
configuration object and then you can
use different classes like edge table
interface to work on a new table you
could use h column qualifier and many
other classes which are available in
hbase admin api what does replication
mean in terms of hbase so edge base as i
said works in a cluster way and when you
talk about cluster you could always set
up a replication from one hbase cluster
to other hbase cluster so this
replication feature in edge base
provides a mechanism to copy data
between clusters or sync the data
between different clusters this feature
can be used as a disaster recovery
solution that provides high availability
for hbase so if i have a hbase cluster
one where i have one master and multiple
region servers running in a hadoop
cluster i could use the same hadoop
cluster to create a hbase replica
cluster or i could have a totally
different hbase replica cluster where my
intention is that if things are changing
in a particular table in cluster 1 i
would want them to be replicated across
different clusters so i could alter the
hbase table and set the replication
scope to one now a replication scope of
zero indicates that table is not
replicated but if we set the replication
to one we basically will have to set up
ah base cluster where we can replicate
edge base tables data from cluster one
to cluster so these are the commands
which can be used to enable replication
and then replicate the data of table
across clusters can we import and export
in hbase of course we can it is possible
to import and export tables from one
hbase cluster to other hbase cluster or
even within a cluster so we can use the
hbase export utility which comes in this
particular package give a table name and
then a target location so that will
export the data of hbase table into a
directory on sdfs then i could create a
different table which would follow some
kind of same definition as the table
which was exported and then i could use
import to import the data from the
directory on sdfs to my table if you
would want to learn more on hbase import
and export you could look at hbase
import operations let's search for the
link and this is the link where you
could learn more about hbase import
export utilities how you could do a bulk
import bulk export which internally uses
mapreduce and then you could do a import
and export into hbase tables moving
further what do we mean by compaction in
hbase now we all know that hbase is a
nosql database which can be used to
store huge amount of data however
whenever a data is written in hbase it
is first returned to what we call as
right ahead log and also to mem store
which is
write cache now once the data is written
in wall and your mem store it is
offloaded to form an internal hbase
format file which is called h5 and
usually these edge files are very small
in nature so we also know that sdfs is
good when we talk about few number of
larger files in comparison to
large number of smaller files due to the
limitation of name nodes memory
compaction is process of merging hbase
files that is these smaller edge files
into a single large file this is done to
reduce the amount of memory required to
store the files and number of disk seeks
needed so we could have lot of edge
files which get created when the data is
written to hbase and these smaller files
can then be compacted through a major or
minor compaction creating one big edge
file which internally would then be
written to sdfs and sdfs format of
blocks that is the benefit of compaction
there is also a feature called bloom
filter so how does bloom filter work so
bloom filter or hbase bloom filter is a
mechanism to test whether a h file
contains a specific row or a row column
cell bloom filter is named after its
creator burton hovered bloom it is a
data structure which predicts whether a
given element is a member of a set of
data it provides an in-memory index
structure that reduces the disk reads
and determines the probability of
finding a row in a particular file this
is one of very useful features of hbase
which allows for faster access and
avoids disk seeks
does hbase have any concept of name
space so namespace is when you have
similar elements grouped together so
namespace yes hb is support such name
space so namespace is a logical grouping
of tables analogous to a database in
rdbms so you can create hbs namespace to
the schema of rdbms database so you
could create a namespace by saying
create namespace and giving it a name
and then you could also list the tables
within a namespace you could create
tables within a specific namespace now
this is usually done in production
environment where a cluster might be
multi-tenant cluster and there might be
different users of the same nosql
database in that case admin would create
specific namespace and for specific
namespace you would have different
directories on htfs and users of a
particular business unit or a team can
work on their hbase objects within a
specific name space this is a question
which is again very important to
understand about the writes or reads so
how does right ahead log wall help when
a region server crashes now as i said
when a write happens it will happen into
mem store and wall that is your edit log
or write ahead log so whenever a write
happens it will happen in two places mem
store which is the right cache and wall
which is a edit log only when the data
is written in both these places and
based on the limitation of mem store the
data will be flushed to create an
edge-based format file called h-file
these files are then compacted and
created into one bigger file which will
then be stored on sdfs and sdfs data as
we know is stored in the form of blocks
on the underlying data nodes so if a
region server hosting a mem store
crashes now where is region server
running that would be co-located with
data node so if a data node crashes or
if a region server which was hosting the
mem store write cache crashes data in
memory the data that in memory which was
not persisted is lost now how does hbase
recover from this as i said your data is
written into wall and mem store at the
same time hbase recovers against that by
writing to wall before the write
completes so whenever a write happens it
happens in mem store and wall at the
same time hbase cluster keeps a wall to
record changes as they happen and that's
why we call it as also an edit log if
hps goes down or the node that goes down
the data that was not flushed from mem
store to edge file can be recovered by
replaying the right ahead lock and
that's the benefit of your edit log or
write ahead log now if we would have to
write hbs command to list the contents
and update the column families of a
table i could just do a scan and that
would give me complete data of a table
if you are very specific and if you
would want to look at a particular row
then you could do a get table name and
then give the row key however you could
do a scan to get the complete data of a
particular table you could also do a
describe to see what are the different
column families and if you would want to
alter the table and add a new column
family it is very simple you can just
say alter give the hvac table name and
then give you a new column family name
which will then be added to the table
what are catalog tables in each base so
as i mentioned your zookeeper knows the
location of this internal catalog table
or what we call as the meta table now
catalog tables in edge base have two
tables one is edge base meta table and
one is
hyphen root the catalog table edge base
meta exists as an hbase table and is
filtered out of hbase shells list
command so if i give a list command on
edge base it would list all the tables
which space contains but not the meta
table it's an internal table this meta
table keeps a list of all regions in the
system and location of hbase meta stored
in zookeeper so if somebody wants to
find out or look for particular rows
they need to know the regions which
contain that data and those regions are
located on region server to get all this
information one has to look into this
meta table however we will not be
looking into meta table directly we
would just be giving a write or a read
operation internally uh based master
queries the zookeeper zookeeper has the
information of where the meta table
exists and that meta table which is
existing on region server contains
information of row keys and the region
servers where those rows can be found
your root table keeps a track of
location of the meta table what is
hotspotting in edge base and how to
avoid hot spotting now this is a common
problem and always admin guys or guys
who are managing the infrastructure
would think about it so one of the main
idea is that edge base would be
leveraging the benefit of sdfs your all
read and write requests should be
uniformly distributed across all of the
regions in region servers otherwise
what's the benefit of having a
distributed cluster so you would have
your data stored across region servers
in the form of regions which are
horizontal partitions of the table and
whenever read and write requests happen
they should be uniformly distributed
across all the regions in the region
servers now hot spotting occurs when a
given region serviced by a region server
receives most or all of read write
request which is basically a unbalanced
way of read write operations now hotspot
can be avoided by designing the row key
in such a way that data being written
should go to multiple regions across the
cluster so you could do techniques such
as salting hashing reversing the key and
many other techniques which are employed
by users of hbase we need to just make
sure that when the regions are
distributed across region servers they
should be spread across region servers
so that your read and write request can
be satisfied from different region
servers in parallel rather than all read
write request hitting the same region
server overloading the region server
which may also lead to the crashing of a
particular region server so these were
some of the important questions of hbase
and then there are many more please
refer to the link which i specified in
during my discussion and that gives you
a detailed explanation of how each base
works you can also look into hp's
definitive guide by o'reilly or hbase in
action and these are really good books
to understand about hbase internals and
how it works now that we have learned on
hive which is a data warehousing package
we have learnt on pig which is a
scripting or a scripting language which
allows you to do data analysis and we
have learned some questions on a nosql
database just note it that there are
more than 225 nosql databases existing
in market and if you would want to learn
and know about more nosql databases you
can just go to google and type no sql
databases
org and that will take you to the link
which is for nosql databases and this
shows there are more than 225
nosql databases existing in market and
these are for different use cases used
by different users and for with
different features so have a look at
this link now when you talk about data
ingestion so let's look at data
ingestion and this is one good link
which i would suggest to have a look at
which lists down around 18 different
ingestion tools so when you talk about
different data injection tools some are
for structured data some are for
streaming data some are for data
governance some are for data ingestion
and transformation and so on so have a
look at this link which also gives you a
comparison of different data ingestion
tools so here let's learn about some
questions on scope which is one of the
data injection tools mainly used for
structured data or you could say data
which is coming in from rdbms or data
which is already structured and you
would want to ingest that you would want
to store that on sdfs which could then
be used for hive which could be used for
any kind of processing using mapreduce
or hive or pig or spark or any other
processing frameworks or you would want
to load that data into say high voltage
based tables scope is mainly for
structured data it is extensively used
when organizations are migrating from
rdbms to a big data platform and they
would be interested in ingesting the
data that is doing import and export of
data from rdbms to sdfs or vice versa so
let's learn about some important
questions on scope which you may be
asked by an interviewer when you apply
for a big data related position how is
scoop different from flume so this is a
very common question which is asked
scoop which is mainly for structured
data so scope works with rdbms it also
works with nosql databases to import and
export data so you can import data into
sdfs you can import data into data
warehousing package such as hive
directly or also in hbase and you could
also export data from hadoop ecosystem
to your rdbms however when it comes to
flow flow is more of
a data injection tool which works with
streaming data or unstructured data so
data which is constantly getting
generated for example log files or
metrics from server or some chat
messenger and so on so if you are
interested in working on capturing and
storing the streaming data in a storage
layer such as sdfs or hbase you could be
using flu there could be other tools
also like kafka or storm or chokwa or
samsa nifi and so on scoop however is
mainly for structured data your loading
data in scope is not event driven so it
is not based on event it basically works
on data which is already stored in rdbms
in terms of flow it is completely event
driven that is as the messages or as the
events happen as the data is getting
generated you can have that data
ingested using flow scope works with
structured data sources and you have
various scope connectors which are used
to fetch data from external data
structures or rdbms so for every rdbms
such as mysql oracle db2 microsoft sql
server you have different connectors
which are available flume it works on
fetching streaming data such as tweets
or log files or server metrics from your
different sources where the data is
getting generated and if you are
interested in not only ingesting that
data which is getting generated in a
streaming fashion but if you would be
interested in processing the data as it
arrives scoop can import data from rdbms
onto sdfs and also export it back to
rdbms flume is then used for streaming
data now you could have one to one one
too many or many to one kind of relation
so in terms of floom you have components
such as your source sink and channel
that's the main difference between your
scoop and flow what are the different
file formats to import data using scope
well there are lots and lots of formats
in which you can import data into scope
when you talk about scope you can have
delimited text file format now that's
the default import format it can be
specified explicitly using as text file
argument so when i want to import data
from an rdbms i could get that data in
sdfs using different compression schemes
or in different formats using the
specific arguments so i could specify an
argument which will write string based
representation of each record to output
files with delimiters between individual
columns and rows so that is the default
format which is used to import data
using scope so to learn more about your
scope and different arguments which are
available you can click on
scoop.apache.org
you can look into the documentation and
i would suggest choosing one of the
versions and looking into the user guide
and here you can search for arguments
and look for specific control arguments
which show how you can import data using
scope so here we have common arguments
and then you also have import control
arguments wherein we have different
options like getting data as avro as
sequence file as text file or parquet
file these are different formats you can
also get data in default compression
scheme that is gzip or you can specify
compression codec and then you can
specify what compression mechanism you
would want to use when you are importing
your data using scope when it comes to
default format for flume we could say
sequence file which is a binary format
that stores individual records in record
specific data types so these data types
are manifested as java classes and scope
will automatically generate these data
types for you so scoop does that when we
talk about your sequence file format in
terms of your scope you could be
extracting storage of all data in binary
representation so as i mentioned you can
import data in different formats such as
avro parquet sequence file that is
binary format or machine readable format
and then you could also have data in
different compression schemes let me
just show you some quick examples here
so if i look in
the content and here i could search for
a scoop based file where i have listed
down some examples so if i would want to
use different compression schemes here
are some examples have a look at these
so i'm doing a scoop import i'm also
giving an argument so that scoop which
also triggers a map reduced job or i
would say map only job so when you run a
scoop import it triggers a map only job
no reduce happens here and you could
specify this parameter or this argument
on the command line
mapreduce.framework.name
so that you could run your map only job
in a local mode to save time or that
would interact with yarn and run a
full-fledged map only job we can give
the connection and then connect to
whatever rdbms we are connecting
mentioning the database name give your
user name and password give the table
name give a target directory or it would
create a directory same as the table
name which would work only once and then
i could say minus z to get data in a
compressed format that is gzip or i
could be specifying compression codec
and then i could specify what
compression codec i would want to use
say snappy b lz4 default i could also
run a query by giving a scope import and
when i'm specifying a query if you
notice i'm not given any table name
because that would be included in the
query i can get my data as a sequence
file format which is a binary format
which will create a huge file so we
could also have compression enabled and
then i could say the output of my map
job should use a compression at record
level for my data coming in sequence
file so sequence file or a binary format
supports compression at record level or
at block level i could get my data in an
avro file where data has embedded schema
within the file or a parquet file also
so these are different ways in which you
can set up different compression schemes
or you can even get data in different
formats and you could be doing a simple
scope import for these looking further
what is the importance of eval tool in
scope so there is something called as
eval tool so scoop eval tool allows
users to execute user defined queries
against respective database servers and
preview the result in the console so
either i could be running a straight
away query to import the data into my
sdfs or i could just use scoop eval
connect to my external rdbms specify my
username and password
and then i could be giving in a query to
see what would be the result of the
query which we intend to import now
let's learn about how scope imports and
exports data between rdbms and sdfs with
its architecture so rdbms as we know has
your database structures your tables
which all of them are logical and
internally there is always metadata
which is stored your scope import
connects to an external rdbms and for
this connection it uses an internal
connector jar file which has a driver
class so that's something which needs to
be set up by admin but they need to make
sure that whichever rdbms you intend to
connect to they need to have the jdbc
connector for that particular rdbms
stored within the scope lib folder so
scope import gets the metadata and then
for your scoop command it converts that
into a map only job which might have one
or multiple map tasks
now that depends on your scope command
you could be specifying that you would
want to do a import only in one task or
in multiple tasks these multiple map
tasks will then run on a section of data
from rdbms and then store it in sdfs so
at high level we could say scoop will
introspect database to get gathered the
metadata it divides the input data set
into splits and this division of data
into splits mainly happens on primary
key column of the table now if somebody
might ask what if my table in rdbms does
not have a primary key column then when
you are doing a scope import either you
will have to import it using one mapper
task by specifying hyphen hyphen m
equals one or you would have to say
split by parameter to specify a numeric
column from rdbms and that's how you can
import the data let me just show you a
quick example on this so i could just
look in again into the scoop command
file and here we could be looking at an
example so if you see this one here we
are specifying minus minus m equals 1
which basically means i would want to
import the data using one map task now
in this case whether the table has a
primary key column or does not have a
primary key column will not matter but
if i say a minus minus ms6 where i am
specifying multiple map tasks to be
imported then this will look for a
primary key column in the table which
you are importing now if the table does
not have a primary key column then i
could be specifying a split by and then
specify the column so that the data
could be split into multiple chunks and
multiple map tasks could take it
now if the second scenario is your table
does not have a primary key column and
it does not have a numeric column on
which you could do a split by in that
case and if you would want to use
multiple mappers you could still say
split by on a textual column but you
will have to add this property so that
it allows splitting the data which is
non-numeric
all of these options are given in the
scoop apache.org link going further how
scoop imports and exports data between
rdbms and sdfs with its architecture so
as i said it submits the map only job to
the cluster and then it basically does a
import or export so if we are exporting
the data from sdfs in that case again
there would be a map only job it would
look at multiple splits of the data
which is existing which your map only
job would process through one or one
table map task and then export it to
rdbms suppose you have a database testdb
in mysql we if somebody asked you to
write a command to connect this database
and import tables to scoop so here is a
quick example as i showed you in the
command file so you could say scope
import this is what we would want to do
you connect using jdbc now this will
only work if the jdbc connector already
exists within your scope lib directory
admin has to set up that so you can
connect to your rdbms you can point to
the database so
here our database name is test
underscore db i could give user name and
then either i could give password on the
command line or just say capital p so
that i could be prompted for the
password and then i could give the table
name which i would want to import i
could also be specifying minus minus m
and specify how many map tasks do i want
to use for this import as i showed in
previous screen how to export a table
back to rdbms now for this we need the
data in a directory on hdfs so for
example
there is a department's table in retail
database which is already imported into
scoop and you need to export this table
back to rdbms so this is the content of
the table now create a new department
table in rdbms so i could create a table
specifying the column names whether that
supports null or no if that has a
primary key column which is always
recommended and then i can do a scoop
export i can connect to the rdbms
specifying my username and password
specify the table into which you want to
export the data and then you give export
directory pointing to a directory on
sdfs which contains the data this is how
you can export data into table seeing
example on this so i could again look
into my file and here i have an example
of import this is where you are
importing data directly into hive and
you have scope import where you are
importing data directly into hbase table
and you can then query your hbase table
to look at the data you could also do a
export by
running your map only job in a local
mode connecting to the rdbms specifying
your username specifying the table where
you would want to export and the
directory on sdfs where you have kept
the relevant data this is a simple
example of export looking further
what is the role of jdbc driver in scope
setup so as i said if you would want to
use scoop to connect to an external
rdbms we need the jdbc odbc connector
jar file now one or admin could download
the jdbc connector jar file and then
place the jar file within the scoop lib
directory wherever scoop is installed
and this jdbc connector jar file
contains a driver now jdbc driver is a
standard java api which is used for
accessing different databases in rdbms
so this connector jar file is very much
required and this connector jar file has
a driver class and this driver class
enables the connection between your
rdbms and your hadoop structure each
database vendor is responsible for
writing their own implementation that
will allow communication with the
corresponding database and we need to
download the drivers which allow our
scoop to connect to external rdbms so
your jdbc driver alone is not enough to
connect to scope we also need connectors
to interact with different database so a
connector is a plugable piece that is
used to fetch metadata and allow scoop
to overcome the differences in sql
dialects so this is how connection can
be established so normally your admins
would when they are setting up scope and
hadoop they would download
say mysql jdbc connector and this is how
they would go to the mysql connectors if
you are connecting to mysql similarly
for your other rdbms you could be
say going in here you could be looking
for a previous version depending you
could be going for platform independent
and then you could be downloading the
connected jar file now if you enter this
jar file you would see a mysql connector
jar and if we look in
[Music]
mysql.jdbc.driver
com.mysql.jdbcom.mysql.jdbc
so this is the package which is within
the connector jar file and this
has the driver class which allows the
connection of your scope with your rdbms
so these things will have to be done by
your admin so that you can have your
scope connecting to an external rdbms
now how do you update the columns that
are already exported so if i do a export
and i put my data in rdbms can i really
update the columns that are already
exported yes i can using a update key
parameter so scoop export command
remains the same the only thing i will
have to specify now is the table name
your fields terminated by if you have a
specific delimiter and then you can say
update key and then the column name so
this allows us to update the columns
that are already exported in rdbms
what is code gen so scope commands
translate into your mapreduce job or map
only job so code gen is basically a tool
in scope that generates data access
objects dao java classes that
encapsulate and interpret imported
records so if i do a scoop code gen
connect to an rdbms using my username
and give a table this will generate a
java code for employee table in the test
database so this code gen can be useful
for us to understand what data we have
in this particular table finally can
scoop be used to convert data in
different formats i think i already
answered that right if no which tools
can be used for this purpose so scoop
can be used to convert data in different
formats and that depends on the
different arguments which you use when
you do a import such as avro file
parquet file binary format with record
or block level compression so if you are
interested in knowing more on different
data formats then i think i can suggest
a link for that and we can say hadoop
formats
i think it is tech
maggie avro
parque let's see you can find out the
link take mac e yeah this is a very good
link which specifies or talks about
different data formats which you should
know such as your text file format
different compression schemes how is
data organization what are the common
formats what do you have in text file
structured binary sequence files with
compression without compression what is
record level what is block level what is
a avro data file what is a sequence what
is a
parquet data file or a columnar format
and other formats like orc rc and so on
so please have a look at this
thank you all for watching this full
course video on big data for 2022 i hope
it was useful and informative if you
have any queries please feel free to put
them in the comments section of the
video we'll be happy to help you thanks
again stay safe and keep learning
[Music]
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn youtube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos turn it up and get certified
click here
you